ALLEN ARCHULETA. BALCONIES BELL
BRADFORD CABALLERO DODD. THE
RAZA GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HELLO HUESO HURTADO
JACKSON LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN AMBERG
BY CAL SKI WIENER. BATES PORGES
CHIANG DALLY. LET'S GO BAK
WITH THE THOSE WHO ARE HERE
REMOTELY AND AGAIN THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE. OPERATING
REMOTELY- WHEN YOUR NAME IS
CALLED PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
PRESENCE BY. SAYING EITHER HERE
OR PRESENT. FACE. OKAY MOVE ON.
MOVE ON NOT THERE RIGHT NOW FOR
JUST. WE'RE JUST PRESENT FOR
JUST PRESIDENT CHIANG THANK
HASN'TCHANGED PRESENT VALLEY
DIE PRESENT VALLEY PRESENT
GROWTH. WE RIGHT. GROW UP YOU
ARE IN MUTUAL EDITOR CENTER
GROVES. CENTER GROVE YOU ARE
NEW. TO ALL RIGHT NEXT NEXT
MEMBER PLEASE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ PRESENT ONE DOES
PRESENT MORLOCK. PRESENCE
MORLOCK PRESENT AROUND.
MORELLO'S HERE. L. PRESENT WILK.
WILK TREASURY WILL PRESENT BOTH
PRESENT GROVE PRESIDENT. I
THINK THE ONLY WERE MISSING WAS
SENATOR BATES SHE SHE PRESIDENT.
SENATOR BATES. RIGHT NOT
ADVANCE IN LEGISLATORS ALREADY
CHECKED IN WITH YOUR I. T.
STAFF. BUT AS SENATOR BATES WE
UNDERSTAND IS ON THE PHONE SO
WE WILL GO AHEAD OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS CHEN
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR MONNING.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. GOD WHO IS ALWAYS WITH
US ON THE JOURNEY WE PRAY THAT
OUT OF THE CHAOS OF THIS YEAR
WE WILL EMERGE WITH RENEWED
STRENGTH AND ENERGY TO BRING
PEACE AND PROSPERITY TO OUR
STATE AND UNTIL WE MEET ON THIS
FLOOR AGAIN MAY THE ALMIGHTY
AND MERCIFUL LORD LEAD US ALONG
WAYS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY. IN
MAY THE HUMAN CONNECTIONS WE'VE
MADE WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AND
STAFF TRANSCEND A DIFFERENCES
IN FORTIFY OUR COMMITMENT TO DO
GOOD AND TO SERVE OTHERS
WHEREVER OUR RESPECTIVE PATHS
MAINLY THIS. OUR GUARDIAN
ANGELS ACCOMPANY US SO THAT WE
MAY RETURN SAFELY TO THE SENATE
CHAMBER AT THE APPOINTED TIME.
WE S. THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. HI ALL RIGHT AGAIN
MEMBERS WE HAVE SENATORS ABATES
BORCHERS DOLLY GROVE JONES
MELINDA'S MORE MORALE AND WILL
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING THAT NON I'M SORRY. I'M
SORRY SENATOR MELENDEZ MY
APOLOGIES THERE ARE THERE ARE
NO OF MIKE'S UP ON THE FLOOR
WILL GO TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS
SENATOR MELINDA BUSH. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS PERCENT CENTER-
TWENTY EIGHT I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
C. OR NINETY THREE REMOVED FROM
THE ROLLS COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR DEBATE
IN THE- THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA SENATOR HERTZBERG SURE
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. IN RESPONSE
THE MOTION JOURNAL ADDRESS FOR
NOBLE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION BEFORE US SENATOR
MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF THE MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER.
ALLEN NO ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA.
WHAT ELSE ARCHULETA NO ATKINS
NO BELL. NO BRADFORD NO
CABALLERO. NO DODD. NO TORONTO
NO GALGIANI. NO GLAZER NO
GONZALEZ NO HERTZBERG. NO HILL
NO WAY SO. NO HURTADO. JACKSON
NO LEYVA NO MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE NO
MITCHELL. NO MONEY. NO NIELSEN.
HI TAM. PAN NO PORTANTINO. NO
ROTH. NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER NO NO WHITE HOUSE
SKI NO WIENER NO. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THOSE
MEMBERS. BATE I I'M ON THE
MOTION AT THE CENTERS OF WE
MUST TO ASK THAT YOU IDENTIFY
WHAT IT IS YOU ARE VOTING ON SO.
BY THE- IDENTIFY THE BILL YOUR
NAME AND YOUR VOTE IF YOU WOULD.
EIGHTY SIX. S. J. K. THE NUMBER
NOW ON THE MOTION TO WITHDRAW I
THINK IS ALL YOU HAVE TO
SOLUTION TO LET YOUR- HI. THANK
YOU BATES HI GORGEOUS. FORGE'S%
MOTION WITHDRAWN BY GORGEOUS HI
CHIANG PAYING MOTION TO
WITHDRAW ABSTAINED. DALLY GOT A
MOTION TO WITHDRAW HI DALLY
HIGH GROWTH GROWTH MOTION TO
WITHDRAW SO WE CAN HAVE A
VIGOROUS DEBATE ON- WHETHER THE
GOVERNOR'S THANK YOU THE MURKY
ANSWERS FOR SIMPLY INTERNET
NAME YOUR POSITION HIGHER NO
AND THEN WE'LL GO FROM THERE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT THE
TONIGHT VOTE THAT'S NEXT ONE
PLEASE GROVE HI. MELENDEZ LINDA
IS ON THE MOTION TO WITHDRAW
SEARING NINETY THREE TO END THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY I. THANK YOU
NEXT ONE PLAN DOES HI MORLOCK.
GOOD MORNING MADAM PRESIDENTS.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU ON YOUR
LAST DAY TOGETHER WERE
DIGITALLY AT LEAST AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON A GREAT JOB.
MORE AUNT MOTION TO WITHDRAW.
HI MORE LOCATION- MORAL NEXT
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. MORALE THE
MOTION TO WITHDRAW BY. MORALE I
WILK. MOTIONS WITHDRAW HI WILK
HI I NINE NOES SIX THE MEASURE
THE MOTION FAILS MOVING ON NOW
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ANYTHING
ELSE UNDER MOST MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SEEING NO HANDS UP
NO MIKE'S UP LET'S MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
AND WE ARE GOING TO START WITH
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE AND WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MADAM PRO
TIM- TO JOIN US PLEASE NOTE WE
ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH EACH OF
THESE MEASURES ONE TIME. WE
WILL ASK OUR ABSENT MEMBERS TO
STEP FORWARD AND RE JOIN US IN
THE CHAMBER THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
GIVEN SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
BEFORE NOON. WE WILL THEN
FINALIZE THE VOTE. AND THEN WE
WILL BE HAVING LUNCH BETWEEN
TWELVE AND TWELVE THIRTY
HOPEFULLY SO THAT'S THE MORNING
SCHEDULE AND WITH THAT MADAM
PRO TEM. WE ARE GOING TO. I
TECHNICIAN WAS A PROFESSIONAL
AND- OH OKAY OKAY OKAY ALL
RIGHT. WHICH IS THE NEXT ONE.
ALL RIGHT. MY APOLOGIES ADAM
PEATY BUT IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO
HAVE YOU IN THE ROOM- WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
SENATOR DOORASHO. MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR THE RUSSELL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I RISE TO PRESENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE LATINO
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILLABLE TOOL
HELP PREVENT BAD ACTOR
BUSINESSES THAT COMMIT WAGE
THEFT FROM SIMPLY FORMING A NEW
COMPANY TO AVOID THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES EVEN AFTER A
COURT OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
DETERMINES THAT WORKERS WERE
NOT PAID FOR THE WORK. MOST
WORKERS HAVE TROUBLE COLLECTING
THE MONEY THEY ARE OWED
ALTHOUGH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE ISSUED-
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN AWARDS
FOR UNPAID WAGES OVER A PERIOD
OF ONLY FOUR YEARS WORKERS WERE
ONLY ABLE TO COLLECT 15% OF
THOSE AWARDS. 75% OF THE
COMPANY'S LEGALLY VANISHED.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO INDICATE THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE FINAL OUTSTANDING
WAGE JUDGMENTS AGAINST THEM
BEFORE INCORPORATING A NEW
BUSINESS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
WORKED. WITH THE CHAMBER AND
THEY HAVE TAKEN THE BILL OFF
THE KILLER LIST- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR DORADO IS THERE ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR. SEEING AND HEARNG NON
AND SEEING NO HANDS UP ON THE
REMOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL. I
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I DODD. HI
DURAZO. HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HI
HELLO I WAS SO. I HER TAUGHT IN.
JACKSON AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY. I NIELSEN NO
HAN. FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. AMBERG.
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER. BY WE
WILL NOW GO TO OUR MEMBERS. WHO
ARE REMOTELY PARTICIPATING
PLEASE REMEMBER TO GIVE YOUR
NAME. WE ARE ON FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
A AND YOU WOULD TOO IF YOU
WOULD IDENTIFY THAT AS WELL AND
THEN CAST YOUR VOTE SO WITH
THAT- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. BATES AS AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE ABSTAINED.
GORGEOUS FORGES AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN FIVE STAINED. CHIANG
THANK AB THREE ZERO SEVEN FIVE
ABSTAINED. DALLY DALY AB THREE
SEVEN THREE ZERO SEVEN FIVE A
STATE. GROWTH. AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN FIVE ABSTAINED. MELINDA
MULLIN THREE ZERO SEVEN FIVE NO
ONE DOES NO. MORLOCK. AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE ABSTAINED
MORALE. INTERVIEW MURROW.
SENATOR MORALE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
YEAH MORALE NO. AB PLEASE
IDENTIFY THE BILL OKAY I DID
BUT AND I WASN'T ON YOU BEFORE
BUT ANYWAY IT'S AB. THREE ZERO
SEVEN FIVE VOTING NO THANK YOU
GENERAL NEXT PLEASE MORALE NO.
WILK WELL AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE ABSTAINED. SENATOR DORADO
MOVES TO CALL MOVING NOW TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATORS
SKINNER. WILL HOLD ONE MINUTE
PLEASE FOR SENATOR SKINNER ALL
RIGHT- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ WE ARE ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. CENTERS SKINNER WILL
GIVE YOU A MINUTE. WHO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
TEN SIXTY SIX WILL STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS FOR WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO COLLECT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THAT ARE
OWED TO THEM AND ALLOWS OUR
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO AUTHORIZE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO RECOVER
UNPAID YOU AYE CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM LARGE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
NOT PAID INTO THE FUND. TEN
SIXTY SIX CODIFIES THE TEN DAY
DEADLINE FOR EMPLOYERS RESPOND
TO ET'S INITIAL NOTICE UNLESS
THERE'S A GOOD CAUSE FOR DELAY.
AB TEN SIXTY SIX WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE LARGE ENTITIES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN CONTRIBUTING.
ROWING ON THAT FRONT. FIVE PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE SO THAT THE
STATE IN TURN CAN PAY THEIR
WORK TO WORKERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER'S HER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR. SEEING NONE WILL NOW GO
TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS SEEING NO
HANDS UP MADAM SECRETARY MADAM
PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT SENATOR
GROWTH HOLD ON I'M LOOKING I
HAVE TO PUT THE CHAT ROOM UP I
APOLOGIZE. WE DON'T HAVE YOU UP.
I AM. ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU CHECK
TO SEE BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I RECOGNIZE YOU IN
THE FUTURE BUT RIGHT NOW THERE
WE GO THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT
OKAY AND I'M SORRY THESE ARE A
PROBLEM. THE JOINT TECHNOLOGY
NOT TO WORRY ALL RIGHT HELLO
PLEASE PROCEED. SO MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL- TEN SIXTY SIX I
FOR THE LIFE OF ME I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND. WHY WE CONTINUE TO
REGULATE PRIVATE BUSINESS OUT
OF THE POINT OF NO RETURN. TO
THINK THAT THE DELAYS AND THE
NON IMPLEMENTATION OF THE EDT
PAYMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT REQUIRES. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE BENEFITS
WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS LIKE THE
TO STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
OBLIGATION TO DISTRIBUTE EIGHTY
SEVEN PERCENT. OF THOSE FUNDS
TO THE UNEMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
IN OUR STATE THAT DESPERATELY
NEED THESE RESOURCES. THEY HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO PAY THESE
BENEFITS WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS.
EDT DEPARTMENT IS A COMPLETE
DISASTER AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN AUDIT AFTER AUDIT
THERE'S ALSO BEEN- A TASK FORCE
IT'S A SET FORTH BY THE
GOVERNOR. INSTEAD THINK THAT-
IT'S THE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
DELAYED YES IT'S NOT AND TO
THINK THAT THE EMPLOYERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR THE DELAY IN
BENEFITS BEING PAID WE'RE NOT
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS
EMPLOYERS- TO FILE QUARTERLY
TAXES IMPAIR EDG. I'M SO YOU
GET IT IN ADVANCE IN ADVANCE-
BY THREE YEARS. SO DID THINK
THAT- THERE'S IT'S THE WAY IT
WORKS IS THERE'S A DELAY SO
EMPLOYEES WORK AND FOR THAT
CREATIVE TRYING TO WORK THE
FOLLOWING YEAR THE EMPLOYER
PAYS ET DE BENEFITS THAT WERE
FOR THAT PREVIOUS YEAR. AND IT
TAKES A YEAR AND NINE MONTHS
LATER FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES TO BE
ABLE TO DRAW ON THOSE BENEFITS
SO YOU ALREADY GET EMPLOYER
MONEY IN ADVANCE YOU CAN CLEAR
MONEY IN ADVANCE AND THEN YOU
BLAME IT ON THE EMPLOYERS. FOR
NOT RESPONDING QUICK ENOUGH
AND- IT'S BEEN SIX MONTHS AND
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPERIENCING
DELAYS IN RECEIVING BENEFITS.
THE PROBLEMS LIE WITH THE IN
APP AND IN ANTIQUATED EDT YOUR
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. EDT MAY CLAIM THESE
DEFICIENCIES ARE A DIRECT
RESULT OF OUR STATE- HISTORICAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE BUT THESE
PROBLEMS WITH THE EDT OFFICE
BLAMING IT ON. AND THE
PANDEMIC- TOO MANY PEOPLE
FILING FOR AN EMPLOY. YOU KNOW.
POINTING AT IT ELSE BUT NO WILL
TAKE ACCOUNT THAT INTO THOUSAND
ELEVEN WE HAD IN OUR- AT THE
AGENCY FOR TO THE- AND TWO. TWO
TWO ELEVEN AND THIS THE
DEPARTMENT FAILED TO MEET ANY
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS. THAT WERE
SET BY THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
LATER LABOR AS EASY LABOR. AND
IT ALSO. HAD A LONG. LIST OF
THIS AUDIT HAD LONG TERM
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS THAT WOULD
BE- IMPROVED- TO IMPROVE ITS
ABILITY TO DELIVERY TIMELY
PAYMENTS NONE OF THOSE WERE
IMPLEMENTED. THE EIGHTY TWO
CONTINUES TO BE A VIOLATION OF
THE R. F. P. P. WHICH IS THE
FIRST PAYMENT PROMPTNESS. WHICH
WAS WHAT I JUST ADDRESSED A FEW
MINUTES AGO THAT WHEN YOU GET
MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT MATCHES. OR
PAYS A PERCENTAGE OF THE WHITE-
FINDER THE EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REQUIRES THAT THESE PAYMENTS GO
OUT WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS.
CALIFORNIA FAILED AND CONTINUES
TO FAIL TO DO SO. AND THE
DEPARTMENT SOLE RESPONSIBILITY
IS TO DISTRIBUTE THE CENTRAL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR OUR
FAMILIES ADD THAT ARE OUT OF
WORK. AND THEY CONTINUE TO FAIL
TO DO SO TO THINK THAT- THAT
AT. PASSING A LAW AND MAKE IT
SOUND LIKE IT'S THE EMPLOYERS-
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THE
EMPLOYERS. INDEPENDENT JUST NO
BURDENS ON EMPLOYERS I DO I
BELIEVE THAT EVERYBODY WHO OWES
EDT PAYMENTS SHOULD PAY THEIR
EIGHTY PAYMENTS. ABSOLUTELY BUT
THIS BILL IS NOT THE SOLUTION-
TO ANY PART OF THAT AND- YOU
KNOW I REMIND YOU ALL THAT WE
HAVE THE DOWNTURN- THIS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I BELIEVE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN AND
TWELVE- WE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OVERDREW THEIR EDT
ACCOUNT AND THEN THEY JUST
FAILED TO MAKE THE PAYMENTS IN
THE IN THE- PLAYERS IN THE
STATE HAD TO MAKE IT AT. IN
MANY BUSINESSES WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE YOU WOULD GET
A BILL AT THE END OF THE YEAR
FOR SIXTY THOUSAND EIGHTY
THOUSAND A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
AND YOU'D HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PUT THAT IN YOUR BUDGET.
WITH MAYBE ONLY MAKE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
BECAUSE YOU TO SEND YOU ALREADY
YOUR- SO POINT 9% AND THEN MAKE
BACK WITH IN ADDITION.
PERCENTAGE TO PAY ADDITIONAL
PERCENTAGE TO PAY ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT YOU ALREADY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE WIFE AND
ARGUE I TRUST FUND. THIS IS A
COMPLETE MISMANAGEMENT BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO COMPLETE
MISMANAGEMENT BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS. GOING BACK ALL
THE WAY TO TWO THOUSAND AND ONE
EDT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM. AND WE
KNOW IT IT WAS ELEVATED. WE ALL
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT ONLY
REPUBLICAN OFFICES GOT
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
CALLS. AND IN THEIR OFFICE
TELLING THAT THEY DIDN'T GET
BENEFITS ARTICLE AFTER ARTICLE
IN THE SACRAMENTO BEE AND ALL
OVER THE NEWSPAPERS. IN
REPORTING WHERE PEOPLE HAD TO
CALL- YOU KNOW SO AT TEN TWELVE
FIFTEEN AND IN EVEN MORE TIMES
TO EVEN GET A HUMAN PERSON TO
RESPOND. WAITING WEEKS AND
WEEKS AND WEEKS FOR PAYMENT.
AND THE EIGHTY D. DEPARTMENT IS
THAT IT IS A DISASTER IT NEEDS
TO BE FIXED. AND IF YOU REALLY
WANTED TO FIX IT YOU WOULD
ADDRESS THE SITUATION IS GOING
ON WITH EDT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DELIVER THE PAYMENTS TO
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE HURTING
HAVE LOST THEIR JOB AND TO
THINK THAT TIME. THIS BILL
MAKES IT SOUND LIKE IT'S THE
REASON WHY THE PAYMENTS ARE
GOING OUT IS BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYERS HAVEN'T PAID IT.
AGAIN EMPLOYERS PAY IN ADVANCE
IN ADVANCE EMPLOYERS PAY IN
ADVANCE- SO THE MONEY IS PAID
UP FRONT. IT'S THE
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENTS WHICH CAUSES THE
DELAYED PAYMENTS TO NOT GO OUT
TO INDIVIDUALS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
ANY. OTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THE MEASURE. SEEING NON
THANK YOU OF. SENATOR SHE
SKINNER. THANK YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- AT
TEN SIXTY SIX OF IMPACTS
COMPANIES WITH FIVE HUNDRED OR
MORE EMPLOYEES THAN WHO ARE
HAVE NOT ARE NOT UP TO DATE IN
THEIR EBT PAYMENTS AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR ITEMS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELT. I BRADFORD. COMPARE DODD.
THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL FIVE WESTERN. HI HURTADO.
JACKSON AYE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. HI MY NAME
HI NIELSEN. NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER HI MY
CASTING. I WIENER HI WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS
AGAIN REMEMBER PLEASE IF YOU
WOULD THE BILL YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR BATES. BATES AB TEN
SIXTY SIX BATES NO BATES NO
FORTUS. WORD IS AB TEN SIX SIX
NOW. GORGEOUS NO CHIANG AB TEST
SIX SIX ABSTAINED DALLY. DALY
AB. TEN SIXTY SIX NO VALLEY NOW
GROWTH. AB TEN SIXTY SIX NO
GROWTH NO MELENDEZ MULLIN IS AB
TEN SIXTY SIX NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK OR LOCK AB TEN SIXTY
SIX NO MORE LOCK NO GIRL.
REALLY BE TEN SIXTY SIX NOW
MORALE NO WILK. AB TEN SIXTY
SIX NO WELL NO. THIS SENATORS
SKINNER MOVES TO CALL
COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW GOING TO
GO BACK TO- UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
VONN ARE FILE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM TWO AND I
WILL READ THE NUMBERS THAT AT
LEAST AT THIS MOMENT WE ARE
EXPECTING TO DO. IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER. FILE ITEM TWO.
THREE FIVE SEVEN. NINE AND
TWELVE THOSE WILL BE THE FIRST
SIX ITEMS WE'RE STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM TO. FILE ITEM TWO AND
THAT IS. SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION SENATOR GLAZERS THE
FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS DISTRICT
BILL- I MET ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THE TRANSPORTATION
TAXES DON'T COUNT ON THE- A
WHITE CAP. WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIVEAU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
ON ON OUR FLOOR SHAKING AND NON
REMOTELY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BELL.
I BRADFORD. CABRERA FIVE DODD.
I DURAZO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. I HILL
I HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON
HI I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONNING I NIELSEN.
NO HAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH
HI RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI STERN.
NUMBER. HI MY COUNTY I WIENER.
I WILL NOW GO TO THE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY STARTING
WITH ENATOR BATES SENATOR
BATES NAME A BILL NUMBER IF YOU
WOULD AND YOUR POSITION. EIGHT
SB ONE THREE FOUR NINE BATES NO
BATES NO FORTUS. FORGERS S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE NOW FORTUS
NOW CHIANG HEY SB THIRTY FORTY
NINE NOW CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI
SP THIRTEEN FORTY NINE NO DALLY
NO GROWTH. S. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE NO ROADS NO MELENDEZ
BELINDA'S SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH S. B. FORTY NINE NO
MORE LOCK NO MORAL. YES FEET
MORALITY S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE NO MORALE NO. WILK LOOK SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE NO WILK NOW.
SENATOR GLAZER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. THREE
SENATOR RECORD YOU WISH TO TAKE
THIS UP FOR PASS TEMPORARILY.
S. TEMPORARILY WILL MOVE THEM
TO FILE ITEM FIVE SENATOR
WIENER MISCHIEF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO CORRECTIONS
CENTER WIENER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TRYING TO PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SP ONE THIRTY TWO-
RETURNS TO US FROM THE ASSEMBLY
ON CONCURRENCE- BY THIS
LEGISLATION ADDRESSES A VERY
REAL PROBLEM. FACING OUR
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA
PRISONS- WE CURRENTLY
AUTOMATICALLY ASSIGN- A
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED TO A FACILITY THAT
CORRESPONDS TO THEIR BIRTH
ASSIGNED. GENDER WE DO NOT
ALLOW THEM TO BE HOUSED
ACCORDING TO WHERE THEY WILL
ACTUALLY BE SAFEST FOR EXAMPLE
A TRANS WOMAN- WHO THE HELL'S-
IN A WOMEN'S FACILITY BECAUSE
TRANS WOMEN ARE BRUTALIZED IN
MEN'S. FACILITY HI THIS IS A
BASIC HEALTH AND SAFETY MEASURE
AND IT WILL REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE DIGNITY OF
OUR TRANSGENDER. RESIDENTS BY
IN THE ASSEMBLY OVER THE PAST
YEAR BECAUSE THIS CAME BEFORE
US- OVER A YEAR AGO WE WORKED
INTENSIVELY WITH OUR COALITION
AS WELL AS WITH CDCR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS- IN. THE ASSEMBLY TO
ENSURE THE CITY. HAS SUPPOSED
POINTS TO AROUND HEALTH AND
SAFETY TO BE A TO APPROPRIATELY
AND SAFELY IMPLEMENT THIS
LEGISLATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER
DEBATER. IS THERE ANY ON THE
FLOOR SEEING AND HEARING NON
WILL NOW GO TO OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS. SEEING NO HANDS UP
VENTURE CHERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I TELL I BRADFORD HI
CABRERO HI DODD. I DURAZO I
GALGIANI HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO. I JACKSON HI I LEYVA
I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN AMBERG HI MY
COUNTY I WIENER HI. MOVING NOW
TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS AGAIN
NAME A BILL SB ONE THIRTY TWO
AND YOUR POSITION SENATOR BATES
WILL START WITH YOU. FACE.
YOU'RE ON MUTE SENATOR CENTER
BATES. EIGHTY SIX THANK S. B.
ONE THIRTY TWO NOW. BATES NOW
FOR JUST. FORGES SB ONE THREE
TWO NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG.
TANG S. B. ONE THREE TWO NOW
CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI SP ONE
THREE TWO NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
SB ONE THREE TWO NO GROWTH NO
MELENDEZ. WINDOWS SB ONE THREE
TWO NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK
OR UNLOCK SB ONE THREE TWO NO
MORE LOCK NO MORAL. SB. ONE
THREE TWO. WHAT IS YOUR VOTER.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR. MORRELL NOW
WILK. SB ONE THREE TWO NO WELL
NOW. SENATOR THE WINNER MOVES-
CALL WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
FILE ITEM CENTER SEVEN SENATOR
BRADFORD. DO YOU WISH TO TAKE
UP THE SIDE OF. SENATOR
BRADFORD. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PASS TEMPORARILY. YOU READY TO
GO FIVE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO ZERO
THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SB TWO OR THREE
WOULD REQUIRE USE UNDER THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN TO CONSULT WITH
LEGAL COUNSEL PRIOR TO WALK
WAIVING THEIR MIRANDA RIGHTS
THIS BILL REQUIRE YOU TO WORK
FACING INTERROGATION TO
CONSULT. WITH AN ATTORNEY WHO
EXPLAIN THEIR RIGHTS. AND WHAT
IT MEANS TO WEAR THEM. WE KNOW
FROM DECADES OF RESEARCH TO
YOUNG PEOPLE AS WELL A ADULTS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO UNDERSTAND
THEIR RIGHTS AND THE
CONSEQUENCES AWAITING THEM.
COULD AND WAVING THEM COULD
INFLICT ON THEIR LIVES AND WE
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE
EXPERIENCE OF INNOCENT YOUTHS
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN
WE'VE BEEN PRESSURED INTO
GIVING FALSE CONFESSIONS AND
HIT THEIR LIVES DEVASTATINGLY
IMPACTED BY THOSE CONSEQUENCES
A PRIME EXAMPLE. IS THE CENTRAL
PARK FIVE FIVE INNOCENT YOUNG
MAN WHO SPENT YEARS IN PRISON
FOR CRIMES THEY DID NOT COMMIT.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
REGISTRY OF EXONERATIONS SINCE
198936% OF PEOPLE WHO FALSELY
CONFESSED THE CRIME. AND WERE
LATER EXONERATED WERE UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN. THIS BILL
PROTECTS ALL CALIFORNIA YOU AND
HELPS BUILD TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SOMETHING WE
BADLY NEED RIGHT NOW. THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSES BILL. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WHICH WAS S. B.
TEN FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR LOREN
SENATOR MITCHELL THIS MEASURE
MEASURE WAS ULTIMATELY VETOED
BY GOVERNOR BROWN. THE
LEGISLATURE PASS ANOTHER
VERSION OF THIS BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH WAS
AMENDED THE YOUTH UNDER THE AGE
OF SIXTEEN. INCLUDED A SUNSET
DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I
REQUIRE THE PANEL TO BE CONVENE
TO REVIEW THE FACTS THE CHANGE
IN THE LAW. THE OPPOSITION THIS
BILL ARGUES THAT WE SHOULD WAIT
AND HEAR THE RESULTS OF THAT
REVIEW. I SAY WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO WAIT. BUT WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO WAIT FOR SOMETHING THAT WE
ALREADY KNOW. YOUNG PEOPLE MUST
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS AND THEY
SHOULD NOT BE ALONE WHEN BEING
IN TERROR TERROR GATED I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT YOUNG SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WHO KILLED TWO PEOPLE
AND WOUNDED ANOTHER ONE IN
WISCONSIN WAS NOT IN A ROOM BY
THEMSELVES EVEN THOUGH WE KNEW
HE COMMITTED THE CRIME. WE KNOW
THAT OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IMPACTS
YOUTH OF COLOR THE HARNESS.
WHICH CAUSES THEM TO LOSE FAITH
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT FOR BED
INNOCENT TEEN FROM ENGAGING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IT WOULD
MAKE. THEIR STATEMENTS AND
MISCIBLE AND IT WOULD NOT
PREVENT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
USING THEIR CONFESSIONS TO
ACCOMPLISH THEIR WORK. SB TWO
OR THREE HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
LARGE COAL POLLUTION
ORGANIZATIONS WHO RECOGNIZES
THIS WILL CREATE GREATER TRUST
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DUE PROCESS
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL
IS ALSO SUPPORT OF A
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS.
MEMBERS THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE. THAT
PROTECTS. YOU FROM ANY SOONER
IS THAT EVERYONE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED AND I STRONGLY AS FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD DEBATE OR DISCUSSIONS
OR ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THE FLOOR. ANY MIKE SUB. RIGHT
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THOSE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
WE DO HAVE A HAND UP BY SENATOR
BORCHERS. PLEASE PROCEED
SENATOR BORDERS THANK YOU. IF I
MAY POSE A QUESTION THROUGH THE
CHAIR TO THE AUTHOR WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION SENATOR
BRADFORD. YEAH PLEASE PROCEED.
JUST A CLARIFICATION THE THAT
CUSTODIAL INTERROGATION OF A
JUVENILE WITHOUT PRIOR
CONSULTATION WITH AN ATTORNEY
SO THE RAISING OF THE AGE FROM
FIFTEEN TO SEVENTEEN- THESE
INDIVIDUALS EITHER WRAPPED UP
THE FINANCIAL WHERE WITH ALL TO
HIRE AN ATTORNEY OR WITH THE
HAVE A POINTED COUNSEL UNDER
THE SITUATION HOW DOES THIS
WORK WE HOPE IT WOULD HAVE
APPOINTED IF THEY CAN AFFORD
ATTORNEY WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ATTORNEY SO. THEY COULD REQUEST
ONE. ALL RIGHT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THE VOLUME IN
WHETHER OR NOT OUR EXISTING
APPOINTED- COUNCIL- ROSTER WHAT
IT WOULD ALLOW FOR THIS JUST
MORE PRACTICAL STANDPOINT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT. I HAVE A
THOUGHT ON THE FACT THAT. WHO
ARE FOR MORE TIMES IN THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY'RE
INNOCENT BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD AN ATTORNEY FOR THE
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY PEOPLE ON
DEATH ROW ONLY ONE HANDED ARE
TURNING NOW WITH SCOTT PETERSON
SO I WOULD HOPE WE FIND A
PRIORITY TO. MAKE ATTORNEYS
AVAILABLE AT LEAST TALK TO
THESE KIDS UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN TO MAKE SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE. DO YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION OF
SENATOR MITCHELL. YOU SHOULD
ASK THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO ZERO THREE I THINK
IT'S NOT AN ISSUE OF RESOURCES
ARE WITH REGARD TO IF ATTORNEY
IF WE HAVE TO AUGMENT PUBLIC
COUNCIL I THINK THE ISSUE
REALLY IS. TECHNOLOGY THE FACT
THAT CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN AS THE AUTHOR SAID
MOST ADULTS DON'T UNDERSTAND
FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT IT MEANS TO
CALL WAVE ONE'S RIGHTS AND SOUL
THE SAME POPULATION OF
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS THAT BRIDGE
BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND SEVENTEEN-
IF THEY DIDN'T WAIVE THEIR
RIGHT AND DEMANDED COUNCIL
COUNCIL BE PROVIDED TO ALL THIS
BILL IS SAYING IS. THAT THEY
SHOULD BE PROVIDED COUNSEL
BEFORE THEY ARE EXPECTED TO
WAIVE A RIGHT I DON'T THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE OF THE NEED OF
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IF THEY
ALREADY UNDERSTOOD THE PROCESS
THEY WOULD ASK FOR COUNCIL
ANYWAY AND COUNCIL WOULD HAVE
TO BE PROVIDED I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO OR THREE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NON SENATOR I'M SORRY WE HAVE
A- SENATOR GROWTH. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTION THE
AUTHOR WOULD YOU ACCEPTTHE
QUESTION FROM SENATOR GROWTH
FIVE. PLEASE FISHING. THANK YOU
MA'AM BUT THROUGH THE CHAIR
THIS IS THE AUTHOR OF GOOD THE
FLOOR JACQUI OF THE BILL
MENTIONED THAT- OUT OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND AT LEAST
TWENTY ONE PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW
AND- ONLY ONE HAD AN ATTORNEY
WAS SCOTT PETERSON. I AM
LOOKING AT STATISTICS RIGHT NOW
AND IT APPEARS TO ME THAT
EVERYONE OF THEM HAD AN
ATTORNEY- YOU KNOW DEATHROW I
MEAN THEY WERE REPRESENTED BY
AN ATTORNEY IN COURT SO I WHERE
DID YOU GET THAT DATA SIR.
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS THE REMOTES
THE MORE COURT APPOINTED SCOTT
PETERSON WAS THE ONLY ONE HERE
LEGAL. OUR PRIVATE ATTORNEY
WITH THE RESOURCES TO FIGHT A
DIFFERENT CASE. AND EXCELLING
IN YOUR STATEMENT THAT EVERY AT
EVERY INMATE ON DEATH ROW AND
ONLY ONE HAD A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY. ACCORDING TO
STATISTICS I READ THAT'S WHAT
TWO YEARS AGO. THAT WAS THE
CASE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE YOU WANTED YOU
TO. THAT STATEMENT YOU. THANK
YOU SO MELENDEZ. R. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I DON'T
DISAGREE. WITH THE PREMISE OF
THIS BILL I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
RETURNED- BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE RESULTS OF WHAT THIS
COMMISSION WAS SUPPOSED TO
STUDY- BUT I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THE NOTION THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE AND TAKE GREAT CARE
OF THE KIDS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE AGREEING TO- AND WHAT
THEY'RE BEING CHARGED WITH THE
NOT A PARENT OR GUARDIAN SHOULD
BE PRESENT ARE CERTAINLY SOME
SORT OF LEGAL COUNSEL I'M SO
FOR THOSE REASONS- I'M GOING TO
BE ABSTAINING TODAY IN THE
HOPES THAT- THIS COMMISSION
COMES BACK WITH THE INFORMATION
TO HELP PLACE- MAKE A DECISION
THAT ARE AT A LATER DATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING ON SENATOR BRADFORD YOU
MAY CLOSE MMHM. I THANK YOU AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO THIS
DISCUSSION HERE THIS IS A
SHRINK FOR MEASURE AS STATED
THERE ARE ADULTS WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO
WAIVE ONE'S RIGHTS SO. LET'S
NOT EXPECT ANYONE UNDER
EIGHTEEN TO HAVE THAT MENTAL
CAPACITY TRULY NO LEGAL SYSTEM
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S MANY OF US
HERE THAT DON'T. FULLY GRASP
ALL THAT'S INVOLVED WHEN
CONFRONTED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND ANAHEIM. WHAT YOUR RIGHTS
ARE AT THAT TIME BECAUSE MANY
TIMES YOU'RE IN A PANIC AND AS
WE JUST SAW RECENTLY ON WHEN
THEY SEE AS THE DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT THOSE KIDS THEY JUST
WANTED TO GO HOME SO I THINK
THIS IS COMMONSENSE MEASURE
WHEN YOU. UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
DEALING WITH SOMEONE UNDER
EIGHTEEN WE SHOULD PROVIDE THEM
WITH ALL THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY SO THEY CAN MAKE THE
RIGHT DECISION AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR A VOTE.
WELL DEBATE HAVE SAY. MADAM SIR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
I. ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. BELL
FIVE BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
DON. FIVE ZERO ZERO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO I JACKSON I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL FIVE MONEY.
HI NIELSEN. NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROSS. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN. NUMBER. I
Y. CASKEY FIVE WIENER I. WE
WILL BRING TO OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS ARE THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVEN S. B. TWO OH THREE
SENATOR BATES. BATES BATES S.
B. TWO OH THREE ABSTAINED. FOR
JUST. WE'RE JUST S. B. TWO ZERO
THREE HI BARGES HI CHIANG. SB
TWO OR THREE OF STAYING. DALLY
SB TWO OH THREE HI DALLY BY
GROWTH GROUP S. B. TWO OH THREE
ABSTAINED. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ SP
TO A DREAM STAYING. WARLOCK.S.
B. TWO ZERO THREE ABSTAINED
MORALE. WELL SB TOOLS NOW
MORALE NOW WILK. LOOK SP TWO OH
THREE HI WILK HI. SENATOR BIRCH
BRAD MOVES A CALL MOVING ON NOW
TO FIVE ITEM IS SENATOR WIENER
YOU PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER
AND ACTUALLY DIDN'T INVITE
MENTAL QUALITY. SENATOR WIENER
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH TRYING TO
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. HI THIS LEGISLATION IS A
TWO YEAR PILOT PROGRAM FOR A NO
COST STIMULUS THAT WILL HELP
JUMPSTART. SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION CAPITAL PROJECTS
BY GOOD AUSTRIAN LIGHT RAIL BUS
BETTER ESSENTIAL ESSENTIAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY FROM
THIS ECONOMIC COLLAPSE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF OUR
SUSTAINABLE. FUTURE WE NEED TO
GET THESE PROJECTS GOING AT A
SPEED TO RADIATE OUTSIDE IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY IT EXTENDS AN
EXISTING SYKORA. EXEMPTION
RELATING TO A BIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN EXPANDS
IT TO COVER PEDESTRIAN PROJECTS
AS WELL AS CERTAIN LIGHT RAIL.
AND BUS PROJECTS. THE BILL- IT
IS LIMITED TO EXISTING RIGHT OF
WAY IT HAS STRONG ANTI
DISPLACEMENT ANTI DEMOLITION-
PROTECTIONS IN A- IN ADDITION
THE BILL MANDATES- STRONG
COMMUNITY OUT REACH COMMUNITY
MEETINGS OR RACIAL EQUITY
ANALYSIS- AND SO FORTH IN
ADDITION FOR LARGER PROJECTS IT
ONLY WOULD BE ENCOMPASSED BY
THE BILL IT OVER ALREADY
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEARED. BY
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN
COLLEAGUES- THIS IS A GOOD BILL
IT DESERVES OUR SUPPORT WE HAVE
A HUGE COALITION BEHIND THAT I
WANT TO THANK OUR COALITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
SENATOR WIENER TO DOES WILL
START WITH CENTER Y. QUE SKI IN
I KNOW THE SENATOR JUST HAS HIS
HAND UP AS WELL SENATOR Y. QUE
GIVE YOURS PERSON I. LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING THIS BILL
AND PARTICIPATING IN DEBATE IN-
THE ENVIRONMENT CALL THE
COMMITTEE IN WE ARE. THAT GIVEN
THE- THANK CATION OUR PROCESS
HERE KOBE WE DON'T HAVE A- THE
YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE. FROM CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS TO STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS IS THAT THE
STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS YOU KNOW
CATEGORY EXEMPTIONS ARE NOT
ABSOLUTE STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS
ARE. SO THE BENEFIT OF HAVING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS IS TO INFORM DECISION
MAKERS AND WE LOSE TRACK OF
THAT YOU KNOW I. I UNDERSTAND
I'M NOT AGAINST BIKE LANES IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO IMAGINE. OTHERS
AN EXEMPTION IT APPLIES OF
ITSELF OVER HOW MILLION. WHAT
WITH THE BIKE LANE BEAT WOULD
COST A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IS BEYOND ME SO BASICALLY
EVERYTHING GETS IN AND THE
DECISION MAKERS. ARE DENIED
THAT. THAT INFORMATION THAT
OPENNESS THAT THE PUBLIC IS
THIS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE
UNDERSEA COOPER WOULD YOU SAY
YOU HAVE A CATEGORY EXEMPTION
THERE'S ALREADY STREAMLINING
THAT GOES INTO THIS. THIS FIVE
OUR SYSTEM IF YOU WANT TO
EXPAND THAT CATEGORY EXEMPTION
THAT'S A DIFFERENT THING BUT
YOU WHEN YOU SWITCH IT TO A
STATUTORY IT'S A NO LOOK. I GET
THAT IT'S LIMITED BECAUSE THIS
IN RIGHT AWAY. AS I GET THAT IT
YOU KNOW IT'S BY PLANE IT'S
APPLE AND ALL THESE THINGS BUT
I JUST REALLY HAVE A CONCERN
THAT YOU KNOW AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE
STUCK WITH THIS COVERT
SITUATION THIS IS A- DEMOCRAT
IS A DIFFERENT BILL THAT LEFT
THE FLOOR ONE HERE AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD. THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO DEVELOP IT AND THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE BUT IT THE CHAIR OF THE D.
Q. IS HAVING A SIMILAR BILL
THAT LOOKS IT FIXED RAIL AND
RIDE WAYS THAT. THE NEW ONES
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE
HAD WOULD HAVE BEEN HEALTH. A
THIS TIME I LOVE MY BIKE PEOPLE
I LOVE THE SMART STREETS AND
ALL THE AND ALL THE APPLE PIE.
BUT I STILL. I AM HESITANT AND-
CONCERNED ABOUT SWITCHING IT TO
STATUTORY EXEMPTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR Y. CASKEY ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOOR SEEING NONE WILL GO TO A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS SENATOR
BORDERS. YESTERDAY WE HAD A
ROBUST DISCUSSION ON. SYKORA
AND THEN APPARENTLY- IT'S
BLEEDING OVER INTO TODAY AS
WELL- I THINK THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY A WELL THOUGHT THROUGH.
WAY ABOVE ALLOWING. FOR MAJOR
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD.
ESPECIALLY IN A CORPORATE
ENVIRONMENT BUT I DO HAVE TO
KIND OF SPARKING BACK. WHY HE
SAID THAT WE NEED EXEMPTIONS.
WHY DO WE NEED CARVE OUTS FROM
SEQUEL UNLESS WE HAVE TO
IMPLICITLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
SEAT ONE IS. YOUR OWN
BURDENSOME IT CAN EASILY LEAD
TO LITIGATION AND CREATE
EXTRAORDINARY DIFFICULTY IN OUR
PROJECT THAT IS ESSENTIALLY FOR
THE PUBLIC GOOD. SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR TAKE
A HARD LOOK AND HAVE THE
POLITICAL WILL ENCOURAGE TO
KNOWLEDGE WE WOULDN'T BE
SEEKING EXEMPTIONS IF SEEK WHAT
WAS FUNCTIONING PROPERLY. IT'S
NOT. AND I THINK THIS IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE. OF PROJECTS
FOR A SERIES OF PROJECTS THAT
WOULD QUALIFY AND THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE SEE THAT STREAMLINING IS
AVAILABLE AND SEEK WORK WHAT A
JOKE. ANYBODY WHO SPEND ANY
TIME IN LOCAL POLITICS AT THE
CITY LEVEL COUNTY LEVEL
PLANNING COMMISSION LEVEL THEY
KNOW THAT THERE'S REALLY NO
SUCH THING. AS A FAST
EFFICIENCY WILL PROCESS IN
STREAMLINING IS IT SIMPLY A
DESCRIPTOR THAT WE USE TO MAKE
OURSELVES FEEL GOOD THAT THERE
CAN BE A FAST TRACK THERE IS NO
FASTRACK. SO I THINK IF WE HAVE
THE COURAGE IN THE NEXT CYCLE.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE ADEQUACY
OR INADEQUACY OF SEQUEL- I
THINK CALIFORNIA BE BETTER OFF
FOR IT I. WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE STAFFORD TODAY. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR JUST ON THE BILL IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE BILL. SEEING
I'M SORRY WE HAVE SENATOR BATES
CENTER BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST NEED TO WAIT
AGAIN- MY CONTINUALLY VOTE
AGAINST THE BILL STATUS REDUCE
A PARKING- WE PASSED A BILL I
BELIEVE THAT'S GOING TO
ENCOURAGE MORE PEOPLE TO HAVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES PEOPLE HAVE
CARS AND THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
A PLACE TO PARK THEM PREFERABLY
NOT ON THE STREETS THAT
SURROUND THESE HOUSING AREAS.
BECAUSE THAT IS CLEARLY A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE THAT I HAVE
BROUGHT UP CONTINUALLY BASED ON
THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT WITH CHILDREN MOVING
BETWEEN PARKED CARS SINCE
GETTING HURT OR IN A COUPLE
CASES LOSING THEIR LIVES SO I
REDUCING PARKING IS NOT THE WAY
TO GO OUR PEOPLE ARE STILL
GOING TO HAVE CARS AND WE NEED
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT. SO BE IT
BASED ON THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO REGISTER AND NOBLE INTO WE
HAVE A MORE LOGICAL APPROACH
WHAT WE DO WITH OUR CARS
BECAUSE THEY ARE PART OF OUR
LIVES AND CERTAINLY IN MANY
AREAS AND MORE THE OUTLYING
AREAS YOU YOU'RE GONNA NEED A
CAR SO WITH THAT I WILL HAVE TO
AGAIN OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
SAN DURO I HAD THE CONGRESS
WITH THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO BOB PRIMARILY MY
CONCERN AND I THINK
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE GROUND
CONCERN IS WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM PROCESSES-
NOT TECHNICALLY BUT DE FACTO
AND SO THAT WAS A CONCERN THAT
I RAISED ABOUT HOW DO OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE VOICE AND
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REALLY
IMPACT THE DECISIONS MADE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- SOME OF THE
THINGS. THAT WERE TOLD TO ME IS
THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
COMMITTEES TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
A VOICE AND REALLY IMPACT THE
OUTCOMES- AND ALSO THAT THIS IS
A PILOT- OF PILOT PROGRAM SO-
WITH THAT I WILL- SUPPORT TODAY
BUT- I THINK THE OVERALL. IT UP
ON EASY IN THIS IS ABOUT HOW
DOES THIS BREAK INTO OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE A REAL
VOICE ON THE GROUND THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR WINNER YOU MAY
CLOSE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
PRESIDENT JUST A COUPLE POINTS
AND I APPRECIATE THE DEBATE.
THE BIKE LANE EXEMPTION IS AN
EXISTING EXEMPTION WERE SIMPLY
IT'S EXTENDING ITS A PLACE. FOR
A WHILE LARGE PROJECTS WILL
HAVE TO BE ENVIRONMENTALLY
CLEARED FIVE THROUGH REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN DOUBTS THAT
WOULD PROBABLY NOT BE A BIKE
LANE PROJECT BUT OTHER BUS OR
LIGHT RAIL RELATED IF IT'S AN
EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY. THIS IS-
AS YOU NOTED FOR EVERYONE A TWO
YEAR PILOT- WE WORKED ON THIS
WITH THAT ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES WILL BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE IT- AND YOUR WHATEVER
ONE'S VIEW OF BROADER SEQUEL
ISSUES- THAT IS WHAT IT IS AND
PEOPLE CAN HAVE THAT TO BE- BUT
THIS IS PACIFIC LEAD TO
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PROJECTS. IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR AGENCY
TO DO ANYTHING IT JUST PROVIDES
THEM WITH AN ADDITIONAL TOOL-
AND THAT INCLUDES AROUND
PARKING BUT IT'S STILL A PURELY
LOCAL DECISION THIS LEGISLATION
MANDATES. ABSOLUTELY NOTHING OF
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT IS
SIMPLY A TOOL I. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I KNOW. ALL DEBATE
HAVE SEIZED MADAM. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BELL. I BRADFORD
AYE CABRERA. I DODD. I TO RAZA
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HER TADO. I JACKSON NO NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I
MONEY. I NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HAN. FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN.
UMBERG I WORK CLOSELY. WIENER
HI. PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS WHO
WERE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
BATES BABIES SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT NO EIGHT NOW FOR JUST.
WE'RE JUST SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
YES. GORGEOUS HIGH CHIANG J. S.
B. TWO EIGHTY EIGHT HI CHIANG
MAI DALLI DALLI S. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT HI DALLY HIGH GROWTH.
ROVE SP TWO EIGHT EIGHT I GROW
BY MELENDEZ WINDOWS SB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORLOCK. SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
ABSTAINED MORALE. SB EIGHT
EIGHT BY L. I. WILK. SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT HI WILK HI SEN
SENATOR WIENER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWELVE FILE ITEM TWELVE WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY THAT IS MY
MEASURE AND I'LL BE TAKING
THOSE UP IN A CLUMP INTO. A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME. ALL RIGHT-
NEXT UP THE NEXT SERIES OF
BILLS THAT WE WILL BE TAKING UP
IN THE FOLLOWING ORDER. FILE
ITEM. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND NINETEEN.
SO LET'S START WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SENATOR FURTADO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR
HER TADO AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER SENATOR FURTADO. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SB FIVE
FIVE NINE RETURNS TO HIS TO THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE SB FIVE
FIVE NINE AIMS TO ADDRESS WATER
SUPPLIED SUBSIDENCE PROBLEMS IN
THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY. BY
STUDYING THE RIPARIAN AT THE
CUMBERLAND BRYANT KERN CANAL
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS AND
DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A STUDY OF
THE CANAL AND TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE NEXT SPRING WITH A
PATHWAY FOR FUTURE INVESTMENTS
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND IS CO
AUTHORED BY THEENTIRE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY DELEGATION I
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE SENATE AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY UP WITH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS THAT. SUPPORTED
AND HELPED MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AND US YOU KNOW SPECIAL
BIG ALSO DID OUR U. S. SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY A CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION THAT ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF FIXING THIS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU XIN HER TADO
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION IN. THE CHAMBER.
SEEING NON ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. ON REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS SAYING NONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
FIVE BELL. I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I THOUGHT. I TERRAZZO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO I JACKSON WHY I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONEY. I NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO. I
SKINNER. STERN UMBERG FIVE Y.
NO WIENER HI. NOW MOVING TO OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS THIS IS
FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN SB FIVE
FIVE NINE TWO BATES. BATES
THESE SB FIVE NINE NO I MEAN
EXCUSE ME ALL RIGHT. BATES I.
FOR JUST. GORGEOUS AS FIVE FIVE
TWO ZERO STICK OUR FOR JUST
FIVE CHIANG. SB FIVE FIVE NINE
I'D CHIANG MAI DALLY DALLI S.
B. FIVE NINE FIVE DALLY HIGH
GROWTH. GRILLED SP FIVE FIVE
NINE I GROW BY MELINDA'S.
WINDOWS SB FIVE FIVE NINE AYE
MONDAY HI MORLOCK. SB FIVE NINE
NINE MOORLACH HI TOMORROW. ALL
SB FIVE FIVE NINE I MORALE HIGH.
WILK WILK SB FIVE FIVE NINE
NINE WILK HI NIELSEN. HI
NIELSEN NO TO. SAID WIENER MOVE
TO CALL WE'RE EXCUSE ME CENTER
HEARD MOVES A CO MY PA NEXT UP
IS SENATOR WE- FILE ITEM FORTY
SB FIVE NINETY TWO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY TWO BY SENATOR
WIENER AN ACT RELATING TO
JURIES SENATOR WIENER. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR. SB
FIVE NINETY TWO- IT IS-
LEGISLATION- TO ENSURE. THAT
OUR- OUR JURIES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. HI RIGHT
NOW WHEN WE PICK JURIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE DRAW FROM A POOL
THAT IS LIMITED. TO THE DMV.
OUR RECORDS AS WELL AS VOTER
REGISTRATION FILES. DOT IS NOT
BROAD ENOUGH. AND IT EXCLUDES A
LOT OF PEOPLE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A DRIVER'S LICENSE IF YOU'RE
NOT REGISTERED TO VOTE YOU WILL
NEVER GET CALLED FOR JURY DUTY
AS WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY.
THE POLICING IS TO STOP ONE OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM YOU
CAN. GO TO COURT. AND WE RELY
ON OUR JURY SYSTEM TO PROVIDE A
JURY OF ONE'S PEERS. AND RIGHT
NOW THAT IS OFTEN NOT HAPPENING
IN CALIFORNIA JURIES ARE
WHITER. AND WEALTHIER- THAN THE
COMMUNITY. AT LARGE. AND SB
FIVE NINETY WILL CHANGE THAT.
BY SAYING THAT IN ADDITION TO
DRAWING JURY POOLS. ARE FROM
DMV AND VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASES WE WILL ALSO USE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TAXPAYER.
ARE ROLES THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY BROADEN NOW- THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE FROM WHICH FROM
HOME WE- ARE DRAW OUR JURIES IT
WILL RESULT IN MORE DIVERSE-
JURIES. AND THIS IS A BILL
WHOSE TIME HAS COME- I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS NOT.
THE FIRST TIME- DIED WE HAVE A-
CONSIDERED- THIS IDEA THIS IS
IDEA I KNOW SENATOR SKINNER HAD
AS PART OF ONE OF HER- PIECES
OF LEGISLATION IN THE PAST- I
THINK OTHERS HAVE. INCLUDED IT
WITH OTHER- IDEAS AND BILLS AND
IT'S ALWAYS GOTTEN STRIPPED OUT
AND APPROPRIATIONS ALL THIS
YEAR- WE DID AS A STANDALONE
BILL. WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. THE BILL HAS
BROAD SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPO. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR. FAISAL
THANK YOU AT A PRESS. Y. ABOUT
THIS YES INCREASE THE POOL OF
ELIGIBLE JURORS AND I THINK
THIS BILL. GOES A LONG WAY TO
ADDED TO THAT IT'S OF COURSE SO
THERE'S MORE THAT WE CAN DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT- EVERYONE. IN
OUR SOCIETY HAS EQUAL ACCESS TO
THAT- BUT IN THE SPIRIT OF. THE
INTENT WITH HIS BILLS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IS GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK WE ALL
SHOULD SUPPORT IT. WHY WHY
SHOULD WE NOT SUPPORT. ALLOWING
MORE PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCESS OF MAKING SURE OUR
JURIES ARE TRULY REPRESENTED OF
SOCIETY THIS IS A GREAT BILL I
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR. ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING NO
HANDS NOPE WE HAVE SENATOR MORE
LOCK- IN THE REMOTE.
PARTICIPATION AREA CENTER MORE
LOCKED THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SO ONE OF
THE CONCERNS WE WERE WORKING ON
THIS YEAR AND SORT OF GOT
BOUNCED OUT WITH THAT WHAT
WOULD NINETEEN WAS. THAT WHEN
THE REGISTERED VOTERS IS USED
AS A SOURCE FOR POTENTIAL
JURORS SOMETIMES THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. INFORMED THE CLERK
OF THE COURT THAT THEY CANNOT
SERVE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
CITIZENS. AND SO I'M- WONDERING
IF IN THIS BILL THERE'S MAYBE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAN THAT.
UP SO THAT WE- I HAVE VOTER
ROLLS THAT ARE. PROPERLY
UPDATED ANTHOLOGIZED MY LUNCH
JUST DIRECTORS BY MY- BARBERING
BUT I MAYBE THE AUTHOR CAN JUST
CLARIFY THAT IS CLOSE THE
REMARKS. PERHAPS IN YOUR
CLOTHES CENTER WIENER BUT WE
ALSO ARE ANYTHING FURTHER
CENTER MORE LOCKED. IT TOO
MANAGER THANK YOU VERY GOOD
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KING A MAN
PRESENT THANK YOU. SIX YEARS
AGO I RAN A BILL THAT WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED LEGAL RESIDENTS
PEOPLE WITH GREEN CARDS- TO
PARTICIPATE IN INJURIES
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS VETOED
BY THEN GOVERNOR BROWN- FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO TALKS
ABOUT INCREASING THE POOL TODAY
IN CALIFORNIA. OVER 90% OF OUR
RESIDENTS ARE LEGAL RESIDENTS
THAT DON'T HAVE U. S.
CITIZENSHIP SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY IT'S
ALL TO MY- CHAU MY CARDS A
LITTLE BIT OF A LEGISLATION I
HOPE TO BE RUNNING NEXT YEAR
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE JURY POOL
TO LEGAL RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO MEET ALL THE
OTHER QUALIFICATIONS THAT ARE
SET FORTH IN S. B. FIVE NINE
TWO THAT DEBATE HAS HAPPEN
IT'LL HAPPEN AGAIN. THANK YOU
NO O. I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES OR HANDS UP CENTER
WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK
YOU INTO THE- CENTER FROM-
FREMONT I THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND OF COURSE THE BILL BEFORE
US TODAY- IS ABOUT. PEOPLE WHO
ARE CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY
WHO ARE NOT GETTING CALLED UP
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ON ANY OF
THE LIMITED DATABASES THAT ARE
BEING USED- IN TERMS OF NON
CITIZENS AND BY THE CENTER FOR
ORANGE COUNTY IS- QUESTIONS ON
THE JURY- VENEER PROCESS
ALREADY HAS A FAIL SAFE TO
REMOVE- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
CITIZENS WHO OR WHO ARE
OTHERWISE INELIGIBLE FOR JURY
SERVICE. THAT ALREADY EXISTS
THIS WILL NOT CHANGE THAT
PROCESS AND SO THAT SHOULD NOT
BE AN ISSUE AT ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL THE BAIT
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BELL. FIVE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I DODD. I THEY'RE
AWESOME I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO. I
JACKSON HI I LEYVA. I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN. I
CAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. FIVE
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER STERN HI
I'M BURKE. I WHITE HOUSE STEVE
AYE WIENER I. SENATOR WE'VE
REMOVED THE CALL. I'M SORRY
BETTER PRICES ARE REMOVED
VOTING PART FORGET BE REMOTE
VOTING. START WITH THE SENATOR
BATES SB FIVE NINETY TWO. BATES.
AS SB FIVE NINETY TWO NO EIGHT
NOW FOR JUST WE'RE JUST SB FIVE
NINE TWO ABSTAINED. CHIANG HEY
SB FIVE NINETY THAT STAYING.
DALLY NEXT. YOU'RE ON MUTE
JANITOR DOLLY WE CAN'T HEAR YOU.
L. A. S. B. FIVE NINE TWO NO.
AGROVET SB FIVE NINETY YOU KNOW
GROVE NO MELENDEZ MELENDEZ SB
FIVE NINE TWO NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. ORLOK SB FIVE NINE
TWO ABSTAINED. MORALE. SB FIVE
NINE TWO BILLS MORRELL NO WILK.
WILK SB FIVE NINETY TWO AT THE
STATE. SENATOR PER WIENER MOVES
THEY CALL A SENATOR MCGUIRE DO
YOU WISH TO TAKE UP YOUR TWO
ITEMS. ALL RIGHT WE WILL START
TO A WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO FIRST. WOULD BE ALRIGHT
IF WE GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE NAM. VERY GOOD WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
THRILLS I MEAN THEY'RE BAD BUT
THEY'RE NOT. EXCEEDED WORLDWIDE
THREE COME SOMEBODY IS NOT ON
MUTE. SENATOR GROVE- WE CAN
HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE
GOING BACK TO FILE ITEM THREE.
SB SIXTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS AND
DECLARING THEIR TO SEE THEIR OF
STICK AFFECT MEDIALLY. SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS- SB SIXTY SEVEN IS A
TRUTH IN LABELING BILL THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR LICENSE
GROWERS TO ESTABLISH
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN FOR
CANNABIS. BY JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPELLATIONS
OF ORIGIN STANDARDS EXIST TODAY
FOR THE WINE INDUSTRY DIFFERENT
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN GROWING
REGIONS BUT NOT CURRENTLY FOR
CANNABIS. SIXTY SEVEN- CLARIFY
THAT APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN CAN
ONLY BE USED FOR CANNABIS PLANT
IN THE GROUND IN OPEN AIR WITH
NO USE OF ARTIFICIAL LIGHT
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL
ALSO ADD MARKING PROTECTIONS.
FOR CITIES OF ORIGIN THAT NEAR
EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR
COUNTIES OF ORIGIN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR GUARD DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM IS
ARE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION IN
THE CHAMBER. CHIGNON IS FOR ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION REMOTELY.
SEEING NONE BETTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- I DON.
I TORONTO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. I HILL I
HUESO. HI HER TADO I JACKSON. I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN HI TAM. FIVE
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER STERN HI NUMBER.
FIVE LAKE COUNTY I WIENER. HI
LET'S PLEASED TO THE REMOTE
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE
SB SIXTY SEVEN SENATOR BATES.
BATES AS SB SIXTY SEVEN HIGH
BATES HI GORGEOUS. SB SIX SEVEN
ABSTAINED CHIANG CHIANG SB
SIXTY SEVEN I'D CHIANG MAI
DELHI DALLI SB SIX SEVEN HI
SALLY HI. GROWTH I'M SB SIX
SEVEN ABSTAINED. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ SB SIX SEVEN ON
MONDAYS HI MORE LOST. SB SIXTY
SEVEN HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
SB SIXTY SEVEN ABSTAINED. WILK.
SB SIXTY SEVEN HI WILK HI.
SENATOR MCGUIRE MOVES A CALL
THAT WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SB SIX
TWENTY NINE COLLEAGUES SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MATTER
PRESIDENTE ABRASIVES IN PRISON
SB SIX TWENTY NINE WHICH IS THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS ACT WHICH
WILL ENSURE THAT JOURNALISTS
ARE PROTECTED AS THEY ATTEND
DEMONSTRATIONS AND MARCHES
PROTESTS AND RALLIES ALL FIRST
AMENDMENT BY PROHIBITING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS FROM
INTENTIONALLY OBSTRUCTING
DETAINING ASSAULTING OR
OTHERWISE PREVENTING THE PRESS
FROM FULFILLING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE IN
REPORTING ON THESE FIRST
AMENDMENT EVENTS. SB SIX TWENTY
NINE WORKS IN CRUCIAL
PROTECTIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS AS THE INTERN REPORT ON
THESE INCIDENTS THIS BILL
SUPPORTED OF COURSE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION THE COMPANIES
PUBLISH NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION ETHNIC MEDIA
SERVICES BECOME REPORTERS
COMMITTING A STILL YOU WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
CERNEY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THE FLOOR. SHE NON IN THE- IN
INDIA A BACKYARD THERE WE'VE
GOT SENATOR MORRELL FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR BORCHERS SENATOR
MORRELL. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST HAD A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR AUTHOR WOULD YOU
ACCEPT THE QUESTION CENTER
MCGUIRE OF COURSE THINKING
WITHOUT OBJECTION PLEASE
PROCEED. YEAH YES I THOUGHT I
READ IN THE ANALYSIS AND I JUST
WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK WITH YOU
WILL THE PRESS BE ALLOWED TO
CROSS THE POLICE LINE. THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO OPERATE BEHIND
THE POLICE LINE UP BUT A
SUPERIOR AND MANAGEMENT
OFFICIAL WITHIN. SHERIFF'S
OFFICE EACH FEE AND OR LOCAL
MUNICIPAL POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WOULD BE ABLE TO ASK THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO NOT BE THERE
INDOOR FORCIBLY REMOVED IF
THERE IS DANGER AT THE TIME.
BUT BUILT OKAY. THIS STORY HAS
A DOUBLE MEANING- NO MILITARY
CLASS AND. HOW CAN THEY CROSS
POLICE LINES MY QUESTION CAN IS
WHAT I UNDERSTAND.OKAY THANKS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT UP WE
HAVE A SENATOR BORCHERS FROM
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPATION
SENATOR BOARD JUST. THANK YOU
MARY- POSE A QUESTION FOR YOU
BETTER PRESIDENT TO THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
SENATOR MCGUIRE YES MA'AM GOOD
MORNING CENTER WERE JUST.
PLEASE MORNING- I THINK MY-
COLLEAGUE A MOMENT AGO ASKED
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I WAS
GOING TO POSE BUT THE
DEFINITION OF A REPORTER. I
THINK- SEEMS LIKE EVERY TOM
DICK AND HARRY- PUTS ON SOME
SORT OF BADGE INSTEAD IS THAT
BIGGER MEDIA WHEN THEY HAD
SIMPLY HAVE A FACEBOOK PAGE- IS
THERE. IS THIS PROPERLY
DELINEATED IN IN A WAY THAT
WOULD ONLY ALLOW FOR-
RECOGNIZABLE IN OBJECTIVE. NEWS
OUTLETS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTREBOARD JUST. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL MEDIA
OUTLETS SO WHAT THE BILL DOES
THE BILL LANGUAGE- ALLOWS FOR
DULY AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE
THE PRESS WHICH IS ALREADY IN
PENAL CODE RIGHT NOW FOUR OH
NINE POINT FIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE- CONTAIN BUT
WHAT WE DO IS WE HELP REFINE
IT. SO WHAT WE SAY IN THIS BILL
NOW IS. YOUR IDENTIFIED NUMBER
THE PRESS THE ENHANCED
DEFINITION OF PROFESSIONAL
BROADCASTING EQUIPMENT AND OR
ID THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
AN INDIVIDUAL LAUNCH FOR SPIRE
REQUESTED. SO YOU'VE YOU'VE
TRIED TO GIVE IT THE AIR OF
FORMALITY BUT IT'S DIFFICULT TO
NARROW IT DOWN. BECAUSE EVEN IF
SOMEBODY HAS A HUNDRED FACEBOOK
FOLLOWERS THEY COULD PUT
THEMSELVES OUT THERE AS BEING A
NEWS OUTLET. SO IS THAT IN HERE
TO SAY THIS IS THE LAST
QUESTION WE'RE NOT ENGAGING IN
COLLOQUY HERE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT OR PERHAPS IN
YOUR CLOTHES OF COURSE I'D BE
HAPPY TO RESPOND ANY GAINS AND
WE'RE JUST THANK YOU FOR THESE
QUESTIONS AND I THINK THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD QUESTIONS.
THAT WE LIVE IN AN ERA NOW
WHERE IF YOU WORK FOR ABC NEWS
OR SEEN IN OR FOX NEWS OR YOU
WORK FOR THE SACRAMENTO BEE OR
LA TIMES THE NEW YORK TIMES. A
REPORTERS CARRYING THEIR IPHONE
OR ANDROID TO BE ABLE TO RECORD
BOTH ON FACEBOOK LIVE WHETHER
IT'S FOR THE OUTLET'S FACEBOOK
PAGE AND OR TO BE ABLE TO
STREAM ON THEIR OWN TWITTER
FEED. THAT WE SEE THAT ALL THE
TIME SO WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
IN THE BILL IS THAT WHILE THERE
IS NO CURRENT DEFINITION OF A
DULY AUTHORIZED MEMBER THE
PRESS IN LAW TODAY. EVERY
PERSON THAT'S LISTED IN THE
BILL'S DEFINITION BE CONSIDERED
A DULY AUTHORIZED OVER THE
MEDIA AND PRACTICE IN THE FIELD
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE
CARRYING WE REFINANCED BY
SAYING YOU'RE CARRYING
PROFESSIONAL BROADCASTING
EQUIPMENT OR HAVE THAT. IDEA
AVAILABLE- YOU WOULD BE
PRESS BUT WE'RE LIVING IN SUCH
TIMES NOW JUST BEING VERY
HONEST ABOUT IT AND WE SEEN
THIS IS THAT- MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA THEIR MOST POWERFUL TOOL
THAT THEY HAVE IS. THEIR PHONE
THAT'S IN THEIR BACK POCKET.
THANK YOU I THINK. I THINK.
YOU'RE EFFORTS AT DECISION OR
COMMIT THERE ARE SOME CRACKED.
CONCERNS THAT I WOULD HAVE.
ONLY BECAUSE WINNING FOREIGN
CORRESPONDENT FOR EXAMPLE IS
EMBEDDED WITH THE MILITARY.
THEY ASSUME A DEGREE OF RISK
ACTUALLY THE USE OF ALL THE
RISKS THE MILITARY IS NOT UNDER
AN OBLIGATION AS FAR AS I'M
AWARE OF PROVIDING PROTECTION
ARE ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD NORMALLY
OUT OF ALLOW HERE IF. MEMBERS
OF THE PRESS AND BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH A NEBULOUS. CONCEPT ON
WHAT EXACTLY A PRESS OUTLETS
IS. THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD
BE FORCED TO ALLOW ACCESS TO A
NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT. PROBABLY
COULD BE QUESTIONABLE WHETHER
NOT THERE ACTUALLY- JOURNALISTS
OR MEMBERS OF THE PRESS SO
YOU'RE ASKING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TO ECOR BREAK THEM INTO AN
UNSTABLE ENVIRONMENT. ON FIRST
AMENDMENT GROUNDS WHICH I THINK
IS ADMIRABLE BUT FROM PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT IT AREN'T YOU
PUTTING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ALL
IN THIS WOULD BE MY OPINION I
THINK WE'RE PUTTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN A REALLY
DIFFICULT POSITION HERE AND
WHAT IT COULD BE EXACERBATING
ABOLISHED FILE. AND FLUID
DYNAMIC ENVIRONMENT AND I THINK
THE EFFORT IS IN THE RIGHT
TRACK I JUST THINK THAT YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT THE OPPOSITION.
AND I SUSPECT THAT THEY ARE OF
THE OPINION THAT YOU'RE ASKING
THEM TO OPEN UP. AN ILL DEFINED
GROUP OF FOLKS WHO MAY VERY
WELL MISS REPRESENT THEMSELVES
INCREASE EVEN MORE HAVOC SO
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A TOUGH
ISSUE BUT I COMMEND THE EFFORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE SENATOR
MCGUIRE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH MANY PRESIDENT INTO
GRATEFUL TO SIT AROUND AND AS
WELL AS CENTER BRIDGES FOR THE
QUESTION AND THE DISCUSSION
HERE TODAY. HERE'S THE BOTTOM
LINE AT THIS BILL WE WORKED
WITH THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY TO BE ABLE TAKE
THREE SIGNIFICANT EVENTS NUMBER
ONE WE GOT RID OF THE
PRESUMPTION NUMBER TWO WE GOT
RID OF THE MISDEMEANOR. NUMBER
THREE WE GOT RID OF THE
FINANCIAL PENALTY AND HERE'S
WHAT I'LL SAY. IS THAT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE SIMPLY EXTENDING THE
STATUTE THAT EXISTS IN STATE
LAW TODAY FOR JOURNALISTS
DURING TIMES OF NATURAL
DISASTER AND WE EXTEND IT TO
FIRST AMENDMENT EVENTS THIS IS
JACKET THAT IS ALREADY IN LAW.
IN BY THE WAY REPORTERS ARE
ALREADY HAVING TO BE ABLE TO
FACE THIS COVERING THESE FIRST
AMENDMENTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
REPORTERS FIVE HUNDRED
REPORTERS JOURNALISTS THIS YEAR
ALONE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAVE EITHER BEEN
DETAINED AND OR ASSAULTED.
WHILE COVERING THESE FIRST AND
INDEPENDENCE IN IT HAS TO STOP
THIS IS A BALANCED APPROACH A
MODERN APPROACH THAT WE PROTECT
OUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND
ALLOW THE PRESIDENT TO DO THEIR
JOB AND HOLDING ALL OF US IN. A
IN GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ALL HAVING. MADAM SIR.
PLEASE THE ROLL. ALLEN HI I.
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I FELL. FIVE
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO. DODD I
DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO. HI JACKSON
FIVE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER STERN I AM
BURKE. BY CASKEY. I WIENER.
FIVE ARCHULETA HI. ALL RIGHT
MOVING NOW TO THE REMOTE
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN SB SIX TWENTY NINE
SENATOR BATES. BATES EIGHT SB
SIX TWENTY NINE AM ST. FOR JUST
WE'RE JUST SB SIX TWO NINE AM
STAYING. CHIANG THANK SB SIX TO
NINE I CHIANG FIVE BELLY. SB
SIX TO NINE OF STATE. GROVE. SB
SIX TO NINE KNOW GROVE NO
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ SB SIX TO
NINE AND- WE NEED TO HEAR YOU
SAY THAT AGAIN SENATOR
MELINDA'S WE LOST YOU AS YOU
WERE VOTING. MELENDEZ SB SIX TO
NINE ABSTAINED THANK YOU.
MORLOCK SB SIX TO NINE
ABSTAINED MOREAU. IN SENATOR
MARCO MORALE WE CAN'T AREAS
YOUR MUTE. I CAN'T HEAR YOU
OKAY. HERE WE GOT YOUR. SB SIX
TWENTY NINE NOW L. NO. WILK. SB
SIX TWENTY NINE HI WILK HI ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE SENATOR MELINDA
IS YOUR HAND IS UP FOR WHAT
PURPOSE MA'AM. AT YES MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE- IRATE I
NOTICED THAT WHILE WE WERE
DISCUSSING A LAST BILL PRIOR TO
YOU GOING TO REPUBLICAN SENATOR
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A ROLL
CALL IF YOU JUST WAIT UNTIL WE
CONCLUDE THE ROLL CALL OF WILL
RECOGNIZE YOU AT THAT POINT IN
TIME SO WE HAVE OF. THE VOTE.
AND THE SENATOR MCGUIRE MOVES A
CALL FIGHT SENATOR MELINDA IS
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR WAIT TIME
ON THE SCREEN THANK YOU I'M
JUST A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE I NOTED THAT DURING
THE LAST BILL WOULD BE PRIOR TO
YOU GOING TO THE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY YOUR REFERENCE WAS NOW
WE WILL GO TO THE BACKYARD- I
TAKE ISSUE WITH THAT AND I FIND
THAT AND SOMETHING I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU REFRAIN FROM REFERRING
TO REPUBLICAN MEMBERS. WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY NOT
BECAUSE WE CHOSE TO BUT BECAUSE
WE'RE FORCED YOU TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE EQUAL MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY AND WE ARE DEFINITELY
NOT IN THE BACKYARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER MELINDA'S
THERE WAS NO NEGATIVE INTENTA I
WAS JUST TRYING TO KEEP IT
LIGHT I WILL MAKE NOTE HEN WILL
REFRAIN FROM WHAT MS PERHAPS MY
PORTIONS OF HUMOR GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. RIGHT.
CALLING WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE ONE OF
OUR GREAT PARTNERS. IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WHO IS
ABOUT TO RETIRE I WILL TRY I
WILL NOT MAKE ANY JOKES ABOUT
THAT FOR FEAR OF OFFENDING
ANYONE- BUT WE HAVE WITH US IN
THE BACK OF THE WHOLE OF OUR
ARMED THREE PARTNER DIANE
BORDER VINE WHO HAS MADE THE
DECISION TO GO QUIETLY INTO THE-
INTO THE NIGHT. WE WILL MISS
HER DEARLY AND WE WILL START
OUR- REPROGRAM- WITH OUR PRO
TEM SENATOR ATKINS. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND NOW BEFORE
I GET STARTED ON SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT OUR INCREDIBLE OF COUNSEL
LET ME OUT RECOGNIZE THAT SHE
HAS SOME FAMILY IN THE GALLERY
WITH US TODAY HER HUSBAND
HAIRY. OPERA TRICIA HER SISTER.
DAUGHTERS ANGELA AND JENNY WITH
THEIR HUSBANDS AND CHILDREN AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT HER SON JACK
IS WATCHING- FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FAMILY. I
ESPECIALLY IS WHERE THEY'LL END
OF SESSION AND WE KNOW HOW MUCH
OF A FAMILY PROBABLY MISSES US
AT- THIS TIME. SO IF WE COULD
PERHAPS AROUND REPLIES WE KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS. WE
APPRECIATE THEIR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT MADAM
PRESIDENT- THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF FAMILIES IS IMPORTANT. AT
THE END OF SESSION THE FOUR
LEADERS IN BOTH HOUSES ALWAYS
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK OF
DIANE BOYER VINE AND HER
INCREDIBLE TEAM. BECAUSE THIS
IS THE TIME OF YEAR WHEN
THEY'RE AMAZING ABILITY AND
EFFORT ARE PROBABLY MOST IN
FOCUS. SEND OF SESSION WE RISE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL NOT ONLY FOR HER
AMAZING ABILITY AND EFFORT THIS
YEAR. BUT ALSO FOR THE ENTIRE
CAREER SHE IS BRINGING TO A
CLOSE HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU MADAM COUNCIL FOR
ALWAYS GIVING US THE ANSWERS
AND ADVICE WE NEEDED. NOT
NECESSARILY THE ONES WE WANTED
ARE THE ONES WE THOUGHT WE
SHOULD HAVE. IN THE TIME WE
HAVE I WANT TO FOCUS ON
SOMETHING THAT I AM
PARTICULARLY GRATEFUL TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR HER-
BEING PART OF AND THAT IS THE
EFFORT TO CHANGE THE CLIMATE I
THIS CAPITAL AND CREATE A
WORKPLACE THAT IS SAFE AND
RESPECTFUL. FOR ALL. WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS AN ASPIRATIONAL
GOAL WE KNOW THE PROBLEMS WILL
BE SOLVED BY THE TIME THE%
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL LEAVES OR
MAYBE NOT EVEN BY THE TIME SOME
OF US LEAVE. BUT WE ARE ON THE
PATH AND DIANE BOY LEVINE
HELPED US GET THERE. AND WHEN
THAT GOAL IS ACHIEVED I HOPE
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
ONCE AGAIN HONOR DIANE BOY
VYING FOR HER IMPORTANT ROLE IN
THAT. NOW I SANDERS I AM BY
DIANE RETIRING. I'VE TRIED TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF FUN THIS
WEEK I KEEP EMAILING HER WITH
FAKE CHALLENGES TO MAKE THIS
LAST YEAR LOOK EASY BY
COMPARISON. HERE'S JUST A
COUPLE. IT TURNS OUT ONE OF OUR
SENATORS MAY ACTUALLY BE A
GIANT BATTERY POWERED BY THE
RABBIT. DOES THAT IMPACT HIS
ABILITY TO VOTE. HEY THIS WEEK
WE PASSED THE BILL THAT WAS
NEVER FORMALLY INTRODUCED.
GUESS WHICH ONE. I THINK I MAY
HAVE ACCIDENTALLY ADJOURN FOR
THE YEAR CAN YOU CHECK THE TAPE
AND LET ME KNOW. I AND YOU ONLY
HAVE A FEW MINUTES TO LET US
KNOW. AND OF COURSE THE LAST
ONE FORMER PRESIDENT PRO TEM
BURTON HAD A MESSAGE HE WANTED
ME TO DELIVER WITH YOU TO YOU
TODAY. AND TO SHARE BUT I JUST
CAN'T EITHER OF THOSE WORDS ON
THE MIKE. NOW WHEN I'VE ASKED
THESE QUESTIONS OF OUR- MADAM
COUNCIL ALL I GET IN RESPONSE
NOW IS HER OUT OF OFFICE
MESSAGE. SO I HOPE YOU
UNDERSTAND I'M I'M HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF FUN AND LAUGH AND
THROUGH SOME OF THE EMOTION AND
THE TEARS WE MIGHT SHED. BUT I
DO WANT TO SAY DIANNE
PERSONALLY I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIRELESS THOUGHTFUL
COMMITMENT TO THE LAW TO THE
STATE. TO THIS LEGISLATURE. A
SPECIALLY IN THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AND AS
SOMEONE WHO WORKED WITH YOU AS
THE SPEAKER AND NOW IS THE PRO
TEM I WANT TO TELL YOU HOW MUCH
EASIER. YOU'VE MADE MY JOB
BECAUSE MY FAITH AND TRUST IN
YOU. I HAVE BEEN SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PARTICULARLY NOW. SO
THE CAPITAL IS GOING TO MISS
YOU WHEN YOU LEAVE AT THE END
OF SEPTEMBER BUT YOU HAVE OUR
BEST WISHES. AND OUR THANKS AND
I KNOW MADAM PRESIDENT THAT ARE
REPUBLICAN LEADER PROBABLY
WANTS TO KICK OFF AND SAY A FEW
WORDS AS WELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM WILL NOW MOVE TO THE-
OF MINORITY LEADER. SENATOR
GROVE THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU KNOW IT
IS AND WITH DEEP SADNESS REALLY
THAT- I RECEIVED A PHONE CALL
AWHILE BACK FROM MISPLAY ARE
VYING IS TELLING ME THAT HER
INTENTIONS TO RETIRE AT THE END
OF SESSION AND THEN THERE'S NOT
VERY MANY PEOPLE IN THE CAPITAL
DOTSON WAS ONE AND OBVIOUSLY
BERNIE IS **** AT THERE'S NOT
VERY MANY PEOPLE IN THE CAPITAL
WHERE YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH SOMEONE WHO. YOU
REALLY FEEL THAT HAS YOUR BEST
INTEREST- AND I THINK THE
SENATE PRO TEMP FEELS LIKE SHE
HAS HER BEST INTERESTS AND
THAT'S NEUTRAL THAT REALLY HAS
OUR BEST INTEREST AT HEART AS
**** INDIVIDUALS AND RESPECTED
DIFFERENT PARTIES- AND I AM BY
YOUR MIND IS ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE I CAN TELL YOU WHEN I
FIRST BECAME A LEADER AND I WAS
ON THE RULES COMMITTEE- IN
THANKS TO MISS LINDA IS GETTING
A BILL PASSED THAT ALLOWED- THE
WHISTLEBLOWER ACT TO TAKE PLACE
WHICH- HAD THE SENATE PRO TEM
COURAGEOUSLY. PUT FORTH THE
WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT AND TO
PUT EVERYTHING IN PLACE AT THAT
ENTAILED I THINK THAT TO DIANE
BOYER BYNES'S DESK WENT FROM
PROBABLY VERY CLEAN AND NEEDY A
VERY NEAT- AND CLEAN TO- STACKS
AND STACKS AND STACKS AND
STACKS OF PAPERS EVERYWHERE AS
SHE DECIPHERED THROUGH. OLD
POLICIES. TEACHERS AND HIRING
OLD. IN THE PROCESS. OF FOR
FILING COMPLAINTS. AND THEN RE
INSTITUTING AND WORKING WITH
MISS CONTRAST TO RE INSTITUTE
AND PUT IN THE- FORM IN POLICY
FORM AND IN WRITING. BUT WHAT
MOST EMPLOYERS ARE ALL THE
PLAYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REQUIRED TO DO. AND
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE FOR
COMPLAINT FILING HAVE A PROCESS
IN PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO FILE
COMPLAINTS AGAINST LEGISLATORS
OREGON STAFF. FOR AN UNSAFE
WORKPLACE- A HOSTILE WORKPLACE.
AND I THINK THAT- THAT TOOK
COURAGE FROM NOT ONLY THE
SENATE PRO TEM BUT- ALSO- TO
PUT THAT TOGETHER BUT- I AM
WHERE MINES TO LEAD THAT CHARGE
AND THEN. AND THEN PUT THOSE
POLICIES IN PLACE OF IT MISS
MELINDA'S THIS BILL COULD COME
TO ITS FULL FOR WISHIN AND MAKE
SURE THAT WOMEN IN THE CAPITOL
WERE. PROTECTED IT'S JUST BEEN
A PLEASURE AND AN HONOR TO WORK
WITH YOU. YOU ARE BY FAR ABOVE
REPROACH IN INTEGRITY AND YOU
ARE BY FAR ABOVE REPROACH IN
THEM. QUALITY OF WORK AND NOW
WE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND ON
BEHALF OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
WE THANK YOU FOR. AND ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE TO HELP US THROUGH
THESE- TWO YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
LEADER. AND EVEN OVER IN THE
ASSEMBLY BUT- GOD BLESS YOU WE
WISH YOU EVERYTHING THAT GOD
HAS FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND
IN THIS NEW LEGACY OR THIS NEW
PORTION OF LIFE THAT YOU'RE
ABOUT READY TO ENTER. AND NOW
WE WILL DEEPLY MISS YOU I'M NOT
SURE YOU WILL MISS US. BUT WE
WILL DEEPLY MISS U. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW. MONNING THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT WELL IT'S MY
HONOR IS WELL TO JOIN IN THIS
TRIBUTE AND THANKS TO OUR CHIEF
COUNSEL OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
BOTH HOUSES I THINK MANY OF US
HAVE SENATORS WERE BEFORE IN
THE ASSEMBLY I'VE HAD OCCASION
TO BE HELPED BY. DIANNE BOYER
VINE INDIVIDUALLY FOR QUESTIONS
ARISING IN OUR OFFICES ARE
DISTRICTS. I'VE HAD THE HONOR
IS A MEMBER OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. TO WORK DIRECTLY
WITH DIANE AND HER SHAPING IN.
PIONEERING OF THE WORKPLACE
CONDUCT UNIT TE PRO TEM AND
MINORITY LEADER ALLUDED TO.
THIS HAS REALLY BEEN PIONEERING
WORK AND IT HAS LED AND IS
LEADING TO A CULTURE CHANGE. IN
THIS INSTITUTION AND YOU'VE
VERY MUCH CARRY THAT LEGACY FOR
WHICH WE THANK YOU IN. IT'S
INDEED MY HONOR ON BEHALF OF
THE PRO TEM IN THE MINORITY
LEADER ON BEHALF OF THE VICE
CHAIR OF RULES SENATOR WILK ON
BEHALF OF OUR SECRETARY ERICA
CONTRARIS AND I KNOW ON BEHALF
OF EVERY MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MY
HONOR TO PRESENT YOU WITH THIS.
KOKAN OF OUR APPRECIATION AND
TO WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN
RETIREMENT AND WE STILL HAVE
YOU ON SPEED DIAL SO YOU BETTER
CHANGE YOUR PHONE NUMBER OR
WE'RE GOING TO TRACK YOU DOWN
WITH FURTHER QUESTIONS. BUT
PLEASE JOIN ME MEMBERS AND
THANKING. I AM. WE WILL GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
BUT THERE'S STILL A FEW OF US
WHO WANT TO CONTINUE- WITH THE
ACCOLADES AND WE WILL GO ON TO-
SENATOR FOR ITS BURKE. THANK
VERY MUCH BETTER PRESENT JUST
VERY BRIEFLY ON ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT OF THE
PROTAGONISTS. SUTTER MINING AND
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT. YOU KNOW
I HAPPEN TO BE DECADES AGO PART
OF THAT PROCESS WAS CENTER
BURTON. AND IT'S JUST
EXTRAORDINARY NO I WAS ON THE
PHONE AND- LATE NIGHTS WITH
FOLKS FROM YOUR STAFF AND- IT'S
EVERY LAW THAT'S WRITTEN COMES
OUT OF YOUR SHOP EVERY SUBJECT
MATTER THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH YOU HAVE TO CREATE. A
THOUSAND THOUSANDS OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR
OFFICE TO DEAL WITH IN THE
CALLS LATE AT NIGHT. I DON'T
KNOW ANY LAW FOR ANYBODY THAT
DEALS WITH THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE ARRAY OF ISSUES. THAT YOU
DEAL WITH SO APPROPRIATELY AND
JUST. AND RESPONSIBLY TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN IS AS CENTER MONNING
SAID. REYES WANTED TO JOIN IN
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR EXTRAORDINARY DEDICATION.
AND INVISIBLE HISTORY THAT YOU
HAVE CONTRIBUTED. TO CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. SENATOR LEYVA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. DIANNE
LAWYER VINE WHAT A CLASS ACT
WHEN I HEARD THAT YOU WERE
RETIRING I SAID NO. I DON'T
KNOW WH REPLACE YOU YOU ARE
SMART YOU ARE HARD WORKING AND
ALL JUST WITH A POOR QUIET
CLASS ABOUT YOU. AREN'T TRULY I
DON'T KNOW WHO WILL FILL YOUR
SHOES BUT I THANK YOU FOR MY
TIME HERE I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEND FOUR YEARS ON RULES
WITH YOU. YOU ALWAYS HAD THE
ANSWER FOR US AND IF YOU DIDN'T
YOU SAID LET ME FIND OUT AND
YOU ALWAYS GOT BACK WAS
PROMPTLY I HAVE APPRECIATED YOU
SO MUCH IN THE SIX YEARS I'VE
BEEN HERE. GO ON TO RETIREMENT
WE ARE SORRY TO SEE YOU GO BUT
YOU HAVE EARNED IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA IS
THERE ANY ANYONE ELSE SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANTED
TO STAND AS THE SENATE'S
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IT WAS A
LONGER NAME THAN THAT I DON'T
REMEMBER ON THAT'S WHEN THE UP
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW THE NAME YOU KNOW THE
LEGEND BUT TO ACTUALLY WORK
SIDE BY SIDE. AND YOU KNOW SHE-
HAVE YOU DON'T KIND OF LOOK.
AND WE WOULD BE AROUND THE
TABLE AND SHE KIND OF GIVES ME
A LOOK AT THE DATA GATHERED WE
KIND OF FORMED THIS NONVERBAL
COMMUNICATION IT'S YOU KNOW.
KIND OF A WITH A SAD DAY BUT I
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE I COULD
INTERPRET THAT WHAT WAS BEING
SAID SHE EITHER SUPPORTED OR
DID NOT HAVE SOME QUESTION. BUT
I THINK I'M SENATOR GROW THAT
KNOWLEDGE TO- WHERE WE WERE- IN
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. ON AND WE DID HAVE
THE FEARLESS LEADERSHIP AMONG
THE PRO TEM TO SET US ON THE
PATH- BUT IT WAS LARGELY YOUR
WORK IN THE WORK OF MANY
OTHERS. THAT HELPED GET US TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY IN TERMS OF
NAVIGATING CREATED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CULTURE SHIFT
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
HELPING HARDER. ON CHARTERED.
IN CREATING A SYSTEM. ON THAT
NOW MANY OTHER STATES DO IN CSL
AND OTHERS ARE LOOKING AT AS A
MODEL SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND GOD SPEED. THANK YOU
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I WANT TO
NOTE I HIT THE EXTREME HONOR.
TO SERVE ON THE UNIFORM LAWS
COMMISSION WHICH IF YOU THINK
SOME OF THE STUFF WE TALK ABOUT
HERE'S LAWYERS IS TOUGH TO
TAKE. TRUST ME THERE IS NOTHING
DRIER THAN THE UNIFORM LAWS
COMMISSION ACCEPTED FOR DIANE
BORDER FND. HER ENTHUSIASM AND
A CHEERLEADING SKILLS AS WE
WOULD ATTEND THESE MEETINGS
WHERE WE WOULD. TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW MANY ANGELS TRULY WERE
DANCING ON THE HEAD OF A PIN-
IT WAS QUITE. WHITE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A REAL
LAWYER. WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
THE NUANCES OF THE LAW AND- IT
INSPIRED ME IMPROVE HOPEFULLY
MADE ME A BETTER PARTICIPANT.
IN THAT COMMITTEE OUR
COMMISSION I SHOULD SAY BUT OUR
HER HER DILIGENCE FOR
COMMITMENT HER PROFESSIONALISM
HER RESOLVE. REALLY IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN I THINK
A TREMENDOUS BLESSING TO THIS
HOUSE AND TO ALL OF US WHO HAD
THE PRIVILEGE AND THE HONOR TO
BE PART OF THIS EFFORT WITH HER
I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE.ARE PRO
TEM. A WOMAN OR MINORITY LEADER
A WOMAN OUR SECRETARY THE
SENATE A WOMAN. AND OF COURSE
OUR LEGISLATIVE COUNCILS WOMAN
AND HAVING A WOMAN PRESIDING-
IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD THAN THE
WORLD THAT MANY OF US
EXPERIENCED YEARS AGO AND YOU
HAVE DONE US ON THE FEMALE SIDE
THAT YOU HAVE DONE US PROUD
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK.
THEY WITHOUT WITHOUT OBJECTION
SAYING NO OTHER MICROPHONES UP.
MADAM THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
WE WOULD LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR A FEW WORDS FROM YOU
THANK YOU AND I'LL BE QUICK
BECAUSE I WANT TO GET OUT OF
HERE BEFORE THREE IN THE
MORNING AS MUCH AS YOU GUYS ALL
WANT TO- THANK YOU FOR THE KIND
WORDS WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY A FEW MINUTES AGO THE
SPEAKER SAID AND ASSEMBLY. WAS
PROBABLY MY FAVORITE HOUSE BUT
A LITTLE SECRET I STARTED
ACTUALLY ON THE SENATE SIDE
WITH AN INTERNSHIP WITH- THEN
SENATOR BOB PRESLEY AND THAT
LED ME ON A- KIND OF. VENTURE
AWAY FROM BUSINESS LAW AND INTO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
IT'S THE BEST KIND OF LAW ANY
LAWYER CAN PRACTICE. MANY
PEOPLE STRIVE TO BE JUDGES BUT-
I WOULD TELL YOU BEING ON THE
FRONT END OF MAKING LAW. AS
OPPOSED TO THE BACK END OF
TRYING TO DEAL WITH FACTS THIS
WONDERFUL. HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAVE AN OFFICE OF SIX
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WHO ARE TRUE
PROFESSIONALS. THAT HELP YOU
GET THROUGH THIS SESSION. WITH
ALL THE BILL DRAFTING AND ALL
OF THE I. T. WORK YOU'VE HAD IN
THE WORKPLACE CONDUCT UNIT I'M
SO PROUD OF THEM IN THE WORK IN
THE OFFICE. IT'S AN HONOR TO
REPRESENT ALL OF YOU. YOU ARE
THE HARDEST WORKING PUBLIC
SERVANTS AND YOU DO THE BEST
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS IT'S JUST
TRULY BEEN MY PRIVILEGE. TO
WORK WITH YOU AND I THANK YOU
I'D BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T THANK
THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SITTING
HERE NOW FOR A COUPLE HOURS- MY
FAMILY IN THE GALLERY. AND THEN
I HAVE FAMILY WATCHING REMOTELY
MY SON AND MY DAUGHTER WHO IS
HER HUSBAND WHO LIVE IN
TORONTO. SO IT'S- ITHOUT THEIR
LOVE AND SUPPORT I COULDN'T HAS
SPENT THE MANY NIGHTS I'VE
SPENT HERE. AND DAYS WORKING
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND
I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK AS
YOU GO INTO THE NEXT SESSION.
AND JUST KEEP UP ALL THE GREAT
WORK. YOU DO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AFTER THE TWELVE. STATE
FOREIGN DI<c.cyan>. FINE FISHING</c>
THE- IN YOUR. MADAM PRO TEM AT
THE PRO TEM'S ORIGINAL DESK
TRYING THANK YOU I DON'T WANT
TO TOUCH ANYONE ELSE'S MIKE BUT-
LAST BUT NOT LEAST- YOU KNOW.
DI<c.cyan> WE WANT TO GIVE YOU A</c>
RESOLUTION FIVE YOU KNOW THESE
THINGS MATTER BECAUSE IT REALLY
IS ABOUT YOUR CAREER IS THERE
AND ALL OF THE WHEREAS IS THAT
YOU ATTORNEY'S MANAGED TO PUT
TOGETHER FOR US- AND IT SAYS A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS SO I HOPE.
YOU ARE GOING TO ACCEPT THIS
WITH THE APPRECIATION AND
GRATITUDE THAT WE ALL FEEL FOR
YOU AND- AS YOU ENTER THE NEXT.
PHASE OF YOUR JOURNEY WE JUST
HOPE THAT YOU WILL ENJOY IT NO
WAY THAT THE DIFFERENCE THAT
YOU HAVE MADE IN THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS AND EVEN BEYOND-
ISRAEL- AND SO WE CAN GRADUATE
YOU AND WE THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH USES SERVICE WE'RE
GOING TO MISS YOU. BY CALLING
TO JUST GIVE IT A MOMENT AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS.
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD
HAVE EVERYONE IN THEIR SEATS WE
ARE GOING TO BE LIFTING THE
CALLS WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THESE ONE TIME. AND
THEN WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
LET'S START WITH FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO. RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN HI. I TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I. DODD. GLAZER. HER
TADO. STERN. STERN I GALGIANI I
TO KNOW. I TWENTY FIVE KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON NOW TO SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEM TO. BEN SCHECHTER
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I. STERN HI GUYS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER I STERN. HI VICE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I.
GLAZER I. STERN BYE BYE SH
THIRTY TWO NOSE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMONS ARKAN CURTAIN FILE ITEM
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GLAZER I. STERN NO
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HIS THIRTY TWO
KNOWS FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INSOFAR CONCURRED FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GLAZER I SKINNER. I
STERN. HI ALLEN I DON'T KNOW. I
WOULD CHOOSE ME I JUST THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS TO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BRADFORD. I
GLAZER I. SKINNER BYE BYE HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS FIVE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN FILE
ITEM THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER I
SKINNER. I. HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED OUR LAST ITEM ON CALL
IS FILE ITEM FIFTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABRERA I GALGIANI. GLAZER I.
NIELSEN. I SKINNER. FIVE NUMBER
NINE HI MY AGE THIRTY ONE KNOWS
TO ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCLUDED IF YOU GIVE ME JUST
ONE MOMENT. CONTACT OKAY.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A THIRTY MINUTE LUNCH RECESS WE
WILL BE BACK HERE LET'S SAY AT
TO THE TWELVE FORTY SIX. ON THE
DART. WE STAND IN RECESS.
MADAM
PRESIDENT. YEAH. CENTER JONES
FOR A PURPOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT WHEN WE READ WHEN WE-
READ. COME BACK IN SESSION CAN
I BE RECOGNIZED FOR POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE PLEASE. WHAT
WITHOUT OBJECTION CERTAINLY
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT. IT
SOUNDS LIKE SENATOR BARGES BUT
IT SHOWS IT IS SENATOR SHOWN SO.
SENATOR BORN JEWISH ISRAELI ONE
YES- I WOULD LIKE TO- OBJECTS
TO SENATOR JONES BEING GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A POINT
OF ORDER. JUST GIVE YOUR BOARD
IS WELL TAKEN CHAU BOARD JUST.
THEY YOU SIR WILL WILL BE WITH
YOU IN A. WE ARE READY TO
RECONVENE AND I BELIEVE SENATOR
JONES YOU HAD A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE THAT YOU
WISH TO PRESENT. SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SHOW
ME WHEN I WAS CHECKING HOLD ON
HOLD ON CENTER JONES. COULD WE
HAVE QUIET IN THE HOUSE AND IF
EVERYONE WOULD PLEASE TAKE
THEIR SEATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES THE FORESHORES. KAMALA
PRESIDENT AND ALLOW ME THIS UP
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
JUST WANT TO CHECK IN WITH THE
FLOOR AND- MY COLLEAGUES-
SENATE. REPUBLICANS AND SENATE
DEMOCRATS AND- JUST GIVE A
BRIEF UPDATE ON MY CONDITION AS
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE VIDEO- I
AM DOING WELL- RECOVERING FROM
MY POSITIVE TEST OF THE-
CORBETT NINETEEN. ACROSS THE
VIRUS- AS YOU ALL KNOW I WAS
TESTED POSITIVE ON ON TUESDAY-
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT I WAS HAD
COME DOWN WITH THAT BUT THE
VIRUS AND THEN ON WEDNESDAY. A
COUPLE OF SYMPTOMS RELATED TO
CHRONIC VIRUS I CAME UP I
ACTUALLY DID LOSE MY TASTE.
WHICH WAS A- INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE BUT I CAN TELL TODAY
THAT THIS LUNCH IS DELICIOUS.
BECAUSE MY TASTE BUDS ARE
REBOUNDING- SIGNIFICANTLY OTHER
THAN THAT I REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
MUCH OF A PROBLEM WITH THIS-
WITH THIS VIRUS THIS WEEK-
MAYBE SOME SLIGHT FATIGUE AND
SOME SLIGHT ACHES BUT NOTHING
THAT REALLY. TOOK ME OUT OF A
PLAY CAN I COMPLETELY AS YOU
ALL SENIOR ENGAGE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS I REMOTELY SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT I WANT TO ALSO
THANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS THAT
HAVE- REACHED OUT TO ME AND-
YOU KNOW GIVE ME THEIR WELL
WISHES AND- OTHER CONCERNS IT
MEANS A LOT TO ME THAT. EVEN AT
THE END OF SESSION LIKE THIS
THAT WE CAN HAVE A CONCERN FOR
EACH OTHER AND I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. AND YEAH AND I WANT
EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THEM AS WELL
AND- I WANT EVERYBODY TO BE
SAFE AND HEALTHY- ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE REALIZED HIS
EXPERIENCES IF- IF YOU DO TAKE
CARE OF YOURSELF. AND MY WIFE
IS VERY ADAMANT ABOUT
COMMUNITY. VITAMIN VITAMINS AND
IMMUNITY SUPPLEMENTS- THAT
WE'VE BEEN TAKING AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S BEEN ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- YOU KNOW GET THROUGH THIS-
WITH A GOOD. WITH A GOOD AMOUNT
OF EASE THANK YOU SENATOR YEAH
I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE ALL OF
OUR COLLEAGUES AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR. AND
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT. THIS
DEAL STILL. BUT I REALLY WANT
TO GO EASE SOME OF THOSE FEARS
ARE CONCERN THAT EVERY. HAS YOU
KNOW CDC UPDATE THEIR-
STATISTICS IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS REGARDING THE DEATH
RATE ON THE CORONA VIRUS IN
THE- NINETEEN NINETY SENATOR
JOHNSON'S GONE BEYOND THE POINT
OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE AND WE-
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF ALL OF
AND VERY PLEASED THAT YOU ARE
FEELING WELL AND I BELIEVE THE
WHOLE. HOUSE EXTENDS TO.
SWISHES A SENATOR HERTZBERG
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE- NEXT
ITEM ON OUR- FILE WHICH IS
GOING TO BE THE BUDGET WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE. AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMóN AN ACT RELATING TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I'M VERY
GLAD TO KNOW THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES FEELING BETTER AND
LET ME JUST SAY YOU KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A CHALLENGING YEAR ARE
SENATE FELLOWS CLASS OF TWENTY
TWENTY I HAD NO IDEA THAT THEY
WOULD LOCK INTO A SITUATION
LIKE THEY DID AND SO LET ME
THANK MY FELLOW YOU'RE SENDING
OUT JIMENEZ WHO STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE AND FIGURED IT OUT.
COULD YOU BE AB EIGHTEEN. FIVE
PERTAINS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION INNOVATION
AND INTRODUCES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LAW. MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THIS
BILL RENAMED THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION TO
FULLY REFLECT THE DEPARTMENT'S
ROLE AS THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
MARKET REGULATOR AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION AGENCY. THIS IS THE
RENAMING OF AN EXISTING STATE
DEPARTMENT IT'S NOT THE
CREATION OF AN ENTIRELY NEW
DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY. CLARIFIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE FEDERAL
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
ACT OF TWENTY TEN AGAINST
ENTITIES UNDER ITS OVERSIGHT.
AS A PERTAINS TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LAW THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
FINANCIAL TECHNOLOGY OFFICE AND
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO REFORM
NEW ACTIVITIES SUCH AS CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PRODUCT MARKET
RESEARCH AND TARGETED CONSUMER
OUTREACH. IT PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE AND OVERSEE NEW
COVERED PERSONS AND CONSUMER
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS. IT
PROHIBITS NEWLY COVERED PERSONS
IN CONSUMER FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM ENGAGING IN
UNFAIR DECEPTIVE OR ABUSIVE
ACTS OR PRACTICES. GRANTED
APARTMENT POWERS THE SPECIFIED
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
LIMITATIONS TO PROMULGATE RULES
AND REGULATIONS REGARDING THE
REGISTRATION OF COVERED PERSONS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS PROVIDING
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PRODUCTS. IT
MAKES OTHER VARIOUS TECHNICAL
AND SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES WITH
THE PURPOSE TO PROMOTE CONSUMER
WELFARE. AIR COMPETITION AND
WEALTH CREATION IN THE STATE
MEMBERS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCH
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THE FLOOR ON THIS ITEM IS
ARE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR CAFIERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I JUST WANT TO SAY A
BIG THANK YOU TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS UP WITH
PROPOSED- BACK IN JANUARY AND
WE HAD SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT IT HAD IS A
LENGTHY HEARING AND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TOOK THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND BECAUSE OF
THAT AMENDMENTS THAT THEY HAVE
DONE- I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU SENATOR
KABIR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR SHE
NINE WE WILL GO TO OUR REMOTE
COLLEAGUES SEEING. OUR HANDS UP
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASKING FOR DIVERT.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I TELL
I BRADFORD. CABALLERO I DODD.
HI TO RAZA I GALGIANI. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO I HER TADO. I JACKSON I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN AND THEN AND
NOW. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I.
ROSS FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
FIVE STERN AYE NUMBER HI HI MY
COUNTY HI WIENER FIVE RIGHT
MADAM SECTOR WE COLLEAGUES
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THAT
THESE MEASURES NOW TWICE ON THE
FLOOR AND THEN WE'LL GO TO OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE REMOTELY A
PARTICIPATING AND THEN WE WILL
BE CLOSING THE ROLE SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR.
BRADFORD I. GALGIANI. NIELSEN.
RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OUR COLLEAGUES REMOTELY WE'LL
START WITH SENATOR BATES THIS
IS OUR AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE. EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR ABSTAINED.
GORGEOUS REDUCE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR NO. BARGES NO CHIANG
MAI AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NOW
CHIANG HELLO DOLLY. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NO GROVE
NO MELENDEZ MELENDEZ EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR NOW MELENDEZ
NO MORLOCK. RELAX AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR NO MORE LOCK NO
MORAL. L. A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR NO MORALE NO WILK. WELL AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR NO WILK NOW
MY COLLEAGUES I HAVE BEEN
ADVISED THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO PUT THESE ITEMS ON
CALL SO SENATOR MITCHELL MOVES
A CALL AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO CANNABIS AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY DAHLE RELATED TO
THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE CANNABIS
CONTROL APPEALS PANEL AND THE
BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS GRANTS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ALSO SUSPENDS THE
CANNABIS EXCISE TAX MARKUPS AND
THE CULTIVATION TAX INFLATION
BUT INFLATION ADJUSTMENT FOR
ONE YEAR ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR. ANYONE ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NON WILL MOVE TO THE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS SENATOR
GROWTH. I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER QUESTION THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU ACCEPT THE QUESTION
SENATOR MITCHELL. RIGHT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTOOD YOU WELL
SINCE I DON'T SIT ON BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND WE GOT THESE
BILLS PLACE LAST NIGHT- ARE YOU
SAYING THAT YOUR SYSTEM IS BILL
IS GOING TO SUSPEND IN TAXES OR
TAXING TAX SCHEDULE ON THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. NOW WE ARE
FIFTEEN BEING THE CANNABIS
EXCISE TAX MARCA AND THE
CULTIVATION TAX INFLATION IS
INFLATION ADJUSTMENT FOR ONE
YEAR AND- I'LL READ TO YOU FROM
THE ANALYSIS- THIS GROW IT
PROHIBITS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION FROM ADJUSTING
THE MARKUP AMOUNT DURING THE
PERIOD BEGINNING ARE ON OR
AFTER THE OPERATIVE DATE OF
THIS BILL AND BEFORE JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF MY
OWN TIME I'M REALLY JUST
APPALLED THAT WITH BUSINESS
STRUGGLING LIKE THEY ARE DURING
THE SCOPE IN NINETEEN SITUATION
NOT BEING ABLE TO OPERATE
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE EMERGENCY ORDER
DEMANDING THAT THEY SHUT DOWN-
AND NOT HAVING RESTAURANTS NOT
HAVING ANY OF OUR IN ROOM
DINING NOT HAVING YOU KNOW BE
IN THE BUSINESS SALONS-
PERSONAL CARE PLACES
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THEY'RE
STRUGGLING BUT THEY STILL HAVE
TO MEET THEIR TAX LIABILITY BUT
WE ARE SPENDING FOR ONE YEAR AT
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY'S- TAX
INCREASE- OR THE TAXES THAT
ARE- FOR THIS CANNABIS INDUSTRY
AND IT'S JUST SAD. THAT AND-
THAT WE DON'T TREAT BUSINESS
THE SAME I MEAN IT. IT I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THIS TAX
SUSPENSION FOR ONE YEAR FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY BUT NOT FOR
ANY OTHER BUSINESS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO- I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE AND
REALLY QUESTION- WHY THIS BILL
IS EVEN PUT IN PLACE. WE'RE IN
A DEFICIT SITUATION COMPANIES
SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMIC ACTUALLY
WAS UNTIL IT WAS THE GOVERNOR
WHO SHUT DOWN THE ECONOMIC- IN
CAN OF OUR STATE. AT AND NOW
WE'RE GIVING TAX BREAKS- AND
NOT ALLOWING TAX INCREASES OR
SPENDING TAX INCREASES FOR A
YEAR ON THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY-
SO YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT- YOU KNOW PAY YOUR FAIR
SHARE IN. ALL THESE COMMENTS
THAT ARE MADE AND THAT.
CANNABIS INDUSTRY NEEDS TO
CONTINUE STEP UP AND WHY
THEY'RE GETTING A TAX BREAK AND
NO OTHER BUSINESSES THAT JUST
BEYOND ME AND I WOULD URGE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER TO OR DO.
SEEING NONE SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I JUST REALLY WANT TO
PROVIDE FURTHER CLARIFICATION
THAT THIS ON IS A SUSPENSION ON
THE EXCISE TAX MARK UP AND THE
CULTIVATION INFLATION
ADJUSTMENT THESE ARE A JUDGE
PLACE TO THE JUSTICE THAT ARE
MADE TO THESE TAXES SO THAT IS
WHAT'S BEEN SUSPENDED AND IT'S
ONLY FOR ONE YEAR. THANK YOU
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE TWICE WITHIN
GOING TO GO TO OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE
TO ROLLING VICE WE NOW HAVE A
FULL HOUSE. TWICE THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE REMOTE
MEMBERS AND THEY WERE CLOSING
THE ROLE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I DODD. I
TORONTO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. I HILL HI
WESTERN. HI HER TADO I JACKSON
I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I
MONEY. HI NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I STERN I BURKE. WHY
CASKEY HI WIENER HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE TIME. OF
WHATEVER. NUMBER NIELSEN NO
AMBERG HI NOW MOVING ON TO OUR
REMOTE COLLEAGUES AB. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR SENATOR BATES BATES BATES
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW
BATES NOW FOR JUST. ORDERS AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW FOR
JUST NOW CHIANG. THANK AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW CHIANG
NO DALLY. GALLEY AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
A GROUP AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
NO GROW NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NO MORE
LOCK NO MORAL. MORRELL AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO NOW
MORRELL NO WILK. WILK AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO. WILK HI
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES. AND WE'RE GOING
TO BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS.
GALGIANI. NIELSEN NO I TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS. NINE I'M SORRY WE
HAVE A SENATOR. BATES HAS HER
HAND UP SENATOR BATES FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. CHANGE PLEASE OR
ADELINE- TWO OF AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FOUR NO. BATES NOW. BY ON
THAT ITEM FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE
FINAL VOTE IS TWENTY EIGHT OUR
EYES NOSE TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES WE ARE NOW MOVING ALONG
TO FOLLOW. MADAM PRESIDENT. CAN
WE HAVE MADE A PRESIDENT. YES
THIS IS SENATOR GROWTH IT WOULD
YES IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF YOU
PUT YOUR HAND UP SO WE COULD
IDENTIFY YOU WHEN YOU SPEAK UP
THANK YOU WE WILL TRY TO GET A
CUSTOM TO THAT NORMALLY WOULD
YELL ON THE FLOOR POINT OF
ORDER REPORTING COMMENTS
QUESTIONNAIRE SO I APOLOGIZE A
GROUP WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION.
WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION MY
QUESTION IS THAT CAN YOU REVIEW
THE TAPE- JUST BRIEFLY OR HAVE
BERNIE LOOK AT IT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT M. SENATOR BATES
WAS HER VOTE ON A DIFFERENT
BILL AND THE BILL WE JUST TOOK
UP WAS AB AT EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO. CLEAR CREDIT AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO AND SENATOR BATES
IS VOTE BUT SHE WAS ACTUALLY
REFERENCING A DIFFERENT BILL.
BUSINESS. S. R. WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA GOTO
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BATES
LET'S GO TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR WHICH IS AB. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
COULD YOU PLEASE INDICATE TO US
YOUR VOTE ON THAT MEASURE. SIX
MY VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO WAS NO RIGHT LET'S HOLD ON
THAT'S CORRECT THEN. YES IN THE
DOCUMENT INDICATES THAT YOU
WERE INDEED A NO VOTE ON THAT
ITEM LET'S GO BACK TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY NINE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR COULD YOU PLEASE. I WAS
HOLDING ONE SECOND HE. VERY
GOOD SO LET'S BE CLEAR. SO THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO ATTEND TO THIS
MATTER ACCURATELY ON AB EXCUSE
ME FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR. DURING THE
FIRST ROUND WHEN WE PUT THE
MATTER ON CALL YOU SENATOR
BATES HAD A NO VOTE RECORDED.
EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME WHEN ON THE
FIRST GO ROUND YOU HAD A NOT
VOTING. NO VOTE IN THE FIRST GO
AROUND WOULD YOU NOW RECITE TO
US ON AB FIFTY NINE. WHICH IS
WEEK FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR YOUR VOTE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR BATES
VERY GOOD THAT'S THE WAY IT HAS
IT WAS REPORTED. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HOPE THAT THAT CLARIFIES
THE SITUATION WILL MOVE THE
FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
PRESIDENT SEVEN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT TRAILER BILL
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS TRAILER.
AND THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
ELIGIBILITY IN THE TO
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER FOLLOWS.
WITH AT LEAST ONE CHILD UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX. THIS BILL
REMOVES THE LIMITATIONS SET
FORTH IN AB NINETY THREE ON THE
USE OF AN I. TEN IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE EITC- THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. IT
REQUIRES I DIDN'T POLICY
PROVIDE SPECIFIED INFORMATION
TO THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD UPON
REQUEST. ASKING FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
FLOORS FOR ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW GO TO THE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS AND WE HAVE
SENATOR MORLOCKS SENATOR MORE
LOG. FLOOR'S YOURS SIR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL BUT I ALSO JUST WANTED.
FORM MY CLIENT CITY MY CLIENTS
MY COLLEAGUES. THAT THE
CONTROLLER JUST ISSUED A REPORT.
STATING THAT THE- LIABILITY FOR
RETIREE MEDICAL IS JUST GONE UP
FROM EIGHTY SIX BILLION TO
NINETY ONE BILLION DOLLARS ON
OUR BALANCE SHEET AS OF JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN THAT
MAY EXPLAIN PART OF WHY THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT HAS BEEN ISSUED BUT-
WITH REGARDS TO THIS IN A FEW
OF THE OTHER BILLS WE HAVE TO
BE REAL CAREFUL. ABOUT HOW
WE'RE SPENDING STATE DOLLARS
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO
VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCK SEEING NO OTHER HANDS
UP. SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARMENIAN PRESIDENT I JUST TO
REITERATE THAT WE ALREADY
PASSED A TRAILER BILL ON THAT
EXPANDED- E. I. T. C. A N. Y.
C. T. C. ELIGIBILITY TO ITIN
FILERS ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
REMOVE THE LIMITATIONS SET
FORTH IN AB NINETY THREE ON THE
USE OF AN I. TEN IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR EITC AIR Y. C. T.
C. ASKING FOR OUR VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED WE WILL GO
THROUGH THE ROLE TWICE. INTO
OUR MEMBERS REMOTE. AND THEN WE
WILL CLOSE THE RULES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MAN SECTOR. ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS I
FELL I BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
DODD. HI DURAZO HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL HI WITH SO. FIVE HER
TADO FIVE JACKSON HI I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. I STERN AYE NUMBER. BY
CAL SKI FIVE WIENER HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. GLAZER I. AMBERG ALL
EYES EXCUSE ME WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE MEMBERS- THIS IS FILE
ITEM. SIXTY FIVE AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX CENTER BATES. BATES
AS AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX NO
BATES NO FOR JUST. OR JUST AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX NOW FOR
JUST NOW CHIANG MAI AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX NOW CHIANG NO DALLI
DALLI AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX
NOW DALLY NO GROWTH. GRILLED AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX NOW GROVE
NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SIX YEAH MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX
NO MORALE NO WILK. AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX NO WILK NO. WHY IS
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM. SIXTY NINE AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR. SENATOR
MITCHELL ARE YOU GOING TO BE
TAKING UP THAT ITEM. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
SENATOR MITCHELL MEMBERS THIRTY
TO THIRTY FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAILER BILL THAT INCLUDES TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS THAT
REFLECT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S DATA AND EVIDENCE
BASED PROPOSALS FOR REDUCING
OUR STATE THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR PRISON BUDGET PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ACHIEVING
OVERALL BUDGETARY SAVINGS. THE
PROVISIONS WERE A TRAILER BILL
THAT PASSED ON OUR FLOOR IN
JUNE. THIS BILL MAKES THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THOSE THAT
PREVIOUS ACTION THAT WE ARE
READY TO. THIS BILL GIVE
STATEWIDE JUDICIAL AUTHORITY TO
OFFER OPTIONAL MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION EXCEPT FOR SPECIFIED
OFFENSES. THE BILL INCLUDES
STATUTORY CHANGES TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS HOUSE OF THE
STATE'S PRISONS. A LOT OF THE
ON GOING COLD NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. SPECIFICALLY CHANGED
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR AN
ELDERLY PAROLE SLOOPS ABILITY
HEARING. ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR NIELSEN. THE
SENATE THE THIS CONTINUES A-
DISCONCERTING PRECEDENT THAT'S
BEEN SET. A LOT OF VERY
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE
DONE VERY SEVERE CRIMES GREATLY
AGREED THE PUBLIC NOT JUST
THEIR VICTIMS BUT SOCIETY AND A
WHOLE. WHERE BECAUSE OF HOLDEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GET EARLY
RELEASE TO SOCIETY. NOW I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE A PAUSE AND
THINK ABOUT THIS A LITTLE BIT.
THE GET OUT OF PRISON. TICKETS
NOW IS PUBLISHED. WELL THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO COME
OUT HAVING BEEN IN A VULNERABLE
ENVIRONMENT THE CONTRACT COBIT.
WE'RE GONNA AND THEIR-
VULNERABLE POPULATION ANYWAY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO PUT HIM OUT
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. I
GUARANTEE YOU THEY WILL BE
LARGELY UNSUPERVISED. AND NOT
SUBJECT TO ANY PUNISHMENT. OR
CONSEQUENCES IF THEY CONTINUE
THEIR CRIMINALITY. SO OUR
CITIZENS THAT WE REPRESENT ARE
NOW ECOMING VULNERABLE TO THE
BEHAVIOR OF DEMONSTRATED PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DISREGARDED. THE
SAFETY OF SOCIETY AND WHO NOW
THEMSELVES MAY WELL BE A
SEPARATE AND INDEPENDENT AND
VERY SEVERE THREAT. I WOULD ASK
YOU TO TAKE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THIS TREND. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN CENTER GALGIANI.
FROM TIME TO TIME I'M CALLED
UPON BY ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS
TO ANONYMOUSLY CALL OUR SHERIFF
AND SILICON COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
SHE AND HER NEIGHBORS BECAUSE
OF GANG ACTIVITY THAT IS IN
WITHIN THIS VERY VERY SMALL
COURT- A LARGE NUMBER OF
DISABLED AND ELDERLY RESIDENTS
THERE. JUST THREE WEEKS AGO SHE
CALLED ME AND SHE WAS IN TEARS
AND SHE WAS DESCRIBING HOW- ONE
OF THE GANG MEMBERS HAD GONE TO
THE HOUSE OF A HUSBAND AND WIFE
AND GOT INTO AN ARGUMENT THE
WIFE COMES OUT OF THE BATHROOM.
THE GANG MEMBER THROWS GASOLINE
ON HER. AND THEN THROWS A
LIGHTER ON HER AND SET HER ON
FIRE. THE HUSBAND TRIES TO HELP
HE SETS HIMSELF ON FIRE BY
ACCIDENT BECAUSE IN THE PROCESS
HE GOT GASOLINE ON HIM. THE TWO
OF THEM RUN OUT OF THE HOUSE.
BY THE TIME THE NEIGHBORS HEARD
THE SCREAMING AND SOMEBODY GOT
TO JOSE TRIED TO PUT THEM OUT.
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT GOT THERE
AFTER THE DAMAGE WAS ALREADY
DONE 85% BURNS TO BOTH OF THEIR
BODIES AND IT WAS SO BAD THAT
IN FACT THE SUSPECT CAUGHT
HIMSELF ON FIRE AND HE'S AT A
HOSPITAL HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
TO. CALL IN AN INDUCED COMA AND
THAT SAME EVENING THAT VERY
SAME EVENING. WITHIN A COUPLE
OF HOURS THE NEIGHBORHOOD WITH
THE NEIGHBORS AND THE WHOLE
CIRCLE WE'RE TOLD THAT IF YOU
SPEAK TO THE COPS YOUR NEXT. IF
I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THIS
BILL INCLUDES DIVERSION FOR
DISSUADING A WITNESS OR CRIME
pVICTIMS. FROM REPORTING A CRIME
OR TESTIFYING. WHEN VICTIMS OF
CRIME ARE SILENCED AND THEY
FEAR FOR THEIR LIFE WE ALL
SUFFER AND I WILL REMIND PEOPLE
TO THIS IS AN INCIDENT THAT
JUST HAPPENED THREE WEEKS AGO
IN MY DISTRICT. BUT WITH THE
CASE YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ABOUT
BEFORE WITH WESLEY SHERMAN KIND
AND LAUREN HERZOG SERIAL
KILLERS THAT WERE OPERATING IN
MY DISTRICT FOR FOURTEEN YEARS.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS BECAUSE PEOPLE
WERE AFRAID TO COME FORWARD AND
BECAUSE THEY WERE SILENCED.
THEY WERE SILENCED AND THEY
WERE AFRAID FOR THEIR LIVES
THIS IS A VERY VERY SERIOUS
OFFENSE. DISSUADING A WITNESS
OR CRIME VICTIMS FROM REPORTING
A CRIME OR TESTIFYING I ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. SEEING NON WE DO
HAVE TO PAN SHOP OF REMOTELY WE
WILL START WITH SENATOR DOLLY
AND THEN NOT BE FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I ALSO TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU THAT CDC ARE
ACTUALLY. EXPECTED MORE
PRISONERS BE BY MOVING
PRISONERS FROM SAN QUENTIN TO
LASSEN WHICH IS THE HIGH DESERT
STATE PRISON WE HAD FOUR
INFECTED PRISONERS MOVED HERE
WE DID IT WAS SIX HUNDRED CASES
OF COVE IT. IN OUR PRISON. OUT
OF THOSE SIX HUNDRED I WILL
SHARE THIS WITH YOU- ALL OF
THEM NOW ARE HEALED UP AND ONLY
ONE HAD TO GO. TO THE HOSPITAL.
AND TO BE TREATED FOR THE
ACTUAL CODE BUT THE POINT IS
THAT WE'RE ALLOWING THESE
PRISONERS TO GET OUT BECAUSE OF
KOBLET. AT OUR ACTUAL. PHONE
POLICIES FROM THE STATE RAN
PRISON IS CAUSING COBIT SO FOR
THAT REASON I WOULD OPPOSE THIS
BILL JUST BECAUSE THERE S NO
REASON TO LET THESE PRISONERS
OUT THERE GETTING ILL. AND THEY
NEED TO BE IN PRISON WHERE THEY
CONSERVE THEIR TIME FOR THE
CRIME WE NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
VICTIMS NEVER TALK ABOUT THE
FAMILIES THAT. HAVE HAD. IT'S
GOING TO BE THREATENED AS WE
JUST HEARD IN THE LAST SPEAKERS
INFORMATION OR THE PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
FOREVER BECAUSE OF THESE
CRIMINALS. AND THAT WE RISKS
WERE DISCONTINUED A LOT ABOUT
HIM THE OTHER TRYING TO GET
COVERED SO THEY CAN GET OUT AND
IT'S JUST WRONG SO I. URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU- THE SENATOR
GROWTH AND THEN WE'LL HAVE
CENTER SKYNYRD INTO YOU MY CUT
MY APOLOGIES CENTER GROWTH
FLOOR SHORES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR UNDER HIS
EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY IS
RELEASING THOUSANDS OF
CRIMINALS AND FROM OUR PRISON
SYSTEMS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT IF YOUR CHILDREN ARE
OUTSIDE THE NEED TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT. THE ELDERLY POPULATION
WHICH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CENTER VALLEY JUST DESCRIBED IN
THE NEED TO BE WORRIED ABOUT M.
INDIVIDUALS IN PLACES IN MY
DISTRICT AND NOT JUST IN MY
DISTRICT BUT EVERYONE'S
DISTRICT. WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
GET OUT ON ZERO BELL WHICH IS
SAM- IT DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT HERE BUT IT'S ABOUT JUST
RELEASING AND RELAXING AND
CRIMINALS ARE THE ACTIVITY THAT
CRIMINALS ARE BEING ABLE TO BE
SUBJECTED TO. WHEN YOU RELEASE-
AT ZERO BELT FOR INSTANCE-
THERE WAS ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
PUT THIS PERSON IN JAIL AND
REQUIRE BAIL BUT BECAUSE OF
KOBE HE WAS RELEASED AND THEN
HE ENDED UP ROBBING A STORE
CLEAN FROM THE POLICE. IN A
TULARE COUNTY CAME AROUND A
CORNER BY A PARK AND HE RAN
OVER A THIRTY PLUS YEAR OLD MOM
AND HER TWO KIDS WATCH THAT
WOMAN IS NOW DEAD BECAUSE OF
THIS PRISONER BEING. RELEASED
ON ZERO ABOUT. THE GOVERNOR
PUTTING TOGETHER AS RELEASING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF WE HEARD
WAS UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND IT WAS
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT FROM
EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CRIMINALS INTO OUR STREETS AND
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES- THAT IS.
ALL OF US IN DANGER NOT JUST AS
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS IT PUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN DANGER
THAT OUR ELDERLY DOESN'T LIVE
ALONE WOMEN WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
VIOLENT CRIMES AGAIN INTO. THIS
ANARCHY ON OUR STREETS WITH
INDIVIDUALS BEING RELEASED INTO
OUT OF PRISON. AND YOU KNOW NOT
TAKING INTO ANY CONSIDERATION
THE VICTIM- WE HAD AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT WAS RELEASED
FROM PRISON AND THAT HE- HE
TERRORIZED HIS EX WIFE- WITH
CALLING ON THE FLOOR IN THE
SAME TYPE OF SITUATION. BUT
THIS INDIVIDUAL TERRORIZED HIS
EX WIFE TO THE POINT WHERE HE
WAS IN. BECAUSE OF OUR CENTER.
AND TERROR IS WIFE AND KIDS
FOUR HUNDRED FIVE YEARS AND HE
GETS OUT HE GETS OUT OF PRISON
WHAT ABOUT THE VICTIMS WHAT
ABOUT THIS WIFE. WHAT ABOUT HER
CHILDREN SHE FEELS LIKE SHE'S
VICTIMIZED ALL OVER AGAIN AND
SHE WENT ON TELEVISION TO SAY
THAT. YOU HAVE INDIVIDUALS
GETTING OUT OF PRISON THAT IT
COMMITTED VIOLENT CRIMES.
COMMITTED CRIMES AGAINST
VICTIMS AND THERE'S NO. THERE'S
NO- CONSIDERATION FOR THE
VICTIMS THEMSELVES SO NOW THE
VICTIM WAS EXPECTING SOMEBODY
TO BE IN PRISON- FOR WHATEVER
MANY YEARS AND THEY'RE GETTING
OUT. AND THEY HAVE TO REALLY OF
NOT ONLY THE CRIME THAT WAS
PERPETRATED AGAINST THEM AS A
VICTIM. BUT ALSO WORRY ABOUT
BEING PROTECTED FROM THE POLICE
WHICH WERE OBVIOUSLY I'M
CHANGING THE WHOLE WORLD OF THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND
DEFENDING THEM WHERE'S THE
PROTECTION GOING TO COMPANIES
STATE VICTIMS WAS HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH A COLLEAGUE
IN THAT COLLEAGUES AS WELL THEY
CAN GET A RESTRAINING ORDER.
WHEN SOMEBODY'S COMING AFTER
YOU WITH THE INTENT TO COMMIT
YOU ARE WAITING A LITTLE PIECE
OF PAPER IS NOT GOING TO MAKE
THEM GO AWAY OR STOP. SO TO
RELEASE AND I REALIZE LIKE THE
BUDGET CHAIR SAIDSHE'S VERY
SMART SHE'S VERY ARTICULATE SHE
UNDERSTANDS ALL THE BUDGET
STAFF I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW SHE
KEEPS IT STRAIGHT WITH ALL THE
BUDGET BILLS THAT GO THROUGH.
GOING TO SAVE THE STATE MONEY
TO RELEASE THESE PEOPLE INTO
THE POPULATION IN INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A DIFFERENT WAY TO
SAVE THE STATE MONEY I REALIZE
THAT IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE TO
KEEP PEOPLE IN PRISON. BUT
THESE PEOPLE ARE IN PRISON
TRIED BY A JURY OF THEIR PEERS
AND THEY'RE IN PRISON FOR A
REASON AND I WANT YOU TO TRY TO
THINK ABOUT THE- THE VICTIMS.
THAT WILL BE- ASSAULTED AGAIN
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE RELEASED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE. THE
SENATORS SKINNER. WAT THE
WOULD YOU. OKAY NOW HERE YOU. I
AM NOT IN CONTROL OF THIS WICKS
THERE YOU GO ALL RIGHT. CAN YOU
MAY YOU MAY RECEIVE THANK YOU I
AM COMPOSING MYSELF. IT IS
SEEMINGLY POPULAR TO. THROWN
AROUND VERY INACCURATE AND
SENSATIONAL STATISTICS ABOUT
VIOLENT CRIME WE'RE HEARING IT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHEN
ACTUALLY VIOLENT CRIME IS DOWN
IT IS ALSO SEEMINGLY- POPULAR
TO MAKE REFERENCES TO THINGS
THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE BILL BEFORE US SO LET ME
CLARIFY WHAT IS IN THE BILL
BEFORE US WHAT IS IN THE BILL
BEFORE US. IS NOT A STATE
MANDATE IT IS. A ABILITY FOR A
COURT. IF I COUNTY APPROVES IT
FOR COURT TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION PROGRAM AND EVEN WITH
IN THAT MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF CRIMES
THAT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED. SO IT
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR. POLICIES ON
JUST LOOKING AT MY NOTES. IT
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR SEX OFFENSES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A WHOLE
VARIETY OF AND OF COURSE
REMEMBER NOW REFERRING TO
MISDEMEANOR SO THESE WOULD BE
MISDEMEANOR. SEX OFFENSES AND
MISDEMEANORS- DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND STALKING BUT THOSE ARE
EXCLUDED SO THIS IS PURELY
OPTIONAL FOR FOURTEEN COUNTIES
IF THEY SO CHOOSE AND IT'S
BASED ON A VERY SUCCESSFUL
DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
OPERATING IN L. A. COUNTY FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT'S FIRST
AND FOREMOST THAT'S THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT'S IN
THIS BILL IT IS NOT A MANDATE.
IT IS NOT A AUTHORIZING THE
STATE WIDE IT IS ALLOWING
COUNTIES IF THEY SO CHOOSE AND
COURTS THE SECOND COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL THE SECOND COMPONENT
OF THIS BILL. IS THE NEXT DATE
REVISION TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
OWN APPROVED STATUTE AROUND
MEDICAL PAROLE. NOW FOR MEDICAL
PAROLE STATUTE REQUIRES IF. E.
CDCR. RECOMMENDS AND OF COURSE
THIS REQUIRES CDCR TO RECOMMEND
AN INDIVIDUAL FOR MEDICAL
PAROLE THAT INDIVIDUAL STILL
MUST GO BEFORE THE PAROLE
BOARD. SO THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE RELEASES THAT THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY ALLOWED YOU
TO COBIT AND THOSE RELEASES
MORE. EXCLUDED TO PEOPLE WHO
WERE WITHIN ONE YEAR OF RELEASE.
AND THE GOVERNOR HAS DIFFERENT
AUTHORITIES FOR SUCH- RELEASES
THIS BILL DOES NOT TOUCH THOSE
THIS BILL ONLY REVISES OUR OWN
STATUTE WHERE A PERSON AN
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL IF THEY
ARE RECOMMENDED BY THE PRISON
SYSTEM TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
MEDICAL PAROLE THEY WOULD STILL
HAVE TO GO BEFORE THE PROBOARDS
PROBOARDS WOULD STILL REVIEW IT
VICTIMS WOULD BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD. JUDGES D. A.'S COULD
WEIGH IN AND IF WE LOOK
HISTORICALLY OVER THE TEN SAY
ODD YEARS THAT WE'VE HAD SUCH
MEDICAL PAROLE THERE HAVE BEEN
VERY VERY FEW. FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY BEEN GIVEN MEDICAL
PAROLE SO THAT IS WHAT'S IN THE
BILL AND I WANTED TO BE VERY
CLEAR. SO THAT WE KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER US
SENATOR MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS IS NOT A
POPULARITY CONTEST SO- LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT IS ACTUALLY IN
THE JAIL THIS BILL ALLOWS A
JUDGE TO PROVIDE UNLIMITED
DIVERSION FOR ANY MISDEMEANOR
WITH THE EXCLUSION OF SEX
OFFENSES DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STALKING. IT DOES ALLOW FOR-
pCHILD ABUSE D. Y. HATE CRIMES
BRINGING A FIREARM INTO A
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE ASSAULT
BATTERY IDENTITY THEFT VEHICLE
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER
POSSESSING A FIREARM- UPON OR
WITHIN PUBLIC SCHOOL IN ON THE
GROUNDS ALL ELIGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION IT SOUNDS LIKE A REAL
NICE BUNCH DOESN'T IT. THIS IS
RIDICULOUS EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
BILL THAT COMES UP LIKE THIS
IT'S MADE OUT TO BE THAT I
WOULD SUGGEST THESE LOW LEVEL
OFFENDERS WHAT'S THE HARM. IF
YOU LISTENED TO THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IF YOU
ACTUALLY LISTEN TO THEM YOU
WOULD HEAR THE TYPE OF HARM.
THAT MAY BE BECAUSE THIS THIS
IS SO INAPPROPRIATE AND TO GO
FURTHER WITH RESPECT TO THE
ELDERLY PAROLE PROGRAM. CAROLI
AGREE JUST BY THE WAY. YOU
TARGET INMATES WHO HAVE
COMMITTED THE MOST VIOLENT AND
TROUBLING CRIME SO THEIR SO
CALLED NON VIOLENCE AND THESE
ARE IN MAJOR BORROWER RECEIVED
EXPEDITED PAROLE HEARINGS BY
THE WAY UNDER PROP SIXTY SEVEN.
AND THREE STRIKES INMATES ARE
EXEMPTED SO YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE THERESULT OF REDUCED
SENTENCES FOR CRIMES LIKE
MURDER KIDNAPPING RAPE AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH THIS IS. IT GOD
HELP US YOU KNOW IF WE CONTINUE
WITH BILLS LIKE THIS BECAUSE
AND BY THE WAY I DON'T THINK
LOS ANGELES SHOULD REALLY BE
HELD UP AS THE LITMUS TEST OR
BENCHMARK FOR HELPING SHOULD BE
DONE PROPERLY GIVEN WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE SO I.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BORCHERS. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE TITLE OF THIS
pWAS SIXTEEN AND HAS NOW BEEN
REDUCED DOWN TO FIFTY. SO WHAT
OCCURRED TO ME IS IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A DUAL PURPOSE JUNE
LEGISLATION. ONE IT HAS ON
CERTAINLY HAS A SOCIAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ELEMENT TO IT.
BUT THE SECOND. WAS THE ELDERLY
PAROLE PROGRAM. WAIT FOR THE
STATE TO NOT HAVE TO SHOULDER
THE MEDICAL COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH AGING INMATES. I'M
WONDERING IF THAT HAS A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT TO THIS
CALCULATION. THAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD SAVE MONEY BY GETTING RID
OF FOLKS THAT WOULD NORMALLY BE.
ACTUARIALLY MORE EXPOSED AND IN
NEED OF MEDICAL TREATMENT. THE
REASON I BRING IT UP IS THAT IF
THERE'S A COST FACTOR TO THIS.
IN ADDITION TO THE SOCIAL
ARGUMENT THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT THERE'S A COST
FACTOR HERE. IS NOT WHAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO. IF PEOPLE ARE
HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES TO PAYING
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY. WE ALSO
HAVE TO MAKE THEIR- LIVING
ENVIRONMENT- HABITABLE ON WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH WITH.
BASICS OF MEDICAL ATTENTION SO
ON AND SO FORTH. SO I GUESS I
BRING THIS UP BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO BE CYNICAL ABOUT IT BUT
IS THIS MOSTLY JUST A COST
SAVING AFTER THAT THE
RHETORICALLY NOT EXPECTING- THE
FLOOR MANAGER TO RESPOND BUT-
IF THAT IS THE CASE I THINK
IT'S TROUBLING BECAUSE. PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A DEBT TO SOCIETY.
STILL HAVE. YET EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE OUT OF PRISON AND IN MY
OPINION. BECAUSE IT FOR LOCAL
OUT FOR THESE EXTERNALITIES
EXPONENTIAL EXTERNALITIES. THEN
WE ARE SENDING A MESSAGE ON
THAT IF YOU'RE TOO COSTLY WE
WILL SHED YOU FROM THE RANKS
AND THAT I THINK IS POOR POLICY.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NO HANDS UP
REMOTELY ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT.
BOB PRITCHETT ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THIS TRAILER
BILL LET ME START WHICH IS
PROVIDING SOME I THINK
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS- I
THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE AND
DANGEROUS WHEN WE START TO ON
THIS FLOOR GIVE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF SPECIFIC SPECIFIC
CRIMES. BECAUSE WHILE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS SOUND ABSOLUTELY
HORRIFIC AND NONE OF US WOULD
WANT TO BE A VICTIM OF THAT
NONE OF US WOULD WANT TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE PEOPLE
BEING RELEASED WE ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COMMENTS ARE
RELEVANT. ACCURATE IN GERMANE
TO THE BILLS BEFORE US. LET ME
START BY SAYING THIS BUDGET THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET NOR THIS
TRAILER BILL HAS TAKEN ANY
ACTION TO QUOTE D. FUND THE
POLICE THAT IS NOT IN THIS
TRIBUTE. SECONDLY THE ARM.
ACTIVE SERIOUS DISSUADING OF
WITNESSES ARE FILED AS FELONIES
NOT MISDEMEANORS AND SELL THAT
STORY WOULD NOT BE GERMANE TO
THIS TRAILER BILL. POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THERE HAVE BEEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE CDC ARE EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE TESTED POSITIVE. TEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR INMATES MANY MORE THAN
JUST ONE HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED
AND RAGICALLY WE'VE HAD FIFTY
EIGHT INMATE DEATHS. AND I
BELIEVE ONE OR TWO CVC ARE
EMPLOYEE DEATH. AND SO FOR SOME
PEOPLE PERHAPS NOT ALL WHO HAVE
PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS COLBERT
NINETEEN CAN LEAD TO DEATH. AND
SERIOUS LONG TERM AND- WITH
REGARD TO ELDERLY PAROLE- THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN THE TOPIC OF
NUMEROUS RESEARCH STUDY AND
SEVERAL BILLS HEARD BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATURE. THE JUDICIAL
APPOINTED RECEIVER ALL UPDATES
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND WILL
UPDATE ANY MEMBER WHO WAS
INTERESTED. ON WHAT HE SEES
WHAT CORRECTIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
WHY ARE HEALTHCARE COSTS HAVE
BEEN SO QUITE FRANKLY HIGH ON
SINCE HE WAS APPOINTED MANY
YEARS AGO NOW. AND SO I THINK
THE ISSUE OF ELLE THE ELDERLY
PAROLE IS REALLY TWO FOLD YES
IT'S COST SAVINGS BECAUSE IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL WHAT WE ARE PAYING
PARTICULARLY FOR. THE ELDERLY-
IN MAY TO HAVE SERIOUS CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. ON AN A PART OF THE
DIALOGUE HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
RELEASE TO OUTSIDE APPROPRIATE
CARE. ABOUT WHERE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM WOULD QUALIFY
FOR MEDI CAL- FOR THEIR ONGOING
HEALTH CONDITIONS. I APPRECIATE
THE CLARIFICATION ON PROVIDED
BY- SUB FIVE. SHARE. THAT THE
BILL ALLOWS JUDGES TO DO WHAT
PROSECUTORS ALREADY CAN
PROSECUTORS CAN EXTEND THE
VERSION IN ANY CASE INCLUDING
FELONIES JUDGES WILL ONLY BE
ABLE TO DO SO FOR MISDEMEANORS.
THE JUDGE WILL REQUIRE THE
DEFENDANT TO COMPLETE THE SAME
TERMS AND CONDITIONS THAT HE O
SHE WOULD HAVE THEY BEEN
TRADITIONALLY SENTENCE. AGAIN
pSEX OFFENSES DV AND STOCKING.
AGAIN IT ONLY APPLIES TO
MISDEMEANORS NOT FELONY CHARGES
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED IN PRIOR
HEARINGS. I'M SORRY I CAN'T
ELABORATE ON THE COMMENT MADE
WITH REGARD TO L. A. COUNTY MY
HOME COUNTY BECAUSE I'M NOT.
REALLY SURE WHAT THE REFERENCES
TO I'M NOT SURE HOW WHAT
RELATIONSHIP THIS HOUSE WITH
WHATEVER SEVEN L. A. COUNTY.
FLOOD ATTEMPTED TO ANSWER- ALL
OF THE QUESTIONS AND ISSUES
RAISED AND WITH THAT COLLEAGUES
AYE ASTORIA AYE VOTE OF AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS I
FELT I BRADFORD I CABALLERO.
DODD FIVE TERRAZZO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HILL HI HUESO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I NIELSEN.
NO HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER HI. ARCHULETA HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO I. GALGIANI. HURTADO.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE.
MOVING NOW TO OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE AB. THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. BATES BATES AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR NO BATES
NOW FOR JUST. WE'RE JUST AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR NOW
BARGES NOW CHIANG. JAMIE AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR NO
CHIANG NO DALLY. ALI AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR NO VALLEY NOW
GROWTH. CENTER GROVE YOU'RE
MUTED. YEAH GO AHEAD AB THIRTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR NOW. NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ. EIGHTY
THREE TWO THREE FOUR NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK OR OR AB
THREE TWO THREE FOUR NO MORE
LOCK NO MORAL. AB. THREE TWO
THREE FOUR NOW MORALE NO. WILK
AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR NO
WILK NO BUYS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN. AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERON AN ACT RELATING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY AUTHORIZES THE INCREASES
FOR THE BOARDS OF ACUPUNCTURE
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND PODIA
ETTRICK MEDICINE UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND THE STATE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM KNOWN ASK
YOUR- IF REVENUES EXCEED
REASONABLE REGULATORY COSTS
THIS BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
THE REDUCE THE FEE TO THE
REASONABLE REGULATORY COSTS.
FIFTY INCREASES PREVENTIVE
PROGRAMS FROM GOING INSOLVENT
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY
INCREASING SIGNIFICANT
LICENSING BACKLOG. ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
IS OR ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THE FLOOR. SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU I'M OUT OF PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- THERE COULDN'T BE A
MORE DIFFICULT YEAR TO DO A
BUDGET. AND MY COMPLIMENTS TO
THE BUDGET SHARE THE MEMBERS OF
THE STAFF FOR THE GREAT WORK
THAT THEY HAVE DONE. TO BRING
THE BUDGET THROUGH THESE IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO LIBERTY TIMES.
ON THE BILL BEFORE US MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
DEAL WITH FEE INCREASES BY
FOURTEEN HEROES. IT'S THE TIME
OF THE YEAR WHERE BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE TOGETHER
HOLD JOINT HEARINGS HE CALLED
THE SUNSET HEARINGS. IN THE
COURSE OF REVIEWING THEIR ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES AND
OBLIGATIONS. WE LOOK AT THEIR
FISCAL CIRCUMSTANCE. AND
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S JUSTIFICATION FOR
INCREASING FEES. GIVEN THE
DIFFICULTY OF THIS YEAR. MANY
OF SENATE HEARINGS DIDN'T TAKE
PLACE. I WAS ASKED IN THE
COURSE OF THIS BUDGET PROCESS.
WEATHER DOT. HI IS CHAIR OF THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE WOULDBE SUPPORTIVE
OF THESE HE INCREASES. THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS AND BUREAUS
REGULARLY REQUESTS. I INDICATED
THAT I WOULD BE IN FAVOR OF
FEES THAT WERE INCREMENTAL THAT
WOULD DEAL WITH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'RE FACING
THIS YEAR. THAT THEY WERE IN
DEFICIT SITUATIONS TO TRY TO
PULL THEM OUT OF DEFICIT
SITUATIONS. WHAT SURPRISED ME
ABOUT THE TRAILER BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. IS THAT THE BOARDS
IN HEROES DIDN'T JUST ASK FOR
THE INCREMENTAL. THEY ASKED FOR
THE INCREMENTAL AND THEY ASKED
FOR AUTHORITY TO INCREASE THE
FEES SUBSTANTIALLY. AT A HIGHER
PLACE. I THINK THIS GOES
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE. OF WHAT THIS
BUDGET SHOULD BE PROVIDING I
THINK IT GOES BEYOND WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE ASKING OF US- WE
SHOULD BE DEALING WITH THESE
THAT ARE SUNSET PROCESS WHICH
HOPEFULLY IF CONDITIONS IMPROVE
WOULD BEGIN. IN THE COMING YEAR
SO RELUCTANTLY I'M NOT GONNA.
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE TODAY. AND
I WOULD DIE. GAIDAR'S BOARDS TO
BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT. RAISING
THE FEES TO MANY MANY FOLKS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS ACUPUNCTURISTS AND MANY
OTHERS THAT WERE IN THIS IS THE
BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU I HOPE
THAT THEY'LL SHOW RESTRAINT SO
WE CAN HAVE THEM DELIVERED TO
PROCESS GO FORWARD AS IT
NORMALLY DOES. SENATOR MELINDA
IS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SO
SENATOR GLAZER BRIEFLY TOUCHED
ON THE FEET ISSUE AND THIS BILL
BUT I JUST WANTED TO GIVE A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL FOR THE REST
OF THE MEMBERS- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
FIFTY APPLICATION IS GOING TO
GO FROM SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
IT IS A VERY LARGE INCREASE. BE
EXAMINATION FEE GOES TO EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS THE INITIAL
LICENSE FEE GOES FROM THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. THE
RENEWAL FEE GOES FROM THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. THEN WE
HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF NEW FEES
WE HAVE THE SETS THE WALL
LICENSE FEE RENEWAL FEE
REPLACEMENT BE A FIFTY DOLLARS
THERE'S AN ENDORSEMENT THE
THERE'S APPROVAL AND RENEWAL
FEEDERS IN CONTINUING EDUCATION
APPLICATION OUR- FEET. FOR THE
BOARD AND BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE.
FOR MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST. THE APPLICATION AND
RENEWAL FEES GOES FROM SEVENTY
FIVE TO ONE FIFTY APPLICATION
FOR LICENSURE FOR FROM ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS WITH A CAP OF FIVE
HUNDRED FOR CLINICAL
EXAMINATION FROM ONE HUNDRED TO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS WITH
THE CAP OF FIVE HUNDRED FOR
INITIAL LICENSURE. ONE HUNDRED
TO TWO HUNDRED WITH THE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TO TWO HUNDRED
WITH A CAP OF FOUR HUNDRED. IF
YOU FOR THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND
ETHICS EXAMINATION. AT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS GETS A
CAP OF THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
FOR EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST
GOES FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO
FIFTY WITH A CAP OF FIVE
HUNDRED. INITIAL LICENSE FROM
ONE FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED WITH
THE CAP BEFORE IT GOES ON AND
ON AND ON THESE FEES ARE. SOME
OF THEM ARE DOING MORE THAN
JUST DOUBLING OR TRIPLING AND
QUADRUPLING AT A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE ARE LUCKY TO EVEN HAVE A
JOB RIGHT NOW AND- BY THE WAY
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
COME BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE.
NOT ALLOW THE BOARD TO JUST.
INCREASES FEES WHENEVER THEY
SEE FIT OR IN SOME CASES DOUBLE
THAT CANNOT AFFORD THIS THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS TO EVEN SUGGEST I
DON'T KNOW. WHO IN THEIR RIGHT
MIND WOULD THINK THAT THIS OF
ALL TIMES IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE IN THIS COUNTRY. OF ALL
TIMES IS THAT THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME WHERE WE SHOULD BE
INCREASING FEES IN INSTITUTING
NEW FEES FOR PEOPLE JUST TO BE
ABLE TO WORK. YOU'RE LUCKY TO
EVEN HAVE A JOB. SO I WOULD
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR GORGEOUS.
CLARIFICATION ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR WOULD YOU CHECK IN
RESIDENT WHICH IS HAPPY AND
INQUIRY CLARIFICATION INQUIRY
SENATOR BORCHERS YOUR
CLARIFICATION IN FOR INCLUDE
PLEASE. THANK YOU SIR THIS
WOULD INCREASE THE FEE FOR THE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
UTILIZATION REVIEW. I ASCRIBING
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS SPENCER'S
AND WHOLESALERS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES DOES THAT INCLUDE
FOLKS IN THE MARIJUANA INDUSTRY
AS WELL. CLOSE SHE SAID SHE
WAS- SHE WILL ADDRESS SAID IN
HER CLOTHES. IT'S A SIMPLE YES
OR NO. SHE CAN ADDRESS IT IN
HER CLOTHES IF THAT IS HER
CHOICE UNLESS YOU PREFER
OTHERWISE. AND I'M NOT TRYING
TO AVERT THE QUESTION I DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWER IN FRONT OF ME
SO I OFFERED TO ANSWER PROVIDED
IN MY CLOTHES LIKE TO GET STAFF
TO GET ME THE QUESTION TO GET
ME THE ANSWER YOU'RE-
REQUESTING. THAT'S WHY I'LL BE
RESPONDING TO MY CLOSE. MAN
PRESENT. WOULD IT BE A WOULD IT
BE OKAY IF I RESERVE MY SPOT.
TO FOLLOW UP AFTER SHE GET
YOUR- QUESTION ANSWERED IT IS
NOT SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO ACCEPT
THE QUESTION. SHE'S INDICATED
SHE WILL ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
IN HER CLOTHES. WELL. HERE'S
HERE'S MY DILEMMA SO LET'S
LET'S ASSUME THAT ON THE FLOOR
MANAGER FINDS OUT THAT
MARIJUANA IS INCLUDED. ONE OF
THE FOLKS THE MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY ARE INCLUDED IN THE
CATEGORY OF DISPENSERS AND
WHOLESALERS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES. I DON'T THEY ARE
NOT LET'S ASSUME THEY ARE. WE
JUST VOTED ONLY. MINUTES BACK
ON EXEMPTING EIGHT TAX INCREASE
FOR FOLKS IN THE MARIJUANA
INDUSTRY. AND THE MAJORITY OF
FOLKS SUPPORTED THAT THAT
SUSPENSION OF A TAX INCREASE
BUT NOW IF MARIJUANA IS
INCLUDED IN THIS FEE INCREASE I
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW FOLKS CAN
RECONCILE THE TWO POSITIONS I
THINK. BUT I'LL WAIT FOR THE
ANSWER FROM THE FLOOR MANAGER
AND I HOPE MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
CD. EXENCIAL IRONY HERE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR PURCHASES
OR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NON. NO HAN TO UP NO MIKE'S UP
SENATOR MITCHELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND TO
RESPOND OFF THE TOP FOR MY
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE CANNABIS. TO CLARIFY ON
THE PREVIOUS OF TRAILER BILL WE
JUST VOTED ON I THOUGHT I MADE
THE STATEMENT. IT DIDN'T
ELIMINATE ALL TAX COLLECTIONS
THAT ELIMINATED AN INCREASE OF
THE TAXES FOR ONE YEAR PERIOD.
I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
PERSPECTIVE AND GOING DOWN THE
LIST OF THE BOARDS AND WHAT THE
RATE OF THE INCREASE WOULD BE
ONE CRITICAL FACTOR WAS NOT
SHARED. ALL OF THESE BOARDS ARE
SELF FUNDING THEY DON'T HIT THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR THEIR SELF
FUNDING AND SOME OF THE ACTUAL
BOARDS THAT WERE REFERENCED ARE
VERY CLOSE TO BEING INSOLVENT
ARE HAVING ZERO BALANCE. MANY
OF THEM HAVE ALSO NOT.
LEVERAGED INCREASES FOR TWENTY
OR THIRTY YEARS. I APPRECIATE
THE TIME NOW IS COMPLICATED BUT
IT WILL BE MORE COMPLICATED IF
THEY TAKE NO ACTION AND THEY
ARE INSOLVENT. THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES IS
PROJECTED TO HAVE A NEGATIVE
FUND BALANCE OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION. BOMB OR NEGATIVE ONE
MONTH IN RESERVE BY THE END OF.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE BOARD IS
NOT RAISE FEES FOR THE MAJORITY
OF THIS LICENSE CATEGORIES IN
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS PODIATRY
THE BOARD OF THE ATTIC MEDICINE
THE BOARD. ON AGAIN NEEDS A
PERMIT FEE INCREASE TO ENSURE
FUND'S SOLVENCY. THAT'S THE
INCREASE WILL ONLY GENERATE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THEY HAVE A FINE
BALANCE OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR TWO POINT
THREE MONTHS IN RESERVE BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD IS PROJECTED
TO HAVE A FUND BALANCE OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN SIX
MONTHS IN RESERVE. THE FEE
INCREASE WILL GENERATE ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION. THE
CLIMBING TO EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND BEYOND. THAT
BOARD IS NOT RAISE THE MAJORITY
OF ITS FEES SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. AND SO I WANTED TO
PUT THAT IN CONTEXT THAT YES IT
FEELS LIKE SOME OF THE FEES ARE
DOUBLING. BUT THEY HAVEN'T
CHANGED IN TWENTY AND IN SOME
INSTANCES THIRTY YEARS THIS IS
OUR EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE BOARD STAY SOLVENT THEY
SERVE A CRITICAL ROLE IN
OVERSIGHT AND PROTECTION OF
THOSE LICENSEES. AGAIN THEY ARE
SELF FUNDED WITH ALL FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I'M ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BELL AYE BRADFORD AYE CABRERA.
DODD HI TORONTO FIVE GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HILL I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON EARLY AYE LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NO HAN. PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I
STERN HI NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WIENER. I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. CABALLERO. GLAZER. PAN
AMBERG. LET'S MOVE OVER TO THE
REMOTE MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY. WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR BATES BASICS BATES A.
B. THIRTY THREE THIRTY NO FACE
NOW FORGES. WE'RE JUST AB THREE
THREE THREE ZERO NO. FOR JUST
NO CHIANG CHIANG AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY NOW CHIANG NO
DALLI DALLI AB THREE THREE
THREE ZERO NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
AB THREE THREE THREE ZERO NO
GROVE NO MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ.
EIGHTY THREE THREE ZERO YEAH
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB THREE
THREE THREE ZERO NO MORLOCK NO
MORAL. AB THREE THREE THREE
ZERO AM AROUND NOW MORRELL NO
WILK. WILK AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY NO WILK NOW HIS TWENTY
FIVE KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVE. YEAH.
ALREADY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ALONG NOW TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR
MITCHELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO ENFORCEMENT OF
JUDGMENTS SENATOR MITCHELL THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS RELATED
TO THE STATE'S HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION WHICH PROTECTS THE
EQUITY IN A HOMEOWNER'S PRIMARY
RESIDENCE DURING BANKRUPTCY.
CURRENT LOSSES THE HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION AT EITHER. SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND BASED O OF THE
HOMEOWNER. THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE
LOW WHEN COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE VALUE OF THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION TO THE
HIGHER OF EITHER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR THE COUNTY WIDE
MEDIAN HOME PRICE NOT TO EXCEED
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND. AND
ANNUALLY ADJUST EXEMPTION FOR
INFLATION. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO PROTECT HOMEOWNERS
DURING THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
TURMOIL. UNTIL LINE
CALIFORNIA'S HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION WITH THOSE OF OTHER
STATES. I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
IS OR ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM ON THE FLOOR.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP GOING
OVER TO THE- REMOTE MEMBERS
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I BOUGHT- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL- IN THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T SEEM TO ME THAT IT WAS A
BUDGET BILL BUT- AFTER DOING A
LITTLE BIT MORE RESEARCH. I AM
CHANGING MY POSITION TO A
SUPPORT- JUST BASED ON THE SAME
ARGUMENT OVER. THE PREVIOUS
BILL- INFLATION ETCETERA- THE-
HOMESTEAD AMOUNT SHOULD GO UP
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MEDICARE'S. THANK YOU SIR MORE
LOOK ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NO HANDS UP
REMOTELY AND NO MICROPHONES. UP
HERE SENATOR MITCH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. ALL RIGHT SHE
HAS OPTED NOT TO ENSURE WE WILL
ASK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS I TELL I BRADFORD.
BECAUSE I OTHER. FIVE DODD I
DURAZO'S. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI HILL
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON AYE AYE LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY I
NIELSEN. I PAN I PORTANTINO. I.
ROSS. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN HI NUMBER HI WE CASKEY I
WIENER HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BRADFORD. LORD LET'S MOVE OVER
TO THE REMOTE MEMBERS PLEASE
CALL. THE FOR THEIR VOTES ON
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR BATES WILL
START WITH YOU. BATES. IF
YOU'RE ON MUTE SENATOR SENATOR
WE GET CHINESE. YOU'RE ON ROUTE.
BATES EIGHTY EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE NOT VOTING OR ABSTAINING.
GORGEOUS. WE'RE JUST AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE STAINED.
CHIANG. HEY EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE ARE CARING I DALY.
AB EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE AND STATE.
GROWTH AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
NO GROVE NO. MELENDEZ BLENDED
AB. ONE EIGHT EIGHT FIVE. EIGHT
MORLOCK. YOU'RE A MUSICIAN. MY
APOLOGIES MADAM PRESIDENT MORE
LOGIC AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE I
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE MORALE. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE NOW R. L.
NO WILK. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE HI WILK HI RISE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
COLLEAGUES- WE'RE GOING TO GO
NOW TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY FIVE
WILL BE RETURNED TO THE
ASSEMBLY. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW TO A BACK TO THE BUDGET
BILLS FILE ITEM. SHE REGISTERED.
SIXTY SIX. WE'RE GOING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB ONE OH
SEVEN. SENATOR MITCHELL NAY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH SEVEN BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACTUAL LEADING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS
THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. FLORIDA
CONSULTATION WITH THE TREASURER
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
THAT TAX VOUCHER PROGRAM TO BE
SUBMITTED BY THE LEGISLATURE NO
LATER THAN MARCH FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. REQUIRES THE
EMPLOYMENT AVAILABLE DEPARTMENT
TO MAKE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION AND UPDATES
REGARDING UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
THE INFORMATION WILL BE POSTED
ON THE WEBSITE AND MUST BE
UPDATED EVERY TWO WEEKS UNTIL
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
REQUIRES THE F. T. V. FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO TRANSFER SPECIFIED
INCOME VERIFICATION INFORMATION
TO EDT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ADMINISTRATING A NUMBER OF THE
DAY BUT MINISTRY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAMS. AND IT
ABOLISHES TO SPECIAL FUNDS THE
STATE CORPORATIONS FUND IN THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FUNDING
CREATES A SINGLE SUCCESSOR FUN
THE FINANCIAL PROTECTION FUN
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK SENATOR MITCHELL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR.
SENATOR MELENDEZ. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITHIN THIS BILL
PROBABLY SHOULD BE WITH AN
AUDIT FOR EDT DISPEL CREATES- A
NEW PROGRAM THAT WE ARE NOT
REALLY LOOKING AT. THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE FACING RIGHT
NOW IN THE STATE WITH RESPECT
TO PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO JUST
LET AND PAY THE BILLS AND THAT
IS EDT. SOUGHT ME SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT HAPPENED- JUST. TODAY
ACTUALLY- IN MY DISTRICT. A
CONSTITUENT. CAME TO THE OFFICE
AND DROPPED OFF FORTY NINE
PIECES OF MAIL THAT WERE
DELIVERED TO HIS HOME. I AM EDT.
THIS CONSTITUENT HAS LIVED IN
THIS HOME FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS. HE GOT FORTY NINE PIECES
OF MAIL DELIVERED- ADDRESS TO
TWENTY THREE DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
THERE WERE OVERPAYMENTS AND
THERE THERE WERE CERTIFICATION
PAPER PAPERWORK FORMS AND THERE
THERE WERE DEBIT CARDS IN THERE.
AND THEY CAME FROM ATWOOD
RIVERSIDE SAN JOSE SAN DIEGO
CHULA VISTA BUENA PARK WEST
SACRAMENTO RANCHO CORDOVA IN
SACRAMENTO ALSO STAND BERNIE
DINO. FORTY NINE PIECES OF MAIL
ADDRESSED TO TWENTY THREE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE ALL SENT TO
THE SAME ADDRESS TO SOMEONE
WHO'S LIVED THERE FOR NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS. HIS NAME WASN'T
ON ANY OF THOSE FORMS BY THE
WAY. SO CLEARLY WE HAVE A
PROBLEM. WITH EDT. THEY'RE NOT
ANSWERING BY THE MOST RECENT
REPORTS 60% OF THE CALLS THAT
THEY'RE GETTING AND APPARENTLY
THEY CAN'T GET THE MONEY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
ENTITLED TO IT AND NEED IT AND
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THEY ARE
SENDING FORTY NINE PIECES OF
MAIL TO THE SAME ADDRESS TO
TWENTY THREE DIFFERENT. PEOPLE
THIS BILL SHOULD HAVE AN AUDIT.
AND ET DE AND THERE AYE
UNDERSIDE PUT- SOME AMENDMENTS
ACROSS THE DESK I BELIEVE.
PLEASE I HOPE SENATOR NIELSEN
HAS THEM. IS THERE A WAY TO.
PERHAPS MADAM PRESIDENT CHECK
WITH HIM TO SEE IF HE HAS SOME
IDEAS BUT THEM ACROSS THE DESK.
WELL SHOW- WE ARE MAKING COPIES
SENATOR MELINDA SO THAT THEY
CAN BE PASSED OUT TO THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE- BODY SO IF
YOU. ARE INTENDING TO BRING
THAT UP NOW IF YOU JUST WAIT SO
WE CAN SHARE A PAST AMOUNT
THANK YOU. YEAH.
SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR PURPOSE JUST AS
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE COPIES TO
BE DISTRIBUTED JUST TO- SHARE
WITH OUR COLLEAGUE. YOU CHECK
FOR EMAIL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST AS WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE AND THEN THIS JUST TO
SHARE INFORMATION WITH EVERYONE
THERE'S BEEN AN EMERGENCY AUDIT
REQUESTS MADE BY THE ASSEMBLY
CHAIR OF THE JAYLA AND THE
SENATOR VICE CHAIR IS
CONCURRING WITH THAT AND WE
EXPECT THAT TO PROCEED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE J. LACK
RULES SO TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTION RAISED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE AN AUDIT IS
FORTHCOMING- FOUR EDT. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL. OKAY LET
LET'S JUST WAIT THERE STILL
BEING DISTRIBUTED. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
NOW HAVE A COPY OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS THERE A MOTION.
THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE I'M
SORRY. MATANCERA BY MAJOR
EXPLAIN WHAT THE AMENDMENT YES
IF YOU IF YOU'LL JUST WAIT ONE
MOMENT SO WE CAN ALL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THEM.
SURE. YEAH. YEAH.
THE CARD IS
EVERYONE HAD TIME TO READ THE
AMENDMENTS. WITH THAT IN MIND.
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK PLEASE PRESENT. OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE SORT
OF AMENDMENTS AND THEN SENATOR
MELINDA SHE'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT. MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ THE
AMENDMENTS. YEAH AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ SAT ONE.
SENATOR MELINDA'S PLEASE
PRESENT ON THE AMENDMENTS. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SAID THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD REQUIRE AN
AUDIT IF EDG BEFORE JULY FIRST
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND I
BELIEVE THE- THE AUDIT THAT
CENTER MITCHELL WAS TALKING
ABOUT A TAKES PLACE AFTER THAT
DATE SO THIS WOULD REQUIRED ON
A DVD BEFORE JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FOR THAT
AUDIT TO INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING
THE MEDIAN NUMBER OF DAYS TO
RESOLVE MY CLAIM. THE MEDIAN
NUMBER OF DAYS BETWEEN
APPLICATION BEING COMPLETED AND
A CLAIMANT RECEIVING BENEFITS
THE PERCENTAGE OF INITIAL
CLAIMS THAT ARE REJECTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT THE MEDIAN NUMBER OF
DAYS FOR THE RESOLUTION OF A
CLAIM THAT HAS BEEN APPEALED BY
THE APPLICANT THE OUTCOMES
WHETHER SUSTAINED OR OVERTURNED
OF AN APPEALED CLAIMS. WE HAVE.
I EVERYONE IN HERE IS AWARE OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE EDT ON
THE SENATE SIDE AND ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE AND I THINK
EVERYONE IS FRUSTRATED AND I
THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME
TO BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT. ON THE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHAT IN THE WORLD IS GOING ON
EIGHT EDT AND HOW TO FIX IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEPENDING ON THAT MONEY JUST TO
GET BY AND IT IS NOT GOING TO
FIX ITSELF. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. FOR PURPOSES OF THE
MOTION TO A LADY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU THIS MOTION IS NON
DEBATABLE. THE MAJORITY. LEADER
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THE-
SENATOR MELENDEZ CHEST FOR NO
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MAJORITY
LEADERS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR MELINDA THIS IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELL I BRADFORD HI CABRERO I
DODD. HI THE RAZA HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HI HILL HI WITH SO. I HER TADO
HI JACKSON AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN.
NO HAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN FIVE
AMBERG I WACO SKI HI WIENER. I
MOVING OVER TO OUR COLLEAGUES.
REMOTELY VOTING WE WILL START
WITH THE SENATOR. BATES WHO IS
I BELIEVE THE MOTION IS. TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE IF
YOU WOULD IDENTIFY THAT IS THE
MOTION AND YOUR VOTE PLEASE.
BATES AS MOTION TO LAY ON THE
TEAM THAT'S ON THE TABLE NO
BATES NOW FOR JUST. THIS MOTION
THE LAY MEMBERS ON THE TABLE
NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. ANY
MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW CHIANG NO DALLY
L. A. MOTION TO LAY THE MINUTES
ON THE TABLE NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
BURROUGHS. GROSS MOTION TO LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NO
GROWTH NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
MOTION TO LAY THEAMEND ON THE
TABLE NOW MELENDEZ NO MORLOCK.
THE MOST TO LAY THEM MELENDEZ
MOTION ON THE TABLE NO. MORLOCK
NO MORALE WELL MOTION THE LADY
IN THEM AND THIS ON THE TABLE
VOTING NO MORALE NO WILK. WILK
NOTED DELAYED THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE NOW. WILK NOW. HIS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MOTION TO LAY THE ON AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE PASSES WE WILL NOW
RETURN TO THE BILL IN CHIEF. IS
THERE ANY OTHER. SHINO
MICROPHONES UP AND NO HANDS UP
TO FURTHER DISCUSS THE MOTION
IN CHIEF SENATOR. AND
PRESIDENT. YES SENATOR GROVE
WHAT IS YOUR POINT PLEASE- CAN
YOU PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE AD THERE
RIVERSIDE DOWN SOUTH AREA WAS
ABLE TO FINISH HER COMMENTS AND
DID NOT HAVE A SEPARATE
COMMENTS AFTER. IT WAS
SUBMITTED. WE HAVE JUST GONE TO
THE MOTION. THE ITEM IN CHIEF
AND THOSE SENATOR MELINDA'S DID
NOT INDICATE- OR HAVE HER HAND
UP A SENATOR MELINDA IS DID YOU
HAVE ANYTHING. FURTHER ON THE
MOTION IN CHIEF. HERE OWN MUSIC.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
JUST. YOU KNOW WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE ISSUE OF EVERYONE IN
THESE CHAMBERS KNOWING THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOW EDT IS
OPERATING AND HOW CALIFORNIANS
ARE LEFT. TRYING TO CALL THEM
EVERY HOUR AND NOT GETTING
THROUGH NOT GETTING A CALL BACK
NOT GETTING AN EMAIL BACK
HAVING TO REACH OUT TO THEIR
LEGISLATORS TO TRY TO HELP
THEM- MAKE SOME HEADWAY ALL FOR
MONEY THAT THEY ARE OWED THAT
THEY SIMPLY CANNOT ACCESS.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
BUT BECAUSE EDT HAS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM AND- WE KNOW WE WANT TO
HELP EDT SOLVE WHATEVER PROBLEM
IT IS THAT THEY HAVE BUT OF
COURSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE UNLESS WE ALLOW.
AND AUDITS WHICH- I GUESS NOT
ALL OF US AGREE SHOULD HAPPEN
BUT THIS THIS BILL JUST DOESN'T
SATISFY THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS- SO I WOULD JUST
ASK AND HOPEFULLY. THERE ANY OF
THE OTHER BY TO LIKE TO ALSO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON THIS BILL
I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT PEOPLE
REALLY TAKE PAUSE AND THINK
ABOUT. WHAT IS BEING PASSED IN
THIS BILL AND WHETHER OR NOT IT
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY AND IN A WAY THAT THEY
DESPERATELY NEED RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU THANK. YOU CENTER
MELINDA CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AB RIGHT TO
WOULD LIKE TO JUST TAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AND- ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE SAID- THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS THAT- REPUBLICAN TEXAS
REQUESTED AN- AUDIT ON THE EDT
WHEN ALL THESE PROBLEMS WORK-
TAKING PLACE- MONTHS AGO. WHEN
WE'D LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID-
PHONE CALLS WERE COMING INTO
OUR OFFICE. THOUSANDS OF CALLS-
PEOPLE HAVING TO WAIT PEOPLE
HAVING NO RESPONSES. PEOPLE
HAVING TO MAKE MULTIPLE PHONE
CALLS BEFORE THEY EVEN GOT A
LIVE PERSON TO RETURN THEIR
CALL- MY OFFICE WAS INUNDATED
WITH CALLS WE REACHED OUT TO
THE EDT- WE- TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THESE BENEFITS ARE
PAID. AGAIN THESE BENEFITS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PAID THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I'M REQUIRES THESE
BENEFITS TO BE ADMINISTERED TO.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING THAT DON'T
HAVE A JOB- AND- THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT SPENDING
ARE THERE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT
MANY. ISSUE TO THEM. 87% OF
THAT WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS. AND
CALIFORNIA HAS SEVERELY FAILED
AGAIN THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS JUST A COME OUT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC. WAS AN AUDIT
IN THE PAST- THAT AUDITED DVD
D. FOR A PERIOD OF TEN YEARS.
AND IT'S CAME IT CAME BACK AND
IT DETERMINED THAT THAT WAS
INADEQUATE AND DEFICIENT. AND
YET WE DID NOTHING ABOUT IT.
AND NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC WHEN- ARE AT
CONSTITUENTS. I DESPERATELY
NEED THESE RESOURCES TO KEEP
FOOD ON THE TABLE PAY THEIR
RENT. BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNMENT
THE GOVERNOR'S MANDATED SHUT
DOWN THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO GO TO
WORK THEIR- FOOD ON THEIR TABLE
AND THIS IS THE ONLY. THAT THEY
HAVE THE TO PAY BILLS AND THE
EDT IS STILL NOT PER. AND I
THINK THAT TO PASS THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND NOT INCLUDE
THE AMENDMENTS FROM MY GOOD
REPUBLICAN NAVY VETERAN THAT
SUBMITTED THOSE OF AMENDMENTS-
IS UNACCEPTABLE I THINK THOSE
AMENDMENT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TAKEN SO THAT THE EDT WOULD BE
I DID. I THINK THAT ALL OF YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED MANY
CONSTITUENT CALLS AND- AUDITING
THE EDT WOULD BE A FIRST STEP
FORWARD I HAVE FOR THE LIFE OF
ME DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE
WOULD NOT ALLOW MISS LINDA'S
AMENDMENTS TO GO FORWARD SO
THAT WE COULD AUDIT THE EDT IN
INCLUDED IN THIS. BILL AND I IT
JUST IT MAKES NO SENSE YOU'VE
GOT TO CARE ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HURTING THAT ARE
RECEIVING THEIR CHECKS THAT-
DDT IS FAILING TO PAY YOU LOOK
AT THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
SAID. AB FIVE THAT WE HAVE THAT
THE DEMOCRATS IN THIS BUILDING
IN MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE HAVE VOTED
FOR TO ELIMINATE THEIR JOBS AND
THEN ADDITIONAL DOLLARS WERE
PROVIDED TO INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT MONEY IS
STILL NOT BEING PUT OUT. THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND THE
LAST ESTIMATE THAT WE HAD WAS
OVER ONE MILLION PEOPLE HAD NOT
YET RECEIVED THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEEDED AND WE ARE MONTHS
INTO THIS PANDEMIC AND MONTHS
WITHOUT PEOPLE WITHOUT A JOB IN
MONTHS WITH THE GOVERNMENT SHUT
DOWN WHERE PEOPLE CAN'T WORK
THEY'RE FORCED TO STAY AT HOME
THEIR FORCE NOT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. FOR THEIR FAMILY PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE AND- A SIMPLE
REQUEST. AND MISS LINDA THIS
WAS TO AUDIT THE EDT INCLUDING
A LETTER THAT REPUBLICANS DID
PREVIOUSLY DENIED- AND THEN THE
AMENDMENTS NOT EVEN. I'M BEING
ACCEPTED. I THINK THAT SOME ANY.
AND I THINK WITH THE ET. I TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE IN OUR
DISTRICTS PAID. THIS BILL
SHOULD NOT BE FORWARD SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK- FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
FURTHER DEBATER DOES. ON THE
SEEING AND HEARING SENATOR
MITCH YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON MADAM PRESIDENT I
THINK I HAVE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
ENTIRE SENATE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE ON THE TWENTY
NINTH OF JULY THE GOVERNOR TOOK
ACTION TO ESTABLISH THIS. TEAM
SUPPORTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN OFFICE OF DIGITAL
INNOVATION TO IDENTIFY STEPS.
TO TRANSFORM THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE THE STRIKE TEAM IS
SUPPOSED TO DELIVER
RECOMMENDATIONS WITHIN FORTY
FIVE DAYS OF THAT DATE. THE
MEMBERS THAT WERE LAID ON THE
TABLE ASKED FOR AN AUDIT THAT.
WOULDN'T BEGIN UNTIL JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A FULL YEAR
FROM NOW SO I KNOW MARKETS.
THAT ARE CALLING WANT
RESOLUTION TODAY NOT TO WAIT
FOR THE OUTCOME OF AN AUDIT
THAT WON'T EVEN START FOR YEAR.
AND LET ME BE CLEAR- LET THIS.
TRAILER BILL DOES IS IT
REQUIRES THE E. D. D. TO MAKE
POLICY PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION AND UPDATES
REGARDING UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE POSTED
ON THE EDT WEBSITE AND MUST BE
UPDATED EVERY TWO WEEKS SO WHAT
THIS TRAILER BUT BUILT US WHICH
WILL TAKE ACTION BEFORE THE
OUTCOME OF THE AUDIENCE WILL
TOOL WOULD BE TO ALLOW OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO GO TO A WEBSITE
AND SEE THE STATUS OF THEIR
CLAIM. YES THE EIGHTY THE THESE
TO BE AUDITED WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT. POLICIES WE NEED TO
PUT IN PLACE TO IMPROVE THEIR
OUTCOME. BUT CONSTITUENTS AND
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT TO START AN AUDIT IN JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. J. LACK
WILL TAKE ACTION TOMORROW THAT
AUDIT COULD BE COMPLETED
HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE CALENDAR
YEAR. AND AGAIN THIS TRAILER
BILL WILL PROVIDE IMMEDIATELY
IMMEDIATE INFORMATION UPDATED
EVERY TWO WEEKS TO ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FOR THOSE REASONS
I'M ASKING. FOR AN AYE VOTE
THIS. CASE USE ME. EXCUSE ME
THE SENATORS CLOSING ALLOW THE
TO CLOSE WITHOUT INTERRUPTION.
THE DEBATE IS SEIZED CENTER
MITCHELL DID YOU HAVE MORE ART
ASKED ADULTS ALL RIGHT WELL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED. PUT. THE
CENTER MELENDEZ FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DEBATED SHE SAYS IT'S
TIME TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE MA'AM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I AM NOT
LOOKING TO CONTINUE THE DEBATE
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
AMENDMENTS AND I ASK FOR DO NOT
CALL FOR AN AUDIT. JULY OF NEXT
YEAR IT CALLS FOR AN AUDIT
BEFORE JULY TWENTY FIRST OF
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA BY
ATKINS I TELL I BRADFORD. I
HAVE ITEM. I DODD FIVE TO RAZA
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. HI HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO I
JACKSON HI I LEYVA. I REQUIRE.
I MITCHELL HI MY NAME. I
NIELSEN NO HAN. FIVE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERN I AM BERG I WAKE HOUSEKI.
I WIENER. I CITIZENS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME ON THE FLOOR. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY OR LET'S
MOVE OVER TO OF THOSE VOTING
REMOTELY THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT AB ONE OH SEVEN.
SENATOR BATES. BATES BATES AB
ONE OH SEVEN NO BASE NOW FOR
JUST. BOARD CENTER BORDERS HERE
ON MUTE. I THINK THE MA'AM I
THINK THE FORMATS CHANGE
BUTTONS ARE COMING UP AND THEY
DIDN'T YESTERDAY. ORDERS AB ONE
OH SEVEN NOW THANK YOU. FORTUS
NO. CHIANG TANG AB ONE OH SEVEN
NOW CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI AB
ONE OH SEVEN NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
AND GROWTH AB ONE OH SEVEN NO
GROWTH NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
ONE ZERO SEVEN NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. AB ONE OH SEVEN NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. FOR AB ONE
OH SEVEN VOTING NO. MORALE NO
WILK. WILK AB ONE OH SEVEN NO
WILK NOW MY AGE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE AB SIXTY NINE. ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I'M
SORRY EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. FILE
ITEM SIXTY THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATING TO FEES AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT EVERY POINT THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL PROCESS
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW AUTHORIZES
COUNTIES TO CHARGE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. THESE FEES
ARE LEVIED ON TOP OF MONETARY
SANCTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
IMPOSES ON PEOPLE WHO'VE
COMMITTED AN INFRACTION OR
OFFENSE FOR EXAMPLE. FINES
PENALTY ASSESSMENTS AND
RESTITUTION. THESE PLEASE HELP
FOR A LONG TIME
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. WITH RISING
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES THE RISE. IN
THE ECONOMY HEADING DOWNWARDS
TOWARDS AS A RESULT OF CALL THE
NINETEEN. PEOPLE WILL BE
INCREASINGLY UNABLE TO PAY
REDUCED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
RELATED FIELD LET ALONE FOR
FOOD HEALTHCARE AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES. SO EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE OF THE PUBLIC FIFTY
TRAILER BILL THAT EFFECTIVE
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REPEALS THE TWENTY THREE MOST
COMMONLY LEVIED AND OPPRESSIVE
FEES THAT COMPOUND THE FISCAL
BURDENS THAT THESE IMPACT THE
GROUP'S ENCOUNTER THIS BILL
DOES NOT ELIMINATE FINES
PENALTY ASSESSMENT OR
RESTITUTION PAYMENTS IT DOES
NOT ELIMINATE RESTITUTION
PAYMENTS THE BILL MAKES THE
UNPAID BALANCE IS RELATED TO
THE ELIMINATED FEES
UNCOLLECTIBLE AND ANNUALLY
APPROPRIATE SIXTY FIVE MILLION
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
FISCAL YEAR IN CLOSER TO THE
COUNTIES TO BACKFILL REVENUE
LOST FROM THE REPEAL OF THESE
FEES SPECIFIED IN THIS BILL THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS THE
FINALIZED THE ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP ON THE
FLOOR. NCINO HANDS UP ON THE
REMOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I DON HI
THE RAZA. HI GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HILL I HUESO. HI HURTADO HI
JACKSON HI AYE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE
I MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN NO
HAN. I PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER I WACO SKI I WIENER I.
TO OUR REMOTE COLLEAGUES WE ARE
TAKING UP AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE FILE ITEM ITEM SIXTY THREE
YEAR VOTE PLEASE SENATOR BATES.
BATES AS AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS WE'RE JUST
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
UPSTATE. CHIANG THANK AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE NOW CHIANG
NO DALLI DALLI AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
AND GROWTH AB ONE EIGHT SIX
NINE NO GROWTH NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB. ONE EIGHT SIX NINE
NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE I. MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. FOR L. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE VOTING NOW MORRELL
NO WILK. WILK AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE NOW WILK NO I H. THIRTY NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. GIVE
US ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR
CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TO AN ACT RELATING TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN RELIEF AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
PROBABLY ERA THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
A CRITICAL MEASURE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS FIRST LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF THE CO AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADVOCATES FOR THE EXTENSIVE
NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. AS YOU KNOW
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
EMERGENCY RULE ONE WILL BE
RESCINDED TOMORROW AND TENDANCE
ACROSS THE STATE WILL BE AT
RISK OF EVICTION THAT IS WHY WE
MISSED OUT TODAY TO ESTABLISH
NEW PROTECTIONS TO GET US
THROUGH THE NEXT FEW MONTHS TO
PREVENT A WAVE OF MASS
EVICTIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WITH NO
CLEAR END IN SIGHT. THE YOUNG
PRINCE PRESIDENT AND JOB LOSS
EXPERIENCED BY TENANTS HAVE
LEFT MANY LANDLORDS STRUGGLING
TO CATCH UP TO COVER THE RENTS
AND THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
THEY HAVE THIS BURDEN IS
ESPECIALLY HARD FOR SMALL MOM
AND POP LANDLORDS WHO DEPEND ON
RENTAL IN INCOME TO COVERING
COVER THEIR LIVING EXPENSES. TO
GET OUT OF THIS EMERGENCY WE
MUST TAKE WE MUST PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL RENT RELIEF TO HELP
MAKE LANDLORDS HOLE WHILE
SHE'LL EAT FIELDING TENANTS
FROM TAKING ON MOUNTAINS OF
DEBT FROM THE MISSED PAYMENTS
FOR TENANTS AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT SET UP A MULTI PHASE
APPROACH THE FIRST PHASE
FOCUSES ON THE INITIAL PANDEMIC
PERIOD WHICH WAS. DECLARED
MARCH THIRTEENTH THROUGH
TOMORROW AND IT PROVIDED A TEN
A CANNOT BE EVICTED FOR RENT
MISTER IN THIS TIME THE NEXT
PHASE IS THE TRANSITION PERIOD
FROM SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO JANUARY THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ATTENDANT IS
IT IS REQUIRE AIRED DURING THIS
PHASE TO PAY IT. 20% OF THE
RENT EACH MONTH DURING THIS
PERIOD AND THE REST OF THE RENT
OWED CANNOT BE THE BASIS FOR AN
EVICTION. IF I TENANTS IS
UNABLE TO PAY 25% OF THE RENT
DO THE NORMAL ADDICTION PERSIK
PROCEEDINGS CAN HAPPEN IN
FEBRUARY. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PAST DUE RENT IS STILL OWED TO
THE LANDLORD THIS RENT IS
CONVERTED TO A CONSUMER DEBT.
AND CAN CAN BE COLLECTED IN
SMALL CLAIMS COURT TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LANDLORDS TO RECOVER
WHAT THEY'RE OWED AND EASIER
FOR TENANTS TO BE ABLE TO GO
INTO COURT WITHOUT THE HIGH
COST OF LITIGATION. TO QUALIFY
FOR EVICTION PROTECTIONS AFTER
SEPTEMBER FIRST TENANTS MUST
ALSO ATTEST THAT THEY
EXPERIENCED A HIGH. EIGHT
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
HARDSHIP BY SIGNING A
DECLARATION UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY. HI INCOME TENANTS MUST
MAKE AN ADDITIONAL THE- THEY
MUST PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENT DOCUMENTATION OF
HARDSHIP IN THAT HIGH INCOME
TENANTS OR TENANTS EARNING OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARSA
YEAR. THE BILL ALSO PROTECTS
THE AUTHORITY OF EXISTING LOCAL
ORDINANCES SO TENANTS IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE MORE
PROTECTIVE LOCAL ORDINANCES CAN
STILL RELY ON THOSE PROTECTIONS
UNTIL THEY EXPIRED. FINALLY FOR
LANDLORDS THIS BILL EXTENDS THE
HOMEOWNER BILL OF RIGHTS ANTI
FORECLOSURE PROTECTIONS TO
SMALL LANDLORDS AND PUT IN
PLACE CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURES. TO REQUIRE BANKS TO
FOLLOW APPLICABLES FEDERAL
GUIDELINES REGARDING BORROWER
OPTIONS AFTER OFFERING COVERED.
NINETEEN RELATED FOR PARENTS.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION. IF WE ALL
HAD A CRYSTAL BALL WE'D LOOK AT
IT AND WE KNOW WHEN THE
COVERAGE- PANDEMIC IS GOING TO
END. WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
THE ECONOMY WHEN ARE PEOPLE
GOING TO GET BACK TO WORK NONE
OF THAT IS POSSIBLE AT THIS
TIME. SO AFTER THIS BILL IS
SIGNED OUR WORK STILL CONTINUES
TO PREPARE FOR THE NEW YEAR
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WERE AT THE
TABLE WITH THOSE. TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO DIRECT FUTURE FEDERAL
AND STATE MONIES INTO RELIEF
FOR TENANTS LANDLORDS AND
HOMEOWNERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AND I BOUGHT. THANK YOU
CENTER W. AERO THE BILL
RECESSION. DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR BARNABY
THREE. I'M SORRY PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY IT IS YES WELL THEN WE
GOT TO THE ACCURATE ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO- CALL FOR A REPUBLICAN
COCCUS. IF THAT MEETS WITH YOUR
APPROVAL. YEAH OKAY. YEAH BOB
SENATOR WHAT WE WOULD DO A
PROPOSED AND WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE PROTOCOL ISSUES IN
THE MIDDLE OF HER PRESENTATION
LET'S HAVE HER PRESENT HAVE THE
DEBATE WENT ON TO FINISHED. I'M
SORRY JUST STARTED AND WE JUST
STARTED THE DEBATER SO WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO DO IS WE WILL HAVE
THE DEBATE IN THE DISCUSSION
AND THEN IF YOU LIKE TO CALL A
CAUCUS WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE
BODY. THAT WOULD BE FINE ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A DISCUSSION ON A BILL IT IS
GENUINE- GENERALLY NOT
APPROPRIATE TO CALL FOR CAUCUS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A DISCUSSION.
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
RIGHT BUT WE WER INFORMED THAT
THIS MATTER WAS GOING TO BE
BROUGHT UP AFTER DINNER SO THIS
CAUGHT US BY SURPRISE. JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MADAM PRESIDENT.
YES SENATOR BREAUX FOR WHAT
PURPOSE AT FOR PURPOSE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT THE CAUCUS WOULD
BE ABOUT FIVE MINUTES OR LESS
IT'S JUST FOR A BRIEF
DISCUSSION ON THE NEW
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND THEN WE WILL BE
BACK TO VIGOROUSLY HELD BY
DEBATE AND DISCUSS THIS BILL.
THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD REVIEW
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ALLOWED TO DO THAT THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE IF YOU JUST WAIT
ONE MINUTE WE'RE TRYING TO BE
ACCOMMODATING BUT THERE ARE
ALSO RULES OF THE HOUSE AND SO
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSED
BY THE LEADERSHIP AND WE'LL GET
RIGHT BACK TO YOU.
BUT SENATOR
BORDER SENATOR GROVE- AFTER
DISCUSSION WITH LEADERSHIP-
THEY'VE AGREED THE CHU MAY GO
AHEAD AND HAVE A FIVE MINUTE
CAUCUS AND THEN WE WILL
CONTINUE. WITH THE DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION. SO FIVE MINUTES AND
THEN WE WILL BE BACK.
RECONVENING AT. THREE OO ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
UNDER DEBATE AND DISCUSSION ON
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY FOUR.
COLLEAGUES BACK ON THE FLOOR
PLEASE. SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS JOIN
AUTHOR OF THIRTY EIGHT I AM
HONORED TO JOIN ASSEMBLY PERSON
CHIU RAMON AND OF MY
CONGRESSMAN MY SENATOR CAFIERO.
THIS MEASURE IS SIMPLY A SIX
MONTH BRIDGE FOR BOTH TENANTS
AND LANDLORDS THIS BILL BY NO
STRETCH OF IMAGINATION IS THE
END ALL BE ALL SOLUTION TO THE
CRISIS IT'S A COMPROMISE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND
STAKEHOLDERS CAN SUPPORT. AND
WILL KEEP BOTH TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS VIABLE IN A FLOAT FOR
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS. THIS IS ON
PRESIDENT CRISIS AS WE ALL MUST
AGREE UPON. THERE'S OVER ONE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE
THAT HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS TO
THE CALL THE NINETEEN. THE ONE
IN FORTY CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN
ONE AND SEVEN RUNNERS THERE
WERE MANY CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MAKE RENT
PAYMENTS PRIOR TO COVERT
NINETEEN. THIRD QUARTER RESULTS
HALL SOULS ARE BLACK AND BROWN
RUNNERS. MANY OF THEM ARE
CENTRAL WORKERS ARE FRONTLINE
WORKERS WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO
MISS WORK. THE SAME INEQUITIES
APPLIES TO SMALL LANDLORDS
AGAIN SOME OF THOSE ARE OUR
FRONT LINE A CENTRAL WORKERS
EVEN SOME MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY AS WELL AS
STAFF ARE SMALL LANDLORDS ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE. THEIR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS THE MAJORITY
OF STRUGGLING HOUSEHOLDS ARE
TENANTS OF SMALL LANDLORDS MANY
OF WHOM ARE ALSO PEOPLE OF
COLOR. IT IS TIME FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ACT NOW TO HELP
BRIDGE THIS. CRISIS THIS BILL
PROTECTS TENANTS STRUGGLING
BECAUSE OF COLD IT ON NINETEEN
WITHOUT WRITING THEM A BLANK
CHECK IT ALSO HELPS AGAIN THOSE
SMALL LANDLORDS BOTH WILL
PURSUE RENT PAYMENTS AND
POTENTIAL FORBEARANCE. THIS BY
NO MEANS IS A HAND OUT JUST A
HAND AGAIN DURING THIS CRISIS
IS DIRECTLY WHAT IS NEEDED AT
THIS TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
BRADFORD ANY OTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR. SEEING
NONE. BUT THE SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT. WE
HAD A LENGTHY LENGTHY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MATTER IN
JUDICIARY- I THINK THE FIRST
TIME YOU PUT IN ME WAS LIKE
FIVE OR SIX HOURS I IN ITS
INITIAL ITERATION AND OBVIOUSLY
MUCH SHORTER ONE. SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WERE BROUGHT
<c.red>NTO THIS PROCESS TO MAKE. IT</c>
UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION
SOMEWHAT TOLERABLE AND I THINK
THE FLOOR MANAGER SAID IT BEST
THIS DOES NOT ADDRESS ALL THE
ISSUES. IN THE CONTINUUM.
BETWEEN A RENDER HEY AT LORDE.
HE MMHM RECIMO SENATE HILLARY
SHE WROTE WITH CENTER BORCHERS.
DO WE HAVE HIM BACK. ALRIGHT
YOU YOU FROZE THERE FOR ABOUT
FIVE SECONDS. SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUES IN REAL
MEANINGFUL WAYS BETWEEN THE
LANDLORD OR THE OWNER OF THE
PROPERTY AND THE CREDITOR THERE
ARE PROVISIONS IN THERE THAT-
ARE DESIGNED TO BE HELPFUL.
TRYING TO ALLOW FOR THE 25% ON
HUMANS BY THE RENTER- ALLOWING
THE OTHER INJECTION BASIE'S TO
EXIST LONG AS IT'S NOT BASED ON
CODE. THAT INCOME. THAT WILL BE
OF PERJURY AFTER DAVID NOW
EXISTS WE'RE IN A RENTER HAS TO
IDENTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO
PAY AND PURSUITS PRESUMABLY THE
GROUNDS UPON WHICH THAT
DETERMINATION IS BASED. WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN IS. WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT BETWEEN NOW.
AND THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO DO TO HELP.
BIRDS THE ONES ARE CURING THE
NOTE BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THERE
IS LANGUAGE IN HERE THAT IS
HELPFUL AND INSTRUCTIVE THAT.
WOULD ALLOW A BANK TO. ENGAGE
WITH A BORROWER IN IN WAYS THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL THERE'S NO
REAL LEGAL TEETH IN IT IN THE
DINNER CAMPING ON WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE.
CONTRACT PRIVATE PROPERTY AND
FEDERAL PREEMPTION ISSUES SO
THIS THING IS FRAUGHT WITH
PROBLEMS. THE REASON WHY I
SUPPORTED IT IN JUDICIARY IS
BECAUSE IT BECAME BETTER IN THE
PROCESS BUT I WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT I BELIEVE THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS. ONE IS THAT WE-
ENDEAVOR TO CREATE A TAX
CREDITS. WHEREBY AID LANDLORD
WHOSE ONLY BEEN BEING. WHICH
ONLY COLLECTED. 25% OF THE RED
BUT HE'S STILL ALL GET ON THE
TERMS OF THE LOAN THAT THERE BE
A TAX CREDIT SO THIS CAN BE
WRITTEN OFF CALIFORNIA TAXES
AND I THINK THAT IS. TERRIBLY
IMPORTANT. THE SECOND THAT THIS
ENDS IN JANUARY. IT CAN'T GO
BEYOND THAT NINETY NINE I KNOW
THERE ARE FOLKS THAT ARE GOING
TO WANT TO SEE THIS GO ON FOR.
YOU KNOW THE DURATION OF THE
PANDEMIC OR THE END OF THE
DECLARE STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR.
REALISTICALLY UNTIL EVERYONE IS
ECONOMICALLY BACK ON THEIR FEET
BUT THAT IS. I DON'T BELIEVE
SUSTAINABLE. I SUPPORTING THIS
IS BECAUSE- ALL THE FOLKS CAME
TOGETHER IN IN IN. IN GOOD
FAITH TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
PROPOSALS THAT WILL GET US
THROUGH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT I WON'T SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION WHEN THIS IF THIS
COMES BACK IN JANUARY FOR AN
EXTENSION I WILL DEFINITELY NOT
BE SUPPORTING IT DOWN BUT WE
HAVE A PURITY TIME WITHIN WHICH
WE HAVE TO MARSHAL THE ENERGIES
AND THE RESOURCES. THAT ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET AND FIND WAYS TO BE
HELPFUL TO THE LANDLORDS AND
THE BORROWERS BECAUSE IF WE
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH WE MAY
HAVE SHORT TERM SURVIVAL BUT
LIQUIDITY IS GOING TO DRY UP
MEANING THAT CREDITORS KNOWING.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH PROPERTIES NEW
BORROWERS ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
BE HELD TO A HIGHER STANDARD
MEETING MUCH MORE CASH DOWN. OR
MORE UNFAVORABLE RATES SO THE
HOUSING ELEMENT MEDIUM AND LONG
TERM IS GOING TO HURT US AS
CALIFORNIANS IF WE DON'T TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION IMMEDIATELY.
OVER THESE NEXT FEW MONTHS SO I
KNOW THE YOU KNOW REASONABLE
PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE ON THIS
ISSUE AND I'M A PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS KIND OF PERSON.
AND I REPRESENT A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT DO YOU HAVE. PROPERTIES
ABOVE THE FOUR UNITS. AND ABOUT
A LOT OF PHONE CALLS- BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
EXEMPTION ONLY THE FOUR UNITS
IN UNDER OR- AND IT'S NOT
AGGREGATE REACHED IT'S TO ME
IT'S NOT BY EIGHT PM IT'S
AGGREGATE SO IF YOU HAVE TO. IF
YOU HAVE THREE DUPLEXES YOU'RE
OUT IT'S AGGREGATE IN THAT
SITUATION. SO I'LL LEAVE IT UP
TO OTHER FOLKS TO CHIME IN IF
THEY HAVE QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSIONS BY DO YOU WANT TO
EXTEND MY- MY RESPECTING
CONGRADULATIONS TO YOU- THE
SENATOR FROM SALINAS WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS AS A CO AUTHOR
AND IS DONE A YEOMAN'S JOB OF
TROLLING TO CRAFT TOGETHER
SOMETHING IN VERY IMPERFECT
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND MY HOPE IS
THAT WE MAKE THIS HAPPEN BUT WE
IMMEDIATELY TAKE ACTION TO MAKE
THIS TOLERABLE IN SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. THIS CAN'T
SURVIVE PAST JANUARY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS US
SENATOR GROW AND MULLIN I SEE
YOUR HAND I'M GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR JACKSON AND THEN
SENATOR GROUP WILL COME BACK TO
YOU AND MELINDA SENATOR JACKSON
YES THANK YOU I'M GONNA SPEAK
VERY BRIEFLY- WE HAD A SIX AND
A HALF HOUR HEARING ON THIS WE
HAD HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE CALLING
IN TENANTS WHO ARE DESPERATE-
WE TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ABOUT TO LOSE THE ONLY PLACE
THEY KNOW IT WILL BE OUT ON THE
STREETS. WE ALSO HAVE SMALL
LANDLORDS WHO ARE AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR PROPERTIES. TO
FORECLOSURE. BUT WE NEVER DID
GET THE- TO COME IN AND TO BE A
PLAYER IN THIS TO PARTICIPATE.
AND SO AS WE GO FORWARD I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST SIMPLY SUGGEST
BECAUSE I WON'T BE HERE- THAT
WE AS WE TALK ABOUT A RECOVERY
HERE CERTAINLY WE NEED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STEP UP.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T PRINT MONEY
CAN'T PRINT MONEY WE HAVE TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET BUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE
THE ABILITY TO COME IN AND BE
HELPFUL. IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE
WILL GET. THE LEADERSHIP THE SO
CALLED LEADERSHIP IN
WASHINGTON. TO STEP UP BECAUSE
THIS PROBLEM HAS BEEN CREATED
BY A FAILURE IN ADDRESSING A
PANDEMIC THAT HAS PUT TO SO
MANY PEOPLE AT RISK. AND KILLED
OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS SO- I BELIEVE. THE
EFFORT HERE HAS BEEN A AGAIN
THE YEOMAN'S EFFORT I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS I'M PROUD TO
BE A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR IN
THIS WEIRD FASHION SOMETHING
THAT WE HOPED. WAS GOING TO
SUSTAIN US THROUGH AND HOPE WE
HAVE A VACCINE AND A CURE FOR
THIS PANDEMIC BUT IN THE
MEANTIME- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO PASS. A IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO HELP
US GET THROUGH THIS PARTICULAR
MOMENT BUT THERE IS SO MUCH
MORE TO BE DONE. AND THERE ARE
SO MANY MORE GROUPS THAT HAVE
TO STEP UP AND OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO BE ONE OF-THOSE PARTICIPANTS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER FOR THE-
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ON THIS MISSION THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON CENTER GROW
WE'RE GOING TO YOU. PRESIDENT I
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
AND I'LL JUST BE BRIEF. SORRY
WE'RE CHANGING PRESIDING
OFFICERS US IN A COPY ARE WE
TAKE QUESTION ABSOLUTELY PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
AM I GET CALLING FROM SALINAS
IS THERE IS THERE A
SEVERABILITY CLAUSE IN THIS
BILL. MEETING MEANING THAT IF
THIS BILL IS CHALLENGE WHICH
I'M PRETTY SURE IT'S GOING TO
BE CHALLENGED IF IT WAS
CHALLENGED IN COURT AND IT MOST
LIKELY WILL WILL THE MORTGAGE
PIECE A STATE BUT THE IN THE-
THIS THE PART THAT SAYS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO PAY RENT THAT
COULD BE SEPARATED AND IT WOULD
IT WOULD CONTINUE TO BE- VALID
IN THE BILL MOVING FORWARD BUT
THE MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE OF THE
MORTGAGE PIECE WE DIDN'T GET TO
BE SEPARATED. GOOD QUESTION-
THERE THERE IS THERE IS THIS
I'M I'M TOLD THERE IS A SEVER
ABILITY WE HAD IT IN OUR BILL
AND I ASSUMED IT'D BEEN MOVED
OVER AND IT WAS AND IT IS SO
THAT YES TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. I AM SO. THE CAN.
THAT I HAVE WITH THIS AGAIN I
AGREES MY- FROM FRESNO THAT.
SENATE AND ARE DESPERATE RIGHT
NOW THERE'S INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE DESPERATE AND THERE SAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORRIED ABOUT
LOSING THEIR HOMES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE SMALL BUSINESS HOUSING
PROVIDERS- THAT WANT TO PROVIDE
SAFE SHELTER AND THEY HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY ERODED. I HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE CALLED MY
OFFICE AND THEIR SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS- AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE SAID IT'S AGGREGATE
IT'S NOT- IT'S NOT TO. YOU KNOW
LIKE THREE DUPLEXES LIKE HE
SAID IT'S A TOTAL OF AN
AGGREGATE AND- I HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LIKE
RETIREES AND THEY HAVE THREE
LITTLE HOUSES ARE THREE LITTLE
COMPLEXES THAT HOUSE TWO OR
THREE- RENTERS IN EACH IN EACH
UNIT OR NOT EACH UNIT BUT THREE
UNITS. AND THAT'S THEIR
RETIREMENT INCOME IT'S WHAT
THEY'VE- SAVED FOR IT'S WHAT
THEY PAID FOR IT AND IT'S THEIR
RETIREMENT- INCOME TO AND BE AT
LANDLORDS IN. SO WITHOUT THEM
BEING ABLE TO COLLECT THE RENTS
THAT PUTS THEM IN A VERY HARD
POSITION AT NIGHT I'M REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT A CHALLENGE THAT
WOULD ELIMINATE. THEIR ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACT TO THIS
BILL AND STILL HAVE INDIVIDUALS
NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY RENT. A
LOT OF THINGS ARE ASIDE FROM
RENT YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
MAINTENANCE ISSUES THEY'RE
SUPER HORNETS ON THE BOOKS FOR
PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN AND- SAFE
AND SAFE AND SECURE SHELTER-
HOMES THAT ARE RENTED. AND
THOSE THINGS COST MONEY EVERY
MONTH THAT THE LANDLORDS IN THE
SMALL LANDLORDS ARE. ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR
WHETHER IT'S A ROOF REPAIR
WATER REPAIR- YOU KNOW
SPRINKLER REPAIR. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS COST MONEY TO USE SO I
REALIZE THAT WE'RE ALL MOVING
FORWARD TO TRY TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT DESPERATELY NEEDS
TO BE SOLVED. AND BUT I JUST
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS IS THE%
WAY. WE SHOULD SOLVE IT SOMEONE
LISTEN TO THAT ARE FLOOR DEBATE
AND. THEM AND THEN MAKE A
DECISION AT THE END BUT I. YOUR
HARD WORK ON THE BILL I'M I'M
CALLING FROM SALINAS. AND I
KNOW YOU DID WORK HARD AND I
KNOW HE REACHED OUT TO MANY- OF
THE- STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAD AND IT. HAD BUT I
STILL FEEL LIKE- ARE SMALL
LANDLORDS AND TO HAVE. SOME OF
OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS COME
UP SHORT. AND BECAUSE THEY
STILL MAY HAVE- BILLS THAT ARE
OWED TO THE BANK AND THEN. YOU
KNOW THE BANK HAS A PROMISE NOT
TO. TAKE PROPERTY AWAY FROM
THEM SO I'M I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AS WELL
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT'LL
AFFECT PEOPLE IN THERE. THAT
ARE RENTING THE PROPERTIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SHARE MY THOUGHTS
THANK. YOU CENTER GROVE.
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
THANK MAD BRO MAY I TO. OF THE
FLOOR MANAGER. WE ACCEPT THOSE
QUESTIONS CENTERED I WILL I
WILL ACCEPT THOSE QUESTION CAN.
THE SOONER CABALLERO- TWO
QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS WHAT IT
IS THAT. THE DIGITAL COUNCIL'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
INVOLVEMENT STARTS IMMEDIATELY
AND THEY SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR
THIRTY DAYS TO BE ABLE TO. WORK
ON THE ON THE DETAILS OF HOW
THEY WILL IMPLEMENT THIS SO
THEIR THEIR ACTION- IT'S
BASICALLY OCTOBER FOURTH I
BELIEVE IS THE DATE THAT THAT
THEY WILL BE READY. AND CAN.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THIS BILL
WERE NOT APPROVED WHAT WOULD
THEY DO EVERY DAY COMMANDEER
THIS WHOLE ISSUE. BUT WHAT THEY
WHAT THEY WOULD DO IS THAT
THEIR THEIR ORDER WOULD END
AND- LANDLORDS COULD START TO
EVICT TENANTS FOR NON PAYMENT
OF RENT. OKAY THEN. I WANT TO
THANK YOU THIS THIS IS A
MASSIVE BUILD SO JUNE BECAUSE I
HAVE. ENLARGE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS. BILL COULD YOU GIVE ME
THE ELEVATOR SPEECH THAT I'LL
NEED TO. PRESENTS IF I VOTE FOR
THIS BILL. I'LL DO THAT I'M
SURE SHE'S ME I'M NOT SURE
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE QUESTION
PERHAPS YOU CAN RESPOND IN YOUR
CLOTHES I WILL THANK YOU. HI
YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN AN APPROPRIATE
QUESTION BUT WE DO NEED A
LITTLE LEVITY AT TIMES THOSE OF
US WHO ARE IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT EVERY NOW AND THEN
GETTING A JOE CAL STANDS OUT.
LET ME BEGIN BY ECHOING THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY OUR LEADER
REGARDING THE BALANCE THAT
SEEMS TO BE ABSENT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE. SMALL MOM AND POP. AND
SOARED. OF NATURE SIDE THEY NOT
ONLY FACE. LOSING POSITION. ON
THEIR IF THEY CAN'T MEET THEIR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS. THAT THEY
ARE REALLY ARE AT RISK OF
LOSING OF THEIR INCOME. A
PUTTING THEM IN A GRAVE GRAVE
SITUATION THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE A REAL BALANCE OR ONE THAT'S
ADDRESSED. PERHAPS THERE WAS
THAT MANY OF US ARE NOT SHOULD
PREACH TO THOSE SEVEN HOUR
DEBATE. THAT WENT ON IN
JUDICIARY I REALISED THE COOL
KIDS NINE SITUATION NINETEEN
SITUATION DOES IMPACT. THE
ABILITY- FOR A BROAD
COMMUNICATION IN HIM DOWN
DEBATE. BUT THIS BILL CERTAINLY
LACKED THAT IN TERMS OF
REPRESENTING ABOUT CONTINGENT
THAT'S OUT THERE VERY. VERY
WORRIED ABOUT SO THERE'S YOU
THERE INVEST THAT BE LAW. AND
WHILE THE BANKS HAVE NOT
PARTICIPATED WE ARE HOPING THAT
THEY WILL. CERTAINLY ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS ADDRESS THESE
ARE VERY HUGE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES IN LIFE THREATENING.
SITUATIONS THAT CAN APPROACH
OUR SENIOR SO. I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WHO HAVE
SPENT MANY MANY. HOURS SENDING
US. ALL LETTERS THIS AND WHAT
MIGHT BE ADDRESSED FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE A NEW TO SOMEWHERE NEAR
IN THE- SO I DO TO THE CALL
THAT I IN. WITHOUT INCOME
DURING COLD NINETEEN YEAH
THERE'S NOTHING THAT YOU NEED
TO SHOW THAT SO YOU START
GETTING A PAYCHECK. ARE THAT
YOU WERE LAID OFF ANY ONE OF
THOSE THINGS SEEMS TO ME TO BE
DATA THAT SHOULD BE BACKING UP.
YOUR PRODUCE IS BEEN TAKEN HERE
ARE NEEDS FAST SO ALL RIGHT
WILL GOING FORWARD THERE'S A
LITTLE MORE CONSIDERATION
GIVEN. TO THOSE WHO ARE
BASICALLY- YOU HAVE TO DO AS
MUCH AS THOSE WHO ARE YET IN
OUR APARTMENTS AND POTENTIALLY
FACING OBJECTION- GOING BACK
AND NOT. I GUESS LEADING IT TO.
BUT IF YOU DE TO BE DURING THE
DAY THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING ORDER LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE WOULD
FIND OURSELVES. IN A SITUATION
THAT HAS SUCH DEPTH IN TERMS OF
THE IMPACT. THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO JUST GET BY DURING
THIS VERY VERY CHALLENGING
TIME. I WILL BE A NO VOTE. AND
IT WILL BE A STRONG NO VOTE
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS
REALLY CONSIDERS ONLY ONE SIDE
OF THE EQUATION AGAIN. AND
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT'S BEEN
WRONG WITH A LOT OF LEGISLATION
THAT SPONSORED HERE RECENTLY.
WHEN I'M FINISHED WITH THIS-
AND YOU TAKE A VOTE I WOULD
LIKE A MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE. TO SPEAK AS A FORMER
LEADER. RIGHT NOW LEADER
EMERITUS OF OUR CAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UGH IN FURTHER. OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING AND HEARING
NON CENTER COVER YEAR YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT THAT ARE ALL OF
THE SENATORS WHO SPOKE ON ON
THIS BILL- IT DEFEATED WHAT YOU
HAVE SAID IS NOT. IS NOT. IS
NOT NEW INFORMATION THESE HAVE
BEEN EXACTLY THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT. THAT WE'VE
BEEN HAVING OVER THE PAST.
COUPLE OF MONTHS OVER THE
POTENTIAL SO. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A- BE TWO. ONE THAT
WAS- A SENATE BILL AND ONE THAT
WAS IT AND ASSEMBLY BILL AND IT
WAS WITH THE WITH THE-
PARTICIPATION OF THE GOVERNOR
SO THAT WE KNOW THAT WHATEVER
IT IS WE PASS. HERE TODAY WILL
BE WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL. BUT BUT BUT
LET ME LET ME GIVE YOU A GOOD
NOTE. IN IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC. WITH BAD NEWS IS THAT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE NOT BEEN WORKING OR WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY VERY
LITTLE. THE INFORMATION WE'VE
RECEIVED FROM- THE DATA
COLLECTORS IS IT PEOPLE HAVE
CONTINUED TO PAY THE RENT.
THEY'VE BEEN NEGOTIATING WITH
THEIR LANDLORDS AND THEY'VE
BEEN TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS TO SET UP A FRAMEWORK
GOING FORWARD THAT WILL ALLOW
LANDLORDS. TO BE ABLE TO- TO
CONTINUE TO TAKE RENT. ON THE
MINIMUM THAT HAS TO BE PAID IS
AT LEAST 25% WITH THE UP A NOTE
AND UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY
AND THE MEANS TEST IS THOSE
OVER. EARNING OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND HAVE TO SHOW. SOME
KIND OF. LETTER FROM THEIR
EMPLOYER OR SOME KIND OF PROOF
THAT THEY BEEN NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. AND THE WHOLE. THE
WHOLE POINT OF DOING THIS THIS
WAY. IS THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A WE NEED TO SET UP.
THEIR CONTINUING WORK AND THE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT IS HOW- WHETHER
WE DO A TAX CREDIT WHETHER THE
STATE BUDGET HAS MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO USE AS COLLATERAL TO BE
ABLE TO- ENCOURAGED THE BANKS
TO DO SOMETHING WHETHER WE GET
FEDERAL FUNDS INTEREST MLS-
ACT. AND THEN ALL SO THAT THERE
ISN'T AS NEVER BEEN A BETTER.
TO REACH FIND. MORTGAGES AND
THERE'S THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
GO AND TALK TO THEIR BANKS. AND
TO BE ABLE TO WORK OUT
SOMETHING WHICH IS PART OF A
FOR A PHOTO OF A FORBEARANCE
FRAMEWORK SO- THAT'S MY
ELEVATOR SPEECH IS IT. WHAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO TAKE ACTION
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE FAILURE TO DO
SO COULD RESULT IN THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. ENDING UP ON THE
STREET AT A TIME WHEN OUR
HOMELESSNESS HAS BEEN THE
HIGHEST AND- AND IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC WHEN PEOPLE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE STAYING IN THEIR
HOMES. THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNTENABLE WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
HAVE THAT HAPPEN AND THIS BILL
WILL. GIVE US THE FRAMEWORK TO
BE ABLE TO PROTECT TENANTS. TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE INTO THE NEW
YEAR AND THAT AND TO HAVE.
HOPEFULLY HAVE COME UP WITH A
BETTER SOLUTION BY JANUARY. AYE
WE'RE COMMITTED TO IT EVERYBODY
THAT'S BEEN AT THE TABLE AND I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR IS AS WELL
SO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I AT AYE FELL I
BRADFORDI CABALLERO I DODD. I
DURAZO. HI GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ BY HERTZBERG I HILL.
I WAS SO. I HER TADO FIVE
JACKSON HI I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I
NIELSEN. HI PAM FIVE PORTANTINO.
HI RALPH. I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
I STERN I AM BURKE I Y. CASKEY
HI WIENER I. RIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE REMOTE MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR AB. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT. BASICS BATES AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT NO BATES NOW FOR
JUST. WE'RE JUST EIGHTY THREE
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT RELUCTANT I.
FORAGES HI CHIANG. AB THREE
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT ALSO A
RELUCTANT HI. CHIANG HI DALLY.
SENATOR THE ONLY. THE DALLAS AB
THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT. UPSTATE
GROWTH S. SENATE ROAD AB THREE
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT ABSTAINED.
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB THREE
MORLOCK MOORLACH. AB THREE ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT ABSTAINED MORRELL.
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT NO
MORALE NO. WILK WILK AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT HI WILK HI GUYS
THE- I'M SORRY WE HAVE ONE MORE
A PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FROM THE REMOTE VOTERS
PLEASE. DALLY. THERE IS THERE
IS. ALREADY DO YOU WANT ME TO
PUT NO NO THAT'S RIGHT WE'VE
GOT YOU DOWN ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE'VE GOT
THE VOTE COUNT THE FINAL VOTE
IS THIRTY THREE IS THE NOSE TO
THE MEASURE PASSES. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE'RE GOING TO. BE.
SENATOR BATES FOR PURPOSE MA'AM.
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE MADAM
PRESIDENT AND PERSONAL
PRIVILEGES. PERSONAL PREVAILED
PRIVILEGE TO DISCUSS HOW YOU
DEAL WITH THE REQUEST FOR
CAUCUS. I'M NOT SURE THAT COMES
UNDER PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. A
FUTURES HOLD ONE SECOND PLEASE.
SO SHE WANTS TO KNOW THE
PROCESS FOR CALLING. FOR
SENATOR BATES WOULD YOU CLARIFY
WHAT IT IS THAT YOU ARE SEEKING
WE HAVE OUR LEADERSHIP TEAM
HERE. I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND US
OF THE PROCESS THAT I
EXPERIENCED DURING THE YEARS
THAT I'VE SERVED HERE IN THE
SENATE. ON HAND IS A LITTLE BIT
OF THE INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE
ON. OR MAYBE YES SORRY OF THE
INSTITUTE. PROCESS THAT HAS
BEEN. ARE EITHER ON. THIRTY FOR
A DISCUSSION IN THE CAUCUS AND
I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE ANY
DIFFERENCE ON JUST BECAUSE OUR
CAUCUS HOUSE TO BE. MORE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND I
SAY THAT IS FORMER LEADER FOR
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF OR MORE
IN CERTAINLY A MEMBER. OF
CONGRESS- FOR APPROXIMATELY SIX
AND A HALF YEARS RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU THAT IS SO NOTED. BY
MOVING RIGHT ALONG. WE ARE
GOING TO FILE ITEM. ALL RIGHT
SHOULD WE GO TO THAT NOW ALL
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO ASK AN EXCUSE
ME I'VE GOT. TO RESPOND TO THIS
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY TWO. SO.
ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO. FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN FIVE
JACKSON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATE JACKSON
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS
AN EMERGENCY MEASURE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ. IT
ARRIVED IN OUR CHAMBER HAVING
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES THE AUTHOR
INTRODUCED THIS BILL TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THE
LEGISLATURE STARTED LAST YEAR
TO RESPOND TO OUR SUPREME
COURT'S DYNAMAX DECISION. M.
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST MISS
CLASSIFICATION. WORKERS
PROPERLY CLASSIFIED AS
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO RELY ON
FUNDED PROBE FOR WORK
PROTECTION INCLUDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
DISABILITY AND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WORKERS COMPENSATION PAID
SIXTY SIX DAYS ACCESS TO P.
P.'S WORKPLACE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS. AND
PROTECTIONS AGAINST RETALIATION.
WORKERS PROPERLY CLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
BENEFITS OF RUNNING AND GROWING
THEIR OWN BUSINESSES WITH
MINIMAL REGULATION. OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE IS A NATIONAL
LEADER IN A STAB WISHING THE
COUNTRY'S STRONGEST WORKER
PROTECTIONS BUT IF COMPANIES
CAN INVADE THEIR OBLIGATIONS AS
EMPLOYERS WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE
THESE LAWS ARE WORTHLESS. AFTER
MUCH DISCUSSION OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS WITH WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE AND RIGOROUS DEBATE WITH
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY. AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
RESPONSE TO OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS AND MAKE SIGNIFICANT
HEADWAY TOWARD ADDRESSING THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION OF WHO IS
AN EMPLOYEE AND WHO IS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. THE
PROCESS OF DRAFTING REASONABLE
CLARIFICATIONS WERE
CONSISTENTLY INFORMED BY A
ROBOT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND
BASED ENTIRELY ON THE
PRINCIPLES FOUND IN THE DYNAMIX
CASE OF A RELOCATION PREVIOUS
CASE LAW AN EXISTING PROVISIONS
OF UNEMPLOYMENT. AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION LAW. THIS MEASURE
STRIKES A BALANCE IT ENSURES
WORKERS WHO ARE SUBJECT TO THE
CONTROL AND DIRECTION OF THEIR
EMPLOYERS ARE PROTECTED. AT THE
SAME TIME THE LEGISLATION.
RECOGNIZES THOSE WHO YOU OPERA
PLEDGE. OPERATE THEIR OWN IN
BUSINESSES ARE GOVERNED UNDER
THE PREVIOUS BOROUGH OF
STANDARD. CLEAR RULES OUTLINED
IN AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
PROMOTE COMPLIANCE AND ENSURE
WORKERS AND BUSINESSES
UNDERSTAND THEIR RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LAW.
MEMBERS OF A GREAT DEAL OF WORK
HAS BEEN DONE ON THIS BILL AND
GOTTEN US TO A GOOD PLACE AGAIN
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. FOR ABOUT
SEVENTY SENATE JACKSON. SENATOR
BROAD GROWTH FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE. FOR PUT YOUR HAND UP.
I HANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
BELIEVE I HAVE AMENDMENTS
ATTESTS. YOU DO HAVE A MEMBERS
OF THE DESK AND I BELIEVE WE
ALL HAVE THEM. OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU READ THE
AMENDMENTS PLEASE. AMENDMENTS
BY SENATOR GROVER SET ONE.
CENTER GROVE. S. SORRY JUST GET
SITUATED HERE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN WORKING AT YOUR
DESK ON THE FLOOR SO I DO
APOLOGIZE. JUST ONE SECOND.
OKAY I DO APOLOGIZE THINKING
BENEFIT A PRESIDENT- FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THESE
AMENDMENTS- IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT ISSUED
A DECISION THAT CHANGE THE WORK
LIFE FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND DEPARTED FROM
THE THIRTY YEARS THIRTY YEARS
OF CALIFORNIA LAW. INCREASE A
NEW TEST TO DETERMINE WHO IS
NOT IS AND WHO IS NOT AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR THE
RULING ESTABLISHED- THAT THE
MOST RECENT THE REALLY IS THE
MOST RESTRICTIVE FORMS OF
EMPLOYMENT TEST ARE RELATED TO
WAGE AND HOUR LAWS FOUND
ANYWHERE IN OUR COUNTRY LAST
YEAR THIS BODY PASSED THE
GOVERNOR'S IN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED AB FIVE WHICH CODIFIED
THE DYNAMICS DECISION INTO LAW
WHILE PICKING AND CHOOSING
WHICH INDUSTRIES WOULD BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. IN
WHICH ONES COULD NOT AND NOW AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN IS THE
FOR THE SAKE TO CLEAN UP THE
MESS THAT WAS MADE BY TAKING
THOSE WINNERS AND LOSERS WITH
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE ONLY
ISSUE CARVE OUTS TO CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH TO ADDRESS THE DIVERSITY
IN THE WORKPLACE AT THE STATE
THAT'S WHY I'M BRINGING FORWARD
AMENDMENTS TO REPEAL AB FIVE
THEREBY REVERSING THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT AND DYNAMICS
IS CODIFIED INTO. AB FIVE. FOR
JOBS IN OUR IN OUR STATE. JOB
CREATION IN THE FOR. A HUMAN
WOULD. ADDRESS IT. DECISION BY
REPLACING AB FIND THE NEW
FLEXIBLE WORKPLACE. AND ABC
TEST TO DETERMINE THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR STATUS-
PEOPLE ARE HURTING AND WE NEED
TO ALLOW THE WORK OF FREEDOM IN
OUR STATE. AND MY MEN WHICH
WOULD ALLOW WORKER FRIEDMAN THE
STATE AND ALLOW WORKERS TO
CHOOSE WHETHER THEY WANTED TO
WORK- ONE DAY A WEEK ONE HOUR A
WEEK FIVE HOURS A WEEK OR NOT
WORK FOR SIX MONTHS AND THEN
COME BACK AND WORK AGAIN. AND
SO THIS WOULD GIVE ARE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS CENTER
FREELANCERS THE ABILITY TO- SET
THEIR OWN SCHEDULE AND PROVIDE
WORKER FREEDOM SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKE. THANK
YOU GROW SENATOR HURTS. I MOVED
TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE. THANK YOU CENTER CENTER
HEARD FOR IS ASKING FOR AN VOTE
I SEE THAT THIS GROW ITSELF FOR
A NUMBER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HOW FIVE
FIVE VIRTUAL. I CAN. I FELL. I
BRADFORDHI CABALLERO I DON. HI
TORONTO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ I HEARD. I HELLO HI
WITH I HEARD. HI JOHN HI I LAY.
I MCGUIRE FIVE MITCHELL I MONEY
I NIELSEN. PAN HI NIELSEN NO.
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH. FIVE
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. FIVE STERN
HI NUMBER FIVE LAKE CHARLES SKI.
I WIENER. FIVE WE TO OUR
MEMBERS THAT ARE VOTING
REMOTELY SENATOR BATES THIS IS
A MOTION TO LADY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE MADAM SECRETARY FACE.
THANKS MOTIONS TO LAY ON THE
TABLE NO BATES NOW FOR JUST.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO LET THEM IN
THE TABLE NOW BARGES NO CHIANG.
HANG MOTIONS LADY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW CHIANG NO DALLY.
A MOTION TO LADY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO. DALLY NO GROWTH.
THE GROUP YOU'RE A MUTE. YOU'RE
STILL ON MUTE. SHE'S ON HERE.
THEN THERE WE GO BROKEN GROWTH
MOTION TO LADY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO GROWTH NOW
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ MOTION TO
LADIES WORTHWHILE IT NEEDED
DEPENDENCE ON THE TABLE NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORLOCK. THE MOTION
TO LAKE ROAD CEMENT ON THE
TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
BROWN MOTION CHILE- CENTER
GROVES AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NO MORALE NO WILK. WILK THE
MOTION TO RAISE CENTER GROVE
THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NO
WILK NOW. AMENDMENTS TO THE
MINUTES HAVE BEEN LAID ON THE
TABLE SENATOR JONES. HELLO I'M
SO SORRY THE AMENDMENTS- HAVE
BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE. THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU. TWENTY NINE
TEN. CENTERED CENTER JONES.
YOU'RE A METER. YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
ALSO HAVE A SET OF AMENDMENTS
ON THE DESK AS WELL VERY GOOD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR JONES SET
TO SENDER JONES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THESE
AMENDMENTS WHAT SPECIFICALLY
NAME TATTOO ARTISTS- IN THIS
BILL- SO THIS IS THAT WE WOULD
BE AN AMENDMENT TO THE BILL
WELL I WHOLEHEARTEDLY BELIEVE
THAT TATTOO ARTISTS NOW FALL
UNDER THE UPDATED DEFINITION OF
FINE ARTISTS THAT'S THAT
INCLUDING THE BILL I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THAT IS STILL OPEN TO
SOME INTERPRETATION. WELL I
DON'T HAVE ANY TATTOOS MYSELF I
HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
GETTING TO KNOW SOME OF THE
TATTOO ARTIST MY DISTRICT AND
THEY ARE TRULY SOME OF THE MOST
CREATIVE AND TALENTED
INDIVIDUALS THAT I HAVE EVER
MET. THEY ARE INDEED FINE
ARTISTS AND- PEOPLE ARE THEIR
CAMPUSES. AND THEIR BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP IS WITH THE
CUSTOMER WHO IS HAS
COMMISSIONED IN THIS PIECE OF
ARTWORK NOT WITH THE OWNER OF
THE TATTOO PARLOR. THESE
ARTISTS ALREADY GET FORGOTTEN
AND ARE OFTEN NOT TREATED LIKE
THE FINE ARTISTS THAT THEY ARE
SO WHILE I DO AGREE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF FINE ARTISTS
SHOULD NOW COVER THEM I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS NO.
ROOM FOR ERROR AND I ASK THAT
WE WOULD ADD THEM BY NAME ADD
TO THIS BILL- AND ASK FOR
SUPPORT FOR MY MINUTES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR JOHNSON
HERTZBERG. THE MAJORITY LEADER
MOVES TO LIVE MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG CENTER HERTZBERG IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE THE
SENATOR JONES IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR JONES IS
THERE OBJECTION TO USING THE
ROLL CALL THAT WE JUST USED.
THE PRIOR ROLL CALL. I'M NOT
VOTING SO I ALSO I IMAGINE IT.
OKAY MANSERGH CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELT. I BRADFORD I CAMBIADO
BOBBY I DODD. I THE RAZA. HI
GALGIANI. I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO BY
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL HI MY NAME
I NIELSEN. NO HAN I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI NUMBER I
REQUEST YOU I WIENER. I THINK
YOU LISTEN TO OUR MEMBERS WERE
VOTING REMOTELY THIS IS ON THE
MEASURE TOO LATE THE AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE PROCEED BASS. MOTION TO
LAY SENATOR JONES- THE MEMBERS
ON THE TABLE NO. BATES NO
FORTUS WE'RE JUST MOTIONS LADY
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NOW FOR
JUST NOW CHIANG MOTION TO A
CHAIN MOTION TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NOW
CHIANG NO DALLY. DAILYMOTION TO
LAY JONES THE MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. AG
GROWTH MOTION TO LAY SENATOR
CHANCES AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NOW GROVE NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
MOTION TO LADY WORTHWHILE WHEN
NEEDED AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
JONES OF THE TABLE NOW MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. THE MOTION TO
LACE TO JONES IS AMENDMENT ON
THE TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. MORRELL LOTION TO LATE.
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NOW.
MORRELL NO WILK WELL MOTIONS
SOLEIL THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE NO WELL NOW. TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE MOVING
TO SENATOR BATES SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
HAVE AMENDMENTS- AT THE DESK ON
THIS BILL- MIGHT HAVE TO DO
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS. TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN SENATOR BATES ELEMENT
YEAH I'M GONNA HAVE THE
SECRETARY READ THEM FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO YOU IF
THAT'S OKAY MADAM SECRETARY.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR BATES SET
THREE. SENATOR BATES. I DO HAVE
AN MS AT THE GAS WHICH YOU JUST
RANDY AND THEY HAD TO DO WITH
THE OF PROFESSIONAL JOURNALISTS
I AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN HAS
ALLOWED FOR PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS TO GET BACK TO WORK
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME AND
THAT'S A GOOD THING HOWEVER
THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RELATED TO
BE THE OB OR FEE OF SPECIFIC
CONCERN IS THE DEFINITION OF
MOTION PICTURE AS INCLUDING
BROUGHT NEWS AND TELEVISION.
SUCH CONFUSING LANGUAGE STILL
BARS FREELANCE PHOTOGRAPH BOOK
PHOTOGRAPHERS AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WITH THEIR CLIENTS
USE THE TELEVISION STATION OR
BROADCAST CLIENT THEREFORE I AM
PROPOSING THAT THE DEFINITION
FOR MOTION PICTURES YOU MORE
NARROWLY DEFINED TO EXCLUDE THE
TERMS TELEVISION AND BROADCAST
NEWS SO IT IS NOT SO OVERLY
INCLUSIVE OF PHOTO JOURNALISM
THAT IS UNRELATED TO ACTUAL
MOTION PICTURE PICTURE INDUSTRY
AND THAT WILL ALLOW OUR VIDEO
JOURNALISM OR TELEVISION AND
BROADCAST NEWS I ASK THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS TO BE ADOPTED INTO
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
HERTZBERG VERY MUCH BEEN A
PRESIDENT TO MAJORITY LEADER
MOVES TO LIVE IN MEMBERS OF THE
TABLE THANK YOU SIR IN HER
FIRST ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
CENTER BATES IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN THE. THE
DEBATE IS THERE OBJECTION TO
USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL.
YES THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELT. I
BRADFORD I HAVE A OUT OF. I
DODD. HI DURAZO HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO. I FURTADO
AYE JACKSON. JACKSON I LEYVA I
REQUIRE. I MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
HI NIELSEN. NO HAN I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH IRA RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN HI I'M BURKE RIGHT HI
BAKER SKI I WIENER. I THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS THAT ARE VOTING
REMOTELY ON LAYING THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE MADAM
SECRETARY. BASICS. MOTION TO
LAY MY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NO BASS NO PORGES. OR JUST MOVE
TO LAY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. HEY
MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW CHIANG NO DALLY.
DALY MOTION TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NOW
DALLY NO GROWTH. GROSS MOTION
TO LAY CENTER BASES AND
MAINTENANCE ON THE TABLE NOW
GROVE NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
MOTION TO LAY BATES HAS WORKED
WELL WHEN NEEDED AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. MOORLACH MOTION TO LAY
SENATE BASIS AMEND ON THE TABLE
NO MORLOCK NO MORALE.
WORLDVISION TO A AMENDMENTS THE
TABLE NO MORALE NO WILK. WELL
AS THE MOTION TO LAY MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE NOW WILK NO. SENATOR
BATES IS THERE AN OBJECTION TO
USING THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL NO
NO SORRY I GOT CONFUSED. IS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS HIM THE
AMENDMENTS ARE LAID ON THE
TABLE. SENATOR BORDERS. THIS.
YOU MATTER. I BELIEVE I HAVE
SOME AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
YOU DO. SAID MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR BARGES SET FOR. SENATOR
BORDERS. I KNOW THAT- THIS
MIGHT GET A LITTLE TIRING. BUT
I THINK YOU CAN TELL HOW
STRONGLY WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY
FIVE. ESPECIALLY IN THE KOBE
EXPERIENCE WHICH IS
HIGHLIGHTING OUR STRUCTURAL.
CHALLENGES FOR STATE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR SOMEONE.
LIVELIHOOD TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY
AND TO HAVE THE PERSONAL CHOICE.
MY OF MY AMENDMENT IS TWO EXAMS
FOR. THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A
FRANCHISEE IN THE FRANCHISE OR
SO THIS LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
THERE'S STRONG REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT. THE CURRENT AB
FIVE RULES. AND ALSO THE
DYNAMICS DECISION- IT COULD
CREATE SUBSTANTIAL PROBLEMS
WITH WHAT EXACTLY A FRANCHISE
IS IMAGINE MCDONNELL'S OR
JERSEY MIKE'S ARE SEVEN ELEVEN.
THERE'S CONCERN THAT WIN A
CORPORATE MOTHER SHIP ALLOWS
FOR A FRANCHISE. THAT BB FIVE
WOULD BE USED EFFECTIVELY USED
TO FORCIBLY CREATE A
RELATIONSHIP WHEREBY IT THE
FRANCHISE OWNER IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE END THE EMPLOYEES WITHIN
THE FRANCHISE ITSELF
COLLECTIVELY BE CLASSIFIED AS
GIVES MORE EASE OF THE
CORPORATE ENTITY A LARGE
CORPORATE ME SO BECAUSE A
MCDONALD'S MOTHER SHIP OR SEVEN
ELEVEN. THIS SEND FUNDAMENTALLY
DISMANTLE THE FRANCHISE SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHOR INTENDED. I DON'T THINK
THE AUTHOR INTENDED TO DROUGHT
TO ALLOW THIS TO BE DRAWN INTO
THE DRAGNET OF EIGHTY FIVE. THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE SO SIGNIFICANT
THAT I BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALLOW THIS EXCEPTION TO
BE. PUT INTO AB FIVE. AND I AND
I UNDERSTAND THE NEW JERK
REACTION- IS TO. LAY THE TAPE
LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
BUT I WOULD ASK. MAJORITY
LEADER IN OTHER MEMBERS ON OF.
MAJORITY PARTY TO CONSIDER THIS
PARTICULAR ONE AS WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE INTENDED IT.
EIGHTY FIVE FOR THIS TO PLAY
OUT THIS WAY BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS WORTHWHILE TO
DEBATE. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY- ASK THAT YOU VOTE
NO. OR ALTERNATIVELY MAJORITY
LEADER DECLINES THE LADY
AMENDMENTS THE TABLE SO WE CAN
AT LEAST DISCUSS IT THANK YOU
FOR THE CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU CENTER BORDERS HERTZBERG
MAJORITY THANKS TO LAY MEMBERS
AND TABLE AS FOR THE THANK YOU
SIR MADERA LEADERS FOR AN FIVE
A- DOESN'T BORDERS IS ASKING
FOR A NOBLE MAN I'M SO. FOR
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS I TELL I
BRADFORD I AVAILABLE FIVE DODD
HI THE RISER HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO I HER TADO. HI
JACKSON FIVE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
I MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
NIELSEN. NO HAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO. SKINNER HI
STERN. HI NUMBER RIGHT FIVE
WACO SKI FIVE WE I. THE COMMAND
CENTER MOVING TO OUR MEMBERS
WERE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON LAYING
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
FAKES BASS MOTION TO LADY
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NO BATES
NO FORTUS. FOR JUICE. OTHER
MOTION TO LADY MEMBERS ON THE
TABLE NO BARGES NO CHIANG. HANG
MOST UNTIL EIGHTY MINUTES ON
THE TABLE NOW. CHIANG NO DALLY.
MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO DALLY NO. GROWTH
AND MOTION TO LAY SENATOR
PURCHASES AND THEN IT'S ON THE
TABLE KNOWN GROWTH NOW MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ ON THE MOTION TO LAY
ON THE TABLE THE MUCH NEEDED
AND WORTHWHILE POOR JUST
AMENDMENTS NOW. MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. THE MOTION TO LAY
SENATOR GORGEOUS IS AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORROW BROWN MOTIONS THE LATE
SENATOR GORGEOUS AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW MORRELL NO WILK.
WILL BE MMENT THE MOTION TO
LAY AMONG MINUTES ON THE TABLE
NOW. WILK NOW. PIES TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE
MOVING TO SENATOR MORALE
SENATOR MORALE YES I BELIEVE I
HAVE- SOME AMENDMENTS TO LAY ON
A TABLE ALSO PLEASE YOU DO HAVE
AMENDMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
LAY THEM ON THE TABLE WOULD
LIKE THEM TO BE HEARD. YEAH I'D
LIKE IT TO BE HEARD OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR MORALE
SET FIVE. SEVERAL YES THANK
YOU- SENATOR LEYVA APPRECIATE
THAT FIRST OF ALL- YEAH THE
REASON FOR THIS IS- YOU KNOW I.
I WAS FORTUNATE TO. BE IN
BUSINESS BUT BEFORE THAT I WAS
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IN
REALLY THE THREE REASONS I DID
IT IS WANT TO FLEXIBILITY OF
TIME IN MY SCHEDULE AS WELL AS
FLEXIBILITY TO PERHAPS IF I IF
I SUCCEEDED TO MAYBE MAKE MORE
MONEY THAN THAN BEING ON A
REGULAR JOB IN THE BAY THING
FREED I NEVER WANT. TO HAVE A
BOSS AND I LOVE FREEDOM AND
FLEXIBILITY AND SELF SOMEONE AB
FIVE CAME ABOUT- YOU KNOW IT I
KNOW THE- IT'S BEEN. TO SO MANY
IN CONTRACTORS ONE. IDEAS
PERHAPS WE COULD LOSE A MILLION
JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US WANT TO SEE
THIS- AND THAT THAT WAS BY THE-
ELLIE ALL BY THE WAY WHO
BELIEVE THAT THAT THREATENS-
OVER MILLIONS. OF FREELANCERS-
BUT THIS IS BEEN A DEVASTATING
TO SO MANY INDUSTRY SUCH AS-
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS-
INDEPENDENT MUSICIANS- AND BY
THE WAY ON THAT JOURNEY AND I
USUALLY WHEN WE LEAVE.
SACRAMENTO AFTER OUR- TIME UP
HERE WELL STOP TALKING BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A MUSIC FESTIVAL IN
WE GOT A NOTICE THIS YEAR THAT
DO THAT AB FIVE. THESE PEOPLE
COME TOGETHER FOR THREE DAYS
FROM ALL OVER LAKE TAHOE AFTER
FORTY YEARS ARE DISCONTINUING
THEIR- THEY'RE SAYING BECAUSE A
THE CITY OF OUR- NORTH LAKE
TAHOE IS NOT GONNA. BE. ABLE TO
EMPLOY THESE PEOPLE. I'M SO
ANYWAY IT'S NOT ONLY AFFECT
THEM ALSO PRIOR REFER. FRIEDMAN
JOURNALIST A NAME FEW BUT EVEN.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
OFFENSIVE IS SANTA CLAUS WHO
ARE IN MALLS AT CHRISTMAS TIME
FOR THREE OR FOUR WEEKS SO- WHO
WANTS THE PACT CONSTANTA BUT
ANYWAY. MY POINT IS THIS THESE
AMENDMENTS AND ON LAND ON THE
TABLE IT IS BUSINESS THE
BUSINESS AND SO AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WOULD EXPAND THE
UNIVERSE. OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
BUSINESSES AND PROFESSIONS
THERE AND NOW THE STAMP FROM
THE ABC TEST AND SO. THIS WILL
PROTECT THE LIVELIHOODS OF
ADDITIONAL FREELANCERS NOT
ORIGINALLY CARVED OUT OF AB
FIVE IN THAT WERE CARVED OUT BY
THE WAY SHOULD BE OFFENSIVE TO
ALL OF US THAT. THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES- FOR SOME AND NOT
OTHERS AND SO AB FIVE FOR WHOSE
UP. TO EARN A LIVING HAVE BEEN
APPLIED BY THE DYNAMICS
DECISION AND OF COURSE OUTLAWED
BY AB FIVE AND I'LL JUST SUM.
UP BY TEN OR ELEVEN WORDS FROM
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
WHICH SAYS IF A LOT NEEDS
NUMEROUS EXEMPTIONS TO MAKE
SENSE. IT PROBABLY DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO SEVERAL CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHERMAN PRESIDENT. A MOVE TO
LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SIR
SENATOR MORALE MAY WE. USE THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. I'D LIKE A
NEW ROLL CALL PLEASE THANK YOU
FOR AND SECRETARY CALL THE-
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
TELL. I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
AYE DODD. HI TORONTO HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO.
I HER TADO. I JACKSON AYE LEYVA
I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROSS I RUBIO. HI SKINNER
HI STERN. HI NUMBER I WACO SKI
I WIENER HI IS TO MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY.
FACE. PLEASE LISTEN TO RADIO
BUSINESS ON THE TABLE NOW BATES
NOW FOR JUST. ORDERS ARE MOTION
LADY MEMBERS IN THE TABLE NOW.
FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. A MOTION
TO LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NOW CHIANG NO DALLY.
DAILYMOTION TUESDAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NO.
DALLY NOW GROVE GROVE MOTION TO
LAY SENATOR MORALES AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE NO GROWTH NO
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ MOTION TO
LAID THE MUCH NEEDED AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE NOW. MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK ORELON THE MOTION TO
LAY SENATOR MORALES AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORAL. MOTIONS LAY SENATOR
MORALIS AMENDMENTS ON CABLE
LOADING UP MORALE NO WILK. WILK
BEER THE MOTION TO LADY MEMBERS
ON THE TABLE NO WELL NOW FIVE
THREE NINE THOSE TEN THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID ON
THE TABLE CENTER MORLOCK WE'RE
GOING TO YOU. THANK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I BELIEVE I
ALSO HAVE A SET OF AMENDMENTS
AT THE TABLE DO DO INDEED. A
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR MORLOCK
SET SIX. CIMARRON THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- WE'RE IN A SAID
PICKLE HERE A GOOD LAW SHOULD
BE UNDERSTANDABLE SIMPLE AND
EASY TO IMPLEMENT. AT LAW WOULD
REQUIRE REGULATIONS REVISIONS
AND LEGAL OPINIONS. FOR
INTERPRETATIONS IT WOULD EVEN
REQUIRE CARVE OUTS. AB FIVE.
WAS A BAD LAW IN CARVE OUTS
PROVE IT. INCOME TAX LAW SHOULD
NOT BE. HEILBRON SHOULD BE.
INCOME TAX LAW SHOULD NOT BE
TINKERED WITH IN SUCH A MANNER
THAT HAVE BECOME SO DISRUPTIVE
TO THE MARKETPLACE AND THE
TIMING OF AB FIVE COULD NOT
HAVE BEEN WORSE. AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN. DOES NOT HAVE
ENOUGH CARBS. ALTHOUGH IT LOOKS
LIKE AN OVERCROWDED STAKE BED
TRUCK PACKED TO THE GILLS WITH
REFUGEES TRYING TO FLEE FOR THE
BORDER. YES PEOPLE THAT ARE
CHASING THIS LAST TRUCK TRYING
TO CLIMB ON BOARD. WE NEED TO
HELP THOSE THAT ARE RUNNING
AFTER IT IN WHO ARE NOT
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO FLEE.
THAT'S WHY WE SHOULD POSTPONE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE.
AND I REQUEST THE AMENDMENTS TO
BE ADOPTED AND REQUES AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER MORLOCK SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BEEN A PRESIDENT MAJORITY
LEADER- MOVED FOR THE
INDICTMENTS ON THE TABLE AS
FRONT THANK YOU SIR CENTER
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE SENATOR MARK MORLOCK IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE UNLESS IT
IS OKAY IF WE USE THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL SENATOR MORLOCK. THAT
IS FINE WITH ME MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SIR MUCH APPRECIATED
I AM OKAY WE HAVE AN OBJECTION
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FELL. I BRADFORD FIVE
CABRERO I DODD. HI TORONTO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I HUESO.
I HER TADO HI JACKSON. I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY
I NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI MY COUNTY HI WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY LET'S
MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY. BATES BATES MOTION TO
LAY THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NO
BATES NO FORTUS. MOTION TO
BELIEVE THE AND THAT'S ON THE
TABLE MORE JUST NOW FOR JUST
NOW CHIANG. TEN MOTIONS LADY
MAN THAT'S ON THE TABLE NOW
CHIANG NO DALLY. THE MOTION TO
NINETY MINUTES ON THE TABLE
DAHLE DALY NO GROWTH. GROWS
MOTION TO LADY AMENDMENTS THE
TABLE NO. GROVE NO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ MOTION TO LAY ON THE
TABLE A MUCH NEEDED AMENDMENTS
NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. THE
MOTION TO LAY MY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO MORAL.
MOTIONS TO LATE- CENTER
MORLOCKS MEMONS ON THE TABLE
NO. MORE MORALE NO WILK. WELL
THE MOTION DELAYED IN MEMPHIS
ON THE TABLE NO WILK NOW. BY
TWENTY NINE NEWS THE MOTION TO
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID
ON THE TABLE SENATOR NIELSEN.
BEFORE YOU VERY GOOD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ANNOUNCEMENTS BY SENATOR NELSON
SAT SEVEN CENTER NIELSEN. AND
THAT THIS AMENDMENT RELATES
SPECIFICALLY TO THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. AT THIS MOST
CRITICAL TIME FOR THE HEALTH
INDUSTRY AND PROFESSIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES. IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE COMPLEXITIES.
OF THESE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
THE MANY MANY MULTIPLE AND
CERTIFIED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ALL WHO HAVE
EXTENSIVE TRAINING AND TESTING.
TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THEIR
PURPOSE SERVING OUR HEALTH
NEEDS. EDIT ADDITION WHO ALSO
HAVE TWO INDOOR AND ENJOY IF
YOU WILL. REGULAR TRAININGS. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE IN THEIR
PROFESSIONS. THEY SHOULD
ANOTHER IS THE PARTICULAR THESE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE NO BUSINESS
WITHIN THE PROVISIONS. OF AB
TWENTY TWO AND FIFTY SEVEN.
THESE AMENDMENTS WOULD REMOVE
THEM FROM THE ONEROUS BURDEN.
AND THE DESTRUCTION OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. THAT THIS
LEGISLATION HAS NOW EFFECTED ON
ALL OF US. URGENT I WILL. ON
THE MEN THANK YOU CENTER NELSON
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THE
MAJORITY OF THE MOST MAKE NAY
THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE.
THERE'S ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
CENTER NIELSEN IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THAT WERE ACTUALLY THERE
NIELSEN WOULD YOU MIND IF WE
USE THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL
MADAM PRESIDENT YES INDEED I DO
EACH OF THESE INDIVIDUALS I
SPEAK TO ARE W. H. AND EVERYONE
OF THEM DESERVE THE FULL
ATTENTION OF EACH MEMBER OF THE
SENATE I DO OBJECT. TO A
NATIONAL CALL THANK YOU SIR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BELL HI BRADFORD HI
CABRERO AYE DODD. I TORONTO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
I WAS SO. HI HURTADO HI JACKSON
FIVE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL HI MONNING HI NIELSEN.
NO HAN I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER HI WAKO CITY I WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY LET'S
MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS OF THE
VOTING REMOTELY PLEASE. FACE
IT'S MOTION TO LADY MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE NOW. BATES NO FOR
JUST. FORGE'S EMOTIONALLY THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NOW FOR
JUST NOW CHIANG. HEY LISTEN TO
LADY AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
NOW. CHIANG NO DALLY. DALY
MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
GRILLS MOTION TO LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NOW.
GROVE NO MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
SOLUTION TO LATE AND MUCH
NEEDED AND THEN THE TABLE.
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. WARLOCKS
THE MOTION TOO LATE SENATOR
NIELSEN'S AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
WELL MOTION TO LAY AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE NO MORALE NO WILK.
LOOK THE MOTION DELAYED THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NO. WILK
NOW. FIVE TWENTY NINE NEWS TEN
THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN LAID ON
THE TABLE SENATOR NELSON DID
YOU HAVE AN ADDITIONAL SET OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I DO INDEED THIS SECOND
AMENDMENT THAT I AM PROPOSING
CITY CENTER NIELSEN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A SECRETARY READ.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR NIELSEN
SET EIGHT GO HEAD CENTER
NIELSEN THANK YOU THESE
AMENDMENTS ALSO RELATE. TO THE
VERY IMPORTANT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSION THE SEARCH EACH OF
US. NEARLY EVERY DAY THESE ARE
THE PHARMACIST. THAT I DO NOT
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE HOSTAGE IN
THIS LEGISLATION THAT FLIP
THROUGH HERE A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
THE PHARMACIST HAVE EXTENSIVE
EDUCATION. THEY LIKE OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS MUST
HAVE. ONGOING CONTINUING
EDUCATION TO MAINTAIN THEIR
SKILLS AND EXPAND AND IMPROVE
THEM PARTICULARLY IN THESE
DYNAMIC TIMES. THE PHARMACIES
PROVIDE SO MUCH. IT ARE SO
CRITICAL TO DELIVERING OUR
HEALTH CARE NEEDS. I BELIEVE
THAT THEY MOST ASSUREDLY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO RETAIN THEIR
INDEPENDENT STATUS IF YOU WILL.
AND TAKE ANOTHER THING IN MIND
FOR MANY OF THESE.
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY. THEY
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL IDENTITY
THAT THEY DESERVE AND THEY'VE
PRACTICED AND DEDICATED THEIR
LIVES. TO THAT INDIVIDUAL
IDENTITY. IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THOSE VERY SPECIFIC SKILLS THAT
SERVICE. SO NOW WITH THE
LEGISLATION THAT OVERRIDES ALL
OF THIS WE MAKE IT ALL
HOMOGENEOUS AND THEY'RE JUST A
TEENY BIT OF THE WHOLE. I THINK
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
IMPORTANCE. AND IT'S NOT AS IN
THE CASE OF THE OTHER CAL CARE
PROFESSIONALSI JUST REFERRED
TO. WE WOULD CERTAINLY HAVE
CHAOS. IN THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY THE PROVIDERS OF THOSE
OF THOSE PHARMACIST WHO SERVICE
I HEARD JULY VOTE. ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN CENTER HERTZBERG THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER- MOVES CHILE
THE MEMBERS ON THE TABLE LESS
RELIABLE. THANK YOU SIR CENTER
NIELSEN. I WOULD DOUBLE JACK TO
THE FOR THE SAME REASONS AGAIN.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO OF-THE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
THIS PROFESSION THANK YOU SIR.
SENATOR HURT IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE CENTER NIELSEN IS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS I FELL HI BRADFORD I
CABRERO I DODD I TERRAZZO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO I TADO. HI JACKSON
AYE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE I MITCHELL
I MONEY I NIELSEN NO PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN HI AMBERGATE
FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER HI LET'S
GO TO WAR MEMBERS OF THE VOTING
REMOTELY MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
PROCEED. BATES BASED MOTION TO
LADY MEMBERS ON THE TABLE NOW
BATES NOW FORTUS. FORGES A
MOTIONS THE MINUTES THE TABLE
NO. FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. HANG
MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW CHIANG NO DALLY.
DAILYMOTION TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. MOTION TO LADY
GROVE NO MELENDEZ MULLIN THIS
MOTION TO LAY THE MUCH NEEDED
AND THEN IT'S ON THE TABLE YEAH
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. THE
MOTION TO LAY SENATOR NIELSEN
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NO MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. MOTIONS LAY
SENATOR NELSON'S AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NOW MORALE NO WILK.
WILL BE MOST THE MOTION SO MAY
HAVE YOUR NAME IS ON THE TABLE
NOW WELL NOW. BUYS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE SENATOR
WILL WE'RE COMING TO YOU FOR A
LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS SENATOR
WILK. PLEASE READ. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR WELL SET
NINE SENATOR WELLS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN HE'S A
MEMBERS PROVIDED EXEMPTION FOR
EIGHTY FIVE STREET ABC TEST FOR
ALL REMAINING LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS IF SOMEONE NEEDS
A LICENSE TO PRACTICE THE
PROFESSION AND IT IS REQUIRED
TO BE TESTED AND TO BE SUBJECT
TO ENFORCEMENT BY THE STATE.
THEY HAVE AND THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. HE'S
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN TESTED
FOR THEIR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
PROFESSION. THEY HAVE INVESTED
HEAVILY IN THEIR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING AND HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SUBJECT TO RIGOROUS
REQUIREMENTS. WHAT REQUIREMENTS
TO PRACTICE YOUR CHOSEN
LICENSED PROFESSION. MEMBERS
ARBITRARILY CHOOSING WHICH
LICENSED PROFESSIONS TO ABIDE
BY THE STRICT REQUIREMENTS OF
ABC TASK IS COUNTER TO THE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE NEED FOR
LICENSURE IN THE FIRST PLACE
OUR STATE LICENSURE IS ENOUGH
TO PROVIDE WORKERS AND
CONSUMERS WITH ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS OR IT'S NOT. BY
SUPPORTING THESE AMENDMENTS YOU
KNOW SHE INTENDED PER A PURPOSE
AS STATE LICENSURE I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE MEN IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MOTION TO LAY
ON THE TABLE THANK THANK YOU
CENTER WILL CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MAJORITY LEADER MOST DELAY THE
NAMES ON THE TABLE AS RELIABLE
THANK YOU SIR CENTER WILL COULD
YOU BE OKAY IF WE USE THE
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. MADAM
PRESIDENT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OFFER A VERY SENSITIVE TO
THE FACT THAT IS THE LAST. LAST
NIGHT OF SESSION. BUT TO ME IT
WOULD BE AN AFFRONT. TO THE
HARDWORKING MEMBERS AT THE THIS
IS THE PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT THEY DO
TO. THAT ALL OF OUR LICENSEES
ARE THE HIGHEST PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS WILL. CALL THE ROLL
B. I. ACTING I GOTTA THANK YOU
FOR WILK THE SENATOR HERTZBERG
ASKING. FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
WORK CAUSE A FOR A NUMBER MEN
SECRETARY CALL ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE AT. AYE WELL. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I DODD.
HI THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
TELL I HUESO I HER TADO. I
JACKSON I LEYVA HI WIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONNING. I NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
NUMBER HI MY CASTING HI WIENER
HI WE CAN HELP SECRETARY WILL
MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS ARE VOTING
REMOTELY MADAM SECRETARY. BATES.
MOTION TO LAY ON THE TABLE NO.
BATES NO FORTUS. ORDERS MOTIONS
LADY MEMBERS THE TABLE NOW FOR
JUST NOW. CHANG TANG MOTIONS
LEVY MAN THAT'S ON THE TABLE
NOW CHIANG NO DALLY. OUR MOTION
TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. GROSS
TO LEADING IN MINUTES ON THE
TABLE NO GROWTH NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ MOTION TO LADIES MUCH
NEEDED AMENDMENTS. MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. MOTION TO LAYS
SENATOR WILKES AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE NO. MORLOCK NO MORALE.
TULARE CENTER WORKS MOTION-
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE NOW.
MORALITY NO WILK. WILK THE
MOTION DELAYED THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE NO WILK NOW FIVE
TWENTY NINE NEWS TEN THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID ON
THE TABLE MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO RETURN TO THE BILL IN CHIEF
AND WE'RE AT THE DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE POINT LOOKING FOR ANY
MICROPHONES UP. ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NONE SINGLE ONE HAND
RAISED SENATOR DOLLY PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST WANT TO RISE I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD ALL THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT. YOU AB FIVE
ACTUALLY HAS SOME REAL
COMPLICATIONS AND WE'VE HEARD
I'M SURE ALL OF YOU FROM YOUR
PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICT THAT
ARE VERY FRUSTRATED IN THESE
CARVE OUTS NEED TO STOP WE NEED
TO FIX AB FIVE IN GENERAL AND
FOR THOSE REASONS- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THERE ARE
SOME GOOD WORK IN THEIR- BUT
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN NOT BE FAR
BEHIND OUR- STILL. WHEN WE SEE
SUFFERING AND YOU KNOW IT'S
ABOUT FREEDOM IT'S ABOUT
ALLOWING PEOPLE THAT WANT TO BE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THOSE
WHO WANT TO SECURE IS OF JOB
AND A FORTY HOUR WEEK THAT'S
GREAT THEY CAN THEY CAN GO TO
WORK FOR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THOSE OF US WHO. WANT FREEDOM
AND WANT TO BE ABLE TO- YOU
KNOW INDEPENDENTLY CONTRACTED
TO GROWN HOURS WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY ARE
SENATOR JOHN. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
I SHARED SEVERAL TIMES IN
COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR
THAT- YOU KNOW FOR MOST OF MY
LIFE I'VE BEEN AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR MY WIFE CURRENTLY
IS- THIS IS THE- MANNER IN
WHICH WE'VE CHOSEN TO. EARN
MOST OF OUR- LIVING MOST OF OUR
CAREER. AND A LOT OF CAL
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVING
THAT SAME CHOICE- THIS BILL
DOES MOVE. THE NEEDLE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE MAJORITY
PARTY DIDN'T ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD HAVE MADE
THIS BILL TREMENDOUSLY BETTER-
SO I'M ASSUMING THAT. NEXT YEAR
MORE AMENDMENTS WILL BE ARE
MORE- ANOTHER BILL WILL COME
FORWARD THAT THAT YOU GUYS
APPROVED SO I'M HOPING THAT A
LOT OF THESE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THAT ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING- TO KEEP FOOD ON THE
TABLE WILL BE ABLE TO REACH OUT
TO YOUR OFFICES AND THERE WILL
BE A LITTLE BIT OF SYMPATHY
THERE FOR. THESE ESPECIALLY
SOME OF THE ONES THAT WE- WE
INTRODUCED. AT INDIAN BUT AS
FAR AS THIS BILL GOES IT DOES
HELP A LITTLE BIT TO CLEAN UP
AB FIVE IT- IT DOESN'T MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS TO CLEAN UP ALL OF
AB VICE DISASTROUS MESS. BUT IT
DOES- HELP A FEW OTHER PEOPLE.
IN DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES SO I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES AGAIN
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL- AGAIN I
AM VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
MAJORITY PARTY DID NOT TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WOULD HAVE
HELPED A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
MORE PEOPLE INCLUDING MY BILL
WHICH WOULD REPEAL AB FIVE
ALTOGETHER AND ALLOWED PEOPLE
THE WORKER FREEDOM CHOICE THAT
WE NEED- I AM. ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN PEOPLE
WORKING AT HOME I'M TRYING TO
ADAPT A DISTANCE LEARNING
HAVING YOUR KIDS AT HOME YOU
KNOW BEING ABLE TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND WORK
FREELY OUTSIDE OF THE HOME-
WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO. WIN OR
EVEN INSIDE THE HOME AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR WOULD BE
REALLY BENEFICIAL ESPECIALLY IN
A TIME IN A PANDEMIC THAT WE
FACE RIGHT NOW- WHEN MOST JOBS
ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS UNLESS RESIDENTIAL
WORKER. AND SO- LIKE I SAID I'M
VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DID
NOT TAKE THE AMENDMENTS BUT-
THIS BILLDOES MOVE THE NEEDLE
A LITTLE BIT. AND I GUESS- A
LITTLE BIT IS BETTER THAN
NOTHING AT ALL SO I ASK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE CENTER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT- I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT IT. THE FACT. THAT WE
HAVE HAD SO MANY BILLS
INTRODUCED TO AMEND. THE
ORIGINAL BELT SHOULD TELL
EVERYONE THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
TERRIBLY WRONG. WITH THIS BILL
WE HAVE ALL HAD PEOPLE. WRITE
TO US. CALL LIGHTS IN TEARS
BECAUSE NOW THEY DON'T HAVE A
JOB AND THEY DID NOT HAVE TO BE
THIS WAY AND- YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A COMMENT MADE. ORIGINALLY
WHERE THE DOCTOR SAID THAT
THOSE WEREN'T REAL JOBS ANYWAY.
WELL I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THEY
WERE REAL JOBS AND THEY WERE
REAL PEOPLE. WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED. BY THIS LEGISLATION
AND NOW THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO IT. AT A TIME. I MEAN IT
COULDN'T COME AT A WORSE TIME
FOR A LOOK WHERE WE ARE IN OR
PEOPLE ARE LUCKY. TO EVEN STILL
HAVE A PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT TO
GO THIS IS HAVING A TERRIBLE
EFFECT ON PEOPLE MEAN JUST.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN
SAID YOU KNOW THEY THEY
ABSOLUTELY MUST WORK IN THIS
FASHION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SOMEONE AT HOME. WHO IS WHO IS
SICK THAT THEY NEED TO TAKE
CARE WHERE THEY HAVE A SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD SO THEY REALLY
NEED. THAT FLEXIBILITY I BAD
PEOPLE RIGHT TO ME AND TELL ME
THAT. THEY WERE NOT HIRED
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO THEY WILL
TAKE SOMEONE FROM OUT OF STATE
RATHER THAN TAKE SOMEONE FROM
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
THAT THEY MIGHT RUN AFOUL OF
THE LAW. THIS IS. ONE OF THE
MOST DISASTROUS PIECES OF
LEGISLATION WE COULD HAVE EVER
PUT FORWARD. AND THAT THE
GOVERNOR COULD HAVE EVER SIGNED
IT IS RUINED. THOUSANDS OF
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS AND I AM
JUST SO DISHEARTENED AND
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE COULDN'T
COME TOGETHER ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND GIVE
PEOPLE SOME RELIEF. AND GIVE
THEM BACK THEIR DIGNITY. AND
THEIR WAY OF LIFE FOR THEM AND
THEIR WAY OF SUPPORTING
FAMILIES THIS IS SHAMEFUL. FOR
ALL OF THE TARGET WE HERE IN
THE SENATE FOR ABOUT LIFTING
PEOPLE UPOUT OF POVERTY AND
ALL THE OTHER BILLS WE PASSED
BECAUSE WE SAY IT'S GOING TO.
HELP LOWER INCOME MANY HELP
BLACK COMMUNITIES AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS HURTING
THEM. SO WHERE THE RELAY FOR
THEM. ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL
DOES THAT NOT MATTER. I JUST I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW A BLIND
EYECAN BE TURNED TO THE PLATES
THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
RIGHT NOW SITE WALLABY
SUPPORTING THE BILL I AM
GREATLY DISAPPOINTED- THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS WERE NOT TAKEN
TO HELP EVERYONE AS HUMANLY
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER MELINDA'S CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I AM
PREPARED TO VOTE FOR THE REAL
LIFE. BETTER YOU SHOULD READ ON
THE FLOOR HI MY- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE EQUAL PROTECTION
CLAUSE THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT
TO THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION WHICH TOOK OUT ANY
TEAM SIXTY EIGHT LET ME PROVIDE
THIS QUOTE FROM DIRECTLY FROM
IT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
TROUBLING ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IT SAYS NOR SHALL ANY
STATE DENY TO ANY PERSON WITHIN
ITS JURISDICTION THE EQUAL
PROTECTION OF THE LAWS THIS
PARTICULAR BILL DOES EXACTLY
THE OPPOSITE IT CREATES THOSE
WHO ARE NOW GOING TO BE. A
PROJECTION OF THIS LAW AND
LEAVES OUT A SCORE YOU SCORE OF
PEOPLE THOUSANDS ACTUALLY WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT OF THOSE WHO
ARE IN THE FRANCHISE BUSINESS
FROM THE PROTECTION OF THIS LAW
SO IT'S REALLY- IT HAS PICKED
WINNERS AND LOSERS WE'VE BEEN
SAYING THAT ALL ALONG YOU KNOW
I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE BEING
PART OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT
MAKES THAT KIND OF DECISION
THAT HARMS. HELP SOME HARMS
SCORES AND SCORES OF PEOPLE
FROM THE LIVELIHOOD THAT THEY
CHOSE PERHAPS AS YOUNG CHILDREN
DREAMING OF WHAT THEY WANTED TO
BE SO WE NEED TO TAKE A LONG
HARD LOOK WE REALLY NEED TO
HAVE THIS REPEAL IF NOT BY WHEN
I WOULD CONSIDER TO BE A VERY
THOUGHTFUL REVIEW OF THIS AS WE
GO INTO THE NEXT SESSION OR
HOPEFULLY THAT THE COURT STEP
IN AND DO THE RIGHT THING. I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL HOWEVER
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER.
BATES CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT I. ALSO BE WILLING
FOR THE BILL BUT AB FIVE PUT IN
SOME EXTREMELY ONEROUS
PENALTIES AND SO CPA'S.
ENROLLED AGENTS. ATTORNEYS ARE
HAVING A REAL DIFFICULT TIME
TRYING TO INTERPRET AB FIVE- IT
IS COSTING A LOT OF BUSINESSES
A LOT IN FEES I ENDED IT- IT
JUST IS JUST OVERSTAFFED WE
WILL DYNAMICS WAS WRONG. NO
ARGUMENTS THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF DYNAMICS SHOULD
NOT HAVE TAKEN THE APPROACH
THAT THEY DID BUT TO HARM- AND
HURT SO MANY INNOCENT
BUSINESSPEOPLE HI IS THIS IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD REALLY STEP
BACK ON AND REFLECT. WHEN I
HAVE A BUSINESS OWNER WHO SAYS
WE CAN'T GET A DECENT OPINION.
AND WE'RE A PUBLISHER AND WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO. READ A
WRITER AND AUTHOR AS AN
EMPLOYEE OUT BECAUSE THEY
USUALLY GET ROYALTIES BASED ON
THE SALES OF THEIR BOOKS SO
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR LONG
LEGAL OPINIONS. WE'RE JUST
GONNA MOVE OUR BUSINESS TO
ARIZONA AND SO I HAD TO SAY
GOODBYE TO SOME PEOPLE SO I
WOULD JUST HOPE THAT WE COULD
TAKE A HARDER LOOK. AT AB FIVE.
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN IS THE
NATURAL COURSE WERE EVERY YEAR
WE- THROW SOME MORE PEOPLE.
INTO THE WHAT HE CALLED ON THE
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S JUST
THAT'S JUST NOT RIGHT SO WE
NEED TO FIX IT IT'S GOT TO BE
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR EVERYBODY-
AND- WITH THAT I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FOR GIVING US
THE TIME. THANK YOU CENTER MORE
ALL SEEING NO FURTHER HANDS
RAISED SEEING NO MICROPHONE ON
THE FLOOR SENATOR JACKSON YOU
MAY CLOSE. ADAM PRESIDENT ARE
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I FELT. I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I DODD I
DURAZO HI GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI HILL.
I HUESO. I HER TADO. HI JACKSON
I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONEY I NIELSEN. I CAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I. ROSS. I RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI STERN AYE NUMBER HI
WAKO SKI I WIENER HI. PLEASE
CALL THE REMOTE MEMBERS. THE
BASICS. AB GIVE ME. YOUR NUMBER
I GOT MYSELF SOMEONE AB. TWO
TWO FIVE SEVENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. SAY IT AGAIN A **** FILE
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN HI. BAYSIDE. EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE FOUR JUST WE'RE JUST AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN LINE FOR
JUST BY CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN I CHIANG HI
DALY. AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
FIVE DALLY HI GROWTH. AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN I GROVE FIVE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN NINE MELENDEZ HI
MORLOCK. AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
BY ORLOK BY RURAL WELL AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN. MORRELL HI WILK.
WILK AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
HI WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE OH
ZERO ON THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO IN THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW
TO FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKER PROTECTIONS AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR
MITCHELL MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
BILL FILLS THE GAP LEFT OPEN BY
THE FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
CORONA VIRUS RESPONSE AT THE
BILL PROVIDES UP TO EIGHTY
HOURS OF COVERT NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR. FOOD SECTOR WORKERS AND
WORKERS EMPLOYED BY AN EMPLOYER
WITH FIVE HUNDRED MORE
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYEES OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS SUCH AS
FIREFIGHTERS. THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE SMALL EMPLOYER%
FAMILY MEDIATION PILOT PROGRAM
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP SEEING NO HANDS
UP MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BELL I BRADFORD I
CABRERO I DON'T. I TERRAZZA HI
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI FURTADO HI JACKSON HI I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL HI
MY NAME HI NIELSEN. NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI STERN. HI NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER HI
LET'S GO PLEASED TO OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY ONE AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR BATES. SURVEYS AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN NO EIGHT
NOW FOR JUST. MERGES AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN NOW OR
JUST NOW CHIANG AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN I'D CHIANG HI SALLY.
DALY AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN NO.
DALLY NO GROWTH AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN NO GROWTH NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN NO MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK MOORLACH AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN VOTING
NOW CARL NO WILK. WILK AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN AND NOW.
WELL NOW. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
RIGHT ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR. FORTY FOUR. SENATOR
WIENER. YEAH THIS IS A. OKAY
HOLD ON ONE SECOND PLEASE.
MARK THE FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
BY IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AN
ACT RELATING TO JURIES SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM PRESIDENT IS -- DOES UP
ON RECONSIDERATION I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT BY PURE COINCIDENCE
-- TODAY -- BY PURE COINCIDENCE
TODAY THE CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT DENIED
REVIEW OF A CASE COMING OUT
OF LOS ANGELES WHERE IN THAT
CASE AND THE ISSUE ON APPEAL
WAS THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
STRUCK A BLACK JUROR QUOTE WHO
SAID QUOTE SAYS GROWING UP IN
LA AS A BLACK WOMAN WITH BLACK
BROTHERS AND QUOTE SHE HAD
EXPERIENCED POLICE HARASSMENT
AND THE QUESTION WAS IS THAT
APPROPRIATE IN DENYING REVIEW
THE COURT SAID THAT THIS
WASN'T THE RIGHT TASTE TAKE
UP THAT ISSUE BUT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE SPECIFICALLY REFERRED
TO ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY AS SOMETHING THAT WAS
MOVING IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
WAS PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AROUND ENDING RACISM IN
OUR JURY SELECTION SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR UMBERG
THANK YOU MEMBERS
I I APPRECIATE WHITE HOUSE
CONSENSUS BECAUSE COMMENTS
SO THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S COMMENTS
ON WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO TO
REALIZE HERE IS THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE BUT THIRTY SEVENTY IS NOT
THE RESOLUTION OF THAT ISSUE
THERE ARE OTHER METHODS AGAIN
I AGREE WITH JUSTICE THURGOOD
MARSHALL SAID WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE PRINT TREES WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS THIS BILL
BASICALLY MAKES IT ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY WHEN RACE
IS AN ISSUE AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT RACE WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEFENDANT EXCLUSIVELY BUT ALSO
WITH RESPECT TO THE VICTIM
WHAT THIS DOES IS ESSENTIALLY
WHERE THE DEFENSE COUNSEL HAS
TEN PRINTER JONES ON A FAMILY
OR TWENTY FOR EXAMPLE -- WHERE
THERE'S LIFE IMPRISONMENT
AND THE PROSECUTORS BASICALLY
ELIMINATED FROM THE EQUATION
WHAT THAT WILL DO IS WILL
SKEW THE JURY AND YOU MARK MY
WORDS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
CREATE NOT JUST AN IMPEDIMENT
BUT IT'S GOING TO CREATE A
MAJOR PROBLEM I URGE A NO VOTE
AND I URGE THAT WE ACTUALLY
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE NEXT YEAR MY COLLEAGUES
INSTANCES GOING I HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF THIS BILL AND AND WHAT WE
MIGHT DO TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE
I URGE THAT WE DO RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE WE RESOLVE IT NEXT
YEAR THANK YOU THANK YOU OF
BEFORE WE GO TO CENTER ROSS WE
HAVE -- SENATOR BORCHERS HAS
HIS HAND UP SENATOR BORCHERS
THANK YOU
WE JUST GOT DONE HAVING A
LENGTHY DISCUSSION ON EIGHTY
FIVE AND THE REASON WHY I
BRING THAT UP IS I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH A LOT OF MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN BOTH HOUSES
FOLKS THAT ACTUALLY SUPPORTED
AB FIVE BUT PRIVATELY HAD HAVE
SPOKEN -- WHETHER OR NOT THE
ISSUE SHOULD HAVE BEEN VETTED
MORE PRIOR TO A DECISION BEING
MADE I USE THIS BY ANALOGY
HERE THAT YESTERDAY'S ROBUST
DISCUSSION UPON PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES YOU'RE HEARING FROM
SO MANY FOLKS IN YOU WILL EVEN
MORE DOWN THE ROAD THAT IF
WE'RE LEARNING A LESSON ON HOW
THIS IMPACTS PEOPLE WHETHER IT
BE DEFENDANTS WHETHER BE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS WHETHER BE PROSECUTED
BE JUDGES THIS CLEARLY DID
NOT GO THROUGH A VETTING
PROCESS AND I WOULD IMPLORE
MY COLLEAGUES LET THIS GO
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS BE
BROUGHT BACK IN JANUARY BECAUSE
IF WE'RE TO LEARN A LESSON
FROM HOW WE BE FIVE PLAYED
ITSELF OUT IT WILL AFFECT YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN WAYS WITH A
LOT OF UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
SO EVEN THOUGH I THINK THIS
THING HAS A LOT OF MERIT
IN A FEW DIFFERENT AREAS HE
DESERVES TO GO THROUGH MULTIPLE
SCREENINGS ARE COMMITTEES
WITH EXPERTS AT HAND AND --
THE NORMAL VETTING PROCESS
THAT ALLOWS FOR GOOD POLICY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR BORDER
SENATOR ROTH FIGURING PRESIDENT
TERM COLLEAGUES AS YOU KNOW
I'VE SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF
TIME IN MY VARIOUS CAREERS IN
OUT OF COURT ROOMS AND I HAVE
TO CONFESS THAT MINE -- BIASES
AGAINST THE USE OF PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES IN FACT I ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD -- THE
DOCTOR MEASURE THAT ELIMINATES
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND -- THE PROCESS
FOR THE USE OF PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES IS RIFE WITH
PROBLEMS INCLUDING PROBLEMS
OF DISCRIMINATION AND THE
LIKE SO WHEN I REVIEWED THIS
MEASURE I WAS PREDISPOSED TO
VOTE TO A ADOPTED MMHM BUT I
WAS APPROACHED BY FOLKS FROM
ALL SIDES AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS AND AFTER BEING POUNDED
FOR A FEW DAYS I DECIDED I
REALLY NEEDED TO DIG INTO
THIS MEASURE AND SEE WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY SAID BEYOND JUST
READING IT AND HOW IT WOULD
APPLY TO THE PRACTICE OF TRYING
TO WORK IN A CALIFORNIA COURT
SYSTEM AND SO I'M SPEAKING
BY WAY OF EXPLANATION OF MY
NO VOTE BEFORE AND MY NO VOTE
AS THIS ROLE IS CALLED ONCE
AGAIN AND WHAT I FOUND WHEN
I LEARNT LOOKED INTO THE BILL
IN THE PROCESS THAT IT WAS
IT WAS COMPELLING FOR USE IN
OUR TRIAL COURTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I FOUND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT WAS GOING TO
LENGTHEN THE PROCESS BY WHICH
ARE CRIMINAL COURT TRIALS
ARE BROUGHT TO CONCLUSION AND
WHEN IT APPLIES TO THE CIVIL
TRIALS IN OUR STATE IT WOULD
LENGTHEN THOSE AS WELL AND
COMING FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WERE JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
IT WAS TAKING MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS TO GET A CIVIL CASE TO
TRIAL SUCH THAT THEY HAD TO
CALL THE CASES CALL THEM AND
THEN A JOURNALISM TO AVOID
HAVING THE CASES DISMISSED
BECAUSE WE HAVE A RULE IN THE
STATE BUT IF THE CASE IS NOT
BROUGHT TO TRIAL WITHIN FIVE
YEARS IF IT'S A CIVIL CASE
IT WILL BE DISMISSED AND THAT
WAS BECAUSE OUR CRIMINAL CASES
WERE TAKING UP ALL OF THE
AVAILABLE COURT ROOMS ALMOST
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY SO I LOOKED
AT THIS PROCESS AND I NOTICED
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION A GROUP OF TRIAL
JUDGES THAT HAVE TO MANAGE THE
PROCESS IN OUR COURT SYSTEM
HAD A SERIES OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WAY THE BILL WAS DRAFTED
END OF THE CALIFORNIA TRIAL
JUDGES ASSOCIATION LISTED
THESE CONCERNS IN ONE OR MORE
DOCUMENTS AND TOOK A LOOK AT
THEM AND I REJECTED THOSE THAT
I THOUGHT HAD LESS MIRRORED AND
I CAME UP WITH A LIST OF ABOUT
TEN CONCERNS THAT I THOUGHT
WERE SUBSTANTIAL AND FRANKLY
I REDUCE START SPENT THE NIGHT
DOING THIS ON A REDUCED THESE
CONCERNS TO A TWO PAGE DOCUMENT
AND I SENT THE DOCUMENT AROUND
AND I ASKED THE AUTHORS STAFF
THROUGH MY STAFF WHAT WERE
THE WHAT WERE THE REASONS WHAT
WAS THE RATIONALE THAT THESE
CONCERNS WERE NOT ADDRESSED
WHY DID YOU NOT TAKE A LOOK
AT THE CLEAR AND CONVINCING
TEST THAT THE TRIAL JUDGE
WAS ASKED TO APPLY CLEARING
CONVINCING EVIDENCE WHEN THERE
WAS A SENSUALLY NO EVIDENCE IT
WAS GOING TO BE PRESENTED IN
THE TRIAL IN WHICH TO UTILIZE
THAT TO US WHY DID YOU HAVE
AN APPELLATE COURT PROCEDURE
WHERE IN CONTRAST TO THE NORMAL
APPEALS PROCESS WE WERE GOING
TO ASK THE APPELLATE COURT
TO EXERCISE A DO NOVO REVIEW
WHICH MEANS JUMPED INTO THE
PANTS OF THE TRIAL JUDGE AND
AND SECOND GUESS THE TRIAL
JUDGE WHO'S ON THE SCENE AT THE
TIME LOOKING AT THE DEMEANOR
OF THE WITNESSES THE ACTIONS
OF THE TRIAL COUNSEL IN THE
LIGHT AND ON AND ON I WON'T
BORE YOU WITH THE LIST OF TEN
OR SO -- ISSUES THAT I WAS
TRYING TO PUT FORTH AND THERE
WAS NO EXPLANATION AND THEN THE
OTHER DAY THERE WAS AN ANSWER
THERE WAS A COMMENT MADE ON IN
BY SOMEONE ON THE FLOOR DEBATE
THAT THE THE OBJECTIONS OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION SHEPHERD
SO SHE ASIAN WERE DRESSED AND
THERE ISN'T THERE IS NOTHING
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH WITH
RESPECT TO THAT THOSE CONCERNS
REMAIN THE JUDGES ASSOCIATION
JUST LIKE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DOES NOT FEEL THE ABILITY TO
TAKE A VERY STRONG POSITION IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR OBVIOUS
REASONS BECAUSE THE BILL IS
YOU KNOW YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PRINCIPLE COOPER ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE WE CONTROL
THE PURSE STRINGS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE'VE NOT BEEN
VERY GENEROUS AS YOU KNOW OVER
THE PAST IN THE PAST YEARS SO
I'M GOING TO BE VOTING NO THE
PROCESS IS ON YOUR GLOBAL THERE
WAS A FAILURE DRESS TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE JUDGES WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE TO MANAGE THE
PROCESS AND FRANKLY I THINK
WE NEED TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME HERE ON THE DETAIL
SO THE WILL PUT TERMS OF THE
THE DOORS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS ACTUALLY A WORKABLE PRODUCT
NOT A WANT NOT OF A PRODUCT
TO SIMPLY ADDRESS ISSUES
ISSUES THAT ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT NEED
TO ADDRESS THE ADDRESS IT'S
A COMPELLING SITUATION WITH
RESPECT TO THESE PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES THERE ARE USED
TO ENGAGE IN DISCRIMINATION
WHICH IS INTOLERABLE BUT WE
KEPT IN FIXING THAT CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE WE CANNOT GET
CASES TO TRIAL WE CANNOT GET
CASES THROUGH TRIAL CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL SO ROTH WILL BE
VOTING NO ON THE MEASURE AGAIN
TODAY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING NONE SEEING NO HANDS UP
SENATOR WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH TRYING
TO PRESIDENT -- IT'S ALWAYS
AWKWARD TO DISAGREE WITH YOUR
FRIENDS IN THE SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE SENATOR
OFTEN RIVERSIDE OF TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR WHOM I HAVE
THE AMONG THE HIGHEST RESPECT
IN THIS LEGISLATURE ON BUT WE
HAVE A FRIENDLY A DISAGREEMENT
AMONG AMONG FRIENDS THAN AMONG
COLLEAGUES -- I NO BILL IS
PERFECT WITH THE AUTHOR DID
TAKE SOME AMENDMENTS FROM THE
JUDGES ASSOCIATION I DON'T I
DON'T THINK SHE'S CLAIMED TO
HAVE TAKEN ALL OF THEM -- BY
THE SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE JUDGES
ASSOCIATION TO TAKE WHAT THEY
CALL IT I THINK WAS A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT ON ALL SIDES ON
THIS BILL IS HONESTLY IT'S
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALSO AN IMPORTANT
STATEMENT BY THIS LEGISLATURE
THAT WE DATA AND THAT WE WANT
TO SEE CHANGE -- AND SO I
BELIEVE THIS WILL BE A GOOD
STOP AND I ASKED HER AYE VOTE
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS I TELL
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
DODD NO DURAZO I GALGIANI
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HILL HI HUESO
HURTADO
JACKSON NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE
I MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN
NO HAN I PORTANTINO I.
ROSS NO RUBIO I SKINNER
I STERN I AM VERY OWN
NO WAY CASKEY I WIENER I
IT WILL BRING IT TO
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
WELL I'M SORRY LET'S CALL
THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME CHOOSE
ME ALL OF THOSE MEMBERS HERE
IN ON THE FLOOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
CABRERO
GALGIANI
HERTZBERG I
HUESO
HURTADO
LET'S GO OVER TO THE
REMOTE MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR AB THIRTY
SEVENTY SENATOR BATES
FACE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ON MUTE
SENATOR BAIT
YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE
NOT ANYMORE THANK YOU OKAY
BATES AB THIRTY SEVENTY NO
BATES NOW FOR JUST WE'RE
JUST AB THREE THIRTY SEVENTY
EIGHT NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG
CHIANG AB THIRTY SEVENTY
NO CHANGE NO DALLY DOLLY
AB THIRTY SEVENTY NO AGAIN
DALLY NO ROAST AB THIRTY
SEVENTY NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AB THIRTY SEVENTY
NOW MELENDEZ NOW MORLOCK SB
THIRTY TO SEVENTY NO MORE
LOCK NO MORALE EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY NOW MORRELL NO WILK
WILK AB THIRTY
SEVENTY NOW WILK NOW
SENATOR WIENER MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
NINETY EXCUSE ME FORTY TWO
WE'RE GOING BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING COLLEAGUES
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN
ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
CENTER LEYVA I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING GOOD
TO BE WITH YOU ARE YOU WILL
ALL REMEMBER THAT I LOVE WALL
WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND I HAD A
BILL A COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN
MY NAME WAS UNCEREMONIOUSLY
STRIPPED FROM THE BILL AND SO
I'M HERE TODAY TO TRY AND GET
AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX PASSED
WHICH WOULD CREATE WORKPLACE
STANDARDS FOR WAREHOUSE WORKERS
OPERATE UNDER A QUOTA SYSTEM
IN MODERN WAREHOUSES COMPANY
SET SPECIFIC QUOTAS FOR WORKERS
TO MEET SUCH AS HOW MANY ITEMS
PER HOUR THEY SHOULD PULL AND
PACKAGE FOR CONSUMER EMPLOYERS
MONITOR THAT PRODUCTIVITY AS
WELL AS HOW MUCH TIME OFF TASK
OCCURS INCLUDING THE TIME IT
TAKES TO USE THE RESTROOM TOO
MUCH OF THIS TIME OFF TASK
OR FAILURE TO MEET THE QUOTA
CAN RESULT IN WORKERS BEING
FIRED WITHOUT A HUMAN MANAGER
EVEN BEING INVOLVED IN ONE
WAREHOUSE FACILITY RIVERSIDE
EMPLOYEES HAD TO WALK FOR SEVEN
MINUTES TO THE NEAREST RESTROOM
LEADING MANY TO SKIP BATHROOM
WHAT BREAKS RATHER THAN FACE
PENALTIES OR LOSE HER JOB
FOR TIME OFF TASK DURING OUR
CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BECOME EVEN
MORE RELIANT ON WAREHOUSES
AS A ORDER ITEMS ONLINE WHILE
THE CENTRAL WAREHOUSE WORKERS
CONTINUE TO TRY TO MEET STRICT
QUOTAS WITHOUT EXTRA TIME
ALLOTTED EVEN FOR NECESSARY
HAND WASHING AB THIRTY FIFTY
SIX WOULD ADDRESS THIS BY
PROHIBITING EMPLOYERS FROM
IMPOSING A QUOTA THAT DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR A REASONABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME SPENT FOR CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS ACCESSING
AND USING A RESTROOM HYDRATION
OR HAND WASHING STATION
DOCUMENTING REPORTING A LABOR
CODE VIOLATION AND TAKING A
LEGALLY MANDATED BREAKS THIS
BILL WOULD CLEARLY BILLION
EIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
UNDER THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
TO INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS
OF VIOLATIONS THAT SPECIFY A
CIVIL PENALTY OF NO MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
AN INITIAL VIOLATION AND NO
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND FOR
SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT WORKERS
DON'T HAVE TO FEAR USING THE
RESTROOM OR WASHING THEIR
HANDS TO COMPLY WITH CURRENT
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDANCE
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM SEEING NO MIKE'S
UP SEEING NO HANDS UP MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ARCHULETA
ATKINS I FELT HI BRADFORD
CABALLERO
DODD NO THEY'RE AWESOME
I GALGIANI
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
I HILL NO WAY SO
I HER TADO NO JACKSON AYE
AYE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
NIELSEN NO HAN PORTANTINO
ROTH
RUBIO
SKINNER I STERN
I'M BURKE
HI CASKEY I WIENER HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
ARCHULETA
ATKINS I
BRADFORD
CABALLERO
NEXT GALGIANI
PAM
PORTANTINO
ROTH
RUBIO
STERN I AM BURKE
GOING NOW TO THE REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO AB THIRTY
FIFTY SIX SENATOR BATES
BASED
AS AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX NO SIX
NOW FOR JUST AB THREE ZERO
FIVE SIX NOW FOR JUST NOW
CHIANG HANG AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
NOW CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI AB
THREE ZERO FIVE SIX NO DALLY
NO GROWTH GROSS AB THREE ZERO
FIVE SIX NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AB THREE ZERO FIVE
SIX NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK
OR LIKE AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
IS NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE
AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX MORALE
BUILDING NO MORALE NO WILK
AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX NO WELL
NOW SENATOR LEYVA MOVED TO CALL
MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
AN ACT RELATING TO PEACE
OFFICER'S CENTER KOBE HERO
GET READY
FLOOR'S YOURS
MADAM PRESIDENT
WE'RE GONNA PASS ON THAT
TEMPORARILY PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING RIGHT ALONG THEN TO FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
FORTY EIGHT. THAT IS A SENATOR
MITCHELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF TWENTY FIVE FORTY
TWO BEFORE YOU TODAY HARMLESS
ERROR HARMLESS ERROR IS NOT
HELD BY ITS STATEMENTS IN A
COURT OF LAW OR DESCRIBE
HARMLESS ERROR IS HOW PRESIDENT
PREJUDICIAL BEHAVIORS DESCRIBED
HARMLESS ERROR IT'S OUR RACISM
IS DEEMED ACCEPTABLE IN OUR
COURTS OF LAW. THIS BEHAVIOR IS
CONSIDERED HARMLESS ERROR IN
OUR CURRENT JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
MANY OF YOU WILL KNOW MORE THAN
FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO IN THE
KLASKY VERSUS CAMP THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THERE
MUST BE A DEMONSTRATION OF COLD
CONSCIOUS DELIBERATE BIAS. AND
THE GENERAL DISPARITIES AREN'T
ARE N INEVITABLE PART OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
DECISION IS WIDELY KNOWN AS THE
DRED SCOTT DECISION OF OUR
TIME. THE NEW YORK TIMES WROTE
THAT THE SUPREME COURT HAD
QUOTE EFFECTIVELY CONDONED THE
EXPRESSION OF RACISM. THE L. A.
TIMES CALLED THE RULING THE
WORSE THE CREAM COURT RULING
SINCE TE SECOND WORLD WAR. AS
A RESULT. PREJUDICE BIAS AND
RACISM ARE HARMLESS ERRORS IN
OUR COURTS AND WHERE THE PEOPLE
SEEK EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW. SPECIFICALLY WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO PROHIBITS THE STATE
FROM SEEKING. ARE UPHOLDING THE
CONVICTION OR A SENTENCE. THAT
IS DISCRIMINATORY BASED ON RACE
ETHNICITY OR NATIONAL ORIGIN.
THE BILL PLAYS A DISTINCT ROLE
IN HOW AND WHEN A PERSON IS
CHARGED WITH THE CRIME. AND HOW
THEY PURSUE THEIR DUE PROCESS
IN THE COURT. IT'S TIME TO
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE POLICY
THAT MAKES IT UNLAWFUL TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLORFUL. PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
THE STATE'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM- THERE ARE. OPPONENTS
INCLUDING BE. JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
IF PEOPLE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS I'LL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO SHARE ON MY CLOTHING.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CONCERNS BUT
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM IS THERE ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP IN THE ROOM.
LET'S GO TO THE REMOTE.
PARTICIPANTS. WE GO TO THE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE. AND
THERE ARE NO HANDS UP THERE
EITHER MADAM. NO ALL RIGHT OF
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I FELL. I BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
DODD. DURAZO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO.
JACKSON. OKAY LEYVA. FIVE
REQUIRE FIVE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE NIELSEN. NO HAN
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH. HI
RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE. BY CASKEY HI WIENER. I
BRADLEY HI WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME ON THE FLOOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
I. BRADFORD I CABALLERO. DODD.
I GLAZER I HER TADO. JACKSON.
IT'S HARD. RUBIO I AM BURKE HI.
MOVING NOW TO THE OF MEMBERS
REMOTELY VOTING THIS IS FILE
ITEM. FORTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO BATUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WHO ARE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FACE BATES AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO NOW BATES NOW
FOR JUST. WE'RE JUST AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO NOW BARGES NO
CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO NOW CHANGE NO DALLY.
SORRY DALY AB. TWENTY FIVE
FORTY TWO NO DALLY NO GROWTH
GROSS AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO
NO. ROVE NOW MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
AB. TWO FIVE FOUR TWO NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK OR LIKE
ABTWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. HE TWENTY
FIVE FOR TO MORROW VOTING NOW.
WELL NO WILK. WE WILL AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY TWO NOW WILK NO.
FIVE TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ALONG NOW
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SENATOR ALAN.
SENATOR ALAN NOT AT HIS DESK
PASS TEMPORARILY MOVING ON.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE. SENATOR HERTZBERG FILE
ITEM. FIFTY ONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE COLLEAGUES WERE
PLEASE EVERYONE AT THEIR DESKS
EVERYBODY AT THEIR DESK GOING
TO GO WITH TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
RELATING TO PRIVACY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM PRESIDENT THIS MAJOR
EXPANDS. AND GUIDES THE USER
VERIFIABLE HEALTH CREDENTIALS
FOR PURPOSES OF VERIFYING COLD
WITH TEST RESULTS. A FULL
RECOVERY FROM COLBERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WILL REQUIRE ALL
AVAILABLE TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL
DISPOSAL AND USING OUR
CRYPTOGRAPHIC CRYPTOGRAPHY AND
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY
VERIFIABLE HEALTH CREDENTIALS
ARE SUCH A TOOL TO PROTECT
PRIVACY OF THE INDIVIDUALS- THE
MEASURE ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
REQUEST THEIR COVERT NINETEEN
RESULTS AND VERIFIABLE
CREDENTIALS. I ASK YOU A VOTE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. SINGLE MICROPHONE UP
SITTING SENATOR SENATOR DOLLY.
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE GREAT
BILL ANYTIME WE CAN KEEP
PRIVACY THIS FALLS RIGHT IN
LINE WITH HIM I THINKTHAT
THERE'S BEEN- YOU KNOW WHAT
COVERED BEING WHERE WE'RE AT
WITH IT AND A LOT OF THE HIP
OF. LAWS HAVE BEEN. MAYBE
SOMEWHAT NOT ADHERE TO AS MUCH.
AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TESTING THERE'S DNA THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT TIME.
OUR PERSONAL INFORMATION AND SO
I AM. HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S ON THE RIGHT
TRACK I THINK WE SHOULD FOCUS
ON THIS SOMEWHAT MORE IN THE
FUTURE I'VE ONLY HAD THIS
PANDEMIC SITUATIONS WHERE WE
HAVE A LOT OF. PERSONAL
INFORMATION. BEING OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC AND SO I LIKE THIS BILL
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
THE SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NON ICE
THIRTY NINE OH ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES GOING BACK TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY SENATOR ALLEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO
PESTICIDES SENATOR ALAN. THIS
BILL AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
LIMITING USE OF ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES WILL WHILE THE
CURRENT PESTICIDE REGULATION
CONDUCTS A REEVALUATION OF
THESE PRODUCTS. A SECOND
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES ARE USED AS A
MEANS TO MANAGE RODENT
POPULATIONS BUT THESE POISONS
UNFORTUNATELY CAN LAST SEVERAL
DAYS IN THE BODIES OF ANIMALS
AND SOMETIMES- MONTHS IN THE
BODIES OF A ROAD IN. WHICH IN
TURN THEM INTO EASY PREY FOR
APEX PREDATORS SUCH AS MOUNTAIN
LIONS AND OTHERS WHO THEN
SUFFER AS WELL JUST LAST WEEK
WE HEARD ABOUT THE DEATH OF P.
SEVENTY SIX THE SIX COLLARED
MOUNTAIN LINE TO DIE FROM ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDES IN THE
THIRD O DIE IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. RESEARCHERS AT UCLA AND
THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE HAVE
DOCUMENTED THE PRESENCE OF THIS
FOR DENNIS CITING TWENTY SIX OF
TWENTY SEVEN LOCAL MOUNTAIN
LIONS HAVE BEEN TESTED IN OUR
AREA SO. LET ME JUST MENTION
THAT. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
IT'S GOING TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR. OUR WILDLIFE I
WILL SAY THAT OUR OUR AUTHOR
HAS WORKED VERY HARD. HE TOOK
SOME LATE AMEND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE AT FIVE O'CLOCK ON
THE LAST DAY TALKING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE HE TOOK HIS LATE AMENDS
THAT. WERE ALL THE FOLKS FROM
AG ALL THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY- DROPPED THEIR
OPPOSITION- SO I WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING. NO
MICROPHONES ON THE FLOOR
SENATOR. I'M SORRY SENATOR
GLAZERS AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR GLAZERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I CERTAINLY
NONE OF US WOULD ARE HAPPY
ABOUT. OUR WILDLIFE SIDE.
EATING SOME ANIMAL THAT HAS-
POISON IN THEIR BODY THAT
AFFECTS THEM I MEAN WHO WANTS
THAT RIGHT. BUT WE HAVE A
PROCESS IN THE STATE THAT DEALS
WITH PESTICIDES AND OTHER
CHEMICALS IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT THE CHOICES WE MAKE.
ARE NOT POLITICAL CHOICES THERE
BASED ON SCIENCE. HOW OFTEN
HAVE YOU. HURT OR YOU YOURSELF
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
NATIONAL DEBATE THAT SCIENCE
MATTERS. SCIENCE MATTERS AND SO
HERE WE HAVE A SITUATION WE GET
THESE ONCE EVERY YEAR TO COME
BEFORE THE SENATE. WHERE
SOMEONE SAYS THIS IS BAD AND WE
NEED TO CIRCUMVENT THE PROCESS
THAT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED IN LAW
FOR HAVING A THOROUGH REVIEW
BASED ON SCIENCE. AND SO MY
OBJECTION TO THE BILL TODAY IS
NOT BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. RAT POISON BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY AM. BUT IT'S ABOUT
HONORING A PROCESS THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A LAW SO THAT THE
JUDGMENT WE MAKE IS BASED ON
SCIENCE NOT BASED ON POLITICS
AND THAT'S THE SHORTCOMING OF
THE BILL BEFORE YOU. AND WHILE
BE VOTING NOW. SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WILL SPEAK ON THIS BILL ADDS
OBVIOUSLY AS SOMEBODY WHO IS
AGRICULTURAL HAZARD PESTICIDE
OUTTURN APPLICATORS PERMIT HERE
MY WALLET AND ALSO SMEBODY WHO
CARES ABOUT WILDLIFE DEARLY AND
I WANTED TO SHARE THAT FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND I WE DON'T SEE EYE
TO EYE ON A LOT OF. ISSUES WHEN
IT COMES TO WILDLIFE AND BUT IF
YOU CAN GET THE FARM BUREAU AND
THOSE FOLKS TO GO NEUTRAL I
GOTTA GIVE IT TO ME MOST OF
TOOK A HECK OF A LOT OF
MINUTES. BUT THE POINT IS MORE
SO IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO USE THESE ANTI
COAGULANTS IN THERE THE REASON
I'M IN THE WRONG WAY. AND SO I
FEEL I AGREE WITH MY FRIEND
FROM THE BAY AREA THAT. YOU CAN
HAVE YOU CAN HAVE ALL THE LAWS
YOU WANT BUT IF PEOPLE ARE
USING- PRESCRIBING THEM IN THE
RIGHT WAY. FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE
ALL KINDS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. ILLEGAL POT GROWS
USING ROW DIDN'T RODENTICIDES.
TO KILL PREDATORS THAT ARE
EATING THEIR PLANTS IT'S
GETTING A WATER STREET JUST
GETTING OUR FISH. IS KILLING
THE MOUNTAIN LION THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PROTECT. AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE LOSING. THE MILLIONS
OF ACRES OF HABITAT FOR THESE
ANIMALS AS WELL SO I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO DO THE RIGHT THING
WHEN YOU HAVE GOOD SIZE WE NEED
TO GO AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
BREAKING THE LAW AND WHO ARE
BUYING THESE THINGS ILLEGAL.
AND USING THEM IN THE WRONG
FASHION I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY
THAT 99% OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
REGULATED IN THIS BUSINESS ARE
DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY I
INCLUDING MYSELF I'M ONE OF
THOSE THAT. YOU THINK YOU HAVE
P. P. EASE INTO YOU SEE ME USE
CHEMICALS I OF THE SPRAY
NOZZLES I HAVE A FULL SUIT ON
AND GLOVES IT'S SERIOUS
BUSINESS AND WE WANT TO PUT IT
ON THE RIGHT WAY WE WANTED TO
NOT BE OVERPRESCRIBED. SO I
WOULD JUST SHARE THAT I THINK
THAT WE TAKE LEGISLATION WE
MAKE LAWS BASED OFF OF THE
MOTIONS THAT NOBODY WANTS
AMOUNT LINE TO DIE BECAUSE OF
AN ANTICOAGULANT THAT IT EIGHT
FROM SOMEBODY WHO POISONED
SOMETHING. SO MY GOAL HERE IS
TO DO GOOD SCIENCE BUT ALSO GO
AFTER BAD ACTORS BECAUSE YOU
CAN REGULATE THE REGULATED
BUSINESS TO DEATH IT WON'T
CHANGE THE OUTCOME LET'S CHANGE
THE OUTCOME BY GOING AFTER THE
BAD ACTORS. THAT ARE REALLY
CAUSING THE PROBLEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
OTHER MICROPHONES UP. I'M SORRY
SAID THE CENTER STORE IN.
DEVELOPERS ARE BE BRIEF I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SCIENCE HERE- UCLA
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE SHOWED
THAT IN A RECENT STUDY SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN THE SECOND
GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES WERE REMOVED FROM
THE SENATE THE SHELVES. THAT
THE USE IS ACTUALLY GOING UP SO
WE HAVE ALREADY MADE EFFORTS TO
TAKE THOSE THOSE PRODUCTS OFF
THE SHELVES AND YET THE PEST
CONTROL APPLICATORS KEEP USING
IT WHY BECAUSE IT'S CHEAP AND
IT'S EASY AND IT'S EASIER IN
SOME WAYS THAN JUST CLEANING UP
YOUR GARBAGE WE'RE DOING THE
MAINTENANCE YOU NEED. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE RATS.
PEOPLE WANT DRUGS THINGS LIKE
TYSON OR OR OTHER EXCUSES WHY
THIS MAY BE A PROBLEM WE'LL
TELL YOU WE CAN COME UP WITH A
LOT OF EXCUSES OVER THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WHILE WE EXISTING
THEM OUTLINES A CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S JUST GOING TO BE A FACT.
IT'S ONLY A FEW LEFT. THERE IS
A PROCESS RIGHT NOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS RESTRICTED BY DPR
FROM IMPOSING THEIR OWN
REGULATIONS THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY TODAY TO BREAK THAT
IMPASSE THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR OWN VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEE SENATOR ALAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I DO WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THOUSAND OAKS
ROOF FOR THAT ADDITION- YOU
KNOW IT DIDN'T WITH WITH GREAT
RESPECT TO MY FRIEND FROM
AMENDED THE ISSUE HERE IS- THAT
THERE IS A PROCESS HAPPENING
IN. THE IDEA IS THAT THAT- THAT
THIS WOULD LIMIT THE USE OF
THESE RODENTICIDES UNTIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF HAS SAID
REGULATION YOU KNOW CONDUCT
THIS RE EVALUATION- IT'S TRUE
THEY'RE DOING THIS BUT YOU KNOW
THERE'S REALLY NO END DATE
THERE'S NO TIME LINE IN SIGHT-
WE KNOW THE PROBLEM SEVERE WITH
THE SCIENTISTS AND CLEAR- THAT
THEY'RE HAVING YOU KNOW THESE
READINESS EITHER HAVING A
NEGATIVE. IMPACT ON OUR
WILDLIFE AND SO WE HAVE TO ACT
NOW- YOU KNOW IT I WITHOUT I
RESPECT YESTERDAY BUT- ALL
DEBATE HAVING SHE'S MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. ATKINS I
FELL FIVE BRADFORD. I CABRERA.
DODD DURAZO I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG. I TELL HI WITH SO.
HER TADO. QATADA NO JACKSON HI
I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE I MITCHELL
I MONEY I NIELSEN. NO HAN.
PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER. FIVE STERN I I'M BURKE.
BY CASKEY I WIENER HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. ARCHULETA. CABALLERO
I DODD I. HUESO. PAN ROTH.
RUBIO. AMBERG FIVE. LET'S GO TO
THE REMOTE MEMBERS. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR A BATES.
FACE BATES AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS
FORGES AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ABSTAINED. CHIANG HEY AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT HI HANG
ON DALLY. AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ABSTAINED. GROWTH. TO
MOVE ALONG. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY AIDS NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHT ABSTAINED.
BOROUGH. WELL AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT NOW. RURAL NO WILK.
WELL AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
NO WILK NOW LET'S GO BACK TO
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
REMOTE PARTICIPATION. GROVE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I HAD
TO GET THE DOOR FOR THE
SERGEANTS AND GROWTH AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND NO.
GROVE NOW RIGHT. FOLLOWED HAVE
CONCLUDED A PRICE TWENTY THREE
NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING RIGHT ALONG TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO.
SENATOR GLAZERS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
SENATOR GLAZERS. IF THANK YOU
OF MADAM PRESIDENT NUMBERS
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINETY
AUTHORIZES NURSE PRACTITIONERS
TO PROVIDE CARE TO THE FULL
EXTENT OF THEIR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING AND IN SOME CASES
WITHOUT PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION.
THIS BILL SPECIFIES EXACTLY
WHAT SERVICES A NURSE
PRACTITIONER CAN PROVIDE.
SERVICES WITH WHICH THESE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING. CALIFORNIANS FOR A
VERY VERY LONG TIME. A FEW
NURSE PRACTITIONERS SERVE
DIAGNOSING PATIENTS. INITIATING
THERAPIES TO KEEP PATIENTS
HEALTHY AND MAKING INDEPENDENT
DECISIONS ABOUT TREATING HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU SUPPORTS MULTIPLE STUDIES
EVALUATING THE ROLE OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AS A PART OF THE
CARE TEAM TO HELP FILL GAPS IN
PRIMARY CARE. AND IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE RECENT WORK
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION AND
NUMEROUS OTHER REPORTS. THIS
BILL MAXIMIZES THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER SKILLS WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE. AND IT
PROVIDES NURSE PRACTITIONERS
FULL PRACTICE AUTHORITY AFTER A
TRANSITION PERIOD OF
COLLABORATION. MEMBERS AT THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AND ITS MEMBERS
SPENT. MANY MANY HOURS DIGGING
INTO THIS ISSUE IN A VERY DEEP
WAY AND PROBABLY MORE SO THAN I
HAVE EXPERIENCED IN MY FIVE
YEARS HERE. WE ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS LISTEN TO ALL
SIDES CERTAINLY THE LISTENING
CAREFULLY TO THOSE IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY. TO
UNDERSTAND AS DEEPLY AS ONE
COULD THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAD ABOUT THE BILL. AND WHETHER
THERE ARE WAYS TO IMPROVE IT.
AND MAKE IT BETTER. YEAH I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY STILL HAS CONCERNS.
AND DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
CHANGES TO THIS BILL HAVE GONE
AS FAR AS THEY NEED TO. HOWEVER
THIS BILL HAS MULTIPLE.
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE. TO MEET
OUR SHARED GOALS. OUR PATIENTS
SAFETY AND ACCESS TO QUALITY
AFFORDABLE CARE. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BILL ITSELF TO SEE THAT
THERE ARE MANY AMENDMENTS. THAT
HAPPENED THROUGHOUT THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. MORE THAN
A DOZEN AMENDMENTS. WERE TAKEN
HERE IN THE SENATE LET ME
REVIEW JUST A COUPLE OF THOSE.
THE STUDENT THAT ARE PRESIDENT.
HAVING TROUBLE HEARING. I'D
LIKE TO REVIEW A COUPLE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS. THE BILL
ENSURES QUALITY AND IN TRAINING
OF NURSE PRACTITIONERS. ARE
REQUIRING ACCREDITATION FOR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS. THE
AMENDMENTS WE TOOK ENSURE THE
CONFIDENCE OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND THE
INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL EXAMINATION
SERVICES FINDS IT THERE ANY
GAPS IN EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
THOSE GAPS TO BE FILLED BY
REQUIRING A SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM
EFORE THE NURSE PRACTITIONER
CAN PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY.
ANOTHER AMENDMENT REQUIRES
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO NOTIFY
PATIENTS THAT THEY ARE
SPECIALIZED NURSES NOT
POSITIONS. AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION WHERE THEY CAN FILE
COMPLAINTS. AND FAMILY MEMBERS
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENT
TO THIS BILL PROVIDED CLEAR
GUIDELINES ABOUT WHEN AND WHERE
REFERRALS TO PHYSICIANS ARE
REQUIRED. TO ENSURE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE ONLY
PRACTICING WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
OUR EDUCATION AND TRAINING AND
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE. WHICH
CORRESPONDS DIRECTLY TO THAT
EDUCATION TRAINING. AND FINALLY
THE BILL WAS AMENDED TO ENSURE
THAT ANY DISCIPLINARY ISSUES.
GO TO THE NEWLY CREATED
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH WILL
HAVE A TESTIFIED NUMBER OF
POSITIONS ON IT. MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS A GOOD BILL AND IT'S
DESERVING OF YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
I RECOMMEND THAT I VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS. I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF OUR- MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM AROUND- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I STILL HAVE TO
STAND IN OPPOSITION. TO THIS
BILL- I GUESS OUT FIRST JUST
SAY IS THAT- WELL HE DIDN'T
REFERENCE IT IN HIS REMARKS-
SENSIBLY THE REASON FOR DOING
THIS BILL WAS SUPPOSED TO- THIS
ACTUALLY. ADDRESS ACCESS ISSUES
IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES BUT I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT- NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE QUITE BUSY
RIGHT NOW AS WELL AS OUR
POSITIONS AND- THERE'S VERY
LITTLE EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT
WOULD DRESS THOSE ACCESS ISSUES.
I DO APPRECIATE- THE-
GUARDRAILS THAT- THAT- AGAIN MY
GOOD FRIEND RENDON PLACED ON
THE BILL IN THE VARIOUS
AMENDMENTS BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DROP PERHAPS A
LITTLE BIT OF A COMPARISON
BETWEEN EVEN WITH THESE
GUARDRAILS. DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A INDEPENDENT PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN THE END OF HIM
PRACTICING NURSE PRACTITIONER
AND THE KIND OF GUARDRAILS
ACTUALLY WE PLACE ON POSITIONS
THEMSELVES. SO I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT. ABOUT LOW OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO THAT IN ORDER
FOR A PHYSICIAN IN FAMILY
PRACTICE THEY JUST HAD TO GO TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL. AND THEN THE
PUBLIC SAID WELL THAT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH. SO ACTUALLY IN
FACT- WE IS PHYSICIANS. HAVE TO
COMPLETE FOUR YEARS OF POST
GRADUATE EDUCATION WHICH IS
MUCH LONGER THAN. THE
UNFORTUNATELY THEN UNDER
STRUCTURE CURRENTLY EVEN HAS TO
GO THROUGH. HOWEVER THAT IN
ITSELF IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO
ALLOW A PHYSICIAN TO HAVE
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE. AND SAID
IT BY LAW HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU D. TO COMPLETE
A RESIDENCY PROGRAM. THREE
YEARS. YOU CANNOT IN THE FAMILY
PRACTICE IS THE PHYSICIAN UNTIL
YOU'VE COMPLETED THREE YEARS OF
RESIDENCY. SO AGAIN YOU'D HAVE
TO ACTUALLY DO A LOT MORE
CLINICAL TIME BEFORE YOU CAN
GET TO BE SURE TO THAT POSITION.
EVEN AFTER YOU FINISH THAT
THREE YEARS OF CLINICAL ALFA OF
MOUNTING MEDICAL FOR YEARS
MEDICAL SCHOOL THREE YEARS OF
RESIDENCY. AFTER YOU COMPLETE
THAT. USE THAN AND OR TO BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE- HAVE TO GET
BOARD CERTIFIED. IN THAT BOARD
CERTIFICATION IN FACT IS NOT
FOREVER. IN FACT THAT POINT OUT
THAT IN ORDER FOR ME TO
CONTINUE TO PRACTICES PHYSICIAN.
EVERY TEN YEARS I HAVE TO
RECERTIFY AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THE NURSE
PRACTITIONER HAS TO READ BE
REEVALUATED. IN THE SAME WAY.
AND I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION FACT I
ASKED ABOUT IT TO COMMITTEE AND
THE AND THE AUTHOR DID NOT GIVE
A STRAIGHT ANSWER. SO THERE ARE
MANY MORE REQUIREMENTS BEING
PLACED ON A POSITION. NOR TO
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY THEN
THERE ARE ON THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS EVEN WITH THE
GUARDRAILS. FINALLY I DO WANT
TO SHARE PERHAPS A THIS THIS
THIS TRUE STORY. THE TRUE STORY
THAT- AS THAT- WHEN I WAS IN
THE CLINIC AND UNFORTUNATELY-
WE HAD WHAT WE HAD PATIENTS AND
WE HAD A YOU KNOW A NURSE
PRACTITIONER THERE WONDERFUL
NURSE PRACTITIONER- GOOD GOOD
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE.
EXPERIENCED OVER A DECADE OF
CLINICAL PRACTICE- AS A NURSE
PRACTITIONER. AND SHE SAW A
PATIENT WHO CAME IN WHO I CAME
IN FOR PNEUMONIA AND
APPROPRIATELY TREATED DIAGNOSED
AND TREATED THE PNEUMONIA. AND
THEN THE PATIENT HAD TO COME
BACK A COUPLE TIMES FOR FOLLOW
UP WITH THE PNEUMONIA. AND SO
SHE NOW ONLY SAW THE NIZHAL SHE
SAW THE PERSON THE FOLLOW UP
THEN FINALLY THIS SEPARATION IS
ALSO SEEN FOLLOW UP BY A
RESIDENT PHYSICIAN. PRESENT
POSITION BY THE WAY IS NOW OUT
INDEPENDENTLY PRACTICE HAS. TO
BE SUPERVISED. AND THAT.
RESERVES'S NOTICED. A
NEUROLOGICAL SIGN IN THE
PATIENT. THAT WELL WAS NOTED BY
THE NURSE PRACTITIONER SHE NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT WAS
ACTUALLY A SIGN. OF A TUMOR. IN
THAT PATIENT. OF COURSE I IS
THE SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN. WHO
HAD TO GO AND- SUPERVISE THAT
RESIDENT OF COURSE CONFIRMS
THAT THAT WAS THE CASE. NOW
PROBABLY EVENTUALLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN FOUND OUT BECAUSE THAT
NURSE PRACTITIONER AT THE TIME
BECAUSE OUR CURRENT LAWS
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE SUPERVISED.
SO THE SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN IN
THE END IN REVIEWING THAT CASE
I WOULD HAVE NOTED IT. AND THEN
FILE THE WAY TO GET IT BUT I
THINK THAT IS THE CHALLENGE
RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW IT'S A
FAIRLY RARE BRAIN TUMOR SO IT'S
NOT SOMETHING WHERE HE DID A
SMALL STUDY PICK IT UP THAT
SOMEONE MISSED THAT DIAGNOSIS.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. YOU KNOW THOSE
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
WHO DEMANDED THAT PHYSICIANS BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN THE MANY
WAYS THAT YOU KNOW BEFORE WE
CAN INDEPENDENTLY PRACTICES
POSITIONS. AND SO I DO THINK
THAT UNFORTUNATELY- BECAUSE OF
PATIENTS I DO- AND CONCERNS
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL
STILL DESPITE ALL YOUR EIGHT IF
YOU SEE THE HARD WORK- IS NOT.
DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH AND WE
JUST EVEN COMPARED THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO. IN
TERMS OF INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
AND WHAT THAT BASICALLY HAVE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK THANK
YOU SENATOR MOVING TO OUR
COLLEAGUES REMOTELY WE'VE GOT
THOSE SENATOR GROW GORGEOUS
MORLOCKAND DOLLY WE'LL START
WITH SENATOR GROWTH. ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO SENATOR
BORCHERS. SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU. I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CHAT WITH THE AUTHOR I
CHATTED WITH THE POSITION AND-
WITH THE NURSE PRACTITIONER.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE RARE.
BILLS WHERE YOU TRULY DO SEE
BOTH SIDES OF THIS ARGUMENT AND
I AM ABSOLUTE RESPECT FOR DR
PAN AND DOCTOR WOULD IT AND I
CAN ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE. SO
HERE'S- MY ASSESSMENT IS THAT
IN THE VALLEY WE HAVE A MASSIVE
SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS RIGHT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THIS IS A
PROBLEM SO WE'RE HAVING
EXPANDED AUTHORITY FOR NURSE%
PRACTITIONERS COULD BE A GOOD
THING IT WOULD NCREASE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE FOR
UNDERPERFORMING COMMUNITIES ARE.
MINORITY POPULATED COMMUNITIES
AND SO THAT IN AND OF ITSELF.
HE IS APPEALING ON THE FLIP
SIDE ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD IS THAT IF YOU
EXPERIENCE. THE ROLE OF NURSE
PRACTITIONERS YOU WILL FURTHER
ALIENATE. THE ATTRACTIVENESS OF
THE AREA TO PHYSICIANS TO
DOCTORS. OTHERS IN THAT'S AN
INTERESTING IDEA SO YOU'RE
ATTRACTING MORE FOLKS TO HELP.
OUR COMMUNITY BUT ULTIMATELY
YOU'RE TAKING AWAY SOME OF THE
TALENT THAT IS NEEDED AS AS
WELL. AND SO I'M LIKE WELL WHAT
EXACTLY DOES A POSITION TO WIN
THEIR THE ATTENDING PHYSICIAN
ENTERS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING- NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. I KIND OF HAVE
THIS IDEA IN MY HEAD THAT IT'S
SOMEBODY IN THE CORNER OR DOWN
THE HOLE IN THE CLINIC OR THE
HOSPITAL ORWHATEVER THE
SITUATION MAY BE WHERE. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY CONSULTING WITH ONE
ANOTHER REGULARLY AND MAKING
CERTAIN THAT THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS RECOMMENDATIONS
AND IN ACTIONS ARE APPROPRIATE
IN THE CIRCUMSTANCES. ONLY TO
FIND OUT THAT THAT RARELY
ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN FACT- ONE
CONVERSATION AGAIN. THE DOCTOR
WAS OUT OF THE COUNTRY. AND
STILL SATISFIED THE NEED IN
THAT SITUATION OF TECHNICALLY
OVERSEEING THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS FACILITY.
SO I APPRECIATE SCOPE OF WORK
AND IT IS IMPORTANT I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH FOLKS IN THE WORK FORCE
THAT CAN SATISFY THE NEEDS OF
OUR OF OUR COMMUNITY. THIS IS
REALLY A FIFTY FIFTY IN MY
OPINION. HEARING WHAT DOCTOR
PAN HAD SAID THAT. ALLOWING
FOLKS THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE RIGORS IN CERTIFICATIONS
AND LICENSURE OF BEING-
PHYSICIANS. HAS BENEFITS AND. I
THINK WHAT I'M I'D LIKE TO WITH
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE TO SAY BUT I
THINK THE ULTIMATE NEED IS
ALREADY SATISFIED IF PHYSICIANS
DON'T HAVE TO BE PRESENT. AND
THEY CAN STILL SATISFY WHATEVER
IS NECESSARY. IS THIS BILL
TRULY NECESSARY. SO I'M M. I'D
LIKE TO HEAR WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE TO SAY BUT THIS IS IT'S A
FASCINATING SUBJECT AND- I'D
LIKE A LITTLE BIT MORE THANK
YOU SENATOR SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SAID IF
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN. OF AB
EIGHT NINETY I'M READING
SURVEYS OF MEDICAL DOCTORS WHO
ARE PLANNING TO RETIRED SOONER
THAN ANTICIPATED. THIS CALL MAY
NINETEEN LOCKDOWN HAS HAD
NUMEROUS NEGATIVE
REVERBERATIONS. I'VE ALSO
OBSERVED HOW NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO BE A HUGE
ASSIST TO GENERAL PRACTITIONERS
SO MUCH CAN BE ADDRESSED FOR
NUMEROUS COMMON AILMENTS.
CONSEQUENTLY THIS PROVIDES A
SOLUTION TO A DECLINING
WORKFORCE WHILE ASSISTING
RESIDENTS WITH MEDICAL ADVICE
BUT BASIC NEEDS AS RELIEF TO A
GROWING NEED. I APPRECIATED IN
ANY OF THE EMAILS  RECEIVE I
KNOW WHATEVER INDIA'S AND I
KNOW WHAT INDIAN PS THANK YOU
BUT THIS IS NOT AN INTRUSION ON
A HOLLOW PROFESSION IT IS A
RELIEF IT IT IS LIKE THE
CALVARY COMING UP OVER. THE
HILL TO PROVIDE REINFORCEMENTS
TO A TIRED ARMY OF WONDERFUL.
AND OVERWORKED DOCTORS. I'M NOT
SURE HOWEVER IF COME FROM WITH
THE BORDER NURSING SYMBOL MEANT
AS I'M UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT
THEIR TRACK RECORD BUT I'LL
LEAVE THAT FOR ANOTHER TIME BUT
I'M SURE PATIENTS WILL KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MD AN MP I
HEARD TONIGHT. THANK YOU
MEDICAL SENATOR GROW. SENATOR
GROVE SORRY. SORRY THANK YOU M.
THIS BILL IS A PRETTY DIFFICULT
BILL BECAUSE SAM. I DO THINK
THAT- ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEDICAL
PROCESS MIGHT HELP US- GET
ACCESS TO RURAL HEALTH CARE.
LIKE WHERE WE HAVE IN THE
VALLEY WE NEED ACCESS TO REAL
HEALTH CARE. I ALSO AM
CONCERNED ABOUT QUALIFICATION
PIECES AND MAKING SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE QUALIFIED TO DO
THE WORK. I DID HEAR FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE BUT I DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND
THEN SOME QUESTIONS AND MAYBE
THE AUTHOR COULD ANSWER MENTOR.
IN THE CLOSE. AND YOU KNOW I
GUESS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A-
CHANCE ON A BILL LIKE THIS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT- IT'S
GOING TO WORK. AND THAT WE
DON'T SET UP OUR RULE
UNDERSERVED DISTRICTS- FOR
LOWER LEVELS OF CARE. THERE IS
A PROPOSITION I BELIEVE IT'S
PROP FIFTY SIX. BIT GIVE US
MANY TO INCENTIVIZE- DOCTORS
LIKE REAL DOCTORS MEDICAL
PROVIDERS TO COME TO THE REALLY
REASON SERVE ENTER SEARCH
COMMUNITIES. I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS LIKE I SAID. I KNOW THAT
WITH THE IMPACTS OF CODED A WE
DO HAVE A LOT OF DOCTORS THAT
ARE YOU KNOW TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
AND HELP. COULD BE BENEFICIAL.
BUT I ALSO AND LIKE I SAID VERY
CONCENED ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
CARE AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT-
THE EDUCATION EXPERIENCE IN THE
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCES BEHIND
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT- PROVIDING
THAT CARE. IN THE ROLE
COMMUNITY WOULD THINK THAT THIS
BILL MIGHT PROVIDE A LOT OF
NURSE PRACTITIONERS TO. COME TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR IN RURAL
AREAS SUFFER MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DEEPER REPRESENTS. BUT IS THAT
THE SAME AS HAVING A DOG.
THAT'S GONE THROUGH TRAIN. AND
GONE THROUGH A RESIDENCY AND
GONE THROUGH YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL CLASSES THAT
ADDITIONAL- LIKE EXPERIENCE
TRAINING I GUESS YOU'D SAY LIKE
EXPERIENCE ON THE JOB- THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION RISK
PRACTITIONERS HAVE A POLICY.
THAT REJECTS ANY PROVISION
WHICH MAY INCENTIVIZE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE AND
RURAL. UNDERSERVED AREAS- SO I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
TO THINK THEY'RE THAT NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE GOING TO WANT
TO COME TO THIS. TO THE RURAL
AREAS THAT I REPRESENT. AND I
WAS WONDERING WHY THAT WASN'T
ALLOWED TO BE IN THAT BILL. AND
THEN I'M LOOKING AT THE MAPS
WITHOUT SUPERVISION FROM THE
FOR NURSE PRACTITIONERS. AS
THEY REALLY DON'T GO TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS- WHEN YOU
REMOVE THE SUPERVISION SO WHY
THERE TEN CENTER NURSE
PRACTITIONER. TO AT LEAST IN
RURAL AREAS LIKE WE DO FOR
PHYSICIANS- THREE PROP FIFTY
SIX SO I KNOW THAT- PHYSICIANS
ARE DO THEIR TRAINING- IN RURAL
AREAS AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES- SO
I WAS JUST CURIOUS WHY. AND WE
DIDN'T HOW LOUD THAT IN THIS
BILL AND THEN IF IT'S SUPPOSED
TO CREATE INCREASED ACCESS TO
CARE ESPECIALLY FOR A MEDICAL
POPULATION- WHY ISN'T THERE AN
INK WHY ISN'T THERE ANY
INCREASED AND UTILIZATION COSTS
FOR THE MEDICAL PROGRAM- ON ANY
OF THE ANALYSIS THAT I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO READ. SO WITH. AGAIN I
THINK THAT OUR MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AND OUR DOCTORS AS IT
WOULD GIVE THEM AN AVENUE OF
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CARE. AND THEN
PROVIDE A QUALITY OF CARE
SERVICES TO OUR CONSTITUENTS I
HAVE A GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THE-
I'M GONNA BE SELFISH I HAD A
GREAT CONCERN ABOUT JUST THE
RURAL AREAS YOU KNOW DOCTORS
GOING TO LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
AND ALL THOSE PEOPLE PLACES
NEWPORT BEACH BUT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU ASK HIM TO COME TO
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA ARE THEY
GOING TO COME. IN SO I HAD THE
SAME CONCERN WITH OR TO HATCH
FEAR RAGE CRESTOR AND MANY OF
THOSE PLACES SO I THE SAME
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL ON THE
NURSE PRACTITIONERS I WOULD
HAVE LIKE SOME TYPE OF
INSURANCE IS. THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO PROVIDE QUALITY CARE
IN IN OUR AREAS IN THE
UNDERSERVED AREAS THAT I
REPRESENT. SO I'M A LITTLE IN
DECIDED- AND DECIDED ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL MEDICAL HEAD
AND LISTEN TO THE COMMENTS AND
THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. A PER SHARE- AM I
CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO'S
COMMENTS HIM BEING A PHYSICIAN
A DOCTOR THAT'S BEEN TRUE- THE
RIGORS OF BECOMING A DOCTOR. I
BUT I ALSO. THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL- RECIPROCITY ARTHUR THE
BILL WHO IS- TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT- ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC THERE'S THAT
THERE'S A GREATER ACCESS TO
CARE. AND SO. IT'S KIND OF A
HARD BILL TO DECIDE ON OR TELL
THEM TO WORK ON IT. AND I'D
LIKE TO HEAR WHAT MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE TO SAY AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. MY
THOUGHTS AND IF THE FATHER
COULD ADDRESS SOME OF MY
QUESTIONS. IN THE CLOSE ABOUT
WHY THAT WAS IT IN THE BILL IN
THE FIRST PLACE I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER. SENATOR WILL. YOU'RE A
MUTE. WHERE THAT. IT IS FIRST
US IN DOWN BY AND FORTH A COMES
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO DO IN THE
CORNER ANYWAY AM THINKING ABOUT
A PRESIDENT SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINETY I'VE
NEVER BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR EIGHT YEARS AND I'VE SERVED
ON THE BT COMMITTEE FOR ALL BUT
IT JUST A HANDFUL OF MONTHS.
AND M FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE ISSUES
IS ALWAYS PATIENT SAFETY
FOLLOWED BY PATIENT ACCESS YEAH
WHEN I FIRST GOT UP HERE IN
TWENTY TWELVE- HOLD ME SIXTEEN
OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
HAD THE PROPER DOCTOR. YOU
PATIENT REYES. SO I AM VOTED TO
FUND MEDICAL SCHOOLS I HAVE
VOTED TO FIND WAITING STUDENT
LOANS FOR DOCTORS AND GUESS
WHAT WE ARE STILL AT ONLY
SIXTEEN HAVING THE PROPER
DOCTOR TO PATIENT RATIO ADD TO
THAT FACT- WE IMPLEMENTED CHAD
COVERED CALIFORNIA TWENTY
THIRTEEN. IT WAS A JOHN BILL
DURING AS SET. WHERE WE
EXPANDED THE L. ELIGIBILITY FOR
NET CAL. IF I RECALL CORRECTLY
THE REPUBLICAN ANNOUNCES THAT
SAID WE'RE GONNA END UP. ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE THE
DEMOCRATIC ANALYSIS SAID A ONE
MILLION IT IS THE FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION SO ALMOST FOURTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE NOW JUST ON THAT
ACCOUNT. WE HAVE TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY. THIS BILL IS
DEFINITELY NOT PERFECT. AT ALL
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
SUPPORTED IT IS BECAUSE
IMPLEMENTED IT WILL DONATE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO WE HAVE
ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE IF WE
IF WE WANT TO- BUT YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS- NURSE PRACTITIONERS
WORK VERY INDEPENDENTLY ALREADY
I TALKED TO A NUMBER OF DOCTORS
FROM MY DISTRICT AND THEY ALL
DIDN'T IT THAT WOULD BE BEEN
THERE LONG ENOUGH. AND THERE'S
A TRUST LEVEL THE DATE THEY
PRETTY MUCH HAVE FREE REIN
THERE SIX YEARS OF TRAINING IN
THIS BILL. THERE'S TWENTY TWO
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THAT
ALLOW LISTENERS PRACTITIONERS
AND FRANKLY WE'RE GOING TO BE
THE MOST CONSERVATIVE. IN IN IN
OUR APPROACH OTHERS AMENDMENT-
THAT I ASKED FOR. IN THIS BILL
WILL COME UP A COUPLE DAY AGO
THEY HAD NOT BE SO. I KNOW
THAT'S A GREAT WAY MY FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I DON'T LIKE THE
NURSING BOARD DOING IT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK. THEY
NEED TO BE FIXED BUT THE OTHER
ONE IS- OUR- GOOD FRIEND FROM
NAPA HAS BUILT HAVING TO DO
WITH MIDWIVES. HE HAS AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN THEIR-
BATTLE IN THAT COMMITTEE
GUARANTEES FORTY PERCENT. OF
THE THAT THE MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ARE DOCTORS-
MYSELF AND THE SENATOR FOR THE-
CHINO HILLS I DON'T KNOW. AYE
DIAMOND BAR- WE ASK FOR THAT
AND THEN AND AN AUTHOR
GRACIOUSLY EXTENDED THAT. SO WE
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
PEOPLE. EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
DONE AT THIS POINT IN HIS IS
JUST BEEN IN VAIN. AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE GOING WITH
THIS BILL TO BE ABLE TO. A
PATIENT SAFETY WITH ACCESS AND
TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS TEACHERS
PARTICULARLY IN THE RURAL AREAS
LIKE LIKE I HAVE SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORTERS STILL. ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE ELSE TO FOLLOW P.
REGULATE NOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE. FOR THOSE THINGS THEY DO
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT'S COMPLETE BUT
IT'S COMPLETE ENOUGH TO GET US
DOWN THE ROAD. TO TAKING CARE
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU
CENTER WELCOME SENATOR. DOLLY
THANK YOU MADAM MEMBERS I NOT
RETURN TO EVERY THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR JUST SPOKE ABOUT I
AGREE WITH ALL THOSE THINGS I
WANT TO SHARE SOMEBODY FROM A
RULE DISTRICT. WHO HAS WORKED
WITH THE DOCTOR WOULD QUITE
FRANKLY FOR SINCE MY TIME. IN
COMING YEAR. ON WAYS TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET. ACCESS
TO CARE IN RURAL AREAS WE DONE.
FRONTIER LEGISLATION FOR
HOSPITALS TO BE ABLE TO HIRE
DOCTORS- WE WORK AND I WAS ON
BEING P. WHEN THIS BILL. CAME
TO THE ASSEMBLY I VOTED FOR
THIS BILL ALREADY I THINK IT'S
ONLY GOTTEN BETTER. SINCE THE
THERE HAS BEEN AMENDMENTS TO
IT. AS YOU GUYS RECALL LAST
YEAR- I HAD MY COUSIN DR DALLI.
WHO WOULD NOT RULE DR AMERICA
HE'S HE SEVENTY ONE YEARS OLD
HE STILL PRACTICING IN OUR
LITTLE COMMUNITY UP THERE. IN A
RULE HEALTH CLINIC AND YES THE
PRIVILEGES AT THE LOCAL
HOSPITAL ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILES AWAY. WE CANNOT ATTRACT
PEOPLE LIKE DR DOLLY ANYMORE
THEY'RE THEY'RE REALLY HARD TO
GET OUT TO OUR RULE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST. QUITE
FRANKLY YOU NEED TO BE A
GENERAL PRACTITIONER NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO THERE'S MOST PEOPLE
GOING TO SPECIALTIES AND
THEY'RE JUST A LOT OF. ANOTHER
WORK FOR THEM- TO PICK UP
THERE'S- LOANS AND ALSO YOU
KNOW THE MICRO AND ALL THE
THINGS WE DEAL WITH SO. THIS
BILL I THINK IS IN THE ROAD IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
IT IS DEFINITELY NOT PERFECT.
BUT IT'S A HECK OF A LOT BETTER
THAN WHERE WE WERE AND I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE THINGS THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL- SENATOR
WILL RAPPORT I WON'T. TALK
ABOUT THIS AGAIN I STRONGLY
URGE A VOTE THIS WILL HELP.
RULE PEOPLE GET ACCESS THANK
YOU SENATOR DOES NOT PERFECT
WILL COME BACK AND FIX THOSE
THINGS ARE PERFECT BUT FOR NOW
I THINK THIS IS A STEP IN RIGHT
DIRECTION THANK YOU SIR AND I
VOTE ON THIS WILL HELP THANK
YOU CENTER WITH CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES. AT YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I'VE GOT SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL AND- THE- WE ARE
IMPORTANT FOR REGISTERED NURSES
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP A COUPLE
TIMES BY CONCERNS FROM SOME OF
THE OTHER MEMBERS- IF IT WOULD
BE OKAY- MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
THAT TOO RELATED QUESTIONS IF I
COULD POSE THOSE. TO THE AUTHOR
PLEASE. TWO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SENATOR GLAZERS WILL
TAKE THE QUESTIONS PERHAPS
ANSWER THEM IN AS CLOSE. OKAY
YEAH THAT'S FINE HOWEVER I
THINK THEY'RE IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
HIM TO BRING HIM UP SOONER THAN
THAT BUT WHAT BUT I'M FINE WITH
THAT TOO- SORT. TO RELATED TO
RELATED QUESTIONS WHY AREN'T
THERE MORE GUIDELINES IN THE
BILL TO STRUCTURE HOW EACH
TRANSITION TO PRACTICE SHOULD
FUNCTION AND THT'S AND THAT'S
THE MAIN PURPOSE OF THE BILL
AND THEN THE SECOND ONE REGARD
THE B. R. IN AS IT STANDS. THE
LANGUAGE LEAVES IT TO THE B. R.
IN WHY ISN'T THE MEDICAL BOARD
INCLUDED SINCE THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT CURRENTLY GOVERN- THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE SO NUMBER
ONE GUIDELINES FOR THE
TRANSITION OF PRACTICE. NUMBER
TWO- WHY NOT INVOLVE THE
MEDICAL BOARD WITH THE
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR GLAZERS I SEE NO
OTHER MICROPHONE SETUP IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND IN YOUR
CLOTHES. VERY GOOD YOU MAY
CLOSE SENATOR GLAZERS. ALL
RIGHT MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
TO ALL THE TO STATE IN THIS
DEBATE TODAY. LET ME JUST A
COUPLE THINGS QUICKLY IN
CONCLUSION HERE NUMBER ONE A
NURSE PRACTITIONERS IS IT IS A
PERSON IS ALREADY REGISTERED
NURSE. AND THEY HAVE EARNED
POSTGRADUATE A NURSING DEGREE A
MASTER'S OR DOCTORATE. AND THEN
THEY'VE BEEN CERTIFIED BY NASA.
CERTIFYING BODY SO THAT'S
HIGHER AND HIGHER AND HIGHER
STANDARDS THAT YOU MUST MEET.
TO BE A NURSE PRACTITIONER. BOB
LIBYA SAY THAT. IN THE BILL IT
REQUIRES A MINIMUM OF THREE TO
SIX YEARS TO ELEVATE TO THE
LEVEL OF BEING A NURSE
PRACTITIONER INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE OF THREE TO SIX YEARS.
AND AS A SENATOR EARLIER
MENTIONED THIS BILL DOES NOT GO
INTO EFFECT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WHICH HELPS ANSWERS THE
QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR JONES
JUST A MOMENT AGO. THAT THE
GUIDELINES FOR TRANSITION A
PRACTICE IS A REQUIREMENT OF
THE OF THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING THE TAKE THIS PERIOD OF
TIME. TO EXAMINE THE TESTING
THAT'S DONE TO MAKE SURE THEY
MEET THE HIGHEST STANDARDS AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE DETAILS
ON TRANSITION TO PRACTICE. ARE
ESTABLISHED AND IN REGARD TO
THE CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE THE
REPORTING SHOULD BE WE'VE
CREATED A SPECIAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THAT'S MADE UP OF
35% POSITIONS VISES THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING SO WE
PROVIDED THAT INPUT THAT NOT
WOULD NOT NORMALLY BE THERE
IT'S THE SAME US- STRUCTURE WE
CREATED FOR THE MIDWIFE'S BILL
THAT WE APPROVED. EARLIER THIS
YEAR. ADD TO MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO
ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT. RURAL
AREAS. I AND WITH THERE'D BE A
LEVEL OF CARE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE AND I ON BOTH
ACCOUNTS. NUMBER ONE I AM TOLD
THERE ARE INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE- NURSE PRACTITIONERS
TO PRACTICE IN RURAL AREAS IS
NOT CHANGED BY THIS BILL
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE NEED TO
WORK ON. GOING FORWARD. AND
NUMBER TWO THIS ISSUE OF LOWER
LEVEL OF CARE. GOES CONTRARY TO
THE FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF
THIS BILL WHICH IS THAT WE'RE
ONLY ALLOWING. ANYBODY IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD TO PRACTICE TO
THE LEVEL OF EDUCATION AND
TRAINING THAT THEY HAVE.
THERE'S NOTHING. NOBODY WANTS
OF STANDARD HERE THEY HAVE TO
MEET THE HIGHER STANDARD WITH
THE PRACTICING IN AN URBAN
AREA. OR IN A RURAL AREA. AND
FINALLY MEMBERS. THERE'S
PRACTITIONERS CAN RACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY IN FOURTEEN
STATES IN AMERICA TODAY. I WHEN
WE LOOK AT AN ISSUE LIKE THIS
WITH THE BUSINESS PROFESSION.
COMMITTEE LOOKS AT IT IF YOU
LIKE THIS IT IS ALL ABOUT
PATIENT CARE. IT IS ALL ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL. BUT SHE'S A
DOCTOR WOULD IS WORKING VERY
HARD ON IT FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME. AND IT'S DESERVING OF
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COLLEAGUES COULD IF WE COULD
ALL GET TO OUR SEATS PLEASE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL HI
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I DODD FIVE
TORONTO HI GALGIANI. GLAZER HI
HI GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HELLO I
HUESO. HURTADO JACKSON. LEYVA
HI WIRE AYE MITCHELL I MONEY.
NIELSEN. PAN NO PORTANTINO. I
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN
I AM BURKE I WAKE HOUSEKI I
WIENER. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BRADFORD. GALGIANI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HURTADO.
JACKSON ALL RIGHT I. MONNING.
NIELSEN. RIGHT MOVING TO OUR
REMOTE MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO AB EIGHT NINETY
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS. BATES.
AB EIGHT NINETY SIX NOW FOR
JUST. FORGES AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
ABSTAINED. CHIANG THANK AB
EIGHT NINETY I. CHIANG MAI
DALLY AB EIGHT NINETY HI
VALLEY HIGH GROWTH. AND GROUP
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY ABSTAINED.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB EIGHT NINE
ZERO NO MELENDEZ NO MORLOCK. AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
ABSTAINED. WILK. AB EIGHT NINE
D. OF WILK AB EIGHT NINETY AYE
WILK HI TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN NOES THREE THE MEASURE
PASSES COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK BRIEFLY TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. I'M SORRY
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR FIRST AND THEN WE
WILL GO TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR SENATOR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS UP ARE
YOU ARE INDEED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CERVANTES AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. SENATOR
GONZALEZ THE FLOOR SHOPPERS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB SIX
THREE NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES THE
STATE IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING TO A
LOW CARBON ECONOMY INCLUDING
TRANSFORMING THE STATE'S GOODS
MOVEMENT SYSTEM WHAT CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE REMARKABLE PROGRESS ON
REDUCING HARMFUL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THE STATE HAS FAILED
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THESE
ACTIONS ON INCUMBENT WORKERS
AND THE BUSINESSES IN WHICH
THEY ARE EMPLOYED THE SITUATION
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING
AT THE PORTS OF LONG BEACH AND
LOS ANGELES SB SIX THREE NINE
ESTABLISHES THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS GUIDED BY AN INDUSTRY
PANEL TO CONFRONT THESE
CHALLENGES AND DEVELOP
PRACTICAL GROUNDED
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD WELL NOTHING CONSERVE
AS A PANACEA SB SIX THREE NINE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WILL
PROVIDE A MORE NEUTRAL PLATFORM
FROM WHICH TO DISCUSS THE ROLE
OF AUTOMATION GLOBAL
COMPETITION AND THE TRANSITION
OF PORT OPERATIONS TO LOW AND
ZERO EMISSIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY LOOK.
DEBATE DISCUSSION THIS ITEM
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP SENATOR GROW.
SENATOR GROWTH PLEASE. THANK
YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE ON MUTE. SO I
APOLOGIZE AS A MIND CANDACE
REYES AND HER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND I SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN IT DOWN WHILE THE MEMBER
WAS PRESENTING HER BILL I WILL
REMOVE IT AND THEN ADD IT BACK
pTHANK YOU SO MUCH SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP NO HANDS. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FELL. I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
THOUGHT. I TORONTO. FIVE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. I HERTZBERG I TELL I
WAS SO. I HER TADO. JACKSON HI
I LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I
MONEY. I NIELSEN. I CAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE. I
Y. CASKEY FIVE WIENER HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. HURTADO. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
NINE SENATOR BATES BATES. AS SB
SIX THIRTY NINE ALL RIGHT BATES
HI GORGEOUS. CENTREBOARD USE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO THEN TO
SENATOR CHIANG. CHIANG THANK
EIGHTY SIX THREE NINE HI TRYING
HI DALLY. AB SIX THREE NINE HI
SALLY FIVE. GROWTH GROVE AB SIX
THREE NINE I'D GROW BY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB SIX THREE
NINE FIVE MELENDEZ I MORE LOCK.
A. B. SIX THREE NINE BY WARLOCK
HI GIRL. AB SIX THREE NINE HI.
FORGERS AREN'T. CENTREBOARD
JEWS YOU HAVE TO GIVE US THE
BILL NUMBER PLEASE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO X. THREE NINE.
CENTREBOARD JUST SIX THREE NINE
WHAT'S YOUR VOTER. HI RIGHT
GOING TO SENATOR WILL THANK YOU.
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB. SIX THREE NINE
FIVE. YOU CAN THAT. ALRIGHT
FAIRLY WE NEED TO GO BACK TO
SENATOR MORALES. SENATOR
MORRELL. AB SIX THIRTY NINE
VOTING ON. IN NORTH CENTRAL HI
SENATOR WILK. WILK. GO BACK AND
GOING BACK TO SENATOR BOARD
JOSEPH WE COULD PLEASE. HOLD
FOR JUST FOR JUST. YES MA'AM OR
JUST EIGHTY SIX THREE NINE NINE
THEY'RE JUST FIVE AND SENATOR
WILK I BELIEVE IS OUR LAST
PHONE SENATOR WILK. WELL
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU AGAIN MADAM
PRESIDENT YES WILK AB SIX THREE
NINE NINE WILK HI THE NEW IS
WILL OUR EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOW GOING TO
GO TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. SB SIXTY EIGHT FILE
NUMBER FOUR SB ONE FORTY SIX
FILE NUMBER SIX SB TWO FOURTEEN
FILE NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR OH
SIX FILE NUMBER TEN S. B. H.
SIXTY NINE FILE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
SB NINE FORTY FILE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
FILE NUMBER TWENTY SIX SB WILL
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT FILE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN. SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX FILE NUMBER TWENTY NINE S.
B. TWELVE FORTY FOUR FILE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE FILE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE AND SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR FILE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
THAT WILL BE THE ORDER. SENATE
GIRL FOR WHAT PURPOSE PLEASE AT
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR I'D LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT TIME THAT'S BEEN
GONE OVER WITH STAFF AND IT'S
BEEN APPROVED AND THEN THE
SECOND REASON THAT I RISE IS-
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PUT A
LETTER. INTO THE JOURNAL. BOB.
YOU WANT TO SEPARATE SORRY YES
IT'S- LET'S WAIT JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE ON THE FIRST ITEM.
SENATOR HERTZBERG WOULD YOU
PLEASE RESPOND ON THE FIRST
ITEM I WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WAS
CIRCULATED TO LEADERSHIP. ALL
THE STAFF MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
THAT IT'S THE SAME CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT WAS CIRCULATED
ABOUT AN HOUR AGO THAT WE
APPROVED I WAS JUST MAKING SURE
IT WASN'T A NEW ONE I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE CONFUSION. IT IS VERY
MUCH EASIER TO BE ON THE FLOOR
AND HAVE YOUR STAFF HAND YOU A
DOCTOR THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
SO WHAT I IS AN ITEM I DO
APOLOGIZE THAT BUT I AM SO THE
SPEECH THERE'S NO OBJECTION TO
THE SPECIAL CONSENT- THANK YOU.
SENATOR. NIELSEN FOR PURPOSE OR-
ONE OF CENTER GROVE'S. THE
LETTER IS IN THE HANDS OF ERICA
CONVERSE RIGHT NOW. DID FOR THE
JOURNAL. THE LETTERS AT THE
DESK. BUT WE STILL NEED TO HAVE
THE MOTION MADE FORMALLY SO
SENATOR GROVE WOULD YOU PLEASE
RECITE YOUR SECOND MOTION. AND
ABSOLUTELY AND IT WASN'T
MOTIONS REGULATIONS I WOULD
LIKE TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL ON SB. SEVEN NINETY
THREE. THAT WILL BE THE ORDER
WITHOUT OBJECTION. STANDUP IS
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MADAM PRESIDENT'S
MEMBERS BY MOVE DEBATE ON
MEASURES BE LIMITED TO THE
OPENING PRESENTATION. TO
PROPONENTS FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
TO OPPONENTS FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH AND A CLOSING SUMMATION.
ALL RIGHT RISE SENATOR GROWTH
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. I OBJECT TO
THAT I RENEWED THE THANK YOU
THERE IS AN OBJECT IT IS NOW I
AM CHECKING OUT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO THE FIFTH FLOOR
DEBATE A BALL ON THE FLOOR THEY
DIDN'T SENATOR IT'S NOT OKAY TO
BE IN THE MOTION THERE'S. A
MOTION AND SEVERAL THE MOTION.
YOU'RE RIGHT TO BE. GET ACADEMY
I WROTE IT DEMOCRATS TO SO REAP
OUT SOLELY. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES YOU HAVE YOUR HAND UP
REMEMBER THIS IS NOT THE
RATEABLE- PLEASE MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'M SORRY. I'M
INTRIGUED PLEASE WHAT IS YOUR
IN COURSE OF. I I'M I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THESE MOTIONS I
WE YOU KNOW TWO YEARS I'VE BEEN
THE SENATE WE'VE NEVER HAD THIS
KIND OF MOTION AND I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE- SECTION OF
THE SENATE RULES THAT ALLOWS
THIS KIND OF MOTION CAN I HAVE
AN EXPLANATION OF. OF HOW THIS
CAN. WHY THIS CAN BE ALLOWED
AND THEN IF IT IS IF IT DOES
PASS WHAT'S THE- PROCESS GOING
FORWARD. DO NOT DRESS SENATE
RACE THE PREVIOUS QUESTION
WHICH IS A FORM OF MANY
DIFFERENT. OR OR NOT USING THAT
AS A NEW WRITER WE ARGUE WE ARE
NOT. IF YOU WAIT JUST ONE
MOMENT. WHAT WE ARE ASSEMBLY.
YES MA'AM WE ARE WE ARE SIMPLY
MAKING A MOTION. THAT IS
PROVIDED FOR. SIX EIGHT. UNDER
MASON'S MANUAL SECTION EIGHTY
TWO WHICH READS WHAT MOTIONS
ARE NOT DEBATABLE AND IT
FOLLOWS THAT A MOTION A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY IS NOT
DEBATABLE. PAGE AVAILABLE IS TO
LIMIT DEBATE AN A NON DEBATABLE.
MOTION IS TO LIMIT DEBATE. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION BEFORE US.
ETANA SECTIONS AGAIN I'M SORRY
AND THEY ARE MASONS RULES OF
ORDER SECTION. EIGHTY TWO. AND.
THAT IS IT THERE ARE A COUPLE
IN A COUPLE OF NUMBERS BUT IT
IS SECTION. EIGHTY TWO
INDICATING THOSE MOTIONS THAT
ARE NOT DEBATE. MASONS REYES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON
BEHALF OF MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES THEIR VOTING
REMOTELY I ALSO OBJECT TO THE
MOTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION BEFORE US TO
LIMIT DEBATE SENATOR HERTZBERG
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
SENATOR JONES. ASKING FOR
RESIDENTS THERE'S SEVERAL
THERE'S SEVERAL REMOTE HANDS UP
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE
POINTS OF ORDER OR WHAT THERE
CONCERNS ARE BUT THEY SHOULD
PROBABLY BE CALLED ON. JUST IN
CASE. YOU WILL. MRS WILSON IS
NOT AVAILABLE RIGHT. I'D LIKE
TO REMIND YOU THAT THIS MOTION
IS NOT DEBATABLE WE WILL
RECOGNIZE YOU AFTER THE MOTION
IS MADE SENATORS HERTZBERG YEAH
THANK YOU MEMBERS WHICH IS FOR
POINT OF CLARIFICATION. THIS
THIS MOTION TO LIMIT APPLIES TO
ALL PARTIES EIGHT TERMS A
PRESENTATION AND OPPOSITION SO
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE WITH
RESPECT TO A PARTY ON THIS IS
JUST A MANAGEMENT TOOL GIVEN
THAT THE WHERE WE ARE TODAY ON
THE AND WHAT MATTERS WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE BANK. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL HEAR THE MOTION.
INTRIGUING. YES WHO IS ARE
SEEKING THE PARLIAMENT SENATOR
MELENDEZ SENATOR MELINDA IS
WHAT IS YOUR PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY MADAM SPEAKER I BELIEVE
THAT THE ROLE HE'S REFERRING TO
RELATES TO CALLING FOR THE
QUESTION WHICH WOULD SHUT DOWN
DEBATE I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT
APPLIES TO JUST MAKING. A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR TO USE TO
SUGGEST THAT YOU WANT TO SHUT
DOWN DEBATE FOR THE REST OF THE
EVENING. YEAH. WE ARE NOT WE
ARE YOU ARE REFERRING TO A
MOTION REGARDING MOVING THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION WHICH IS NOT
WHAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO
HERE SO I UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
GLAD I AM SAYING IS THAT BURNED
OUT SHE ACTUALLY USE REQUIRING
TO THAT IS THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION NEXT WE HAVE ARE YOU
JUST GONNA SHUT REPUBLICANS
HOURS DEBATE HELP HOMEOWNERS
ONLY. OUT OF THE CHAMBER
PROMOTION RIGHT NOW YOU'RE ONLY
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEBATE
THANK YOU CONTRAST SHOULD YOU.
SHASTA PARLIAMENTARY QUESTION.
SENATOR GIRL. THIS IS. I AM I
HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
MISS MELINDA'S IT'S ME. BE
SENATOR AND CENTERED SENATOR
MARK IN JANITOR WE GOING TO BE
POSITIVE WE LOOK AT ALL THE
FOLLOWING WHICH. SENATOR LACTIC
SENATOR. I RELATE YOU SHOULD BE
REPRESENTED OR MARKETS. MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE BILL
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY THE
SENATOR MARIA YES AND I JUST I
THANK YOU FOR GIVING A SECTION
EIGHTY TWO DIED I GOT THAT BOOK
BECAUSE I BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE USED OVER THE YEARS
CAN YOU JUST REFERRED ME TO
WHAT PAGE THAT WAS ON SO I CAN
QUICKLY LOOK IT UP. EXCUSE ME
LET ME GET THE BOOK BACK WHAT
IS THE PAGE NUMBER FOR THAT
SECTION MISTER MORALE WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. SECTION EIGHTY TWO
CENTER MORALIS ON PAGE SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU. AND THE LIST
DOES CONTINUE TO PAGE SEVENTY
SO PAGES SIXTY NINE TO SEVENTY.
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT. NEXT
QUESTION WE HAVE SENATOR BATES.
YES I AM WONDERING DOES SENATOR
BATES HERE IS THE LIMITS ON
DEBATE THE TIME OF SPEAKING
WHICH I KNOW IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DIDN'T HAVE IN THE ASSEMBLY
WHEN I WAS A MEMBER ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT LIMITING SPEAKERS
ARE LIMITING TIME OF DEBATE
INDIVIDUAL SPEAKERS IS ONE
THING THAT LIMITING SPEAKERS
REALLY IS THE SUPPRESSION I
BELIEVE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AND I CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT OUR RULES REALLY WANT BAD
**** ANSWER. THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE. IF IT IS LIMITING THE
TIME WE SPEAK. THERE MIGHT BE
IN ORDER THAT LIMITING SPEAKER
SO I DON'T THINK SO THERE'S
ONLY TWO AND THEY'RE BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND STAND UP FOR
DEMOCRATS TO STAND UP. AT
CERTAINLY IS NOT BALANCED THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND YEAH REPEAT THE
MOTION. IT IS TO- DEBATE ON
MEASURES TO BE LIMITED TO THE
OPENING PRESENTATION. COOPER
TWO MINUTES EACH TO OPPONENTS
TWO MINUTES EACH AND I CLOSING
SUMMATION SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENS IN COMMITTEES. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW IS
THERE ANOTHER INQUIRY ANOTHER
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. SENATOR
THE CHEER AND THERE WERE HANDS
UP WE'VE RESPONDED TO ARE THOSE
HAND STILL UP SENATOR MORALE
YOUR HAND IS STILL UP I ASSUME
THAT YOU'VE HAD YOUR INQUIRY.
RESPONDED TO LET'S GO TO
SENATOR. MELENDEZ NO ACTUALLY
WE'VE HAD EVERYBODY EVERYBODY
HAS EVERYBODY'S HAD THEIR
OPPORTUNITY SENATOR NIELSEN SIR.
AND THERE IS A MOTION BEFORE US
SO IT IS ONLY A MATTER OF
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY THE
MOTION IS NOT DEBATABLE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE SENATOR MELINDA
THIS IS ASKING FOR NO VOTE
SENATOR NIELSEN IS SORT OF A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY. SENATOR
NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE
ARMAMENT FREE INQUIRY IS FOR A
REASON. THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN
GIVEN. THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED IN
MY EXPERIENCE HERE AND I WANT A
DOG ON REASON. NOT JUST BECAUSE
WE'VE DONE AROUND AND HAVE NOT
GOTTEN A WORK DONE AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE GET ALL THE SO
CALLED BILLS OUT OF HERE THAT'S
NOT A REASON. HARLEM ENTRY
INCREASE OR IS SIMPLY A REQUEST
FOR INFORMATION THE MOTION IS
NOT DEBATABLE. AND SO SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND CENTER MELINDA'S IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I URGE LETTER YOU GUYS
TAKE A PICTURE OF THE SCREEN TO
SEE WHO VOTES FOR THIS SO WE
CAN GET THIS OUT THERE.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM. I DODD
HI DURAZO. HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO.
JACKSON AYE LEYVA. I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN NO
HAN. I PORTANTINO. I. ROSS. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE. HI I Y. CASKEY I
WIENER HI. LET'S GO TO THE
VOTERS WHO ARE OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE VOTING REMOTELY THIS IS A
MOTION TO LIMIT DEBATE. SENATOR
BATES BASED ON THE MOTION TO
LIMIT DEBATE NO FACE NO PORGES.
WHAT IS IT LIKE DEBATE BOB
GORGEOUS OF EMOTION TO LIMIT
DEBATE NOW. OR JUST NOW CHIANG
HANG ON THE MOTION TO LIMIT
DEBATE NO. CHIANG NO DALLY. THE
ONLY ON THE MOTION TO LIMIT
DEBATE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. THE
MOTION TO LIMIT DEBATE AND
SILENCE- OUR VOICES ABSOLUTELY
POSITIVELY NOT. ZERO NO.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ ON THE MOTION
TO NOT ONLY PHYSICALLY RENO NO
NOBODY CARES TO MOTIONS.
THEY'RE ALWAYS ON THE MONNING.
THANK YOU. NEXT MELENDEZ NO
THANK YOU MORLOCK. MOORLACH ON
THE MOTION TO LIMIT DEBATE NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. THE
ECONOMY SENATORS GENERAL YOU'RE
A NEW. THERE YOU GO. OKAY
SKINNER MORALE IS A NO VOTING
NO. TO LIMIT THE BILL FOR US TO
DEBATE THANK YOU SIR MARIN NO
MAKE THAT WILK. NEAR THE FLOOR.
SIGN FROM WILK NO ON THE MOTION
TO LIMIT TODAY THANK YOU WILK
NOW BUYS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
ON THE MOTION TO LIMIT DEBATE
THE MOTION PASSES. MOVING ALONG
IT NOW. THERE ONE EVEN ALL
RIGHT MA'AM PRESIDENT WE HAVE
YES SENATOR. LOW M. I ASKED TO
REMOVE ALL BILLS FROM CONSENT
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE THE.
TWENTY FIFTH WILL BE THE- SUCH
WILL BE THE ORDER. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
TWENTY MINUTES. FOUR AND DINNER
AND THEN WE WILL BE BACK PLEASE
PROMPTLY SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
PURPOSE SIR YEAH WE'LL DO
DINNER IT'S- AND COME BACK AT.
SIX THIRTY FIVE TWENTY TWO
MINUTES TWENTY MINUTES A LOT OF
WORK TO DO AND IF I COULD JUST
A- YOU KNOW ADD THAT THERE IS
PRECEDENT TO IF I COULD SPEAK
TO THE FILE- ON ADDITION OF THE
MEANWHILE YOU'RE THERE JUST
JUST A FOR CLARIFICATION TWO
RESPECTS ONE IS. WE'RE TRYING
TO MANAGE THE PROCESS BOTH
PARTIES TREATED ALL PARTIES
TREATED EQUALLY AND HAVING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD THIS
WE'VE DONE SO MANY TIMES. AND
PRO TEMPORADA APPROACH HIM A
BURDEN AND SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER ROMERO HAVE ALL ENGAGE
IN THIS EXACT PROCESS THAT. WAS
REFERRED TO WITH RESPECT TO
MASON'S MANUAL AND I WITH THAT
I HOPE WILL BE SEE BACK AT SIX
THIRTY FIVE. WE ARE ENEMIES
PRESIDENT MADAM PRESIDENT. WE
ARE IN RECESS MADAM PRESIDENT
AND CONDITION OF THE FILE
BEFORE YOU RECESS. YOUR
UNFORTUNATELY YOU'RE OUT OF
ORDER WE WERE IN RECESS WILL BE
BACK AT SIX THIRTY FIVE.
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS.
GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I HOPE EVERYONE ENJOYED
THEIR DINNER BREAK WE'RE GOING
TO GET STARTED IN THIRTY THIRD
GIVE ME SIXTY SECONDS SO YOU
HAVE A MINUTE AND WE'RE GOING
TO START WITH SENATE BILLS THAT
HAVE COME BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SO SIXTY SECONDS WE'LL
GET STARTED.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO START. WITH FILE
ITEM. MEMBERS OF I CAN GET YOUR
ATTENTION WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR ARCHULETA
AN ACT RELATING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNIFORMS CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU BETTER
PRESIDENT I PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOUR EIGHTY WILL MINIMIZE
PUBLIC CONFUSION BY MANY POLICE
ARE FOR BANNING POLICE OFFICER
FROM USING COMMA FLOOD BY
PROVIDING GUIDELINES FOR PROPER
LABELING AND IDENTIFICATION AS
AN ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REMAIN
COMPLIANT WITH THIS BILL. FOR
THAT I ASK FOR NOVEL. THANK YOU
CENTER ARE TO LETTERMAN REMIND
ALL OF OUR MEMBERS OF THESE ARE
BILLS THAT ARE BACK ON
CONCURRENT WE HAVE ALREADY
DEBATED THE BILL SO LESS IS
MORE IN THIS CASE. ANY CENTER
GROVE. THIRD ROW CENTER GROVE
YOU'RE ON MUTE. M. CENTER ROAD
HOLD ON WE CAN FEARLESS MOVING
BUT WE CAN'T HEAR YOU SO HOLD
ON ONE SECOND YOU'RE A MUTE.
CAN SHE HEAR ME. OKAY. CENTER
GROVE YOU HAVE TO AMUSE
YOURSELF. THERE'S A BOX THAT
SAYS THE HOST WOULD LIKE TO AND
YOU YOU AND I CLICK YES AND SO
I WOULD JUST ASSUME THE HOSTESS
AT UT SORRY I WAS JUST LETTING
YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAD WERE ON
MUTE I DON'T WANT YOU TO WASTE
YOUR WORDS WHEN WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU THAT'S ALL PLEASE
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THAT
MADAM PRESIDENT. AS THE FIRST
FEMALE VETERAN THAT'S EVER
SERVED ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR OR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE FLOOR I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SWEAR TO
DEFEND. THIS COUNTRY AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC- YOU. HAVE A PRIVILEGE
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT I BELIEVE
THAT ANYBODY WHO'S WILLING TO
PUT YOUR HAND IN THE AIR AND
SWEAR TO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES. FOREIGN
AND DOMESTIC INCLUDING UP INTO
GIVING THEIR LIFE. FOR THIS-
GREAT AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY THAT
WE- LIVE IN. I THINK THAT THAT
IS- OF AT MOST RESPECT. AND I'M
NOT SAYING THAT JUST BECAUSE
I'M A FEMALE VETERAN I SAY THAT
BECAUSE OF MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
ANGLER. AS SENATOR ROSS IN
ALSO- SENATOR MELENDEZ AND IF I
FORGOT SOMEBODY I DOAPOLOGIZE.
SO IT SENATOR ARCHULETA I DO
AND I REALIZE THAT YOU'RE A
VETERAN TO SIR. I DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL I KNOW THAT IT
PROVIDES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY OR EMPLOYEES IN PEACE
OFFICERS. AND SHALL NOT
AUTHORIZED TO ALLOW THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO WEAR. A UNIFORM AB
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO ANY
UNIFORMITY UNITED STATES IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT CAMOUFLAGE. IT'S
ABOUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN-
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PEACE
OFFICERS WHO WE DEEPLY RESPECT.
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN IN- THAT
REPRESENTS DESTIN BLUE LINE
THAT PROTECT US AND PROTECT OUR
CITIZENS EVERY DAY. BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE- WHERE- UNIFORMS- AT
ART MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
MATTER. SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT
YOU KNOW SHERIFFS AND POLICE TO
PROMINENTLY SLATE ACROSS THEIR
BACK OR CHEST AREA- IT BANS THE
USE OF CAMOUFLAGE UNIFORMS. BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IT
EXEMPTS MEMBERS OF SPECIAL
WEAPONS AND TACTICS UNITS LIKE
SWAT- OR SNIPER TEAMS AND
TACTICAL TEAM ENGAGE IN
TACTICAL RESPONSE FOR OPERATION
OF DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. IT JUST MAKES THEM
COME UP WITH THE DIFFERENT
UNIFORMS AND THE- UNITED STATES
MILITARY WHETHER IT'S AIR FORCE
COAST GUARD. UNITED STATES ARMY
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS. AND
IT DOESN'T MATTER IT'S THAT ARE
UNITED STATES NAVY I DIDN'T
WANT TO FORGET MY COLLEAGUE
MISS MELINDA'S. BUT IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT- WHAT BRANCH OF
SERVICE THAT YOU SEE SO. ME A
FREE SIR IN OUR COUNTRY WE WANT
TO SURE THAT. IS WEARING A-
THAT DIDN'T. GROW TO SERVE. AND
SO THE ON. INCITING OFFICE CAN
I GET YOU ATTENTION ADVICE
CHAIR OF I'M AT SENATE ROOM YOU
NOT HEAR. I THANK YOU FOR THE
TO BRING THIS BILL FOR AND
WOULD ACTUALLY- ASK EVERYBODY
TO THE I THANK YOU FOR LETTING
SAY A FEW WORDS THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE MEMBERS I SHOULD
HAVE STARTED WITH THIS WE
PASSED A MOTION BEFORE TOOK A
DINNER BREAK THAT EACH MEMBER
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK.
SO I HAVE MICHELLE HERE HELPING
ME KEEP TIME SO YOU'LL GET YOUR
TWO MINUTES AND THEN WHEN I
CALL ON YOU I'D ASK YOU TO STOP
OR IF YOU'RE ON THE FLOOR WE
WILL CUT YOUR MIND. OR IF YOU
WERE VOTING REMOTELY WE WILL
CUT YOUR MIKE BUT REMOTELY SO I
SHOULD HAVE SAID THAT AT THE
BEGINNING OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
SENATOR WILK. SENATOR WELLS CAN
YOU HIT A MUTE PLEASE. THIRTY
WILK. THERE'S A LITTLE BOX ON
YOUR SCREEN HIT A NEW PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
GUYS GOT TO DECIDE WHICH ONE
YOU WANT TO DO IT BECAUSE I
THINK SOMEBODY'S PLAYING GAMES.
THIS IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
YES MEANS ROSE TO TALK AS IT
RELATES TO THE MEMBERS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO I'M SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHTY
BECAUSE IT WAS A MUCH BETTER
BILL WHEN IT CLEARED THIS
HOUSE. AND I'M TIRED OF THESE
BILLS GOING OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND BEING DIMINISHED
AND NOT AND PUTTING IT ON
POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS. AND I JUST
I JUST THINK THAT WE KNOW WE
NEED TO STAND UP FOR OURSELVES.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD REJECT
THIS CENTER ARE TO LET IT
SHOULD BRING IT BACK NEXT
SESSION AND HOLD FIRM ON THAT.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I KERR
ENCOURAGED MY COLLEAGUES TO
VOTE NO. IN THE WORLD IT JUST
TO BE CLEAR WE HAVE MADE UP OUR
MIND. MEMBERS STILL HAVE A
RIGHT TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
ON CONCURRENCE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE NOT TO BUT YOU.
STILL HAVE THAT RIGHT TO SPEAK
FOR TWO MINUTES. THIS FROM.
JOHN I'M GONNA COME YOU IN A
MINUTE I GONNA GO TO SAY WIENER
WHO'S ON THE FLOOR. PRESENCE OF
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER SENATOR JONES. MADAM
PRESIDENT- A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
AND THEN A POINT OF A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY ON THE
CONCERN I JUST TOOK A PICTURE
OF MY SCREEN. IRAN THIS HASN'T
HAPPENED YET SINCE I'VE BEEN
OPERATING MY COMPUTER IT'S SAID
THAT THE HOST WILL NOT AND MUTE
ME- AND SO I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
ON THERE BEFORE I CAN TEXT THAT
TO SOMEBODY. I KNOW IT'S AS I
SAID BEFORE SENATOR JONES IF
SOMEONE GOES OVER THERE TWO
MINUTES ON THE FLOOR THERE
MICHAEL BECAUSE- IN ORDER TO DO
THAT FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THE I.
T. GUYS ARE NOW IN CONTROL SO
YOU'LL HAVE YOUR TWO MINUTES
BUT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTROL CUT YOU OFF AS WELL SO
IT'S FAIR FOR EVERYBODY ALL
SENATORS HAVE THE SAME RULE.
OKAY AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
CHALLENGE FOR THOSE OF US
REMOTELY THOUGH- VERSUS BEING
ON THE FLOOR- IT FOR RAISING A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY A POINT
OF ORDER YOU KNOW. YOU'LL SEE
US ON THE FLOOR PUT. PUT YOUR
HAND UP IF YOU HAVE A HOLE IN A
TREE ENQUIRE RES I CAN SEE IT
RIGHT HERE AND I WILL CALL ON
YOU. OKAY OKAY NOW MY
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY 8%
RESEARCHER EXPLAINING THE RULES
ON THE TWO MINUTES MY I DON'T
KNOW IF YOURS IF THAT'S THE
STANDARD RULES OR THE MOTION
THAT- CENTER HERTZBERG MADE
EARLIER. I DID WANT
CLARIFICATION ON CENTER
HERTZBERG MOTION MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS THE MOTION
WAS FOR TWO SPEAKERS I IN
SUPPORT AND TWO SPEAKERS IN A-
IN OPPOSITION BUT THERE. WAS NO
TIME LIMIT ON THOSE TWO
SPEAKERS. NO IT WAS ALL TO PER.
TWO MINUTES EACH OPPONENTS TO
MINUTES HE- AND I HAVE I HAVE
IT IN FRONT OF ME HERE IF YOU
CANNOT OKAY I MISSED THAT- WHEN
HE MADE HIS MOST I APOLOGIZE
THAT'S NOT NOT A PROBLEM. OKAY
ARE YOU GOOD. CENTERED AROUND.
OKAY VERY GOOD SO WE'RE GOING
TO MOVING ON NOW TO SENATOR NO
YOU'RE NOT GOOD. OKAY PLEASE ON
MUTE SENATOR JONES. SO I'LL
EXPLAIN- THAT WAS THE BOX THAT
WAS NOT ALLOWING ME THAT I NEED
SO THAT I CAN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION- THIS IS GONNA BE A
CHALLENGE- OF THE STORM'S GONNA
READ THAT AGAIN YES. YES YES
FROM NOW ON I'M GOOD THANK YOU
SIR OKAY WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR DOLLY.
OKAY I NEEDED MYSELF I HOPE I'M
DOING THIS RIGHT YOU DID A
DIFFERENT ALONG. JUST REAL
QUICK I WANTED TO ASK A
QUESTION THE AUTHOR. SENATOR OR
SHOULD WE TAKE A QUESTION YES
MADAM PRESIDENT PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU THROUGH THE CHAIR- SO
WHAT A LOT OF TIMES WE HAVE-
THESE OFFICERS COME. FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE AND OTHER STATES
WERE DUE AND FEDERAL- WEEK WHEN
THEY'RE DOING LIKE- THEY WORK
TOGETHER WHEN THEY'RE DOING.
SWAT AND NOT BUT THEY BUT THEY
COULD. IS THIS IS ONLY FOR
CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM WHEN
THEY'RE DOING MARIJUANA. THESE
HAVE THE CAMPS PROGRAM THAT
YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE OF WHERE
THEY IT'S IT WAS IN
COORDINATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES THAT ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. IS THERE GONNA BE A
CONFLICT WITH THIS BILL- WITH
THOSE WITH THOSE TYPE OF-
MANEUVERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WORKING TOGETHER. LET ME ANSWER
THAT BY TELLING THESE ARE
TACTICAL TRAINING EVENTS THAT
YOU'RE SPEAKING OF IN THE CALM
FLIGHT UNIFORM IS AUTHORIZED
OFFICE IT IS THIS BILL IS THE
STOP THE CONFUSION FROM THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. IN OUR ARMED
FORCES AND POLICE OFFICERS BUT
SWAT TACTICAL OFFICERS TRAINING
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. ALL
PERMISSIBLE. I READ THAT BUT
BUT SOMETIMES. THEY'RE NOT FROM
THE OUR STATE IN THERE THIS I
GUESS IF THEY'RE COMING
PROSTATE YOU GOING TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH- THE UNIFORMS THEY
NEED SO WE CAN ALL KEEP TRACK
OF WHO'S WHO. WELL I WOULD
THINK SO YES. THANK YOU AND I'M
GONNA ASK ALL FURTHER QUESTIONS
AND THEN ASK FOR AUTHORS TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS IN THEIR
CLOTHES OKAY THAT WE CAN BE A
LITTLE MORE EFFICIENT WITH OUR
TIME NEXT EPISODE UNDER WAR
JUST SENATE REPORTERS. THANK
YOU JUST A PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
WAS DECIDED EARLIER. HOW WILL
THE TWO SPEAKERS BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST BE SELECTED. THE
GENERAL PURITY WENT OVER THAT.
WE DID NOT IS IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT IN THE NEXT
PERCENT SINCE PEAKING IN
SUPPORT THE TWO WERE DONE AND
THEN IF THERE'S TWO PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION IT'LL BE APART AND
COMING UPON THE PRESIDING
OFFICER TO KEEP TRACK. THAT'S
WHAT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT IN THE ROOM.
AND WE HAVE TO DO THE RAISING
OF THE HANDS ON THE- ON THE
WATER AND I'M GOING BACK AND
FORTH. WHAT WOULD YOU KNOW IF
I'M IN SUPPORT OR AGAINST.
USUALLY AS A PRESIDING OFFICER
YOU TAKE PEOPLE IN THE ORDER
THEY RAISE THEIR MICROPHONES OR
THEY RAISE THEIR HANDS THAT'S
WHAT I'VE BEEN. SPECIFICALLY MY
NEXT QUESTION MADAM PRESIDENT.
IS I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE'RE NOT- WE'RE NOT VIEWED.
SECOND ON THE LIST NOT AT ALL.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ON THE
FLOOR. ARE GIVEN THE SAME
CONSIDERATION VICE VERSA AS US
ALL REMOTELY SO HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE. THE TWO- TIMING
ISSUES WELL THAT'S WHAT I JUST
TOLD YOU AS I AM AS A PRESIDING
OFFICER AND I'M LOOKING OUT I
SEE MIKE SCHOOL UP I SEE HANDS
GO UP IT'S REALLY QUITE EASY TO
TELL WHO'S PUTTING THEIR HAND
UP WHO'S PRETTY THE MICROPHONE
UP. AND THEN I MAKE A LITTLE
LIST AND CALL ON PEOPLE IN THE
ORDER. THAT THEY PUT THEIR MIKE
OR THEIR HAND UP. SO IF I'M- IF
I'M- ARE YOU CAN ASK ME WHETHER
NINE FOUR AGAINST AND THEN MAKE
A DETERMINATION MY HOPE WOULD
BE SENT US OVER ME MY HOPE
WOULD BE THE SINCE EVERYONE
KNOWS THE RULES IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT AND YOU'RE THE THIRD
PERSON AND TWO PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN IN SUPPORT I WOULD ASK
PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR TO PUT THE
MICROPHONE DOWN AND I WOULD ASK
YOU TO PUT YOUR HAND DOWN. OKAY
YOU'RE GONNA BE SIGNED ME OUT
TO. SETARA THEN THAT'S FAIR
DEAL DESIGNATES BEFORE WE GET
GOING. I'M LOOKING FOR TWO
SPEAKERS FOR SPEAKERS AGAIN WE
GOT JOHNSON GOT HERTZBERG HER
TADO IN GROWTH AND THEN IT WILL
BE DETERMINED THAT WAY YES. AND
BEAR WITH. OKAY THANK YOU SIR
OKAY WE'RE THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO
TO. CENTER GROVE. YOU KNOW WHAT
CENTER GROVE ALL COME BACK TO
YOU BECAUSE YOU DID ALREADY
SPEAK ON THIS SSUE SO WE'RE
GOING TO TRY AND GET THROUGH
THIS MOTION WE'VE HAD. ONE
PERSON SPEAKING OPPOSITION
WE'VE HAD TWO PEOPLE SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. AND I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES UP AND CENTER GROVE
WILL COME BACK TO YOU ON THE
NEXT ISSUE SO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. BELL I
BRADFORD HI CARRILLO FIVE DODD
I DORADO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. JACKSON AYE LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
AMBERG HI LAKE COUNTY I WIENER
HI. WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE VOTING
REMOTELY CENTER GROVE I SEE
YOUR HAND IN A COME TO AFTER
THE VOTE HAS BEEN TAKEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE MOVE TO A
REMOTE VOTING SENATORS THIS IS
FILE ITEM S. B. FOUR EIGHTY.
EIGHT THUNDER BATES I'M SORRY
YOUR YOU ARE MUTED IF YOU
COULDN'T ON MUTE YOURSELF THERE
SHOULD BE A LITTLE BOX THAT
POPS UP. ALL OF THIS GETTING
THE ON MUTE. MESSAGING MADAM
PRESIDENT I THINK SO THAT
THAT'S WHERE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE PROBLEMS WOULD NOT
BE MORE EXPEDITIOUS FOR US TO
REGAIN CONTROL OF THE CENTER
BORDERS LOOKING TO SHIFT VOTE
THIS IS NOT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO BRING THAT UP BUT I
THINK YOU. CENTER BATES. OKAY
I'M IN YOUR MIND YOU DID I
BEGINNING AGAIN THIS IS BATES
L. OR EIGHTY STATE. THANK YOU
FOR JUST. GEORGES SB FOUR
EIGHTY. FOUR JUST OUTSIDE
CHIANG CHAIRS BEFORE EIGHTY I
SANG ON A DAILY. SENATE EARLIER
MUTED I KNOW YOU KNOW HOW TO DO
IT BECAUSE YOU DID IT A SECOND
AGO. WELL IT'S CONFUSING-
BECAUSE THERE'S A BOX UP THERE
THAT'S- AYE AND MUTED AND THEN
I GOT ME TO BAXO. DOLLY SB FOUR
EIGHTY I THANK DALLY HIGH
GROWTH. CENTER GROVE. HE SAYS
IN THE BOX WE CAN HEAR YOU.
PART OF ME WE CAN HEAR YOU. IT
SAYS IN THE BOX SO MANY TEXT TO
A PHOTO OF IT IT SAYS THE HOST
IS NOT ALLOWING PARTICIPANTS TO
AND YOU CAN CELLS SO IN THE
LAST TWO DAYS ALL OF US HAVE I
NEEDED. OURSELVES IN SPOKE. THE
LIGHT WE HAVE TO REMIND YOU TO
AND YOU DAIS SO FOR YOU TO SAY
CENTER DALLY I KNOW YOU KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS. YEAH WE DO KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS BUT YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWING US TO AND MEET
OURSELVES. AND THERE'S THE BOX
RIGHT THERE AND I CAN SEND YOU
A PICTURE OF IT RIGHT NOW SO
DID YOU SEE IT. MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATOR GROW I AM WELL AWARE
WITH THE BOX LOOKS LIKE I HAVE
DONE SO MANY TIMES MYSELF. AND
I'VE I'VE EIGHT LANE TWICE NOW
YES WE ARE USING THEM YOU BOX
TO EARN YOU YOU SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP TIME. BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE FLOOR WE CAN CUT OFF THE
MIKE MUCH MORE EASILY. SO YES
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE DID BEFORE YES CAN YOU
PLEASE CAST YOUR VOTE. YES I
WILL BUT PLEASE DON'T FREAK
SHOW MY MEMBERS LIKE THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING WHEN
YOU GUYS ARE BLOCKING US FROM
MY INTENT WAS THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE DISCUSSION. FOR GROWTH
CAN YOU PLEASE VOTE FOR IN THE
MIDDLE OF A- AND ROTENONE WHAT
WHAT TOM MEASURE YOUR VOTING ON
ITS- SB FOUR EIGHTY SB FOUR
EIGHTY GROWTH NOW THANK YOU.
FACEBOOK NOW. MELENDEZ. AND.
FEDERAL IS IF YOU CAN UNDER
YOURSELF PLEASE YOU SHOULD SEE
THE BOX BUT CENTER GROVE WAS
TALKING ABOUT. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR. GOOD I'M GLAD-
SENATOR MELENDEZ. S. B. FOUR
EIGHT ZERO VOTING I THANK YOU
MELENDEZ HI MORLOCK. SB FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE MORLOCK HIGH MORALE
HE- SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY-
ESTATE. WELL. WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
SENATOR WILL. YEAH I HAD TO
TAKE A FOUR TIMES WE GOT CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW WE GOT. WILK SB
FOUR EIGHTY ABSTAINED THANK YOU
SIR. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS I HER TADO.
NIELSEN. FIVE FIVE THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK RECESS. YES PLEASE STAY
ON THE FOR SERVICE.
FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WERE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PATIENCE HERE
THIS EVENING COULD DEPRECIATE
THE PARTNERSHIP AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS FINAL NINETY
SESSION. LADIES IN GENERAL THE
SENATE WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU
TO PLEASE TURN YOUR ATTENTION
TO MY LEFT INTO MATTER PRO TEM
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR I
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION. I
WANT TO ADD MY- GRATITUDE AND
THANKS TO YOU COLLEAGUES. THOSE
OF YOU HERE AND THOSE OF YOU
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. YOU
KNOW WHEN- WE UNDERTOOK THE
START OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T EXPECT THIS.
WE ANTICIPATE THE END OF
SESSION. IS NEVER EASY
PARTICULARLY IN A YEAR WHERE WE
HAVE TO ADJOURN. SIGNEE DIE.
BUT WE WERE PREPARED FOR THIS
MOMENT WE DID PREPARE FOR THIS
MOMENT AND WE PREPARED FOR THIS
MOMENT IN A UNIFIED FASHION AS
SENATORS. IN THE SENATE CHAMBER.
WITH HER COLLEAGUES BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS. AND
I THINK FRANKLY WE HAVE COME
TOO FAR TO GIVE UP OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE DONE. A WEEK AGO-
WE CELEBRATED WHAT WOULD HAVE
BECOME OUR END OF SESSION
RECOGNITION TO MEMBERS I HOPE
WE CAN FIX THIS MIGHT. W
CELEBRATED EACH OTHER IT WAS
GENUINE IT WAS REAL. AND WE
SAID WHAT WE APPRECIATED ABOUT
EACH OTHER INDIVIDUALLY. AND
THAT WAS IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
THAT'S THE FOUNDATION OF HOW WE
COME TOGETHER AND WORK. AS
COLLEAGUES WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
PRIVILEGE. THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAVE GIVEN US.
WE'VE COME TOO FAR NOT TO
COMPLETE THE WORK AND THE TASK
AT HAND AND SO REPUBLICAN
LEADER AND HIGH. ARE GOING TO
DO A RESET RIGHT NOW AND I'M
GOING TO ASK EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU. THE PUT ASIDE. OUR HURT
FEELINGS OUR ANGER OUR
FRUSTRATION. IT IS CLEARLY BEEN
A FRUSTRATING YEAR. I DON'T
KNOW HOW ANY OF US COULD HAVE
GOTTEN TO THIS POINT TONIGHT
WITHOUT OUR LOVED ONES OUR
FAMILY OUR CONSTITUENTS OUR
COMMUNITY TELLING US THEY WERE
COUNTING ON US AND THAT THEY
BELIEVED IN US. I BELIEVE IN US
AND I BELIEVE IN OUR ABILITY TO
RISE ABOVE AND BEYOND THIS
MOMENT. A FRUSTRATION ANXIETY
AND UNCERTAINTY AND THE TOP OF
THE CLOCK IS TICKING. AND WE
HAVE WORK TO DO FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE DONE GOOD
WORK TOGETHER. ON SO MANY
ISSUES DO WE AGREE ON ALL OF
THE ISSUES NO AND DO WE LONG
FOR THE DAYS OF ROBUST DEBATE
IN WHICH WE HAVE THE LUXURY TO
DO THAT ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY
AND WE WILL DO IT TOMORROW BUT
TONIGHT WE HAVE A TASK AND I
PLEDGE TO YOU AND I PLEDGE TO
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER. THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS AND TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WE'RE GOING TO GET
AS MUCH AS WE CAN DO DONE
TONIGHT WE STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT. AND WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO IT WITH THE
DECORUM THAT IS WORTHY OF THIS
HOUSE AS I LOOK AT THE DEAN OF
THE SENATE. AS I LOOK AT EACH
OF YOU. WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO IT WITH A DECORUM THAT IS
EXPECTED OF US IN THE SENATE.
AND SO I PLEAD WITH YOU. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD LET'S HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF KINDNESS AND
PATIENCE FOR EACH OTHER. BUT
CAN WE DO IT WITH BREVITY. AND
HAVING SAID THAT I NEED TO STOP.
AND ASK OUR MISTER PRESIDENT IF
YOU WILL NOW TURN IT OVER AND
PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER. MY FRIEND OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PROTEIN LADIES IN GERMAN THE
SENATE WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER. SHANNON GROVE MADAM
LEADER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND THANK YOU MY COLLEAGUE THE
SENATE PRO TEM UM FROM SAN
DIEGO WHO IS- AN OUTSTANDING
PARTNER IN SITUATIONS LIKE THIS
YEAR THIS IS BEEN- AN
UNPRECEDENTED SESSION. I'VE
SAID THAT BEFORE FOR THE WAY WE
ENDED SESSION LAST YEAR TO
WHERE WE ARE NOW WITH AN AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST DEADLINE. MANY
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF- BUT I
KNOW THAT- I AGREE WITH MY S.
SENATE WITH THE SENATE PRO TEM
AND MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP THAT. AND
WE CAN RESET THIS HOUSE IN THAT
WE ARE BIGGER THAN- THE ISSUES
THAT JUST TOOK PLACE AND THAT
WE CAN- WORK TOGETHER AND USE-
TO PASS A BILL THAT NEED TO BE
PASSED AND THEN STOP THE BILLS
THAT NEED TO BE STOPPED. IN
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS
CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTING ON
US. YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT
YOU KNOW I OFTEN REFLECTED YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ONE OF
FORTY I MEAN THERE'S ONLY FORTY
OF US IN THE CALIFORNIA STATES
IN IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT YOU YOU ARE
ONE OF FORTY IN THE ENTIRE.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE. AND SO- I'M
CALLING ON MY COLLEAGUES AND-
MIGHT AT MY DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES
TO LET'S RESET LET'S DEBATE THE
BILLS WE WANT TO DEBATE BUT
LET'S- LET'S DEBATE IT BRIEFLY
AND LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION
THAT BENEFITS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND LET'S REMEMBER
THAT ABOVE ALL REGARDLESS OF
HOW WE FEEL ABOUT BILLS AND HOW
WE FEEL ABOUT AND- AT THE
IDEOLOGY THAT EACH ONE OF US
HAVE. THAT WE HAVE A JOB TO DO
AND WE HAVE JUST ABOUT A FEW
JUST THREE YOU KNOW TO OUR
ACTUALLY. JUST THREE HOURS AND
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO DO IT SO- I
APPLIED MY- COLLEAGUE AS SENATE
PRO TEM FOR REACHING OUT AND
TALKING TO ME ABOUT THIS AND S.
WORKING THREE DS- THAT'S WHAT I
LOVE ABOUT HER YOU KNOW AND- WE
CAN BE DIFFERENT WE BOTH HAVE
CAUCUSES THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS. IS
THAT WE WANT TO DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR CALIFORNIA AND WHAT'S BEST
FOR THE HOUSE AND SO- I'M SO
APPRECIATE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT I HAVE WITH HER. AND I
FORWARD TO MANY FORWARD TONIGHT
S. C. SPEND AND SO. WOMEN THANK
YOU. THEY WROTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND APPROACHAND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE WE HAVE NO OTHER
INDIVIDUAL WHO I WOULD LIKE TO
BE A TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME AND
PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR. I DO SEE
TWO HANDS REYES AT THIS TIME-
THIS TIME WAS GOING TO BE
RESERVED FOR BOTH THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AS WELL AS
MADAME PROTEIN PROTEIN ATKINS
BUT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE SAID SENATOR BURGESS
WE DO SEE HAND UP SENATOR
BURGESS AND FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
THAT'S OKAY DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT. NO WORRIES AND WE'RE JUST
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO SENATOR MELINDA AS WE
DO HAVE A HANDOUT CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I JUST WANT TO THANK
LEADER GROVES- FOR KEEPING A
COOL HEAD. AND WORKING THROUGH
THIS- I LOOK FORWARD TO. HAVING
WORKING BETTER TOGETHER FOR THE
REST OF THE EVENING THEN WE SEE
IT IN THE LAST COUPLE OF HOURS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
HEARING AN APOLOGY APOLOGY-
THAT PRESIDING OFFICER. BEFORE
YOU. TO OUR MEMBERS RETREATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER MELINDA CENTER MELINDA
IS A CONVERSATION. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER TIM- ATKINS AS WELL AS
LEADER GROVE I HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS SO WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO DO ON THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO THOUGH FIRST AND
FOREMOST LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GONNA RECOGNIZE THE MAJORITY
LEADER SENATOR HERTZBERG SENT
HER TO PRISON HERTZBERG FOR
WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR PRESIDENT AND
THANK YOU SO KINDLY AND ADAM
PROTANDIM MADAM. REPUBLICAN
LEADER OF THE PURPOSE OF RISING
IS TO RESUME THE MOTION. MADE
EARLIER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RESCIND THE MOTION
ADOPTED THIS DAY. LIMITING
DEBATE. ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE TO DO IS
TALK ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
BE GOING RIGHT NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO. BILLS WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE A VERBAL ORDER
HERE WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING AT
THIS TIME ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE THOSE WHO ARE IN
PERSON AS WELL THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP THE FOR THE
NEXT FOUR BILLS THE NEXT FOR
BILLS. ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE. FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX. IN FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN. SIXTY EIGHT. D. THREE.
FIFTY SIX. AND FORTY SEVEN LET
IS A JOURNALIST WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT IS
GONNA BE PRESENTED BY SENATOR
LABOR CENTER LIVE ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT FILE SIXTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHE IS BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINETY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AN ACT RELATING TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE GOOD EVENING
CENTER LEYVA THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR WRITES
TODAY PRESENT AB. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE FOR YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
RAISING A WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES
WITH THE PERFORMANCE OF THE T.
S. C. INCLUDING EXTREMELY LONG
PERMIT PROCESS TIMES POOR
ENFORCEMENT. DELAYED SITE
REMEDIATION AND A FAILURE TO
RESPOND TO PUBLIC CONCERNS THE
PHYSICAL CONDITION A DTS MUST
BE FIXED IN ORDER TO HAVE A
HEALTHY DEPARTMENT THAT IS
CLEAR AND ALSO WHY THIS BILL
FIXES I'M GOING FAST FIXES
NINETEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN H. W. C.
A. BY RAISING OVER TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE IMPLEMENT THEM FROM
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL AGREED
TO BOARD. TO APPROVE D. T. S.
C. I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. PLEASE IN GERMAN THE
SENATE WE'RE GONNA IF THERE'S A-
OR DEBATE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION- DEBATE. WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE SENATOR MELINDA AND
SO ON THE ITEMS CENTER
MELINDA'S GOOD EVENING. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- I HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE MARKER IT SHE
WILL AGREE TO. ACCEPT ONE IN
THE INSURANCE. RELATED WOULD
YOU TAKE A QUESTION FROM A
CENTER MELINDA'S YES PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER MELINDA'S. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I WILL TRY TO
BE BRIEF THERE'S JUST ONE THING
THAT IS TROUBLING ME- ON THIS
BILL AND THAT IS THAT THE TASK
FORCE INCLUDES REPRESENTATION
FROM ASSEMBLY AND SENATE POLICY
AND BUDGET COMMITTEES THOUGH I
DON'T SEE ANY REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTATION- ON THIS TASK
FORCE AND I WONDER IF YOU
COULD- SPEAK TO WHY THAT IS.
THANK YOU. I HONESTLY DON'T
KNOW WHY THERE IS NO
REPUBLICANS INCLUDED I'M SORRY
SENATOR MELINDA'S. SERIOUS. OUR
WELL I REALIZE YOU ARE THAT FOR
GIACCHINO I BELIEVE YOUR- JOINT
AUTHOR ON HERE SO I JUST WANT
TO. REMIND EVERYONE THAT WHEN
YOU KNOW ISSUES LIKE THESE
AFFECT- REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO DOES IT'S
IRRESPECTIVE OF PARTY
PREFERENCE AND I THINK IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL IF PERHAPS THERE ARE
MORE BALANCED- IN ALL ASPECTS
OF OUR LIVES FRANKLY BUT
CERTAINLY- WITH THE TASK FORCE
IT'S GOING TO BE CONVENIENT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER MELINDA'S
IT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA
DO A FINAL CALL THE FINAL CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THOSE
WHO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY THOSE
ARE ON THE FLOOR FINAL CALL.
CENTER LATER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I HAVE A BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL I
BRADFORD. CABRERA I DODD HI THE
RAZA HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO ON HI HER TADO. HI
JACKSON I LEYVA HI WIRE. HI
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN
HI I'M BURKE I WOULD CASKEY.
WIENER HI. METACENTRIC CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE WERE THEN GOING TO
TRANSITION TO THOSE FOR VOTING
FOR MULTI SECTOR. BRADFORD I.
WHITE HOUSE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN SENATE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE A TRANSITION INTO
THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK EACH
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO SAY
YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER. AND
YOUR VOTE. BETTER SECTOR. FACE.
SERVICE YOU SHOULD BE GOOD. I
THINK I MAYNEED IT NOW YES
MA'AM AB BATES AB NINE NINE
FIVE NO FACE NO GORGEOUS. OR
JUST AB NINE NINE FIVE NOW FOR
JUST NO CHIANG PAYING EIGHTY
NINE NINE FIVE NO. CHIANG NO
DALLY ALI EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE
STATE. THE GROWTH A GROUP
EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE I KNOW
GROVE NO MELENDEZ. MELINDA IS
AB NINE NINE FIVE YOU KNOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB NINE
NINE FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. MORRELL EIGHTY NINE
NINE FIVE VOTING NEW GROUND NO
WILK. IT WILL BE NINE NINE
SCIENCE NO WILK NO. HIS TWENTY
EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. THERE'S PER TRYING TO
KEEP YOU ON YOUR TOES HERE THIS
EVENING WE'RE GOING TO BE GIVEN
OUT OUR NEXT FOUR NUMBERS ARE
NEXT FOR NUMBERS AND IT'S GOING
TO CHANGE A BIT AND I DO
APOLOGIZE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OUR NEXT FOR FILE
ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS. WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP. HI ITEM
FIFTY THREE. I DON'T SEVENTY
SIX. I DON'T SEVENTY SEVEN AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM.
475-376-7740 SEVEN SO LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING
TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY THREE.
SURROUNDED FRAZIER TO RESENT
MATTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MURATSUCHI AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES CENTER ONLY GOOD
EVENING. EVENING MISTER
PRESIDENT THIS BILL AIMS TO
EXPAND ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ADOPTION TO CALIFORNIA BY
ALLOWING CONSUMERS TO ACCESS
TV'S WITHOUT UPFRONT COSTS
FINANCING OR LONG TERM
COMMITMENTS. THROUGH A MONTH TO
MONTH MEMBERSHIP AGREEMENT
DIRECTLY WITH THE CONSUMER THE
MANUFACTURE. ARE THEY TOOK
IMMENSE TO ENSURE THAT- THERE'D
BE A LOT OF ACCESS TO THIS
PARTICULAR MODEL THEY'RE SIMPLE
TO THINK THIS IS ONLY WRITTEN
FROM. YOU JUST A FEW COMPANIES
BUT THE IMMENSE OF- QUITE
EXPANDED THE FOLKS YOU CAN
ACCESS THIS PARTICULAR MODEL
THIS IS ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
BETTER THERE ARE THERE OTHER
WAYS FROM FOR LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE FOR YOUNGER PEOPLE FOR
OTHER PEOPLE WHO. WANT TO TRY
OUT THE V. MARKET MIGHT BE A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT BUYING ANY
V. TO ACCESS THAT MARKET- IN A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE AFFORDABLE
WAY. AND WITHOUT IT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER. DISK OR DEBATE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FROM THE SENATE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. WE SEE
CENTER MORLOCK GOOD EVENING
CENTER MORLOCK THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
I HAVE A HIGH REGARD FOR
INNOVATION THIS IS A STATE WITH
A LOT OF IT- SOMETIMES WE
ENCOURAGE IT SOMETIMES TO
SQUELCH IT. SOMETIMES IT WORKS
AND SOMETIMES WE- KIND OF. YEAH
YOU CAN GET IN ITS WAY BABY
OVER LEVEL BA A RECENT EXAMPLE
SO I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED WHEN
WE HAVE INNOVATION. WELL THAT
IS JUST BENEFITING PERHAPS ONE
COMPANY I CERTAINLY GOT A NICE
WRITE UP TODAY AN ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER BUT IT SEEMS A LITTLE
AWKWARD TO ME THAT WE'RE JUST
HELPING OUT ONE PARTICULAR.
COMPANY AT THIS POINT. I TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE OTHERS SO I
WILL BE OPPOSED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU CENTER
MORLOCK. BASINGER THE SENATE DO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. FINAL
CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. HARIAN C. NINE
CENTER AROUND YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE. YES THE ONE WITH
INCREDIBLE RESPECT MY FRIEND
FROM ORANGE COUNTY- DID YOU
THIS IS NOT ACCURATE THIS IS
JUST FOR ONE COMPANY THERE
THERE ARE SEVERAL COMPANIES
THAT WERE INITIALLY AND THEN
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TO THAT
WERE JUST TAKEN- HAVE EXPANDED.
THE BILL TO ALL MANUFACTURERS
THAT WHY THE- MEDICAL ARE NEW
ON THE BILL NOW SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL CONCERNS
IT'S NO LONGER THE CONCERN- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THIS IS A WAY OF GETTING MORE.
IEDS OUT TO PEOPLE IT'S GOT
STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL SUPPORT AS
WELL AS IN A SECOND WORK.
MEDICAID PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA NO ATKINS
AYE BELL AYE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO DODD HI THE RAZA. HI
CAL JOHNNY NO GLAZER. GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG. HILL I HUESO.
HURTADO HI JACKSON AYE LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NO HAN. PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE. MAJKOWSKI I
WIENER I. I'M SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THOSE PRESENT ONCE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HUESO. PAM
RUBIO. UMBERG THERE ISN'T CHEN
THE SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THOSE PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL
NUMBER AND YOUR VOTE MADAM
SECTOR. EIGHT PLEASE AB THREE
TWENTY SIX NO BATES NOW FORGES.
WE'RE JUST EIGHTY THREE TO SIX
NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. TANG
AB THREE TWO SIX NOW CHIANG NO
DALLY. AB THREE TWO SIX NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. I'M SORRY I
WAS SENT I APOLOGIZE AND MEET
YOURSELF IT SAYS IN THE
YOURSELF. CAN YOU HEAR ME. THE
NEW JUST OFF. YOU'RE GOOD
CENTER THE GROVE WE CAN HEAR
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR OKAY THE
SCREEN STILL SAYS YOU NEED TO
AND YOURSELF AND I THOUGHT I
ALREADY DID- I AM AT EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY SIX NO. AB THREE
TWENTY SIX NOW. GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB THREE TWO
SIX NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK OR
LIKE AB THREE TWO SIX NO MORE
LOCK NO MORAL. A. B. THREE TO
SIX NOW. MISTER RURAL I DO
APOLOGIZE IN A ROW WOULD YOU
MIND JUST STATING YOUR NAME THE
BILL NUMBER IN YOUR VOTE. OKAY
YES MORALE. AB THREE TO SIX NOW
THANK YOU MORRELL NO WILK. AB
THREE TWO SIX NO WILK NOW.
SANDERLIN WAS A CO PAYS IN
GERMAN OF THE SENATE RIGHT NOW
CAN BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX FOR MOVING ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SIX AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN THEN WE'RE GONNA
TAKE ON FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY SIX. THIS IS
A- YES THIS IS A MITCHELL
CORRECT. ADAM BUDGETARY
PREPARED PRESENT. HE CAN GIVE
US ABOUT ONE MINUTE LADIES IN
GENERAL ALLOW THE BUDGET YEAR
TO BE ABLE TO PREPARE FOR HER
REMARKS. WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. THE BUDGETARY JUST.
CORRECTED ME SHE IS ALWAYS
READY- AND I DO APOLOGIZE BEEN
A BETTER CHAIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. EIGHT IT CALLING SENATE
BILL ONE ONE FIVE IS MY LUCKY
BILL JUNIOR FINAL AT A BUDGET
YEAR I AM NOT ALWAYS READY AS
YOU COULD TELL MADAM SECRETARY
WHO IS PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AND
ACTUALLY BEEN TO THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE INTERRUPTION
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY MADAM
BUDGET YEAR. BUT YOU BILL
JUNIOR ASSOCIATE WITH THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY KEY
PROVISIONS APPROPRIATES TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION. ON
A VERY FUNDS FOR A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS PROVIDES A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. CORPORATE FORTY MILLION
TO DSS PROVIDE THIRTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION TO SOLVE THE
SPREAD OF COLVIN. TRANSFER THE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS HIRING CREDIT ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AS IN GERMAN
THE SENATE WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR FOR THOSE
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR THOSE PATICIPATING
REMOTELY. AARON SEEN.
MANUFACTURING CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BELL I
BRADFORD AYE CABRERO HI DODD
AYE DURAZO. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HURTADO HI
JACKSON. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE I WAS KIND OF SCARY
HI WIENER I REMINDED ALL
SENATORS REMINDED ALL SENATORS
WE ARE NOT PUTTING THE BUDGET
BILLS ON CALL SO WE'RE GONNA
NEED YOUR VOTE MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE GO THROUGH THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
WERE PRESENT AND WE'RE GOINGTO
TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. MADAM
SECRETARY. HUESO HI. MADAM
SECRETARY WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TRANSITION INTO THOSE ARE
PROTESTING REMOTELY THOSE
PEDESTRIAN REMOTELY CAN YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL
NUMBER IN YOUR PHONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
BATES THANKS S. B. ONE ONE FIVE
NO BATES NOW FOR JUST. FORGE'S
SP ONE ONE FIVE ABSTAINED.
CHIANG. THANK SB ONE ONE FIVE
HI JANE HI DALLY. DALY S. B.
ONE ONE FIVE NO DALLY NO.
GROWTH SB ONE ONE FIVE NO
GROWTH NO MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ
SB ONE ONE FIVE NO MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCKED. OR LUCK SB ONE ONE
FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. SB
ONE ONE FIVE NEWS MORALE NO
WILK. S. C. ONE ONE FIVE NINE
WILK HI. HIGHS THIRTY ONE DOES
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES LADIES
IN JOURNALISTEN IT WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
MATCHING BUDGET MATTER MUCH
TEARS APPEARED 2% BETTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE REPEAT. SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING RELATING
TO EDUCATION FINANCE AND MAKING
AN EFFORT PROCREATION THEREFORE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. SENATE
MITCHELL IS BACK. THIS IS THE
CASE YOU TWELVE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION CLEAN UP TRAILER BILL
IT PROVIDES EIGHTY MILLION A
ONE TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT
JOURNAL FUNDS TO REIMBURSE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES FOR
SCHOOL MEALS PROVIDED DURING
CALL OF IT. AND WITH REGARD TO
HIGHER READ THE BILL AUTHORIZES
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROCEED WITH STATE SUPPORTED
CAPITAL OUTLAY OUTLAY PROJECTS.
IN THE BILL ALLOWS FOR LIMITED
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND MOST CHARTERS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS. ASKING
FOR MY VOTE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR WE'RE GONNA
START WITH SENATOR MARLA GOOD
EVENING CENTER MORLOCK. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR SCHOOLDISTRICTS
WHAT THE STATE HAS AND WE FOUND
OUT THAT THE BUDGET HEARING
THAT MAYBE THE MOST THE
MAJORITY OF THEM. HAVE
DECLINING ENROLLMENTS BUT THERE
ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE GROWING
THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS. YEAH AND
THEY BENEFIT THE COMMUNITIES WE
HAVE BEN. SO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LAST WEEK AND YEAR.
SQUELCHING A SUCCESSFUL FORMULA
IS NOT GOOD LEADERSHIP- WE HAVE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS CALLS ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. IN CONCERN- ON
CAPPING FUNDING FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS I RECOMMENDED A NO VOTE
ON S. B. H. ONE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE TURNING OUR
ATTENTION TO CENTER BOARD JUST
GETTING CENTER. GOOD EVENING. I
WAS. AN ALMOST NINE OUR
LAUGHTER NINE O'CLOCK AND
PAPERS ARE STILL GETTING PUSHED
AROUND THE CAPITAL IT'S TOUGH
TO KEEP UP WITH THESE THINGS
BUT MANTO'S A QUESTION TO THE
FLOOR MANAGER OR THE BUDGETS
CHAIRPERSON. THANK YOU CENTER
GORGEOUS ONE MOMENT AT SYMMETRY
PREPARED YES HE IS- YEAH PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER BURGESS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT S. B.
EIGHT TWO ZERO RESTRICTS
CONTRACT SERVICES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
WAS THIS THE SAME BILL THAT I
BELIEVE IT WAS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ THAT WE DON'T WOULD
LAST CYCLE. IN THAT DID NOT
WORK EARLIER IN THE YEAR RATHER
AND DID NOT PASS IT IS NOT THE
EXACT SAME LANGUAGE IT DEALS
WITH SOME ASPECTS OF WHAT WAS
INCLUDING HURT HER BILL BUT IT
IS NOT THE EXACT SAME BILL NOW
SIR. ALL RIGHT. ON MY OWN TIME
I CAN'T GO DOWN I THINK I THINK
THIS IS FAIR SO THIS IS A
PROBLEM HERE. I DO APOLOGIZE
CENTER GORGEOUS I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
A MICROPHONE OPEN IF YOU DON'T.
HELLO MISTER DALLI WAS ADDED
THAT CENTER BOARD JUST PLEASE
PROCEED. YOU KNOW I- THERE IS A
REASON WHY THIS BILL DID NOT
PASS UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OPPOSED IT AND THE- MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE OPPOSED TO. AND I
THINK IT GOT CONVERTED INTO A
BUDGET BILL BUT THE LIFE WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. WHY A POLICY LIKE
THIS WOULD FIND ITS WAY TO A
BUDGET- A BUDGET BILL- I DON'T
THINK THAT IS. A GOOD PRACTICE
THE FIRST LINK- I WILL
CERTAINLY BE VOTING AGAINST
THIS AND- ENCOURAGE THOSE THAT
HAD VOTED AGAINST THE
UNIVERSITY OF CON CALIFORNIA
BILL EARLY IN THE YEAR. THEY
SHOULD TO OPPOSE THIS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT GONNA
GO TO THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE CHAIR NIELSEN.
GOOD EVENING TO PRESENT LED
THEM IN THE SENATE ARE URGING
NO VOTE. ONE OF THE ISSUES IS
INDEED THE CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND
WOVEN THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET OUR
LITTLE TWEAKS TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS. I'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO FIGURE OUT WHY PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS SO. PARANOID.
ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS EVERY
YEAR BILL AFTER BILL THEY TRIED
TO CONSTRAIN OR LIMIT OR WIPE
OUT CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THE
BIGGEST BENEFICIARY OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN THE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. AND THESE ARE ONES
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
BEEN DEMANDING MORE CHARTER
SCHOOLS. I WILL NOT COUNTENANCE
TO SUPPORT ANYTHING THAT DOES
ANYMORE. CLIPPING OF THE
WEARING YOUR ELIMINATION EITHER
COVERTLY OR OVERTLY OF OUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THE
INTERESTING THING TO ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THEY
HAVE ALWAYS JEALOUSLY PROTECTED
THERE ARE SEPARATE
CONSTITUTIONAL ECONOMY. IT
WOULD SEEM LIKE THEY ARE NOW
SEEKING THAT IF THEY ARE NOT
OPPOSING THIS BILL. I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
BUT I CANNOT SPEAK FOR THEM BUT
I DON'T LIKE IT I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
LAYS IN GERMAN THE SENATE WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE ENATOR
DOLLY THEN WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE SENATOR MELINDA
CENTER DOLLY THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SORRY
ABOUT THAT I DID NOT HAVE MY
THING ON YOU FIRST TIME. DURING
THIS WHOLE SESSION REAL QUICK I
KNOW THAT WE'RE IN A HURRY SO I
SHARE TO ABOUT CHARTERS THEY
WERE DOING. HOME SCHOOL AND
DISTANCE LEARNING WAY BEFORE
COPING AND THEY'RE REALLY GOOD
AT IT. AND SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO WENT TO THAT
IN IN TERM AND THEN THIS BILL
DOESN'T HELP THEM OUT NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO AS YOU ALL KNOW.
I PUSHED REALLY HARD TO TRY TO
GET THE A DONALD BILL. TO THE
FLOOR- LIABILITIES AND ISSUES
NOT IN HERE WHEN YOU TAKE YOUR
LIABILITY WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
ROLE PART OF THE STATE. AS SUCH
AS THE PRESIDENT HAS. AND
MYSELF. KIDS DON'T HAVE-INTERNET THEY DO THEY CAN'T
DISTANCE. THEIR SENT HOME THE
PACK. IN THEIR OWN THEIR OWN
THIS BILL NOT FAIR. AND THE
SCHOOLS CAN BRING THEIR KIDS IN
IF THEY HAD THE LIABILITY WAY
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I'LL BE
OPPOSING THIS. LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
HOLLINGS. WE'RE NOT GONNA
RECOGNIZE CENTER MELINDA CINEMA
IS A FULL RESOURCES. I THANK
YOU MISTER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE HAVE. VOTED OUT A NUMBER OF
BILLS THESE PAST FEW DAYS MANY
OF WHICH WE HAVE DISCUSSED. THE
ISSUE- AB AND GRACE AND- MAKING
SURE THAT THINGS ARE- SHARING
EVEN PLAYING FIELD. FOR
CHILDREN OF COLOR AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHEN YOU PUT A BILL
THROUGH LIKE THIS- IT HURTS
COMMUNITIES O COLOR HURT STATE
STUDENTS BECAUSE OFTENTIMES
THEY ARE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT
THEY WOULD NORMALLY GO TO. IS A
FAMILY SCHOOL- IT'S NOT AN
ADEQUATE SCHOOL FOR THE PARENTS
WHO REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CHILD HAS A BETTER
LIFE. AND HAS A CHANCE AT
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE AND THE
NUMBER ONE WAY TO DO THAT MR
EDUCATION AND A GOOD EDUCATION.
SO MANY PARENTS WERE OCT TO
CHOOSE A CHARTER SCHOOL. IN
ORDER TO ADD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING ATTAINABLE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN THIS BILL
TAKES THAT OPPORTUNITY AWAY
FROM THE VERY COMMUNITIES. THAT
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. IT
IN YOU KNOW NEARLY BILL AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW ANYBODY
WHO STANDS OUT TO. ADVOCATE TO
MAKE ALLIES WHETHER A BEAR-
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM LINES
EITHER YOU KNOW HOLD WRITING OF
LIES- THAT WE HAVE TO DISCUSS
WHETHER. IT MAKES IT MORE FAIR
FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES. WHY WOULD YOU NOT
THEN IT INSIST THAT THE
EDUCATION THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
THE STUDENTS IS ALSO A BRONZE
STANDARDS AND IS A GOOD QUALITY
EDUCATION BECAUSE THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY IS GING TO REQUIRE
THAT SOME STUDENTS OF COLOR
HAVE TO REMAIN IN A FAILING
SCHOOL AND THERE IS NO DO OVER
WITH. YOUR CHILD'S EDUCATION
YOU GET ONE SHOT AT IT AND THEN
THAT'S IT SO I WOULD URGE YOU
TO THINK ABOUT THAT AND THINK
ABOUT THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE
HAD OVER THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS
WHEN YOU'RE VOTING ON THIS BILL
PLEASE DON'T VOTE TO TAKE AWAY
A QUALITY EDUCATION FROM A
STUDENT WHO VERY MUCH NEEDS IT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
THURMOND IS THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE HAVE ANOTHER HIT UPPER GONNA
GONNA CENTER MORALE GOOD
EVENING CENTER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND I AND I WILL BE BRIEF-
I KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE BUT I
JUST HAVE TO EXPRESS ON THIS IS
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
PRODUCING RESULTS. FOR STUDENTS
AND SELF FOR THE FACT THAT
THAT- THE STATE'S DEPRIVING
THEM OF THE FUNDS THEY NEED TO
OPERATE- IF THEY'RE PENALIZING
OUR PARENTS AS WELL AS THEIR
CHILDREN BECAUSE REPLACE THEM
IN THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS WHICH
THEY ARE OUTPERFORMING- THEY
YEAH THE OTHER MODEL OF OUR OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY.
AND SO ON ANYWAY I FEEL LIKE
WHAT WE'RE DOING WAS RECOVERY
NAME OUT AGAIN ANOTHER CAR THIS
TIME IT HAS TO DO WITH OUR KIDS
THE AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND SO WE
SHOULD. BE PROMOTING A POLICY
DETAILS- FAVORITISM. TOWARDS
NINE AS I SAID THAT FOR THE
FOR. THE NUMBER THING BUT ANY
THIS. I URGE YOUR NOBLE ABOUT.
IN THE REASON WHY IS WE WANT TO
HELP- WE WANT HELP ALL CHILDREN
IN ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY HAVE WE
WANT HELP THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS
WHICH ARE OUTPERFORMING OTHER
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. HERE IN SEEN THAT
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL DEBATE
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT BACK TO
BUDGETARY TO BE A CLOSE BY TO
BUDGET YOUR- I'LL RESTATE WHAT
I SAID A LITTLE EARLIER ON THIS
BILL. ALLOWS FOR FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND MOST
CHARTERS. WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
ONE CATEGORY OF CHARTER. BILLS
TO PROVIDE NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS BUT- CHARTERS ALSO
WILL BE FUNDED FOR PLANNED
GROWTH. IN AVERAGE DAILY TO
THIS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR. I ASKED FOR MY
VOTE. LAYS IN GERMAN THE SENATE%
WE WANT TO REMIND YOU ON THESE
BUDGET BILLS WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH ONCE AND THEN CLOSE THE
ROLE IF YOU DON'T VOTE YOU
MISTER VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BELL. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE CABRERA. AYE DODD HI THE
RISER I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON.
I LEYVA. FIVE REQUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI
FIVE WIENER. HI LASING JOURNAL
THE SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION WE'RE GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY BERGEN
ASK EACH INDIVIDUAL TO BE TO
STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER
IN YOUR VOTE MATTERS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
BATES SB EIGHT TWENTY NO BATES
NO BORJAS. WE'RE JUST S. B.
EIGHT TWO ZERO NOW FOR JUST NOW
CHIANG. THANK S. B. EIGHTEEN
ZERO NOW CHIANG NO DALLY. GHALI
SB EIGHT TWO ZERO NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. SB EIGHT TWO ZERO NO
GROWTH NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ S.
B. EIGHT TWO ZERO NINE MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK WELL I GUESS WE
EIGHT TWENTY NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. WELL SB EIGHT TWENTY
MORALE BUILDING L. MORRELL NOW
WILK WILK SB EIGHT TWENTY NOW
WILK NOW. HIS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES PLEASE
ENTER THE SENATE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO OUR
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
AGAIN THIS IS AN EXERCISE FOR
MAKING SURE THAT YOU'RE ON YOUR
TOES WE'RE GONNA BE ANNOUNCING
THE NEXT FOUR ITEMS ITEM FORTY
SEVEN. ITEM FIFTY SIX IDENTITY
THREE AND ITEM. FIFTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX FIFTY
THREE FIFTY FIVE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ITEM. I OKAY. ITEM
FIFTY THREE SUSPENSE WAS WE'RE
GONNA GO FORTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE AND FIFTY SEVEN
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO WITNESS CABALLERO
SHE'S PREPARED RESENTMENT OF
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE IT READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AN
ACTUAL LEADING TO PEACE
OFFICERS. SENATE COPYWRITING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT AB TWELVE NINETY NINE
REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION WHEN MISCONDUCT
IS ALLEGED GAINST AN OFFICER
AND TO FINISH THAT
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
MISCONDUCT. EVEN IF THE OFFICER
QUITS THE FORCE BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION IS DONE. IF THE
COMPLAINTS- SUSTAIN AB TWELVE
NINETY NINE WILL REQUIRE POST
TO INCLUDE THIS INFORMATION IN
OFFICERS PROFILE SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
NOTIFIED. OF AN APPLICANT'S
PAST MISCONDUCT WHILE THEY'RE
PERFORMING A PRE EMPLOYMENT
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER CAREER
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ASKING
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR REMOTELY
WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER. TO
SENATOR JONES GOOD EVENING GOOD
AFTERNOON. MISTER PRESIDENT I'M
A CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AND
WOULD ASK FOR A AND I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING TO SENATOR DOLLY GOOD
EVENING. YOU'RE GOOD SIR. M. I.
YES NEAR ME WE'RE GOOD THANK
YOU. THAT IS WHAT TO SAY LONG
TIME COMING GREAT BILL. IT AS
RISE IN THE COUNTY WHERE
OFFICERS CAME THEY WERE BAD
EGGMAN FROM ONE DEPARTMENT TO
ANOTHER THERE'S NO WAY TO TRACK
AND THIS IS A- LONG TIME
COMING. SUPPORTERS BILL
STRONGLY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR- REMOTELY FINAL
CALL HERE IN C. NINE CENTER
COPIER CAN YOU PLEASE CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I DODD I
THE RAZA HI CAL JOHNNY HI
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI. AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I
JACKSON I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONEY I NIELSEN.
HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN
HI NUMBER FIVE AWAIT COSTI I
WIENER. HI GOING TO TRANSITION
TO THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE'RE GONNA ASK EACH
INDIVIDUAL SENATOR TO PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER
AND YOUR VOTE MADAM SECRETARY.
BATES EIGHT ABA SIXTY SIX ALL
RIGHT BATES HI. YEAH I HAVE THE
RIGHT NOW AB TWELVE NINETY NINE
SORRY HI. BATES FIVE FOR JUST.
FORGES AB TWELVE NINE NINE BY
FORAGES HI CHIANG. MAYBE CALL
NINE NINE HI CHIANG I DALY. THE
ONLY AB TWELVE NINE NINE HI
DALLY I GROWTH. AB TWELVE NINE
NINE NINE GROVE HI MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB TWELVE NINE NINE HI
MELENDEZ HI WARLOCK OR LOCK AB
TWELVE NINE NINE HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. WELL AB. TWELVE
NINE NINE. MORRELL AYE WILK.
WILK AB TWELVE NINE NINE NINE
WILK HI. IN CENTER CAN YOU
PLEASE DO US A FAVOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE BRADFORD I. BUYS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
RIGHT NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX CENTER DRESSES PREPARED
RESENTMENT OF SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRD THREE THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AN ACT
RELATING TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
GOOD EVENING SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THREE RUN ONE- TO PROVIDE
A AND REQUIRE ETHNIC STUDIES IN
HIGH SCHOOLS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA LET
LEGISLATIVE LATINO API BLACK
WOMEN'S AND LGBT CAUCUSES. AND
I WOULD SAY OUR CURRENT
GENERATION OF YOUTH AMENDMENTS
TAKEN OF THE ON THE FLOOR ART
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLEAR FIND
IN NATURE AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WE ARE BOTH. PLEASE ENJOY
LISTENING WE'RE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE REMOTELY. LOOKING FOR
ALL SENATORS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE PERRANCE NINE. MEN OF
SECTOR YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA POLLACHI I A
NO I INTERRUPTED THE ROLE I DO
SEE A HAND THAT JUST CAME UP
FROM SENATOR BURGESS I
APOLOGIZE LAYS IN GERMAN THE
SENATE IF IT'S ALL RIGHT WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
GORGEOUS CENTER BURGESS. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU BYE MAY POSE
A QUESTION TO THE FLOOR MANAGER.
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
CENTER DRAWS A CENTER DRESSER.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION.
WE'RE GONNA ASSET CENTER DRAWS
HIS MICROPHONE PLEASE BE TURNED
ON. WE NEED SENATOR DRAWS THIS
MICROPHONE PLEASE TURN ON.
SENATOR ALSO PLEASE PROCEED. I
WILL DO MY BEST THANK YOU.
CENTREBOARD JUST THANK YOU IT'S
KIND OF IN LINE WITH THE LAST
ETHNIC STUDIES BILL THAT WE HAD
AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL. IN TERMS
OF THIS REQUIREMENT AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL. IS THIS IN
ADDITION TO THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENT FOR CREDIT HOURS TO
GRADUATE OR IS IT ALREADY IS IT
WILL BE ABSORBED INTO THE
EXISTING CREDIT HOURS. IT'S
HARD I'M SORRY YOUR SURGERY AT-SOME DRESSING. IT IS A WILL BE
PART OF- WILL BE PART OF THE
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. IN
ADDITION SO IF YOU NEED A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL WILL THIS
BE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
NOW. NO OR AS I UNDERSTAND NO.
ALL RIGHT- KAMALA TEN THANK YOU
SANTA ROSA- I HAPPEN TO BE A
FAN OF. A TEAM CURRENTLY JEANS
FULL OFFER. THIS CAMPAIGN
MANDATING IT. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND STE THAT'S NEXT
STUDIES TO INCLUDE THE LAST
SERIES OF ETHNIC STUDIES THAT
WERE EXCLUDED AND OTHERS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN SO I'M
ASSUMING THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE UP TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I KNOW BE IF ANY OTHER PEOPLE
WISH TO COMMENT ON THAT- BUT I
THINK AS WE MOVE. A LOT MORE
TOWARDS VOCATIONAL AND
PRACTICAL TRAINING AND RE
INTEGRATING SHOP IN THESE OTHER
TRADES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM. I WOULD BE LEERY OF
ADDING ANY MORE REQUIREMENTS TO
GRADUATION I KNOW WITH WE'VE
HEARD THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
THAT BUT- I HAVE A FEELING THAT
SOMETHING ON YOUR BODY HAS TO
GO AWAY FOR THIS TO BE
CORPORATE IN. THAT'S WHAT
CONCERNS. BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR WE APPRECIATE
THAT SURVEYS IN GENERAL THE
SENATE WE DID START TO ROLL
CALL WHAT WE'D LIKE TO GET A
PROPOSED AT THIS TIME IS THAT
WE'D LIKE TO GO TO START THE
ROLL CALL OVER AGAIN. MADAM
SECRETARY IS GOING TO START
FROM THE BEGINNING SHE WILL
FIRST GO THROUGH THOSE WERE
PRESENT AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE PROTESTING
REMOTELY WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
ONCE AND THEY WERE GOING TO
SHUT DOWN THE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
TELL I BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. I DOUBT DODD. I TORONTO
HI HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO. HI
JACKSON AYE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI
NIELSEN BY HAND HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI AMBERG HI MY CRUSTY I WIENER.
HI WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO THROUGH THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY NAME
BILL NUMBER AND VOTE. THERE'S A
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE. WE
EXPECT YOU TO BE IN YOUR SEAT.
SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THEN WE'RE GOING TO
ASK TO BE ABLE TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WE NEED EVERYONE
IN THEIR SEAT TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE MOVE FOR WITH OUR WORK
FOR THE EVENING MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE GO TO THOSE ARE
PROTESTING REMOTELY THEY WERE
GONNA CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES BATES A. B.
THREE THIRTY ONE ABSTAINED OR
JUST. WE'RE JUST AB THREE THREE
ONE HI OR JUST HI CHIANG CHIANG
AB THREE THREE ONE HI CHIANG HI
DOLLY DALY AB THREE THREE ONE
OF STATE GROWTH. AB THREE THREE
ONE ABSTAINED OR OPPOSED NO I
GREW UP EIGHTY THREE THREE WHEN
NO NO. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB
THREE THREE ONE NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK OR UNLOCK AB THREE
THREE ONE NO. MORLOCK NO MORALE
WELL AB THREE THREE ONE EL
MORRO NO WILK. WILK AB THREE
THREE ONE FIVE WILK HI. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI. HIGHS THIRTY THREE
KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
BEIJING GERMAN OF THE SENATE.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
OUR FINAL ITEM AT THIS TIME OF
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE THEN WE'RE GONNA
START BACK WITH HER UNFINISHED
BUSINESS DOCKET. SO LET'S GO TO
ITEM FIFTY FIVE THAT SENATOR
HUESO CENTER HUESO YOU PREPARE
TO PRESENT HE IS NOT OF SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY. GOOD
EVENING CENTER HUESO. THE NEW.
THANK U. S. PRESIDENT SANDERS
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE WILL ALLOW
OUR SCHOOLS TO REPLACE
INEFFICIENT H. FAX SYSTEMS AND
WATER FIXTURES AS WELL AS
EXPEDITE THE INSTALLATION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGERS
WITHOUT- THIS BILL HAS A STRONG
EQUITY POSITION THAT MANDATE
25% OF THE FUNDS GO TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
THESE SCHOOLS HAVE FIRST
PRIORITY THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES CPUC TO QUICKLY
APPROVE UPENDED EEVEE CHARGER
APPLICATIONS AND ENSURE THEY
ARE SAFELY INSTALLED. AB FORTY
ONE WILL IMPROVE AIR QUALITY-
IN WATER QUALITY AT SCHOOLS
REDUCE SCHOOL UTILITY BILLS AND
PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU CENTER HUESO
WE LIKE TODAY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FROM THE STATE SENATE. HERING
SENIOR. MANTA SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ACTUALLY AYE ATKINS AYE FELT. I
BRADFORD I HAVE A. CABALLERO
DODD I TO RAZA. I GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HI
HILL NO WAY SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON. I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M
BURKE. WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
I. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING TOWARD TO A-
SENATOR HAVE JUST BEEN REMOTELY
IF DON'T MIND PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER AND
THE VOTE ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE NO. BATES NO
FORTUS. MERGES AB EIGHT FOUR
ONE NOW FOR JUST NO CHIANG
CHIANG AB EIGHT FOUR ONE NOW
CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI AB EIGHT
FOUR ONE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. AB%
EIGHT FOUR ONE NOW GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB EIGHT
FOUR ONE NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. OR LIKE AB EIGHT FOUR ONE
NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. WELL A.
B. EIGHT FOUR ONE ROUND NO WILK.
WELL AB EIGHT FOUR ONE. WILK
FIVE. PRICE TWENTY FIVE DOES
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES. THANKS
SO MUCH FOR YOUR COOPERATION
WERE NOW TO BE MOVING ON TO.
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ANNOUNCE OUR NEXT
FOUR FILE ITEMS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWELVE SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY LET'S START
WITH FILE ITEM TWELVE WE'RE
GONNA LOOK TO SENATOR JACKSON
SHE'S PREPARED 2% BETTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACTOR
RELATING TO EDUCATION. SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL IS
REGARDING TITLE NINE. IT IS-
RESPONSIVE TO THE ATTACKS SINCE
A STUDENT CIVIL RIGHTS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. BY OUTLINING
TRANSPARENT FAIR AND EQUITABLE
PROCESSES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
COLLEGES TO ENSURE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
INSTITUTIONS COMPLY WITH
EXISTING LAW AND PROVIDE A FAIR
PROCESS FOR ALL PARTIES TO
PROTECT THE CIVIL RIGHTS SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF STUDENTS. THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THE
INTERACTION OF THE BILL WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATIONS
THEY DELETE A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION ND MORE SPECIFICALLY
PRESCRIBE THE PROCESS. AND
PROCEDURES SCHOOLS ALREADY USE
IN ADDRESSING SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND HARASSMENT ON CAMPUS I'M
PROUD TO SAY WITH RECENT
AMENDMENTS THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. AND CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT SCHERING THE GOAL OF AN
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO EDUCATION
FOR ALL STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ON
CONCURRENCE IN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. SENATORS WE HAVE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
ALL SENATORS FINAL CALL. SCENE
IN HARRY NINE BETTER SURGERY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BELL AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I DODD. HI TERRAZZO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
HI HUESO. HI HER TADO I JACKSON
AYE LEYVA I REQUIRE I MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME. I NIELSEN. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER
FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER. HI
PLEASE JOURNALISTS WE'RE NOT
GONNA TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TO
PLEASE ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME THE
BILL NUMBER AND THE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY'S KALRA. FAKES BATES
SP FOUR NINETY THREE NO BATES
NO. FOR JUST FORGES SB FOUR
NINE THREE NOW FOR JUST NO
CHIANG. CHIANG SB FOUR NINE
THREE I'D CHANG AYE DALY. L. A.
S. B. FOUR NINE THREE NO. TALLY
NO GROWTH. SB FOUR NINE THREE
NOW GROVE NO MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ SP FOUR NINE THREE NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. SB FOUR
NINE THREE HELLO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. WELL SB FOUR NINE THREE
NO MORALE NO WILK. SB FOUR NINE
THREE HI WILK HI. HIGHS THIRTY
ONE KNOWS. EIGHT THE MEASURES
TAKEN CURTAIN WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
SYNERON. THOROUGHNESS REPAIR TO
PRESENT MANUFACTURING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL OUR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY GOOD EVENING CENTER
OWNED YEAH MEMBERS THIS CREATES
AN ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
PROJECT PROGRAM FOR A SPECIFIC
TRANSIT PROJECTS TO GIVE
EXPEDITED REVIEW UNDERSUPPLY
DOES NOT IT'S NOT IT'S A GOOD
EXEMPTION IT GIVES EXPEDITED
REVIEW THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT
HAVE TO BE VERY HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS. ON A
LOT OF LEVELS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY VOTE. WHAT
IS IN GERMAN TO HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR AND OR PERSISTING
REMOTELY. CURRENCY NINE MENTOR.
CENTER BURGESS. I JUST WANTED
TO WORKING GRADUALLY TO MY- MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IT SEEMS AS IF
QUITE A FEW FOLKS ARE
APPRECIATING THE IMPORTANCE OF
SECRET STREAMLINING SEQUEL
REFORM CYCLIC TENSION SO I
THINK THERE'S A TREND IN THE
CYCLE AND I HOPE IT CONTINUES
NEXT YEAR AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE REMOTELY
OR ON THE FLOOR. C. NINE SENT
AROUND YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
TAKE A. HOPE CENTER LIKE WE SAW
EIGHT WE DESCENDED CENTER
ALLEN'S CLOSE WE DID SEE YOUR
HAND GO UP CENTER MORLOCK DO
YOU NEED TO COME IN ON THIS WE
WHERE YOU CENTER LEGISLATORS
CLOSE ALL TURN OVER YOU CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU ARE. MISTER
PRESIDENT I JUST GET CONCERNED
ABOUT BILLS THAT. PROVIDE
STREAMLINING OR EXEMPTIONS FOR
SOME WHEN WE NEED TO DO IT FOR
ALL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU. IT'S GOING TO BE A
FINAL CALL FOR DISCUSSION OF A
FINAL CALL. HERE IN C. ON
REMOTELY AND OR HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS CENTER ALLEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ONE FINAL TIME
SEQUENCE IS THERE TO PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT FOR THOSE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE HIGH
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS THEY
DESERVES SPECIAL TREATMENT
PLEASE. VOTE I. METACENTRIC YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE WELL.
I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. I DODD
I TORONTO I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
I WAS SO. I HER TADO I JACKSON.
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL I
MONEY. HI NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M BURKE I
REQUEST YOU AYE WIENER. HI WE
KNOW THAT TO BETTER TRANSITION
TO THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
IF YOU COULD PLEASE SAY YOUR
NAME BILL NUMBER AND VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. FACE. SURVEY
TYPOLOGIES IF YOU DON'T MIND ON
MEETING YOURSELF. THERE WE GO.
BATES SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ALL
RIGHT BATES HI GORGEOUS. WE'RE
JUST SB SEVEN BY SEVEN ON FOR
JUST FIVE CHIANG K. S. B. SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN I CHIANG MAI DALI.
DALI S. B. SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN HI
DALLY HI GROW YEP THAT'S RIGHT
SORRY. CENTER GROVE. S. C. M.
I'M SORRY COULD YOU GET I WAS
DEALING WITH OTHER ISSUES I
APOLOGIZE CAN GIVEN THE BILL
NUMBER NO THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON IT'S ALL GOOD THIS IS A FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN. A GROUP SB SEVEN BY
SEVEN NINE. GROVE ALL RIGHT.
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ SB SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN AM STAYING. MORLOCK
WELL I GUESS YOU SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN ABSTAINED MORAL. MORRELL
SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN OBTAIN.
WILK. SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ALL
RIGHT WILDER HI SIR WILL DO YOU
MIND A SENIOR AT YOUR NAME IN
YOUR VISION I APOLOGIZE SIR.
NOT A PROBLEM SIR WILK SB SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN HI WILL GUY. THANK
YOU CENTER APOLOGIZE. LASERJET
OF THE SENATE I IS THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO EMISSIONS IN CONCORD
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
TO AYE FILE ITEM NINETEEN FIVE
TO NINETEEN IT'S AN ARTILLERY
GOOD EVENING SENATOR BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE BY
SENATOR ARE. AND RELATING TO
PRIVACY SENATOR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY AND IN THAT RESENT SENATE
BILL NINE OH FIVE WHICH IS BACK
FROM THE ASSEMBLY. ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT PRIVACY VOLUNTEERS IN
SCHOOLS DURING THE TIME WHEN WE
NEED VOLUNTEERS. MORE THAN
EVER. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY WERE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR OR FOR
THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR OF THOSE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. THIS IS GOING TO BE
OUR FINAL CALL FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. HAVING SEEN NINE
MINUTES SURGERY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BELL I
BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE DODD
HI THE RISING. HI COUNTY ANI
FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE FURTADO AYE JACKSON AYE
LEYVA. I REQUIRE I MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN HI NUMBER I
WORK CLOSELY AYE WIENER HI
MESSAGES CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI. WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE TRANSITIONING TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR YOUR NAME BILL
NUMBER INFO MADAM SECRETARY.
SPACEX BATES SB NINE OH FIVE
ABSTAINED GORGEOUS. YES BATES
BORCHERS AS THREE NINE OH FIVE
ABSTAINED CHIANG. SB NINE OH
FIVE FIVE CHIANG HI DALLI DALLI
ESPINO FIVE STATE. GROWTH.
GROUP SB NINE OH FIVE NO GROVE
NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB NINE
OH FIVE NO MELENDEZ NO. MORLOCK
MORE- LIKE SB NINE OH FIVE
ABSTAINED. MORRELL. MORRELL SB
NINE OH FIVE NO MORALE NO WILK.
WILK SP NINE OH FIVE ABSTAINED.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS THREE
THE MEASURES CONCURRED. WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE TWENTY CENTER
PORTANTINO CENTER PORTANTINO'S
PREPARED IS IT PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATED TO FIREARMS CENTER
PORTANTINO GOOD EVENING. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
SB NINE FOURTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH CHAPTER RING
OUT AMENDMENTS AND DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE FROM ALL
SENATORS. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FINAL CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. XENON MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELL FIVE BRADFORD HI CABRERA I
DODD HI TERRAZZA. HI GALGIANI I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO I JACKSON AYE LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. HI MITCHELL HI MY NAME.
I NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI NUMBER ALL
RIGHT HI MY COUNTY AYE WIENER.
HI LADIES IN GERMAN THE SENATE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE'S
TRANSITIONING TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WOULDN'T
MIND CAN YOU PLEASE SAY YOUR
NAME BILL NUMBER IN THE VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES BATES SB
NINE ONE FOUR NO FACE NO FOR
JUST. OR JUST SB NINE ONE FOUR
NOW FOR AGES NO CHIANG.
CHINASKI NINE ONE FOUR NOW
CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI S. B.
NINE ONE FOUR NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. SB NINE WENT FOR NO
GROWTH NO MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ
SB NINE ONE FOUR NO MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. S. FEED NINE ONE
FOUR NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
MORRELL SP NINE ONE FOR NOW
MARONE NO WELL. SB NINE ONE
FOUR NO WILK NOW I TWENTY NINE
KNOWS. TEN THE- S. SECOND THANK
YOU SO MUCH I NEED TO SHOW.
LITURGY NOT BE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO I'D LIKE TO BE
TO ANNOUNCE OUR NEXT. FIVE
MEASURES OUR NEXT FIVE MEASURES
WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO. FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY EIGHT
AND REPEAT ONCE. FILE ITEMS
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
EIGHT WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO WE'RE
GONNA SAY GOOD EVENING TO
CENTER HER TITLE. SIR CENTER
CENTER TIDO IT MY LAST. BIT OF
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CENTER TOTAL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GREEN MISTER
PRESIDENT SB NINE SEVEN FOUR IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND A SUNSET
INCLUDE SMALL STATE WATER
SYSTEM TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. I RESPECT LAST NIGHT-
THANK YOU CENTER TADO WOULD
LIKE TODAY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
REMOTELY. WE'RE GONNA DO A
FINAL CALL SENATORS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FINAL CALL. AARON
SEEN NINE MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I FELL.
I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI DODD.
HI TORONTO HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI HILL I HUESO. I HER TADO I
JACKSON. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN. I
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN AYE
NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER
HI. MADAM SECRETARY I BELIEVE
WE NEED TO CALL. ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE IN
PERSON. RUBIO HI. THERE IS A
GENERAL SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR THE NAME BILL
NUMBER IN VOTE MADAM SECRETARY.
BATES. EIGHT SB NINE SEVENTY
FOUR NO EIGHT NOW FOR JUST. OR
JUST SB NINE SEVEN FORD STAYING.
CHIANG SB NINE SEVEN FOUR AYE
CHANG AYE DALY. L. A. S. B.
NINE SEVEN FOUR HI DALY HI
GROWTH. SB NINETY SEVEN FOR AYE
GROVE AYE MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ
SB NINE SEVEN FOUR NO MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. SB NINE ONE FOUR
ABSTAINED. BUT I PUBLIC GENESIS
INTERLOCK- IT'S A IF WE GO BACK
TO CENTER MORLOCK INSTEAD OF
NINE ONE FOUR TWO NINE SEVEN
FOUR I APOLOGIZE IF YOU DON'T
MIND JUST. REPEATING ONE MORE
TIME SIR. MISTER PRESIDENT
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT I
APOLOGIZE WARLOCK SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR ABSTAINED THANK YOU.
MORRELL WHAT A GREAT JOB MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. YES MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU- MORALE SB
NINETY FOUR NOW. MORALE NO WILK.
SB NINE SEVEN FOUR HI WILK HI.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR HILL STREET
THE ASSEMBLY MINISTER CONCURRED
IN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE MORE THAN
GOING TO BE TAKING FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT AND 302-324-2520 EIGHT
AND THIRTY CENTER AMBERG IS
PREPARED PERCENT. OF SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
NINE EIGHTY BY SENATOR UMBERG
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY GOOD
EVENING CENTER AMBER THANK YOU
SB NINETY MINUTES CLARIFY
DEFINITIONS PROTECT CRITICAL
IMPRINT RE RE RESEARCH ENSURE
CONSUMERS ARE KEPT SAFE BUT I.
THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER. LET IN
GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO BE SEEN
IF THERE'S ANY TO OR DEBATE ALL
SENATORS DISK OR TO. FINAL CALL
ALL SENATORS TO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. HEARING SEEN ON MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS I FELL FIVE BRADFORD AYE
CABRERA AYE DODD FIVE THE
RISING. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HI
HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO. I
JACKSON AYE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY BYE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE PAN I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN AYE NUMBER HI
QUICO SKI I WIENER. I. WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE TRANSITION TO
THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
THE NAME BILL NUMBER INVOLVED
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES. EIGHT
SB NINE EIGHTY ALL RIGHT BATES
FIVE FOR JUST. BORDERS NINE
EIGHTY I FOR JUST HI CHIANG. SB
NINE EIGHTY I HANG ON DALLY
DALLI S. NINE EIGHTY HI. SALLY
I GROWTH. SB NINE EIGHTY I
GROVER AYE. I'M SORRY MADAM
MADAM LEADER WE JUST CA GOT
CLIPPED A LITTLE BIT IF YOU
DON'T MIND JUST EIGHTY NINE SO
SORRY IF YOU DON'T MIND IS
SITTING THAT OVER AGAIN ONE
MORE TIME. SB NINE EIGHTY I.
THINK YOU LATER GROVE. GROVE HI
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB NINE
EIGHTY HI MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK
MORE LIKE SB NINE EIGHTY HI
MORE LOCK HI GIRL. MORRELL S.
B. NINE EIGHTY HI CORONA AYE
WILK. WILL THIS BE NINE EIGHTY.
WILK HI. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MINISTER CONCURRED IN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR CENTER SKINNER IS PREPARED
TO PRESENT MEADOW SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO REAL
PROPERTY. THANK YOU SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE MODIFIES HER FOR
CLOSURE AUCTIONS ARE HELD TO
PRESERVE OWNER OCCUPIED HOME
OWNERSHIP PROVISIONS- FOR THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE THEM SUNSET IN
FIVE YEARS AFTER I GO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ALL SENATORS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. AARON SEEN ON MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS I FELT I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DOT. HI TORONTO. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON
AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL
I MONEY I NIELSEN NO HAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO
AYE SKINNER HI STERN HI NUMBER
I REQUEST YOU I WIENER I.
ARCHULETA I'D. PLEASE ENTER THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE SAY YOUR NAME BILL
NUMBER AND THE VOTE. THIS IS
BATES SB TEN SEVENTY NINE NO.
PLEASE NOW FOR JUST FORGE'S SP
TEN SEVEN NINE NOW FOR JUST NO
CHIANG K. S. B. TEN SEVEN TEN
SEVENTY NINE NOW CHIANG NO
DALLI DALLI SP TEN SEVENTY NINE
NO. DALLY NO GROWTH GROWTH SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE NO ROAD NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ S. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. A SPEECH IN SEVENTY
NINE NO MORE LOCK NO MORAL.
WELL SB TEN SEVENTY NINE NOW
MORALE NO. WILK WELL SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE HI WILK HI. LACING
GENTLEMEN HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
CONCURRED IN WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TAKE CARE SOME HOUSEKEEPING
HERE QUICKLY WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT AND THIRTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT AND THIRTY
WILL THEN BE TAKING UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE FILE I'M TWENTY FIVE IS
CENTER MONEY NEEDS PREPARE TO
PRESENT. BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
OH TWO BY SENATOR MINING AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT GOOD
EVENING CEREMONY. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I STAND TO
PRESENT MY FINAL BILL TO THE
SENATE. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU IT'S BEEN AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE SERVING WITH ALL OF
YOU. I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN CONCURRENCE ON S. B.
ELEVEN OH TWO. AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE CLARIFYING
IN NATURE I URGE FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
SERVING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH DISTINCTION AND HONOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR MONEY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR OR- VIA REMOTE LEADER
GROVE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE ON A TIME
CRUNCH BUT I COULD NOT LET THIS
OPPORTUNITY GO BY. WITHOUT
TELLING SENATOR MONEY THAT IT
HAS BEEN AN OUTSTANDING
PLEASURE TO SERVE WITH YOU EVEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND THEN
MOVING TO THE SENATE YOU ARE
LIKE OUR DEAN OF THE STUDENT H.
R. DEAN OF THE SENATE A TRUE
STATESMAN AND- I APPRECIATE
YOUR HONESTY OR INTEGRITY AND
WHO YOU ARE AS A GENTLEMAN SO
THANK YOU SIR FOR ALL THAT YOU
DO. AND WE WISH YOU NOTHING BUT
THE BEST AS YOU AND HAVE FUTURE
ENDEAVORS AHEAD OF YOU. WELL
SAID LEADER GROVE. FINAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THE MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU LEADER GROW AND AGAIN
BECAUSE- I LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE COLLABORATION ON ALL
FRONTS. GOD SPEED GOOD HEALTH
THANK YOU. BETTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I DON.
THERE ARE SO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL I MONEY. I NIELSEN.
FIVE PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH
HI RUBIO. I SKINNER FIVE STERN.
I NUMBER RIGHT I MY COUNTY I
WIENER HI. PLEASE IN GENERAL
THIS WE'RE GONNA I UNDERSTAND
TO LAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GONNA CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS WERE GONNA CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE ALL THOSE ARE IN
THE CHAMBERS WERE GONNA ASK
THOSE RUNNING CHAMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY. TIME IS
OF THE ESENCE MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD HI. HER TADO.
THAT'S IT. NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TRANSITION TO
THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF
YOU COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME BILL NUMBER IN YOUR PHONE.
MADAM SECRETARY. DATE BATES S.
B. ELEVEN OH TWO NO BATES NOW
FOR JUST. WE'RE JUST B. ELEVEN
OH JUNE FOR JUST NOW CHIANG. SB
ELEVEN OH TWO NOW CHIANG NO
DALLY. NOW S. B. ELEVEN OH TWO
NO VALLEY NOW GROWTH. AND
GRILLED I LIVE IN NEW TWO SKEWS
ME MADAM PRESIDENT GUIDE-
MISTER PRESIDENT GROVE ELEVEN
OH TWO NOW GROWTH NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ S. B. ONE ONE ZERO TWO
NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK HELLO
YOU BILL MONEY. S. B. MORE LIKE
SB ONE A ONE OH TWO NO.
MOORLACH NO BROWN. BURLESQUE
FEEL OH TWO NOW MORRELL NO WELL.
WILK S. B. ELEVEN OH TO HAVE A
VERY RELUCTANT NO WILK NOW.
PLEASE IN GERMAN OF THE FINAL
VOTE FOR ITS FINAL PRESENTATION
CENTRE MONEY HIS TWENTY KNOWS
TEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE INCURRED
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
MONEY. LADIES ANGELES INTO
REMOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY FILE ITEM TWENTY TO
SENATOR ALSO FILE ITEM TWENTY
TO CENTER DRIVE SO SHE'S
PREPARED TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO TENANCY GOOD EVENING SENATOR
RUSSELL. HI. THE SB LIVE A
NINETEEN WOULD CODIFY RELOOK
PROTECTIONS FOR VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES AND FAMILY
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS WITHIN THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS FOLLOWING A
CRIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BIBLE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE REMOTELY ALL SENATORS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HEARING
SEEN NINE FINAL CALL NINE OF
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS  TELL I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD HI THE RAZA.
HI CAL JOHNNY. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG HI HILL
AYE HUESO. HER TADO HI JACKSON
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL I MONEY. I NIELSEN. NO
HAN. HI PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN HI
I'M BURKE RIGHT HI MY COUNTY I
WIENER I. MAN OF SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE. GALGIANI HUESO. WE'RE NOT
GONNA TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
THE BILL NUMBER AND YOUR VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES BATES S.
B. ELEVEN NINETY NO NO GORGEOUS.
WORKERS SB ELEVEN NINETY NOW
FOR JUST NOTE CHIANG SB ELEVEN
NINETY NO CHIANG NO DALLI DALLI
SP ELEVEN NINETY NO DALLY NO
GROWTH GROW THIS THE ELEVEN
NINETY KNOWN GROVE NO MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ SB ELEVEN NINETY NO
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOST OR LOCKED
AWAY SB ELEVEN NINETY NO MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. SB ELEVEN
NINETY NOW MORRELL NO WILK. SB
ELEVEN NINETY YOU KNOW WILK NO.
HIS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN
DECEMBER IN AN UNCERTAIN
CURTAIN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO FINAL FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP OUR FIRST OF
TWO CONSENT CALENDARS HERE FOR
THE EVENING SOLEIL'S IN GERMAN
THAT'S MOVED TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY THAT SENATOR JACKSON
CENTER JACKSON'S PREPARED TO
PRESENT. MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
TWELVE OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
JACKSON AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH FACILITIES GOOD EVENING
CENTER JACKSON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT S. B. TWELVE OH SEVEN
THIS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
IS A BILL THAT INSURERS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS. BY REQUIRING
THESE FACILITIES MAINTAIN
NINETY SIX HOURS OF BACKUP
POWER IN THE EVENT OF A POWER
OUTAGE RESULTING FROM AN
EMERGENCY NATURAL DISASTER OR
PUBLIC SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICE.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A PS PS.
RECENT AMERICA AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE CLEAN ENERGY IS AN
OPTION FOR BACKUP POWER AND ADD
FLEXIBILITY WHICH EXIST IN
FEDERAL REGULATION TO ALLOW FOR
OFF SITE FUEL STORAGE IS NEEDED
WITH THE FIRES THAT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
OUR SENIORS WHO OTHERWISE WILL
BE PUT IN HARM'S WAY WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
DISCUSSION- BUT DEBATE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE NO WAY FORWARD
WITH CENTER MELINDA'S YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR SENATOR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I GUESS I HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR AND I
HEARD HER SAY WHAT THE
AMENDMENT STEP I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WERE NO
CHANGES MADE TO THIS BILL THAT
WOULD IDENTIFY AS SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THESE UPGRADE IS
THAT CORRECT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE REGULATORS- I APOLOGIZE AND
RELIGIOUS DID YOU WANT TO
FINISH. I THINK YOU I'M SORRY
MISTER BYRD I JUST- WANTED TO
ASK A QUESTION- I'M THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THE- WERE THERE ANY
CHANGES TO THE BILL THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY. THE SOURCE OF
FUNDING- FOR THESE UPGRADES.
AND RESENT THANK YOU SENATOR
ORGAN TURNOVER CENTER JACKSON
YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION FROM SEN
CERTAINLY. THERE ARE THERE ARE
NO PUBLIC FUNDING SOURCES THESE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PROVIDED BY
THE NURSING HOME FACILITIES.
OKAY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
I MY OWN TIME I. WANT TO
REITERATE. SOMEONE THE
DISCUSSION WE HAD PRIOR-
PREVIOUSLY ON THIS BILL THAT
THIS COULD BE A VERY COSTLY
ENDEAVOR. FOR THESE FACILITIES-
AND I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO COME UP THE
FINALS. TO PAY FOR THIS. I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE ADEQUATE SOURCE
OF POWER BUT I WORRY THAT WE'RE
GOING WE MAY BE PUTTING SOME OF
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T COMPLY. WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT WE ARE
NOW PUTTING ON THEM AND I.
CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER IF
THERE'S- ANOTHER WAY WE CAN.
SATISFY THIS NEED SO FOR THESE
REASONS I WILL BE PUTTING THAT
THINKING IS PRESENT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER MELENDEZ. WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. FINAL CALL FOR ALL
SENATORS. HARRY NINETEEN NINE
CENTER JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- YES THANK YOU MOST OF
THESE FACILITIES ARE ALREADY
UNDER FEDERAL GUIDELINES WHICH
TO ALREADY REQUIRE THE NINETY
SIX HOURS SO THESE. NURSING
HOMES HAVE BEEN. COMPLYING
THEY'VE BEEN REQUIRED TO DO SO
THE SIMPLY ADD STATE FUNDED OR
STATE PROGRAMS STATE FACILITIES
WHICH- ARE DO NOT HAVE. THOSE
SAME REQUIREMENTS IN FACT THEY
REQUIRE ONLY SIX HOURS- WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS INADEQUATE IN
TODAY'S WORLD AND SO- WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. OF OUR SENIORS WITH
THIS MEASURE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER JACKSON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE IF YOU'RE
PARTICIPATING IN THE CHAMBERS
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THIS
WILL BE OUR FINAL BILL. BUT IF
YOU MISSED THE VOTE. WE WILL
CALL IT A SECOND TIME THIS IS
GOING TOBE THE FINAL BILL.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO. FROM HERE
ON OUT AFTER THIS BILL. WE'RE
GONNA CALL THE ROLL ONCE IF
YOU'RE NOT PRESENT IN YOU DID
NOT VOTE YOU WILL MISS THE
VOTE. SO FINAL BILL WILL CALL
THE TO THE ROLE TWICE MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
TELL I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
AYE DODD. HI THE RAZA. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
HI HER TADO I JACKSON. I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME I NIELSEN NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN HI I'M BURKE HI
REQUEST YOU AYE WIENER. I.
SECRETARY CAN WE PLEASE
TRANSITION TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
THE BILL NUMBER AND YOUR VOTE
MATTER SECTOR. BATES BATES SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN HI BATES FIVE
FORGES. ORIGINS HAS BEEN FORM
SEVEN R. BURGESS HI CHIANG. SB
COLO TWELVE OH SEVEN ARE CHIANG
AYE DALY. L. A. S. B. TWELVE SO
HI SALLY HI GROWTH. SB TWELVE A
SEVEN I GROVE HI MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ SB TWELVE SEVEN
ABSTAINED MORLOCK WELL I GUESS
THE TWELVE OH SEVEN HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORAL. SB TWELVE OH SEVEN
ON BROWN HI WILK. WELL GUESS
SPEECH WELCOME SEVEN NINE WILK
HI. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ONE THE ASSEMBLY MINISTER
CONCURRED IN. NOW CAN BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THEIR CONSENT
CALENDAR WE'RE GOING TO BE
TRANSITIONING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES WILL BE
PLACED ON TODAY'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. SB SIXTY
EIGHT NUMBER FOUR. IT SB ONE
FORTY SIX NUMBER SIX SB TWO ONE
FOUR NUMBER EIGHT SB FOUR OH
SIX NUMBER TEN SB EIGHT SIX
NINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB NINE
FORTY NUMBER TWENTY ONE SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX NUMBER TWENTY
SIX SB. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN SB NINE SIX
NUMBER TWENTY NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. 681-406-2144. OH
SIX EIGHT SIXTY NINE NINE FORTY
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX ELEVEN FORTY
EIGHT AND SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETY SIX. ALL SENATORS IS
THEIR OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. HEARING
SEEN NINE NINE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO. THE CONTENT COUNTER IS
ADOPTED THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE FILE IEM THIRTY ONE
THAT SENATOR UMBERG SOONER
UNPREPARED TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY BY
SENATOR ON BURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS
WELCOME BACK CENTRE NUMBER.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS VOTE I.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS THERE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
REMOTE. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FINAL CALL. HEARING SEEN NINE
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I TELL AYE BRADFORD. BY
ADAM I DODD I THE RISE. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HURTADO AYE JACKSON AYE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING I NIELSEN. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER HI
MY COUNTY HI WIENER HI WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING TO OUR
SENATORS ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY MANUFACTORY. YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MERCURY
MINE EACH OF THE SENATORS TO
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME THE
BILL NUMBER IN YOUR PHONE METAM
SECTOR. FAKES EIGHT SB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX I. I'M SO SORRY.
MADAM THAT MEASURE SENATOR IT'S
TWELVE TWENTY WERE- CALLING ON
SB TWELVE TWENTY TWO SORRY NO
YOU'RE GOOD DON'T. PROVIDED ON
THE WRONG PAGE YOU GUYS SORRY
SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE. I'M SO
SORRY CENTER BATES AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO BE PAYING WOULD YOU
MIND IS SAYING YOUR NAME.
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
BATES I APOLOGIZE MADAM
SECRETARY. FACE HI GORGEOUS.
WE'RE JUST S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
NINE. GORGEOUS HIGH CHIANG
CHIANG SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
CHIANG HI DALLI. DALLI S. B.
TWELVE TWENTY I SALLY HI ROSE.
SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE GROW BY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ SB TWELVE
TWENTY NO MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK
WELL I GUESS FEET TWELVE TWENTY
BY MORLOCK HIGH MORAL. WE'RE L.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY OBSCENE.
WILK. WELL S. B. TWELVE TWENTY.
WILK HI. HIGHS THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE ASSEMBLY MINISTER
CONCURRED IN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING TO YOUR
SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
ONE WE'RE MOVING TO THE SENATE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER ONE
WE'RE GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE
NEXT TWO BILLS THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE TAKING THE NEXT TWO BILLS
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD
ON THE SENATE SETTLEMENT OF
FILE NUMBER ONE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT AND FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE. CENTER
JACKSON IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SENATE
JACKSON FOR AN UNDERSECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR JACKSON
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WELCOME BACK CENTER.
THANK YOU AND IN THIS IS ALSO
MY LAST BILL. DURING THE
FOURTEEN YEARS I HAVE BEEN
HONORED TO SERVE IN THIS
INSTITUTION. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF OUR WORK
HAS BEEN TO PROVIDE THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT AND I RISE TO
PRESENT S. B. ONE EIGHTY TWO
FOR CONCURRENCE IN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THIS IS A MEASURE
OF THE CALLS FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PLANNING IN WILDFIRE
AREAS MY DISTRICT HAS. SUFFERED
A NUMBER OF WILDFIRES OVER THE
PAST TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS AND I
PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN EVACUATED
NO FEWER THAN THREE TIMES
MYSELF AND WITH RECOGNITION
THAT ONE OF THE PRIMARY ROLES
OF GOVERNMENT IS THE PROTECTION
AND THE SAFETY OF ITS PEOPLE
I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THIS AS MY FINAL BILL.
WHICH HAS BEEN MADE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT BY THE WILDFIRES THAT
WE ARE EXPERIENCING. ANNUALLY
AND ALMOST MONTHLY FRANKLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT NO NEW DEVELOPMENT
IN OUR VERY HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS WILL BE APPROVED WITHOUT
CRITICAL COMMUNITY DESIGN HOME
HARDENING AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE STANDARDS AS A CENTRAL
FEATURES OF THAT DEVELOPMENT
PLAN. IT ALSO ENSURES A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH COMMUNITIES
CURRENTLY AND VERY HIGH FIRE
RISK START THE PROCESS OF
RETROFIT PLANNING AND THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES INCORPORATE
WILDFIRE SAFETY INTO THEIR LONG
TERM PLANNING THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT HAS BEEN. HARD FOUGHT AND
IF FOR SOME RECALL WE HAD A
VERY VERY INTENSE AND ROBUST
DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR. ENTER TO
WIN NOW I'M HONORED TO SAY FROM
SAN FRANCISCO IS NOW A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS MORE MEMORIALIZED IN
AGREEMENT. MADE EARLIER THIS
YEAR WITH THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- AND IT'S TRIGGER THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO PUSH THE
TIMELINE BACK BY A YEAR FOR
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT ITS
PROVISIONS THIS MEASURE TRUST
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY WITH THE
STRONG MAJORITY IN NO NO VOTE.
WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE IN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS SENATE JACKSON THANK
YOU FOR SERVING WITH SUCH
DISTINCTION TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CLIFORNIA WE'VE
BEEN HONORED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH YOU- WE'RE GONNA NOW BE
TURNING OVER ABSOLUTE. WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING. FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SAID DAHLE GETTING.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR WE WAS LAST YEAR WE DID.
THERE WAS A COUPLE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE SOME DISAGREEMENTS
ABOUT AND ONE OF THOSE BILLS
WAS NGUYEN IN SB NINE A ONE.
THERE'S A FIVE WEEK WE TALKED
ABOUT MAKING URE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE CONSERVATION EASEMENTS.
ACTUALLY DO LAND MEASURE ON IT
AND- WELL THIS BILL THAT THE
SENATE DID NOT HAVE THAT IN IT
AND WHEN IT CAME BACK. IT HAD
IN IT LAST YEAR WE NEGOTIATED
IT OUT BUT I CAN SEE THAT TO.
MY FRIENDS THAT HAVE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS THE
DON'T WANT TO MAJOR LAND IS ONE
OF LOCK IT UP AND LET IT BURN
MABEL TO PUT AN AMENDMENT IN
THIS BILL. IT'S REALLY
FRUSTRATING BACK TO THE TO. THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM NAPA AND- LOT
OF US WORKING REALLY DILIGENTLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE THAT
ARE TAKING OUR TAX DOLLARS.
WITH LIKE A WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND BUYING
UP EASEMENTS ON LAND ARE NOT
MANAGING. AND THOSE WHO ARE THE
BEST YOU HAVE NEIGHBORS. THEIR
NEIGHBORS EACH PIECE OF
PROPERTY IT'S NOT FAIR. WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP OUR LAND SAFE AS
PEOPLE THAT HAVE CONSERVATION
IS ON AND THAT THE TAXPAYERS
ARE PAYING FOR OUR MANAGER LAN
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT A
MOMENT CAME IN THIS BILL. AND
IT'S JUST REALLY NOT RIGHTS SO
I JUST WANNA SHARE THAT DID
COME BACK WITH SOME IMAGES
THAT. ARE NOT GOOD SO I'LL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HOLLINGS.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR FINAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM ALL
SENATORS FINAL DISCUSSION. AND
DEBATE FROM ALL SENATORS.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER
JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO. YES
THANK YOU THERE IS. VERY MUCH
WORK TO DO IN CALIFORNIA AND
ALL THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AS A
RESULT OF THE CHANGING CLIMATE
IN THE INCREASING SEVERITY OF
WILDFIRES. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE IN THAT BATTLE. AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. MADAM
SECRETARY ONE FINAL TIME CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE
BELL I BRADFORD I COVER IT
CABALLERO. HI THERE ARE DODD. I
DURAZO I GALGIANI HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL HI MY NAME I NIELSEN.
FIVE TEN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER HI. LAYS IN GERMAN THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE SENATORS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY. FACE SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO BABIES NO NO FORTUS. SIR
JACKSON IT WAS AN HONOR SERVING
WITH YOU. S. B. ONE EIGHT TWO
FOUR JUST ABSTAINED. K. HANG SB
ONE EIGHT TWO HI CHIANG HI
SALLY. I'M SO SORRY CENTER
DOLLY IF YOU DON'T MIND TAKING
YOURSELF OFF FROM YOU. GALLEY
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO. NO DALLY NO.
GROVE ED GROWTH SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB ONE EIGHT TWO NO
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK CENTER
JACKSON WARLOCK S. B. ONE EIGHT
TWO ABSTAINED. MORRELL HELLO SB
ONE EIGHT TWO NOW MORRELL NO
WILK. GO RIGHT AHEAD CENTER
WILL. YEAH YOU GUYS ARE PLAYING
WITH THE BUTTONS YOU DON'T TEST
MY BUTTON S. WILK SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO HI WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY TWO
NOTES FIVE THE ASSEMBLY
MINISTER CONCURRED IN. THANK WE
HAVE BEEN DOING WERE. KEEPING
YOU ON YOUR TOES THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO SENATOR JACKSON ONCE
AGAIN WE'RE GONNA NOW GO TO SAY
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM ET IN YOUR- SUPPLEMENTAL
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY ONE WE'RE GONNA GO
TO EIGHTY AND THEN EIGHTY ONE I
KNOW WE'RE JUMPING AROUND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. LAYS
IN GERMAN RATCHET WERE MAKING
SURE YOU'RE AWAKE AS- BERNIE UP
HERE'S ABOUT THE THROAT PAIN IN
MY HEAD. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FILE IEM SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY
AND EIGHTY ONE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY AND EIGHTY
ONE. THE MAJORITY LEADERS
PREPARE TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ACT RELATING TO PRISONERS THIS
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT OF. THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S ALTER THE
COMPOSITION OF THE CALIFORNIA
RICHARD COMMISSION ASTRONOMICAL.
LASING GENTLEMAN ON THE FLOOR
AND PARTICIPATING REMOTELY DO
IN DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FINAL CALL
HERE IN SEEN ON MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BELL I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DODD HI THE RAZA I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL FIVE MINING I NIELSEN.
PAN I PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI MY COUNTY HI WIENER HI
WE'RE NOT GNNA TRANSITION TO
THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
NAMED BILL NUMBER AND VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES SB THREE
SIXTY NINE ABSTAINED. FOR JUST.
SB THREE SIX NINE ABSTAINED.
CHIANG TANG SB THREE SIX NINE
I'D CHIANG I DALLY. ALI SB
THREE SIX NINE OF STATE. GROSS
GROVE SPM THREE SIX NINE AND
STAYING. MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB
THREE SIX NINE NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK WELL I GUESS WE THREE
SIX NINE HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE
YES MORALE SB THREE SIX NINE
NOW MORRELL NO WILK. WILK SP
THREE SIX NINE NINE WILK HI.
SIZE THIRTY TWO KNOWS TO THE
ASSEMBLY LIMITS ARE CONCURRED
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA ROLL TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE VIOLATE A MEDIA
CENTER GALGIANI IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT MATTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR GALGIANI
AN ACT RELATING TO VITAL
RECORDS. CENTER GALGIANI GA
JOHNNY GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB SEVEN
FORTY ONE WITH A LINE THE
PROCESS FOR UPDATING
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATES AND THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN
WHAT THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING
THEIR OWN BIRTH CERTIFICATES
AND MEN MEANT STREAMLINED THE
VARIOUS COURT AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
ALL SENATORS. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. HEARING SEEN NINE
MATTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I TELL. I
BRADFORD MICROBIOTA I DODD. HI
TORONTO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO AYE HURTADO AYE
JACKSON. I LEYVA I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY HI NIELSEN.
HAM FIVE PORTANTINO. HI RALPH
FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI MY COUNTY I WIENER
HI. WE'RE GONNA TRANSITION TO
THOSE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR THE NAME
BILL NUMBER AND THEY'LL MEADOW
SECTOR. BATES BATES SB SEVEN
FORTY ONE NO BATES NO OR JUST.
WE'RE JUST SB SEVEN FOUR ONE
NOW FOR JEFF NO CHIANG. THANK
YOU SB SEVEN FOUR ONE I'D
CHIANG I DALY. L. A. S. B.
SEVEN FOUR ONE NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. GROWTH SB SEVEN FOUR
ONE NO GROWTH NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB SEVEN FOUR ONE NO
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. SB SEVEN
FOUR ONE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
MORRELL AND SB. SEVEN FOUR ONE
ZERO NO WILK. SB SEVEN FOUR ONE
ABSTAINED. FIVE THIRTY NO SEVEN
THE CINEMAS ARE CONCLUDING
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE SENATOR PAYNE IS
PERCENT COMPARED 2% MET OF
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR PAN AN AT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE GOOD EVENING CENTER
VAN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB FIFTY TWO REQUIRES
THE STATE CONTRACT MANY.
GENERIC PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THE LEADS-
THE MINIMUM TEN DRUG
MANUFACTURED AND MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES AYE
INFRASTRUCTURE I VOTE FOR THE
CONCURRENCE IN SEVEN MINUTES
THANK YOU. ALL SENATORS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FROM ALL SENATORS.
HEARING SEEN NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE WELL. I BRADFORD
HI CABRERA I DON HI DURAZO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO I JACKSON AYE LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I
MONEY BYE NIELSEN HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER HI STERN HINUMBER
FIVE WACO SKI I WIENER HI.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TRANSITION TO
THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME PHONE
NUMBER AND VOTE. BETTER SECTOR
FACE EIGHT SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
HI BATES HI GORGEOUS BORDERS SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO NOW FORGES NO
CHIANG. HEY SB FIVE TWO I'D
CHIANG HI DALLY THE ONLY SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. SB EIGHT FIVE TWO NOW
GROWN NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ S.
B. EIGHT FIVE TWO NO MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. SB EIGHT FIVE TWO
NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. MORRELL
SB EIGHT FIVE TWO NOW MORRELL
NO WILK. WILK SB EIGHT FIVE TWO
FIVE WILK HI. NIELSEN I DON'T
KNOW. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY MINISTER
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS GIVE ME
TWENTY SECOND SO BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. CENTER BATES YOU HAVE
A HAND UP FOR WHAT PURPOSE. SHE
DIDN'T CALLING ME I NEEDED TO
VOTE CHANGE. ALL RIGHT CENTER
BATES- CAN YOU STATE WHICH VOTE.
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO I BOUGHT IT
ALL RIGHT AND I WISH TO VOTE NO
ALL RIGHT GIVE US ONE SECOND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
SOONER BATES. THANK YOU. THERE
IS A GERMAN OF THE SENATE IS
THERE OBJECTION FOR A SOONER
DATE TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE HER
VOTE FROM GOING SHE WOULD GO TO
I. DIDN'T KNOW IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. THIS IS ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE. IN SENIOR OBJECTION
YOUR VOTE CHANGES GRANTED
CENTER BATES THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA CHANGE THE VOTE
GIVE US ONE MOMENT IN THE ONE
OUNCE THE FINAL VOTE IN JUST
ONE MOMENT CENTER BATES.
THANK
YOU SENATORS AND THANK YOU
CENTER BATES ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE WITH THE VOTE CHANGE
HIGHS THIRTY ONE. KNOWS EIGHT
THE SEVEN M. AS A CONCURRENT IN.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK. BERNIE GO
BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
WE'RE GOING BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP. FILE ITEM SEVENTY.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY AND THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE SO WE'RE GONNA DO
TO A DECISIVE MOMENT FILE ITEM
SEVENTY. AND THEN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE WERE UNDER AS
THIRD READING. SENATOR PAN IS
PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
SEVENTY MEN OF SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN AND ACTUALLY
RELATING TO CONSUMER PRIVACY
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
OF SICK AFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTER PAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS I RIGHTS
RESENT EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN BY
SIMILAR MULLIN WHICH WOULD
FURTHER HARMONIZE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA CNSUMER
PRIVACY ACT WITH EXISTING
CONFIDENTIALITY AND PRIVACY
RULES. FOR CERTAIN HEALTH
RELATED INFORMATION EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN PROTECT PATIENT
INFORMATION ULTIMATELY
SAFEGUARD LIFESAVING MEDICAL
RESEARCH TO BETTER THE LIVES OF
PATIENTS ACROSS THE STATE
SIXTEEN RESPOND TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS TO TRY TO
DEVELOP TREATMENTS INTACT AND
ACCEDE. EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN
ESTABLISHES THE FIRST IN THE
NATION PROHIBITION ANDREA
DEDICATION BE ATTENTIVE FIVE
PATIENT RECORDS THE FINANCIALLY
ADVANCING PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
TO REITERATE THIS BILLS A
PRODUCT OF COLLABORATION
BETWEEN LIFE SCIENCES
HEALTHCARE PRIVACYGROUPS
THERE'S NO FORMAL. OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT BUT-
THANK YOU SENATOR PAYNE.
DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
SENATOR RISING QUICKLY PLEASE I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- THE
INCLUSION OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. FINAL
CALL ALL SENATORS FINAL CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FINAL
CALLED OR DEBATE. HERE N SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THEIR DUTY MANAGER. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. THIS CALL
BY. HI DODD. HI THE RISING HI
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON AYE
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. I
MOEY. HI NIELSEN I CAN HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN I AM BURKE HI
MY COUNTY. HI WIENER HI. LAYS
IN GENERAL NOT GONNA TRANSITION
TO THOSE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IF YOU DON'T MIND
GIVING US YOUR NAME THE BILL
NUMBER ENTER VOTE. BETTER
SECTOR BATES. EIGHT AB SEVEN
ONE THREE HI EIGHT FIVE FOUR
JUST BORDERS AB SEVEN ONE THREE
ARE GORGEOUS HI CHIANG. J. A.
B. SEVEN ONE THREE AYE CHANG
AYE DALY. KELLY A. B. SEVEN ONE
THREE OF STATE. GROVE. GROSS AB
SEVEN ONE THREE AM I GROW HI
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB SEVEN ONE
THREE I MELENDEZ FIVE MORLOCK.
EIGHTY SEVEN ONE THREE HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. MORALE AB
SEVEN ONE THREE ON MORRELL AYE
WILK. AB SEVEN ONE THREE NINE
WILK HI PRICE THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE URGENCY EYES THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
FACING GENERALLY TAKE A QUICK
TIES A QUICK BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING. CONSIDER PAYING FOR
WHAT PURPOSE JUST ONE REQUEST
TO BE TRANSMETAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER PAN REQUESTED ME TO
TRANSMIT ALL THE DESK WILL NOTE.
I KNOW THE ARRANGED. YEAH THE
SIMPSONS
YES WHERE YEAH.
IN
ADDITIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL FILE.
PLEASE GIVE US A FEW MOMENTS.
GOV ADDITIONAL VOTES WERE GONNA
GO WITH AN ADDITIONAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL SENATORS WHO
PARTICIPATED REMOTELY IN THE
CHAMBERS WERE GONNA GET STARTED
IN THIRTY SECONDS PLEASE RETURN
YOUR DESKS.
PLEASE IN GENERAL
THE SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TAKING UP A SECOND CONSENT
CALENDAR WE'RE TAKING UP A
SECOND CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. SB TWELVE FOUR FOUR
NUMBER THIRTY TWO S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO SB TEN THIRTY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE. SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR MEN OF SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILLS.
TWENTY TWELVE FORTY FOUR
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR EIGHT SIXTY FIVE FOURTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. LAYS IN GERMAN IS THERE
ANY. ABDUCTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON OUR
SPECIAL CONTENT CALENDAR.
HEARING SEEN NINE I IS THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE KITCHEN
COUNTERS ADOPTED THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
BE NOW MOVING ON TO OUR SENATE
SETTLEMENT OF FILE NUMBER TWO
REMOVING ON TOUR SENATE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO
SENATE SETTLEMENT OF FILE
NUMBER. TWO FOR ALL THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WE ARE
THE OUT NOW WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ALSO
HAVE THE SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE NUMBER TWO. WE'LL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECONDS TO PREPARE. AS
IN GERMAN OR NOT GONNA START
WITH OUR SECOND SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE WE'RE GOING TO READ THE
FIRST FOUR MEASURES FOR TAKING
UP FAR FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
888-586-8780 EIGHT. WE'RE GONNA
START WITH CENTER BY CAL SKI
CENTER CASKEY IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT. BENEFACTOR PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO DEBT COLLECTORS.
MISTER PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY
BANKING I'M- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS MADE THE BILL BETTER
WE HAVE THE- DEBT COLLECTORS IN
THE DEBT BUYERS WHO ARE NOW
LICENSE SUPPORTING THE BILL I
REGION AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BY CASKEY DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. OR R. OR REMOTELY WE DO
LET'S SAY GOOD EVENING TO
SENATOR MELINDA CENTER MELENDEZ
THE FLOOR IS YOURS FACT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I DON'T HAVE
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILING RIGHT.
I MEAN I'M LOOKING EVERYWHERE
FOR IT I DON'T HAVE WAS JUST
GIVEN. TO ALL THE REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS. YES IT WAS IT WAS-
EMAIL TO IT CAN YOU GIVE US A
QUICK SECOND CENTER MELINDA
SUFFICIENT YOUR PATIENTS
APPRECIATE EARNS HER THE SAME
PER DESPAIRING. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH WHAT WE POTS FOR THIRTY
SECONDS LET'S TAKE A PAUSE FOR
THIRTY SECONDS. AND IF EACH OF
THOSE REMOTE SENATORS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING CAN HIT THE NEW
BUTTON AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU THIRTY SECONDS PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE FILE INTO
MY DEFIANCE ON OUR SECOND
SUBLIMINAL FILE CENTER MY
CASKETS PREPARED RESENTMENT OF
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ. THE
BILL RATE IS STILL GOT AMENDED
IN THE- HOUSE ASSEMBLY- BANKING
COMMITTEE IT'S A BUT THAT'S
BETTER BILL. SENATE BETTER THE
SECOND TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I APOLOGIZE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER MELENDEZ WILL START WITH
YOU. HI I'M SORRY MR PRESIDENT
WHAT BILL IS THIS. THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE. SB NINE AWAIT
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SB NINE
AWAIT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING CENTER MIGHT IS YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON THIS SPECIFIC
BILL. WELL I DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T EVEN SEEN IT YET I'M
LITERALLY JUST GOT AN EMAIL SO.
OKAY WILL COME DOWN WOULD
RESHAPE SOME TIME TO DIGEST
WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO VOTE ON.
HER PERCENT RIGHT. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WHY DON'T WE GO TO
SENATOR BORJA SENATOR GORGEOUS
GOOD EVENING SIR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I'M- EARLY MY IN MY
OFFICE RECEIVE THIS. FOUR
MINUTES AGO NO ONE'S BEEN ABLE
TO REPEAT IT YEAH I MEAN I KNOW
WE'RE PRESSED FOR TIME. I WOULD
JUST. I WOULD HAVE AN OPTION
OTHER THAN JUST SIMPLY DROP
STAIN ON EVERYTHING BECAUSE-
AND THAT MAY BE THE ONLY OPTION
MOVING FORWARD BUT I JUST WANT
TO LET. FOLKS KNOW. THANK YOU
CENTER BURGESS- INSTEAD OF JUST
WANT TO TALK ABOUT PRICES HERE
FOR A MOMENT. SO ALL SENATORS
WHO WERE IN THE ROOM WITH US
YOU'RE NOW. JUST RECEIVED THE
SETTLEMENT OF FILE AS WELL. SO
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
ALL SENATORS KNOW THAT ALL
SENATORS RECEIVED A SETTLEMENT
OF FILE WHETHER IT'S- IN EMAIL
AND OR IN HARD COPY FORM. SO
WE'RE PREPARED FOR ANY
DISCUSSION- BUT AS OF THOSE
SENATORS WHO WERE ALSO HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. ALSO RECEIVED THE
SUPPLEMENTAL- JUST ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AGO. RIGHT CENTER USING
GOOD EVENING SIR. WE NEED TO
TAKE A LITTLE BREAK HERE FOR
FIVE. OKAY YOU DON'T HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE THE DOCUMENTS THAT
WE NEED TO LAYS IN GERMAN LET'S
DO THIS LET'S TAKE A BRIEF
BREAK CAN YOU GIVE US JUST A
FEW MOMENTS WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT. HI YES. FOR
WHAT PURPOSE BURKE BURGESS. I
GUESS MY PURPOSES- MY STAFF
HASN'T SEEN THIS I KNOW OR
MOVING FORWARD I THINK THIS
COULD VERY WELL BE LEGISLATIVE
MALPRACTICE AND I'D BE OPEN TO
A COMPLETE ABSTENTION OR NO
VOTE ACROSS THE BOARD IF THAT
IS HELPFUL BUT I CAN'T VOTE ON
THESE THINGS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIS IN ORDER SO I ASSURE YOU
THAT. THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
STAFF HAS RECEIVED. THE
SETTLEMENT OF FILE ARE YOU SURE
YOU YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON
THAT THAT WE ARE IN CONTACT
WITH. REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE EVEN AS WE SPEAK
EACH OF THESE BILLS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IN FRONT OF THIS
BODY AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY
AND ARE COMING BACK TO WAS ON
CONCURRENCE. THAT SAID WHAT WE
LIKE TO BE TO DO IS OFFER A
BRIDGE OFFER A BRIDGE AND WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP A
BILL THAT IS ON CALL BEFORE WE
DO CENTER MORALE FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. YEAH I JUST WANNA LET
YOU KNOW MY- YOUNG LADY AT.
WHO'S MY LEGISLATOR DIRECTOR I
GUESS IT CAME OVER ON EMAIL AT
TEN FIFTY ONE IS WHEN SHE GOT
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE SO. SHE
HASN'T EVEN HAD A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT IT OKAY. IN AND I DON'T
HAVE IT YET EITHER SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO. HAVE A SENT OVER
TO MY HOUSE AND THEN. I WILL
PRINT IT OUT I GUESS SO- THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE AT I THINK IN FIFTY
ONE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A
ROW WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. AGAIN LADIES IN GENERAL
ISN'T THAT THOSE WHO WERE IN
THE CHAMBERS ALSO RECEIVED THE
HARD COPY FORMAT APPROXIMATELY
THE SAME TIME- HERE SO WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO DO. LAYS IN
GERMAN. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR. WE'RE GONNA-
QUICKLY GO TO LEADER GROVE TO
BE A SAFE YOU CONSTANTLY LIKE
TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR LITER GRO FLEAS. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SINCE WE
DID JUST RECEIVE THIS CAN I
CONFIRM THAT THEY'RE JUST SB
BILLS COMING BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY CORRECT. I BELIEVE SO
ONE SECOND LATER GROW. LEADER
GROVE YOU'RE A 1100% CORRECT
IT'S JUST SENATE BILLS COMING
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ALL ON
THIS SUBLIMINAL FILE SO ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE IF FOR
INSTANCE S. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX THE FINAL VOTE IN THE
SENATE LAST TIME THEY WERE HERE
WAS ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
ELEVEN- SO I JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ALL UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE
BILLS. AND THAT CAME BACK FROM
THE ASSEMBLY AND I ROUGHLY I
REMEMBER DISCUSSING EARLIER
TONIGHT THAT THEY'RE PROBABLY
EIGHTEEN OF THESE CORRECT. EVEN
THE APPROXIMATE NUMBER IS
CORRECT IN YES MA'AM NEEDS OF
ALL BEING. IN FRONT OF US
BEFORE THANK YOU TO GROW
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SIR. WE
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AT
LEADER GROVER WHO WORKS FOR
YOU- INTO FOR ALL SENATORS WERE
NOW GOING TO. WE'RE GONNA ALLOW
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
THOSE PARTICULAR RULING TO BE
ABLE TO. REVIEW THE
SUPPLEMENTAL WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK IN OPEN UP THE ROLE ON A
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR THIS IS SB
THREE SEVENTY FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR SB THREE SEVENTY. BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I.
CABALLERO I GALGIANI YEAH HUESO.
HURTADO. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. GALGIANI HUESO. HURTADO.
CENTER WIENER MOUSSA CALL
LADIES IN GERMAN THE SENATE WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD TO.
BASIN
GENTLEMAN OR NOT GONNA. THIS IS
GOING TO BE A FINAL TIME THAT
WE'RE GOING TO RE OPEN. FILE
ITEM. FORTY FOUR FOR A WHILE SO
IF YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE ON THE
BILL WE ASK THAT YOU GO UP NOW
SO MADAM SECRETARY AND FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR. PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. GALGIANI HUESO.
HURTADO BYE BYE TWENTY ONE NO
SIXTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR SENATE
SETTLEMENT OF FILE NUMBER IS OR
THE I ASKED FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE ASSEMBLY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO AN
IMMEDIATE SOME SAID THAT ALL
THIS TIME BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER WIENER WITH THE MEASURE-DOES PASS WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR SENATE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO.
FINAL FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO THIS
IS A BUDGET BILL. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR MITCHELL ARE BUDGET
CHAIR ON FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO
MADAM SECRETARY. CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
THREE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW. AND
ACTUALLY DIDN'T JUVENILES AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET GOOD EVENING CENTER
MITCHELL. COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
AS A PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL
RELATED TO THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
WITHIN HHS. THE BILL CLOSES
INTAKE FOR YOUTH INTO DJJ ON
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
COUNTIES WHO CURRENTLY RECEIVE
NO STATE FUNDING TO HOUSE TO
HOUSE THE J. J. L. W. THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT PROVIDE
THAT FUNDING. FUNDING WILL BE
GUARANTEED TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES PLUS A BLOCK GRANT
FUNDS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT ASKING FOR NOVEL.
BEIJING GERMAN THE SENATE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE VICE CHAIR
BUDGET CENTER NIELSEN GOOD
EVENING. THURMOND MEMBERS I. R.
J. NO VOTE THIS IS NOT COOKED
YET TOO MANY THINGS AT THE VERY
VERY LAST MINUTE IT IS A MAJOR
CHANGE. AND WE ARE NOT ASSURED
THAT OUR COUNTIES ARE GOING TO
BE TAKING CARE OF OUR- THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE WE'RE LOOKING AT LEADER
GROWN LEADER GROVE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
TO- URGENT NOTES THAT THIS IS
NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
OUR COUNTIES PARTICIPATE. IN
THE DISCUSSION- OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET ITEM SO I
WOULD READ. THE REQUESTED NO
THOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
CONTINUING DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GO TO GREAT JOB UNDER
VERY TRYING TIMES I ALSO URGE
YOU KNOW THOUGH BECAUSE I STILL
DON'T HAVE IT I NOW HAVE
RECEIVED CHIU SUPPLEMENTALS IT
GOES UP TO- ITEM ONE OH ONE
THIS IS AN AYE AYE TOMORROW TOO
I DON'T LOOK FOR ANYTHING THAT
I HAVEN'T READ SO I ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO VOTE NO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER WOKE UP FOR
THOSE WHO'VE BEEN PROTESTING
THIS HAS BEEN IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR YOUR WORK SIR
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR BEATS.
BOOKS INTERVIEW TYPOLOGIES YOUR
AND YOU. JUST A POINT OF
INFORMATION FIRST EXIST SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE. YES MA'AM.
THERE NOW I WOULD LIKE TO URGE
A NO VOTE ON TO THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE IS
INCOMPLETE IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE RESPONSIBILITY THE COUNTIES
ARE INHERITING. MANY COUNTIES
DO NOT HAVE FACILITIES TO SERVE
LONG TERM POPULATIONS FOR MANY
COUNTIES OF STAFFING. AND
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
NEED THAT ARE FOR ON SHORT TO
MID TERM RESOURCE RESOURCE
SERVICE I WILL NOT BE FUNDED.
BY THE COUNTIES DO YOU AGREE
WITH THE INTENTION OF THE BILL
HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATING FOR
MONTHS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CRAFT A POLICY THAT SHE WAS
OUR SHARED GOALS. TO HELP THESE
ARM. JEFFINVOLVED YOUTH. NOT
ALL DOES EIGHT TWENTY THREE
SHIFT A HIGH NEED. OF
VULNERABLE USED TO OUR COUNTY
SAID ALSO DIRECTLY SHIPS
CONSIDERABLE COST LEGAL
LIABILITIES AND SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING UNCERTAINTIES TO THE
COUNTIES. COUNTY IS PROBATION
CHIEFS AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ARE UNIFIED IN A
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE DJJ L.
REALIGNMENT. SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE BOTTOM LINE ARE
UNWORKABLE AND PROVIDE CHINESE
THE TOOLS TO DON'T PROVIDE
COUNTY SAN TO SUCCEED. AND WILL
RESULT IN BETTER OUTCOMES FOR
KIDS AND I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT SO I URGE A
NO VOTE ON ESP EIGHT TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
BATES GOOD EVENING CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SERVICES FOR BOTH FROM COUNTY
LAND- IT WOULD BE REALLY NICE
IF THIS WAS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT- AB EIGHT TO THREE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE TRYING TO CATCH
UP. IS THE SENATE VERSION OF AB
ONE EIGHT SIX EIGHT WHICH WAS-
BEFORE THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE A DAY OR SO
AGO THEY'RE ALL RUNNING
TOGETHER NOW APOLOGIZE BUT IS
THE BUDGET BILL. BUT MISTER
PRESIDENT IT WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA THAT WE DID A COOPERATIVE.
RESPECTFUL COLLABORATION WITH
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY SONORA
CRAMMED DOWN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND MORE LIKE CENTER
DOLLY GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I ALSO WAS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR FOR SIXTEEN
YEARS. THE REASON I RAN FOR
THIS JOB WAS TO STOP THE STATE
FROM PUSHING DOWN UNFUNDED.
MANDATES I KNOW THERE'S
SOMEBODY WITH THIS BUT I'LL
TAKE IN THE DAY NOT GONNA SERVE
OUR YOUTH AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
SERVE OUR COUNTY SO I REQUEST A
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR FINAL CALL ALL
SENATORS HERE IN SEEN ON. MANTA
BUDGETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
JUST TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
POINTS AND I APPRECIATE MEMBERS
ARE ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
TIMING OF THIS I COMPLETELY GET
THIS- THIS WAS A- MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL THAT HAS CHANGED.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON A
PRETTY CONSTANTLY SINCE THEN.
BUT JUST TO CLARIFY- TWO
HUNDRED MILLION THE COUNTIES IS
NEW FUNDING. FOR THE BE GOING
FROM ZERO TO TWO HUNDRED TO
DEAL WITH THIS POPULATION THE
DJ DAY POPULATION WILL A TRIP.
OVER FOUR YEARS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A TOTAL OF IGHT HUNDRED
YOU. THAT'S ALL THAT'S LEFT IN
THE J. J. RIGHT NOW EIGHT
HUNDRED YOU. PALM AND WITH THAT
ANSWER AND I DON'T. THANK YOU
MADAM BOETTICHER METACENTRIC IN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BELL
AYE BRADFORD. HI CABALLERO.
DODD NO TERRAZZO HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG I
HILL NO WAY SO. HER TADO NO
JACKSON. FIVE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL I MONEY. I NIELSEN NO
HAN. PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER. I Y. CASKEY FIVE WIENER
HI. GLAZER GERMAN SENATE RIGHT
NOW GOING TO THE ARE PRETTY
REMOTE IF YOU MIND US YOUR NAME
BILL NUMBER AND THE NUMBER AS
WELL AS YOUR BILL. MADAM
SECRETARY. FACE BATES SB EIGHT
TWENTY THREE NO BATES NOW FOR
JUST. REGIS LET ME KNOW WHAT
WELL THIS IS BUT I THINK IT'S
S. B. EIGHT THREE TWO EIGHT TWO
THREE NO SIMPLE JUST I'M SO
SORRY I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
BUT IT'S- THE SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWO THREE IF YOU DON'T MIND
JUST REPEATING IT I'M SO SORRY
COVERED HIS V. EIGHT TO THREE
NOW FOR JUST NOW. CHIANG SB
EIGHT TWO THREE NOW. CHIANG NO
DALLY. ALI SB EIGHTY NO DALLY
NO GROWTH. M. S. B. EIGHT TWO
THREE NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB EIGHT TO THREE NO
MELINDA'S SNOW MORE LOCK OR
LIKE S. B. EIGHT TWO THREE NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. SB EIGHT
TWO THREE NOW HER L. NO WILK.
YOU CAN'T VOTE FOR SOMETHING
YOU NEVER EVER GOT SO S. B.
EIGHT TWO THREE NO. SENATE
MITCHELL MOVES TO CALL WILK NOW.
SENATE MITCHELL IS A CALL LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
MOVING ON WE ARE. CONTINUING
OUR WORK IN THE SENATE SIMPLE
FILE NUMBER TWO. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WE'RE GONNA
ANNOUNCE FOR THEM AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA START- IN THE HIGH
NINETIES WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT NINETY
NINE AND ONE HUNDRED. FILE ITEM.
NINETY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
NINETY NINE ONE HUNDRED CENTER
WIENER IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN. BUT OUR
SECTOR PLEASE READ. TORONTO.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO SEX OFFENDERS LIVING CENTER
WIENER I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB ONE FORTY FIVE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE- THIS
ELIMINATES DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST LGBTQ. YOUTH IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM I RISK
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER WE
ARE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE LET'S
START WITH SENATOR BATES. GOOD
EVENING CENTER BATES. MAKE SURE
ACTUALLY MY HAND WAS THAT
BEFORE- YEAH MISTER PRESIDENT
BECAUSE IF YOU CALL THE FILE
NUMBER I HAVE A LIST OF BILLS
BUT THEY ARE MY FILE NUMBER SO
PLEASE ALSO MENTION THE BILL
NUMBER AND THAT WILL HELP I
DON'T REALLY HAVE A COMMENT ON
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I WILL DO THAT FROM NOW ON
ANDI APOLOGIZE THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR BATES- LET'S TURN
IT OVER TO A SENATOR MELINDA IS.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I DID
NOT HAVE BECAUSE OF MY
TRANSITION. FROM THE ASSEMBLY
INTO THE SENATE I NEVER HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
BILL I NEVER HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT ON IT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO
WRITE WHAT HE BELIEVES IS AN
UNFAIR- SYSTEM BUT WE ARE ABOUT
CHILDREN HERE SO TO ME IT IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT TYPE OF.
INTERCOURSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE WHO IT IS WITH WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN SO. ARE
YOU KNOW A BETTER APPROACH
WOULD BE TO FIX THE LAW- THAT
RELATES TO. OUR. HETEROSEXUAL
ENCOUNTERS RATHER THAN TRY TO
CHANGE THIS ONE TO MAKE IT FOR
THIS I JUST IS BLOWS MY MIND
THAT WE'RE EVEN HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION- RIGHT UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD WE BE
PASSING A BILL THAT SOMEHOW CAN
JONES SEX WITH A MINOR EVER I
DON'T CARE WHO IS INVOLVED THEY
SHOULD NEVER EVER HAPPEN IN IT
WE SHOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED TO
HIDE. BEHIND THE MANTLE OF
TRYING TO MAKE IT FAIR FOR THE
LGBT COMMUNITY OR ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN HERE SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK EVERYONE TO
CONSIDER IT PARTICULARLY THOSE
OF YOU WHO HAVE CHILDREN OF
YOUR OWN- JUST THINK ABOUT.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HERE AND WE
OFTEN HAVE. CONVERSATIONS WHERE
IN FACT I JUST I THINK JUST A
FEW DAYS AGO ONE OF THE MEMBERS
STOOD UP AND TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT IT'S MINERS AREN'T
REALLY- STOLI COGNITIVELY
DEVELOPED. UNTIL THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX. SO WE YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS WHERE
AND WHEN BILL WE SAY OH THEY'RE
NOT MATURE ENOUGH AND ANOTHER
BILL THEY SAY THEY ARE MATURE
ENOUGH FOR TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN. PLEASE REMEMBER THAT
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO BETTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER MELINDA'S ARE NOT
GOING TO GO TO THE VICE CHAIR
BUDGET CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
NIELSEN. THIS PRESENTLY ON THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT CHILDREN WE'VE- TALKED
ABOUT CHILDREN WHO HAVE
CONDUCTED THEMSELVES IN VERY
DANGEROUS MANNERS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN THE DID
NOT GET NURTURED HER LOVE YOUR
SUPPORT IN ORDER DISCIPLINED.
FOR ALMOST A WON'T. AND NOW
SOMEBODY PLURAL WHOEVER THEY
ARE TO ONCE DESPERATELY TO REDO
REDO THIS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM DID MAKE LIFE. CENTER
GROVE AND I AM SO SORRY THANK
YOU CENTER OF SENIOR SIMPLY FOR
TO COMPLETELY REDO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM LITERALLY AT THE
LAST MINUTE. ALMOST TIME TO
ADJOURN SINE DIE AND WE'RE
STILL DILLON AROUND WITH. WE
JUST GOT SOME MORE INFORMATION
RIGHT NOW. I JUST HAVE GOT TO
ASK THE SENATE IN TERMS OF A
VERY SENSITIVE ISSUE. AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO DO IT RIGHT WITH
OUR YOUTH AND LET'S DO IT RIGHT
LET'S NOT DO IT FAST AND HASTY
AND ILL THOUGHT OUT JUST
BECAUSE SOMEBODY DECIDES IT'S
GOT TO BE DONE NOW IT DOES NOT
NEED TO BE DONE NOW. I URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
NELSON OR NOT GONNA GO TO
LEADER GROSSLY TO GROW. AND
THANK YOU I'M THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW AS I READ
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT ARE
IN THIS BILL AND THAT IT
PROVIDES AN INDIVIDUAL
CONVICTED OF A SPECIFIED SEXUAL
ADVANCE IT NON FORCIBLE ORAL
COPULATION. WITH A MINOR NON
FORCIBLE SODOMY WITH A MINOR
NON FORCIBLE SEXUAL PENETRATION
WITH THE MINOR WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO BE ON AN AND SIX
REGISTERED CENTER LIST- IF THE
PERSON IS MORE THAN TEN YEARS
OLD. OLDER THAN THE MINOR. IS
NOT MORE INSERT THIS PERSON IS
NOT MORE SO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. A TWELVE YEAR OLD AND A
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD- A TEN YEAR
OLD AND A TWENTY YEAR OLD. I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW SOMETHING
LIKE THIS THAT THAT THAT DEALS
WITH OUR CHILDREN WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE GET EVEN.
REMOTELY SUPPORT IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM SO I WOULD ASK.
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
LATER HAVING TO GO TO THESE.
JONES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AS I'M LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
AND- RECOGNIZING THAT I VOTED
NO I WHEN THIS ORIGINALLY WAS
IN THE SENATE I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT TO THE SENATORS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY VOTE- JUST THIS
EVENING WAS FORTY ONE TO
EIGHTEEN- REQUIRING FORTY ONE
VOTES TO GET OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY SO DID BARELY PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY- I. I CERTAINLY
SHARE THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUES- THAT HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AND-
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION ALSO URGING NO VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
JONES ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FINAL CALL HEARING
SEEN NINE CENTER WIENER WE LIKE
TO CLOSE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT THIS HAS NO
APPLICATION TO ANY MONEY UNDER
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN SAID THE
CENTER FOR BAKERSFIELD IS MIS
READ THE LAW. THIS SIMPLY
TREATS LGBTQ KIDS THE SAME WAY
THAT WE CURRENTLY TREAT STREET
KIDS LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT TO
SPELL OUT FOR UNIDO BETTER
CENTURY. CAN YOU I'M SO SORRY
AT ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
HAS C. CENTER MIND AS I DO SEE
THAT YOUR HAND IS UP BUT WE-
DIDN'T DO THE FINAL CALL FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
MELINDA'S I REALLY DO APOLOGIZE
WE'RE. PREPARED YOU KNOW CALL
FOR THE VOTE. SO MANY SECRETARY
CAN YOU. CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ATKINS I FELL FIVE
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I DON.
DURAZO HI GALGIANI. GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. AYE HILL
HI WITH SO. HURTADO. LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I
MONEY I NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO.
RUBIO SKINNER I STERN. HI I'M
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER HI WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED REMOTELY WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK IN YOUR NAME BILL
NUMBER AND A- BETTER SECRETARY.
FAKES S. B. BATES SB ONE FORTY
FIVE NO BATES NOW FOR JUST.
SCREEN ONE FORTY FIVE FOR JUST
NOW FOR JUST NOW CHIANG SB ONE
FORTY FIVE NOW. HANG NO DALLI
DALLI S. B. ONE FORTY FIVE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. SB ONE FORTY
FIVE KNOWN GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ ON SB ONE FORTY FIVE
IT LEGALIZES SEX WITH A FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD CHILD NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORLOCK. MOORLACH SB ONE FORTY
FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
YES HE ONE FOR FIVE VOTING
ALTERED VERSION. MORALE NOW
WILK. SB ONE FORTY FIVE NO WILK
NO HIS TWENTY THREE KNOWS TEN
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CONCURRED
IN PLACING GEMMA NOT GONNA LIVE
TO CALL AND FILE ITEM ONE OF
TWO FILE ONE OF TWO IS OUR
BUDGET BILL SB EIGHT TWENTY
THREE. BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CABALLERO. GALGIANI GLAZER.
HUESO MCGUIRE. PAN HI BY TWENTY
ONE KNOWS THIRTEEN IS A
MINISTER CONCURRED IN PLACE IN
GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO ANNOUNCE
OUR NEXT FOR BILLS WE'RE GONNA
ANSWER NEXT FOR BILLS PER THE
REQUEST WILL ANNOUNCE THE FILE
ITEM IN THE BILL NUMBER WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE S. ZERO THREE FILE ITEM
ONE OH ONE. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN LET'S
NOT START WITH FILE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
CENTER HILLS PREPARED TO
PRESENT. HEY WITH THE URGENCY.
BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE BY SENATOR HILL AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY CENTER HILL THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND A BEFORE I
BEGIN MY FINAL BILL I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY-
CONSTITUENTS FOR ELECTING ME
AND SENDING ME HERE TO
REPRESENT THEM AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU. FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS COMMITMENT TO THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP OVER
THE YEARS. AS WELL AS THE TIMES
WE'VE LAUGHED IN THE TIMES WHEN
WE'VE CRIED. THANK YOU FOR THAT
IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE. SB NO.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE SEEKS TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE
FOR OUR FRONTLINE FIGHT THE
FIGHT WORKERS FIGHTING COVERT
NINETEEN IN SHORT SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE IS A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA ADDRESSES. HI RICH
COVER NINETEEN OCCUPATIONAL
SETTINGS FAIRLY AND EVENLY FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK SENATOR HILL IS A GENERAL
GONNA OPEN UP FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR JONES. YOU'RE
GOOD TO GO CENTER JOHNS. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I THOUGHT-
BARGES HAD HIS HAND UP FOR
STRUGGLE FIRST WELL FIRST OF
ALL I DO WHEN I RECOGNIZE
SKINNER HILL- WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN HE WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST ONES TO. REACH ACROSS THE
AISLE AND WELCOME ME AS A NEW
MEMBER AND THEN AFTER THAT WE
BUILT A GREAT FRIENDSHIP AND
COLLABORATIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WE'VE WORKED ON
SOME PRETTY GOOD DEALS
TOGETHER. MOST NOTABLY ARE MADE
IN THE USA BILL. WHICH HAS MADE
A- GREAT IMPROVEMENTS FOR-
MANUFACTURES IN CALIFORNIA.
HARD STOP UNFORTUNATELY- ON
THIS BILL I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND
OUR SENATE REPUBLICANS THAT
THIS HAD ALL ELEVEN REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO IN JUNE WHEN IT LEFT
THE SENATE I ALSO I A NO VOTE
TONIGHT. BUT THAT. BUT I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
APPRECIATE. CENTER HEALING ALL
THIS HARD WORK IN THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR JOHN CENTER
BURGESS. OF THE FOUR. SENATOR
HILL YOU'RE A CLASS ACT IT'S
BEEN AN HONOR SERVING WITH YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER GORGEOUS LAST CALL FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE LAST CALL
FOR ALL SENATORS. HEARING SEEN.
HERE IN C. NINE CENTER HELLO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU FOR THE NICE COMMENTS
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
AMAZING WORK. BETTER SECTOR FOR
THE FINAL TIME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BELL. AYE BRADFORD.
CABALLERO I. BRADFORD. SENATE
RIVER I DODD HI THE RAZA HI CAL
JOHNNY HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON AYE
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL AYE
MONNING HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HAN. PORTANTINO I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
AMBERG HI MY COUNTY HI WIENER
HI WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TRANSITION TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME
BILL NUMBER AND VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY. BATES BATES SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE SADLY I MUST
VOTE NO BATES NO FORTUS.
SIMILARLY S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE OF COURSE. CHARGES NO
CHIANG. HANG SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE I. HANG HI DOLLY L. A. B.
ELEVEN FIFTEEN NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. GROVE SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE NOW GROSS NO MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
SENATOR HILL WE'RE GONNA MISS
YOU AS THE HER SIGNATURE THANKS
FOR BEING A CLASS ACT MORE LIVE
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY NINE NO MORE
LOCK NO GIRL. MORALE SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE NOW. MORALE NO WILK.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE HI WILK HI.
FIVE THIRTY NO STATE ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY NOW IS A-
THE SIMPSONS INCURRED AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE MOVING NEVER
JUMP AROUND A LITTLE BIT LADIES
IN GERMAN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NINETY NINE WHICH IS SB
EIGHT OH THREE CENTER BILLS
PREPARE TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY SENATOR
PELL AN ACT RELATING TO MEDIKAL
CENTERVILLE. THIS IS THE PEER
SUPPORT BILL BACK FROM CURRENTS
THE MINISTER- IN THE ASSEMBLY
OR TECHNICAL ARJUN ARE VOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU CENTER BILL
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK SIR.
HEARING C. NINE I HAVE CENTER
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
I TELL. I BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM HI DODD. I TORONTO.
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI WITH SO.
I HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. I MONNING
HI NIELSEN NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE HI MY COUNTY I WIENER. HI.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TRANSITION TO
THOSE ARE FROM PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY CENTER BATES YOU MIND
KNOWING YOUR CAMERA JUST A BIT
SO WE CAN SEE YOUR FULL FACE
APOLOGIZE SORRY IT'S OKAY IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CAME BILL
NUMBER AND VOTE. INSPECTORS
BASS BATES SB EIGHT OH THREE HI
ILLUZZI JIM BATES FIVE LARGEST.
FORGERS SB EIGHT OH THREE I'M
STAYING. CHIANG. THANK SB EIGHT
OH THREE I. CHIANG HI DALLI
DALLI SB EIGHT OH THREE HI
DALLY I. GROWTH. YEAH SB EIGHT
OH THREE AYE GROVE AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB EIGHT ZERO THREE I
MELENDEZ HI MORLOCK. S. B.
EIGHT OH THREE I ORLOK HI BROWN.
MORRELL SP ZERO THREE NOW
MORRELL NO WILK. SB EIGHT OH
THREE HI WILK HI. NIELSEN NO TO
I'D- HI THIRTY SIX NUMBERS ONE
THE SENATE SECOND CURTAIN WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT. FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT CENTER PAIN IS PREPARED
TO PRESENT. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
COMMITTEE- CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH IS SAID
ABOUT THE DESK WILL KNOW WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT S. B. TWO
SEVENTY FIVE BETTER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR PAN
AN ACT RELATING TO PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT SOONER
FANS THANK YOU SB TWO SEVENTY
FIVE A STEP STATE TV STOCKPILE
REQUIRES STOCKPILE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HEARING SEEN ON.
PATTERSON CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BELL. I BRADFORD HI
CABRERO I DODD HI DURAZO. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JACKSON. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY. I
NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN I NUMBER HI HI MY COUNTY
HI WIENER. HI WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE PERFECT
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY NAME
BILL NUMBER IN VOTE PLEASE
BETTER SECTOR FACE. BATES SP
TWO SEVENTY FIVE NO BATES NO
GORGEOUS. THREE TWO SEVENTY
FIVE GORGEOUS NOW SO FAR JUST
SEEING THAT NOW. CHIANG J. AS
THE TWO SEVENTY FIVE HI JANE I
DALY. L. A. S. B. TWO SEVENTY
FIVE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. AND
GROW THE SPT SEVENTY FIVE NO
GROSS NOW MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ
S. B. TWO SEVENTY FIVE NO ONE
DOES KNOW MORLOCK. IT'S FREE TO
SEVENTY FIVE NO WARLOCK NARROW
NARROW. SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE NO
MORALE NO WILK. SIX WILK S. B.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE HI WILK HI BY
THIRTY ONE NO CITY THE SIMPSONS
FROM CURTIN WE'RE NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE ONE S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE CENTER BILLS
FOR IT PREPARE TO PRESENT MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
BY SENATOR VAL AN ACT RELATING
TO TRANSPORTATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
CENTERVILLE. MAN PRESENT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE FINANCING
OF OUR STATE HIGHWAY OPERATIONS
PROTECTION PROGRAM WHICH IS OUR
STATE HIGHWAY REHABILITATION
PROGRAM ORIGINAL VOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR MELINDA GATES.
GOOD EVENING OKAY THANK YOU CAN
GET ALL THE STUFF ON MY SCREEN
HERE- THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I AM SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL. THIS
IS GOING TO MARKET IN- SB. FOR
FOUR DECADES FORTY YEARS I
THINK IT IS AND I'D THAT
DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE ANY SENSE
TO ME WHY WE WANTED TIE THE
HANDS OF FUTURE LEGISLATURES
WITH RESPECT TO THIS FEES IN
ADDITION THE VOTERS APPROVED
PROP SIXTY NINE TO
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECT DETECT
AND- PREVENT DIVERSION OF THESE
FUNDS- AND BECAUSE PROP SIXTY
NINE PROTECTS ONLY TO REVENUE
AND NOT. THE REVENUE BOND
PROCEEDS. WHICH WERE GENERATED
BY THIS BILL. WE CAN SEE UP TO
FIVE BILLION IN TRANSPORTATION
FUND THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE.
DIVERT AND SO I JUST I DON'T
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO DO
THIS TO FUTURE LEGISLATURE- AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR WE'RE
NOT GONNA GO TO CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I HAVE
SOME REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF DEBT WE'RE TAKING ON
THAT WE JUST FOUND OUT TODAY
FROM THE STATE COMPTROLLER THAT
ARE. READ AND UNFUNDED RETIREE
MEDICAL HAS GONE UP FROM EIGHTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS TO NINETY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. AND WE
HAVE ENCOURAGED SO MUCH DEBT
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. THAT IT
WOULD BE WISE. THAT WE WAIT
UNTIL OUR ECONOMY STABILIZES
AND OUR- FINANCES NORMALIZE
BEFORE WE ENTER INTO A
TRANSACTION LIKE THIS SO I
WOULD BE OPPOSED S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU. FINAL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE KAREN
SCENE NINE. MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I DODD. HI
THERE AWESOME. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE. HURTADO
AYE JACKSON. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY I
NIELSEN NO PAN. HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH. BROUGH RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
HI STERN. HI NUMBER HI REQUEST
YOU AYE WIENER HI. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY NAME
BILL NUMBER AND VOTE THANK YOU.
BATES BATES SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE BATES NOW FOR JUST. S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE BOARD JUST
NOW FOR JUST NOW. CHIANG SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE NO CHANGE NO
DALLI. DALLI SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. GROVE
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE NO
GROVE NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE NO ONE DOES
KNOW MORLOCK. S. B. I'M MORE
LIKE SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE L. S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE NOW. MORALE
NO WILK. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
NO WILK NOW. HIS TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TEN THE SYNONYMS
CONCURRED IN LADIES IN GERMAN
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NIGHT NUMBER NINETY
SIX WHICH IS SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN FOR NOW GOOD WITH MORE
THAN GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE SB NINE OH EIGHT
MORE THAN GOING TO GO TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT S. V. TEN
SIXTY FOUR THAT START WITH
SENATOR DODD HE'S PREPARED TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM NINETY SIX SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. BUT OF
SURGERY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS CENTERED ON.
ACTICIN IS GREAT BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FINAL CALL HEARING XENON
INTERCEPTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OUR I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I TELL. I BRADFORD I CAN
BY ADAM I DON. HI TORONTO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI WITH
SO I HER TADO I JACKSON. I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
I MONEY I NIELSEN. PAN
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN AYE AMBERG
HI FOR CASKEY HI WIENER HI.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY NAME
BILL NUMBER AND VOTE PLEASE
PRESS SECRETARY. FACE IT'S S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN NO EIGHT
NOW FOR JUST. SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN BORDERS OF STAYING.
CHIANG SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN I
CHIANG HI DALLY. L. A. S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN HI DALLY I
GROWTH. SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
ABSTAIN. I THE LEADER OF THE
MIND STATING YOUR NAME PLEASE.
S. SENATOR GROVE S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN AM SIX. THANK YOU
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HOLD ON A
SECOND HERE. SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN HI. MELENDEZ I MORLOCK.
FEDERAL MOORLACH SP ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN ABSTAINED. MORRELL.
YES MORALE SB TWELVE THREE
SEVEN NO MORALE NO WILK. WILK
SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN HI WILK
HI GUYS MISTER PRESIDENT
MELENDEZ- SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN HI TO UPSTAGE INCREASED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN'T GO AYE
TO SAYING WE CAN GO I DIDN'T
KNOW WERE UNABLE TO LOCATE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE KNOWN AND
SORRY. MELENDEZ I DON'T KNOW.
THANK YOU HIGHS THIRTY ONE DOES
THREE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
SECOND CONCORD AND WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE CINEMA CASKETS
PREFERRED TO PRESENT AN- CENTER
NIELSEN FOR PURPOSE YOU RISE.
RECORDED ON THAT LAST BILL I
DON'T NINETY SIX I BELIEVE I'M
NO. ITEM NINETY SIX GIVE US ONE
MOMENT MADAM SECRETARY. YOU'RE
A MARKED AS A NO I'M STAYING
THANK THANK YOU. BETTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE. SENATE BILL NINE
ZERO EIGHT BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AND ACTUALLY DETECTCOLLECTORS CENTER MY CASKET SB
NINE AWAIT I STILL URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THE CONCURRING
AMENDMENTS. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE HEARING C. NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BUT WE HAVE A SENATOR
MELINDA CENTER MELINDA'S. I'M
SORRY WHAT IS THE BILL RIGHT HE
DIDN'T EVEN HE DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING. CENTER BY CASKEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO.
GIVE US A. CENTER MY CASKEY CAN
YOU GIVE A BRIEF DESCRIPTION
IT'S A LICENSING BILL FOR DEBT
COLLECTORS IN DEBT BUYERS WHO
DEBT BUYERS AND COLLECTORS I
AGREE WITH THE LICENSING THERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I URGE
AN IPHONE. IT'S NINE OH EIGHT
S. B. NINE OH EIGHT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR CENTER
MELINDA'S ON YOUR OWN TIME
PLEASE. I'M YES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I APOLOGIZE IF THAT'S
FRUSTRATING TO HAVE TO SAY WHAT
THE BILL IS BUT IT'S MOVING
VERY QUICKLY AND WE ARE TRYING
TO KEEP THEM FROM WORK IN A
REMOTE FASHION SO THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER MONDAY
CENTER JONES. SORRY MR
PRESIDENT I GOT THE BILL NUMBER
BUT NOT THE FILE NUMBER Q.
SHARE THE FOUNDER PLEASE FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SB NINE AWAIT.
YEAH THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY
ANY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL. I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO AYE DODD
AYE DURAZO. I GALGIANI. I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO.
I JACKSON AYE LEYVA I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I NIELSEN
NO HAN I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE%
I'M BURKE I WOULD BECAUSE HE-
HI WIENER HI LET'S GO TO REMOTE
MEMBERS NAME BILL NUMBER
INFOPLEASE MATTERS AFTER. BASS
IT'S S. B. NINE OH EIGHT. AMY
GORGEOUS. THREE NINE A
REPORTERS OF STAYING. CHIANG
DANCE THE NIGHT AWAY AT STAINED.
BALLY. DOLLY SB NINE AWAY NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. ZERO I AM
WORKING ON IT SIR SORRY ABOUT
THAT THAT'S OKAY WHAT FILE ITEM
MARIANA SORRY WAS WORKING OF
SOMEONE ELSE WE'RE WORKING ON
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SB NINE
ONLY. THE S. B. AT NINE AWAIT
OF STAINED WOULD YOU MIND IS
GIVING SURNAME CENTER OF I
APOLOGIZE. GROSS SB NINE OH
EIGHT STEPS STAINED MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ SB NINE OH EIGHT.
RIGHT NINE AWAIT YES SB NINE OH
EIGHT NOW. MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. SB NINE OH EIGHT HI
MORLOCK I AM PEARL. YES MORALE.
SB NINE AWAIT NO GIRL NO WILK.
SB NINE OH WAIT THIS WAS A
SIMPLE BILL. HI WILL I BY
THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR THE
SEMIRAMIS OR CONCURRED IN WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT S. B.
TEN SIXTY FOUR MATTER SECTOR
CAN PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
TEN SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
PRISONS CENTER SKINNER. THAT
FOR CAN GOOD PROCESS BILL AS
RELIABLE. THANK YOU SENIOR
SKINNER OR LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CENTER MELINDA'S. I'M
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SO. I'M
GOING TO HAVE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS- NUMBER ONE
IT UNNECESSARILY MICROMANAGES
THE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS WITHIN
OUR STATE PRISONS. THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS THAT IS
ALREADY REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
WHICH CURRENTLY STATES THAT
NUMBER ONE NO DECISION SHALL BE
BASED UPON INFORMATION FROM A
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE UNLESS
OTHER DOCUMENTATION
CORROBORATES INFORMATION FROM
THE SOURCE OR UNLESS THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SURROUNDING THE
EVENT AND THE DOCUMENT AND
RELIABILITY OF THE SOURCE
SATISFIES THE DECISION MAKERS
AT THE INFORMATION IS TRUE. AND
NUMBER TWO THE ANY DOCUMENT
CONTAINING INFORMATION FROM A
CONFIDENTIAL SOURCE SHALL
INCLUDE AN EVALUATION OF THE
SOURCE'S RELIABILITY OF BRIEF
STATEMENT OF THE REASON FOR THE
CONCLUSION REACHED IN A
STATEMENT OF REASON WHY THE
INFORMATION OF SOURCES NOT TO.
DISCLOSE THIS BILL INSTEAD
REQUIRES A DETAILED DESCRIPTION
OF THE INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
THE CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT.
SECONDLY THE IT REQUIRES THE
ACTUAL OR APPROXIMATE DATE THE
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED
THIRDLY A STATEMENT FROM CDC
ARE ON A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANTS HISTORY OF PROVIDING
INFORMATION. ON FOR THE
EVIDENCE USED TO CORROBORATE
THE INFORMATION. IT IS-
UNLIKELY THAT AN INDIVIDUAL IN
CUSTODY WOULD BE WILLING TO
PROVIDE. SUCH INFORMATION-
ESPECIALLY THEY FEEL THEY MIGHT
BE SUBJECT TO PHYSICAL
RETRIBUTION SO I THINK WE CAN
AGREE THAT. CDCR CAN
CORROBORATE ANY INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANT THIS BILL GOES.
REALLY Q. FAR IN IDENTIFYING
THE INDIVIDUALS WHICH WOULD
HAVE THE ADDED WHICH WILL HAVE
I SHOULD SAY THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND THERE'S. GREAT
CONCERN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
RUNNING AS YOU STAND ON IT
WOULD DEPRIVE CDC ARE FROM
USING RELIABLE EVIDENCE HAVE
BEEN MADE CRIMINAL. ACTIVITY TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. YOUR
HEARINGS FOR THEM TO WORK
CRIMINAL PERSECUTION I MEAN
PROHIBIT THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS FROM CONSIDERING
SEVERAL OTHER ANALYSTS CONDUCT
ORGANIZED LEASE RENTAL HOMES
TOWARDS THE NO. CEREMONIES AND
SO DINNER BUT WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE BILL. WELL YES I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT- THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
BILL RELAY TO ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT WHICH IS
WHAT EXACTLY THIS BILL DOES
AND- I JUST. HER SEVERAL POINTS
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO MAKE. IF
I MAY CONTINUE. THANK YOU
CEREMONIAL I'M SORRY ONE MORE
TIME CENTER MELENDEZ. NO I SAID
THERE YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU WANT US TO SPEAK ON
THE AMENDMENTS BUT- IF WE GO TO
MEAN THE MAINTENANCE TIßN
DIRECTLY TO WHAT THE BILL DOES
WHICH IS WHAT I'M- TRYING TO
TALK ABOUT IN MAKING MY CASE AS
TO WHY THIS BILL. SHOULD NOT BE
PASSED SO I WONDER IF I CAN.
CONTINUE WITH THAT FRIEDMAN
FIVE SINCE SINCE SINCE THIS
BILL WAS IN FRONT OF THIS PARTY
HERE PREVIOUSLY WE ARE LOOKING
TOWARD CAME- CONVERSATION ON
THE AMENDMENTS RELATED TO THE
BILL- BUT YOU'VE MADE. YOUR
POINTS WHICH WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THAT WE STILL HAVE A
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
TO SPEAKING OF THIS ALL RIGHT
CENTER MELINDA'S WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO GO TO LEADER GROVE. TO BE
A SAFE YOUR COMMENTS. OUR OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ROLAND AS
SET TAT'S GOING TO CENTER
GROVE. AND THANK YOU AND. CAN
YOU HEAR ME SIR YES MA'AM WE'RE
GOING TO HELP YOU TO GROW.
THANK YOU AND MISTER PRESIDENT-
YOU KNOW I HAVE A BAD TASTE IN
MY MOUTH OVER THIS BILL
BECAUSE- SPECIFICALLY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S- THAT HAVE
OPPOSED THIS BILL THAT THE
STATE DIDN'T DEPRIVE CDC ARE
FOR USING RELIABLE EVIDENCE FOR
INTIMIDATE. ACTIVITY AND HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND
DISCIPLINARY HANDED HEARINGS-
WHEN INMATE IS ALLEGED TO HAVE
COMMITTED SERIOUS RULE
VIOLATION GIVEN NOTICE TO THE
PROPOSED DISCIPLINARY HEARING.
INCLUDING WRITTEN RIGHTS
ADVISEMENT CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
VIOLATION. THE NAMES OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS ARE NON
CONFIDENTIAL. INFORMANTS ARE
PROVIDED TO THE IN. AND SO
THAT'S JUST THOUGHT TO THINK
THAT SOMEBODY'S ACTUALLY TRYING
TO HELP US- OR HELP SOMEBODY
SOLVE A CRIME IT HAPPENS WITHIN
A PRISON AND THEN THIS. THIS
IS- THIS IS GOING TO EN MASSE
THOSE INFORMANTS AND SO I GUESS
HOW WOULD YOU SOLVE CRIME
CRIMES IN PRISON. IF THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD IF
YOU'RE GONNA AND MASS THE
PEOPLE THAT. ARE HERE TO HELP
US SOLVE THOSE CRIMES IN
PRISON- THE OTHER ISSUE THAT I
GUESS I HAVE WITH IT IS YOU
HAVE- IT SEVERELY IMPEDES
CCAR'S ABILITY INVESTIGATE PAST
PRISON CRIMES TO PREVENT FUTURE
CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT. WE ARE AND
I DID NOTICE THAT THE CDCR
SECRETARY- THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD ON STAFF IN THE
ADMINISTRATION RESIGNED. AND
IT'S- IT SEEMS EVIDENT AND I
DON'T KNOW BUT YOU WOULD THINK
THAT A LOT OF THESE BILLS THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH WOULD CAUSE
HIM TO FEEL LIKE YOU WERE WE'RE
TYING HIS HANDS. SO THAT HE
COULDN'T DO THE JOB THAT HE
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT- THE
PRISONS WERE OPERATED IN A
SAFE. EFFECTIVE MANNER AND SO I
GUESS I WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU ESPECIALLY WITH EXISTING
LAW THAT AFFORDS INMATES FACING
DISCIPLINARY HEARINGS A SUMMARY
OF EVIDENCE IS- SUSTAINED WITH
THE CHARGES. AND AGAINST THEM
THE HEARING THE INMATES AT A
HEARING IN YOUR MATES AND OFTEN
CALL ALL WITNESSES. AND ENERGY
SAW EVIDENCE. EXUDING THE-
SERVER IN THAT SEEKS. ISSUE AND
WE NEED TO SEE IF WE DON'T. I
AM REALLY NOT TRYING TO BE RUDE
BUT I'M JUST GONNA ASK YOU TO
PLEASE SPEAK TO THE AMENDMENT
SAYS. BUT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE TO THE CONVERSATION SO
IF YOU COULD PLEASE SPEAK TO
THE MOMENTUM WE HAVE HEARD
YOU'RE- VERY CLEAR POINTS WHICH
WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE.
RETROFITTING MIGHT SPEAK IN THE
NAME IS PROTECTED IN THE
FORWARD. EVERY DECISION
ACTUALLY. ASKED FOR AN I. AND
NOBODY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
HAVE CENTER NIELSEN. I GOTTA
CONFESS I'M REALLY MORE
SPEAKING TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FIVE OR SIX YOU
MAY BE WATCHING THIS TONIGHT. I
WOULD CAUTION MY COLLEAGUES TO
BE A LITTLE BIT CAREFUL. IT'S
DISTURBING TO ME TO SEE ALL
THIS ACTIVITY ROAMING AROUND
HERE RIGHT NOW AS WE'RE
REACHING DEADLINES. LIKE
SOMEBODY'S AFRAID. THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE TO SHUT DOWN. I
SUBMIT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT MAY BE THE VERY
BEST THING THAT WOULD HAPPEN
NOW THESE TO THE POINTS THAT
WERE CHALLENGING FOR THE
SENATOR MELENDEZ. UP AND THE
SENATOR GROW. DAVID DWELT ON
ISSUES DIRECTLY RELATED TO SOME
OF THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS THEY
WERE DRIFTING OFTEN BE
INDELICATE OR THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT SUBSTANTIVE INFORMATION.
AND SOME OF YOU MAY NOT
UNDERSTAND HOW SENSITIVE THIS
WHOLE ISSUE IS OF CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANTS. MAYBE YOU DO NOT
KNOW WHAT GOES ON IN PRISONS.
SO I WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT
BE CAUTIOUS. AND DON'T WAKE UP
NEXT YEAR SUNDAY AND BE
CRITICIZED AND SAY WELL I
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS. WELL
YOU DO KNOW ABOUT IT AND YOU'RE
SITTING RIGHT HERE. EVERYBODY
SHOULD ANALYZE AND TAKE A LOOK
WE'VE GOT A SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER THREE THE JUST HIT MY
DESK RIGHT NOW I BET WITHIN TEN
MINUTES WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT. I URGE CAUTION
IN THOSE AREAS AND WE NEED TO
TALK TO PLEASE THE IMMENSELY
SYNGENTA NINETY GETTING. CLOSE
TO MIDNIGHT. HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO DO WE'RE GONNA
NEED FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
TO THE AMENDMENTS I HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY TOLERANT ENTIRE
NIGHT. AND THEY DO BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THIS.
SO CENTER. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
YOU SPEAK TO THE IMMINENCE. ON
S. B. TEN SIXTY FOUR I AM
OPPOSED- BECAUSE OF THE
MAINTENANCE AND AGAIN THE BILL
BECAUSE THE SUN COLLABORATED
ALLEGATIONS AND SO- I WILL BE A
NO VOTE I STRONGLY URGE THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER MORAL CENTER
GORGEOUS SENTIMENTS PLEASE
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU SIR.
CENTREBOARD JUSTIN IMMINENCE.
WE NEED TO GET CENTER THANK YOU
CENTER GORGEOUS. SORRY WHY I
THINK I THINK PARK FOR THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT
CORROBORATE OR EVEN
UNCORROBORATED INFORMATION HAS
SIGNIFICANT THE LADY IN THE
PENAL SYSTEM. AND THE IDEA OF
DISREGARDING AT WHOLESALE
ULTIMATELY I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE- IT'S GOING TO BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN SO IF
ANYONE GOES TO TRIAL. THE WHOLE
IDEA IS EXPOSING WHETHER OR NOT
THE INFORMATION PROVIDED WITH
ALL THE BIAS SEES THAT ARE
BROUGHT INTO A EIGHT EIGHT
ACCORDINGLY SETTING THAT'S FOR
A JURY TO DECIDE NOT
NECESSARILY. HOLSEY TANGENT
OREGON. OUR ENTIRE LEGAL SYSTEM
IS TERRIBLE I I'VE BEEN ASKING
EACH IN INDIVIDUALLY TO SPEAK
TEN MINUTES WE APPRECIATE THAT
HEARING SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
DEBATE MATTER SUCH REGRET
COMING AND- MET MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I STARTED MY HAND UP.
IT'S BEEN A FULL TIME ARCHULETA
TALK LATER THIS ATKINS I FELT.
I BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
DODD HI DURAZO HI GALGIANI.
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. I HER TADO.
JACKSON I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL I MONEY I NIELSEN. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
NUMBER I REQUEST YOU AYE WIENER
HI. WE'RE NOT GONNA TRANSITION
TO THOSE WHO ARE VOTING
REMOTELY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
SAY YOUR NAME BILL NUMBER AND
PLEASE NOTE OF SECTOR STATE.
MISTER PRESIDENT. FOR WHAT
PURPOSE METAL LEADER. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REMIND YOU THAT IT
IS NOW TWELVE OH ONE YES ME AND
WE STARTED THE ROLL CALL PRIOR
TO THE MIDNIGHT HOUR SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROCEED
WITH A VOTE. MATTER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE REFER SEAT WITH A
VOTE. BATES BATES SB TEN SIXTY
FOUR NO BATES NO GORGEOUS. LOS
FORGES SB TEN SIXTY FOUR NOW
FOR JUST MARROW CHIANG YES THE
TEN SIXTY FOUR NOW CHIANG NO
DALLY. SALLY SB TEN SIXTY FOUR
NO DALLY NO GROWTH. GROVE SP
TEN SIXTY FOUR NOW GROVE NO
MELINDA'S. MISTER PRESIDENT WE
ARE PAST THE DEADLINE SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU STARTED THE
ROLL CALL PART TWO BUT WE ARE
NOW PASSED THE DEADLINE SO- I
GUESS IS A POINT OF ORDER CAN
SOMEONE TELL US BY WHERE IT
SAYS THAT. YOUR YOU CONTINUE
FOR THE COUNTING ON THE BALLOT
AFTER MIDNIGHT. INTRIGUING
QUERY I SUPPOSE YES MA'AM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE INQUIRER SO
WE STARTED THE ROLL CALL VOTE.
PRIOR TO THE MIDNIGHT HOUR THAT
IS WHY WE ARE ADVANCING IF WE
HAD STARTED THE ROLL CALL AFTER
MIDNIGHT HOUR WE WOULD NOT BE
CALLING ROLE SO WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE TO DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ROLL CALL VOTE. THE
MEANT A SENATOR WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT BACK OVER TO BETTER
SECRETARY. TO BE A CALL THE
ROLL AND TO BE ABLE TO GET YOUR
BILL BETTER SECTOR MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ S. B. TEN SIXTY FOUR
NOW MELENDEZ NOW MORLOCK. S. B.
ONE OH SIX FOUR ABSTAINED
MORALE. YES WELL AS BEATING
SIXTY FOUR NOW ROUND NO WILK.
MISTER PRESIDENT. YES
MINIMALLY- IF YOU DON'T MIND
CAN WE JUST HAVE CENTER WILL BE
ON A RECORDED VOTE AND WILL
COME- COME OVER TO YOU AND I
HAVE NOT MET HIM LATER IF THAT
WORKS FOR YOU PLEASE. IT'S LIKE
TO ASK- WHAT PRINCE- THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND IT'S LIKE A
STATE OF PLAY. ACCORDING TO
FOOTBALL LIKE ONCE THE- I GUESS
ONCE THE PLAY HAS STARTED THAT
IT STOPS COULD YOU IDENTIFY
THAT- RULE FOR ME. LEADERS RUN
THANK GOODNESS ARE MARCHED THE
RIVER PROMISE YOU ARE GOING
INTO YOUR QUESTION WE'RE GONNA
COMPLETE A ROLL CALL BETTER
SECTOR CAN PLEASE COMPLETE THE
ROLL CALL. WELL WILK SB TEN
SIXTY FOUR NO WILK NO. THANK
YOU. HIS TWENTY SIX KNOWS NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MATAMATA WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE. SENATOR GROW FOR
WHAT PURPOSE. AND JUST WHAT I
CLARIFIED OR WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CLARIFY WHAT- WHAT RULE IF
BERNIE COULD JUST LET US KNOW
WHERE YOU COULD LET US KNOW
WHAT RULE IS IT ON THE SENATE
SIDE THAT ALLOWS- YOU TO
CONTINUE. TAKING A ROLL CALL
VOTE AFTER MIDNIGHT ON UCONN'S
DEADLINE. VERSION OF THAT
SENATORS WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
TO DO IS MINIMAL IF YOU DON'T
MIND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO BE HAD TO GATHER OUR
THOUGHTS AND WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH THE BODY AND MADAM
LEADER YOU'LL BE THE FIRST WE
GET BACK TO ON THAT INQUIRY.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT SIR YOU
MADE THE CALL WHEN WE REJECTING
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND YOU
CONTINUED SO I WOULD ASSUME
THAT YOU HAD YOUR DUCKS IN A
ROW- BEFORE YOU CONTINUE THAT
PROCESS. YOU KNOW THAT THIS
TEAM IS AMONG THE BEST IN THE
NATION SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS AND WE'LL
BE BACK WITH. EACH OF YOU HERE
IN A FEW MOMENTS THANK YOU.
SENATORS WERE GONNA CALL CENTER.
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR.
MISTER
PRESIDENT. CENTER GROVE. I KNOW
THERE'S A TIME CLOCK ON THE
CALENDAR- ABOVE YOUR HEAD ON
THIS ON THE BOARD MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FROM STAFF IN
THE IN THE BUILDING THAT YOU
DIDN'T START THE ROLL CALL THE
HOTEL JUST AFTER MIDNIGHT I'D
LIKE THAT TAPE REVIEWED- AND
I'D LIKE AN ANSWER BECAUSE I
CAN'T SEE IT REMOTELY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND CENTER GROVE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
SECRETARY SENATE IN HER TEAM-
PULL THE TAPE AT THIS TIME
WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU HERE
MOMENTARILY. THANK YOU.
MISTER
PRESIDENT. GOOD EVENING LEADER
GROVE I CAN BE THERE IN FIFTEEN
MINUTES IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO
REVIEW THE TAPE WITH YOU SO WE
CAN CONFIRM IT WE WERE WORKING
TEAM TO REVIEW THE TAPE LEADER
GROVE AND I PROMISE YOU AND TO
YOUR ENTIRE CAUCUS THAT WE ARE
WORKING AS- EXPEDITIOUSLY AND
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
HELLO. CENTER
NIELSEN. OKAY. SENATOR GROW
TURN YOUR MICROPHONE OFF WE'RE
GONNA ASK ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE
PROTESTING REMOTELY IF YOU
DON'T MIND TO PLEASE PUT
YOURSELVES WE'D BE GRATEFUL.
MISTER PRESIDENT WE HAVE SCREEN
SHOTS WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO SEND
ONE TO YOU I THINK YOU'RE A
PRETTY SHAKY GROUND.
THEY DON'T
LIKE IT DISPARITIES IN GERMAN
THE SENATE. WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED HERE IN ABOUT A MINUTE.
WE'LL BE PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER LEADER ROVE MOMENTARILY.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO RETURN
TO THEIR SEATS. AND WE'LL GET
STARTED HERE IN JUST ABOUT A
MOMENT. MISTER PRESIDENT. THEN
LATER CAN YOU GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT MY MASK JUST BROKE AND
I'M GONNA GO GET A NEW ONE YOU
ONE SECOND. SURE.
I APOLOGIZE
MAN LEADER AND THAT WAS MY THAT
MY MASK JUST BROKE. IF WE CAN
EVERYONE PLEASE TAKE THEIR
SEATS. FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IS SEEKING FOR YOUR
HARD WORK. WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER LEADER GROVE WITH
ACTIVATING ANSWER LEADER ROOM
UPON HERINQUIRE RE. WE DO HAVE
A FEW ITEMS THAT WE COULD TAKE
UP HERE THIS EVENING. THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE AFTER THE MIDNIGHT
HOUR. I'M GOING TO PARAPHRASE
HERE THE LEADERS TO INQUIRE RE-
ON WHAT GROUNDS. CAN THE SENATE
ADVANCE VOTE EVEN IF THAT VOTE
IS CONTINUING. AFTER THE
MIDNIGHT HOUR HAS STRUCK AND IT
IS THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF
THE HOUSE TO ALLOW FOR ROLL
CALL VOTE TO PROCEED WHEN IT'S
INTRODUCED PRIOR TO MIDNIGHT.
THE SECOND INQUIRY BY THE
LEADER WHICH WE HAVE TO DEEPLY
APPRECIATE. THAT WAS IN REGARDS
TO THE TIMESTAMP DID DEVOTE
ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE PRIOR TO
THE MIDNIGHT HOUR STRIKING. IN
ACCORDING TO ADDITIONAL RECORDS
THAT HAVE BEEN REVIEWED BY
EIGHT SHOWS VERY CLEARLY THAT
THE VOTE WAS AVANCED PRIOR TO
THE MIDNIGHT HOUR. SO WILL TURN
IT BACK TO- LEADER GRILLED AND
LEAVE YOU THOSE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WOULD ASK
OUR CARE FOR IS AN ITEGRAL I
DON'T WANT. TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH PETER GROVE. HEY
THOSE ARE THE ARE ASKED BUT I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO DIRECT YOU
TO ARTICLE FOUR SECTION TEN
SUBSECTION C. OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WHICH PROHIBITS.
WHICH PROHIBIT. DIMMICK LASSES
ARE. ARE GOOD FOR CENTER
SECTION ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
TEN SUBSECTION C. OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION WHICH
PROHIBITS THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR PASSING BILLS
AFTER MIDNIGHT THAT BILL DID
NOT PASS PRIOR TO THE MIDNIGHT
HOUR AND YOU WERE ON VERY SHAKY
GROUND SERVICE. HELLO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND LEADER GROVE WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE YEAH. WE APPRECIATE
THE FEEDBACK AND THE DESK CLERK
NOTES SO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE DO HAVE A SCREEN SHOT. WE
APPRECIATE THAT LEADER GROW
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
LEADER GROWS WE UNDERSTAND
WE'RE YOUR POINT IS THAT THAT
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING ON NOW TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE AFTER
THE MIDNIGHT HOUR ND UNDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. IT'S
PRESIDENT YOU CAN'T TEST MISTER
PRESIDENT. YOU CAN'T JUST
DISMISS THE FACT THAT YOU WERE
INCORRECT SO I APPEAL THE
DECISION OF THE CHAIR AND
REQUEST A ROLL CALL VOTE. AND
LET ME SEE I'M VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE DESK STAFF
FOR NOT UPHOLDING THIS. IN THE
LEADER OF THE GETTING ICY
MISKIN TERRACE. WELL FIRST AND
FOREMOST- MINIMALLY- I JUST
GOING TO SAY WE HAVE THE BEST
DISTAFF IN THE NATION HERE. AND
THEY WORK THEIR TAILS OFF FOR
ALL OF US HERE IN THE STATE
SENATE. IN IT IS THE CUSTOM IN
THE PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE. AND
YOUR YOUR POINT IS DULY NOTED A
MAN LATER WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD IN OUR AGENDA
TONIGHT. HE'LL THE DECISION OF
THE CHAIR. THERE THERE IS NO
APPEAL. MADAM CHAIR THERE'S NO
APPEAL WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING
FORWARD RIGHT NOW TO BE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN. FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN SIR I CAN'T
REQUESTED. DECISION OF THE
CHAIR AND THE DECISION OF THE
CHAIR THIS THIS ISSUE IS
DEBATABLE. CAN YOU GIVE ME A
MOMENT. AND THEN LATER. AND
AGAIN SIR YOU CAN HAVE WHATEVER
CUSTOMER HOUSE OF THE CUSTOM OF
THE HOUSE BUT YOU'RE VIOLATING
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
LATER AGAIN IT IS THE RULING
THAT THERE IS NOTHING TO APPEAL
YOUR REQUEST FOR INFORMATION
HAS BEEN ENTERTAINED AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD.
FOR THE SEEDINGS BUSINESS.
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU MADE IT IS
AND I AM. DECISION AND THE
CHAIR PLEASE RESIDENT LEADER
GROVE WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE
FORWARD AND WE ARE NOW AN ORDER
ON THIS MATTER MR PRESENT POINT
OF INQUIRY CENTER SYLLABLE JUST
IT WOULD APPOINT INQUIRY. THANK
YOU- I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE- PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY INTO THIS MATTER.
MAKING MIGHT I RECOMMEND THAT.
EITHER ONE OF WE CONTINUE
INVESTIGATING IT OR TWO WE CAN
MOVE FOR WITH THE REMAINING
ITEMS FOR TWO NIGHTS BUT UPON
COMPLETION OF THOSE THAT CAN BE
COMPLETED AFTER TWELVE PM OUR
THAT WE REVISIT THIS ISSUE-
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT IN NOT
ALLOW THE SENATE TO DISBAND
UNTIL THIS ISSUE IS RESOLVED.
WOULD THAT BE HELPFUL. OR JUST-
AGAIN REDUCE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THIS CONVERSATION HERE'S OUR
BOTTOM LINE AND I KNOW WE MAY
NOT SEE EYE TO EYE THIS
EVENING- THE LEADER OF-
REPUBLICANS ADVANCED IN. AND
ENQUIRE RES WE NOTED THAT HER
INQUIRE RE WE ANSWERED HEARD
INQUIRY I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
MAY BE DISAGREEMENT ON THIS
ISSUE AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD HERE
TONIGHT SO. MISTER CHAIR YOU
YOU MADE IT WILL MEAN THAT THE
BILL PASSED I'M APPEALING THAT
DECISION SO I SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO APPEAL THAT DECISION
WHEN YOU SAID THE BILL PASSED
I'M APPEALING THE DECISION OF
THE CHAIR THAT THE BILL PASSED
AND THAT BILL THAT. THAT ROUTE
THAT. IS DEBATABLE. LATER GIVE
US ONE I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO MISS MISS ME AND I'M NOT
GONNA LET IT HARRELL MINIMALLY-
I THINK THAT I HAVE SHOWN
INCREDIBLE DOES THE DIPLOMACY
HERE TONIGHT I HAVE NOT
DISMISSED ANYTHING THAT ANY
INDIVIDUAL FROM EITHER PARTY
HAVE ADVANCED IN FACT HAVE
WORKED INCREDIBLY DILIGENTLY ON
BEHALF OF PROTEIN AMERICANS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE
HEARD TONIGHT AND THAT IS THE
GOAL OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. AND SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MAY BE A
DISAGREEMENT ON THIS ISSUE BUT
WE HAVE ENTERTAINMENT CENTRE
ENTERTAINS THE INQUIRY WE HAVE
MADE A RULING AND WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING FORWARD
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
MAY BE DIFFERENCES- SHOW ME
PLEASE JUST SHOW ME WHERE YOU
HAVE THE AUTHORITY OR YOU HAVE
THE ABILITY TO I'M DENYING MY
REQUEST TO APPEAL THE DECISION
OF THE CHAIR YOU MADE A RULING
AND I'M TELLING YOU THAT I'M
ASKING TO REPEAL THE DECISION
OF THE CHAIR. AND I ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL VOTE. THERE WAS A UN
MANDATED THERE WAS NO OFFICIAL
RULING- WE PROVIDED. THE ANSWER
TO YOUR COURT REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. SO THAT WAS THE IN.
SIR I BEG TO DIFFER YOU RULED
THAT THE BILL PASSED I'M
APPEALING THAT RULING THANK YOU
MATE. THANK YOU MADAM LEADER.
THERE ARE RECORDS ON SCREEN
SHOTS TO SHOW THE FIRST AND
VOTE WITH ALLEN AS AN I WAS
POSTED AT ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
AFTER ELEVEN FIFTY NINE IT TOOK
ONE MINUTE AND SEVENTEEN
SECONDS TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL
CALL VOTE THIS VOTE DID NOT
PASS PRIOR TO MIDNIGHT
ACCORDING TO THE CONSTITUTION.
HELLO HI. SCHERING YOUR MARKS
ON.
GOOD EVENING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN LEADER GROVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IS
APPRECIATED AS WE'VE BEEN
CIRCLING HERE AT THE DESK.
LEADER GROVE AT REQUESTED
INFORMATION ON TWO ITEMS NUMBER
ONE- IF THE BODY IS ABLE TO
ADVANCE VOTE PRIOR TO MIDNIGHT
EVEN IF THE VOTE HAD NOT BEEN
COMPLETED UNDERSTANDING AT
LATER GROWTH AS A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION OF WINNING THE VOTE
STARTED. COMPARED TO WHAT THE
HOUSE CURRENTLY HAS BASED OFF
OF TIME STANDS STILL LEADER
GROVE REQUESTED INFORMATION IN
UNDER SECTION TWO THIRTY
PARAGRAPH EIGHT OF MASON'S
LEGISLATIVE MANUAL IN ANSWER TO
A PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY IS NOT
A DECISION. AND THEREFORE
CANNOT BE APPEALED- AN
UNDERSTANDING. THAT YOU MAY
HAVE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION BUT
PETER GROVE ARE FORMAL AND
FINAL IS AN ANSWER TO A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY IS NOT A
DECISION. AND THEREFORE CANNOT
BE APPEALED. MISTER BROWN. THAT
CENTER BORDERS ONE OF THE
QUIRKS LISTEN I THINK ALL OF IT
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY I THINK
ALL OF US WOULD PROBABLY DO
WELL IF WE BRUSHED UP ON OUR
CONSTITUTION AS WELL AS OUR
PROCEDURES AND THIS IS PROBABLY
GONNA TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
MAY I SUGGEST THAT WE MAKE A
REQUEST THAT WE SUSPEND THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE VOTE
PENDING FURTHER INQUIRY INTO
THIS MATTER BUT FOR PURPOSES
THE TONIGHT MOVE ON WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE AGENDA IN THE
POST MIDNIGHT. VOTES AND
REVISIT THIS AT AN APPROPRIATE
POINT BUT NOT CERTIFIED THE
VOTE UNTIL WE RECONCILE THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
BURGESS AND I'M SORRY TO KEEP
YOU WAITING AGAIN WE'RE OUR
BELIEF IS AN ANSWER TO A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY IS NOT A
DECISION AND THEREFORE. CANNOT
BE APPLIED. LADIES AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
LEADER GROVE CENTER BARGES AND
ALL THOSE. WHO VANTUR NOT GONNA
BE MOVING FORWARD INTO OUR
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FOR THE
EVENING. THERE ARE THREE MISTER
PRESIDENT I BELIEVE THAT WOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED AS A POINT OF
ORDER. THERE WERE JUST- FOR
WHAT PURPOSE. WHY I BELIEVE
THAT POINT THAT POINT OF WATER
WOULD HAVE BEEN TO ALLOW US TO
REVISIT THIS AT A LATER POINT
BY SUSPENDING THE CERTIFICATION
OF THE VOTE ON THAT PARTICULAR
BILL BUT ALLOW US TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE REMAINDER OF
THE BILLS. OR JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY JUST A PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY OR A POINT OF ORDER. IF
THIS WOULD BE A POINT OF ORDER
THEM. AND A IN ORDER IS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO ASK YOU WHICH
RULE YOU BELIEVE WE'RE BREAKING
AT THIS POINT ON YOUR POINT OF
ORDER. I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
CITATION ON THE ON THE
PARLIAMENTARY RULE THAT I COULD
INVOKE RIGHT NOW. BUT I SUSPECT
IT WOULD BE. THAT IF THERE IS.
LEGAL DISAGREEMENT. AS WELL AS
PROCEDURAL DISAGREEMENT THERE
MUST BE A WAY TO PRESERVE THE
RIGHTS. OF THE PARTIES THAT
BELIEVE FURTHER INQUIRY AND
RESEARCH ARE APPROPRIATE. BUT
ALLOW US TO DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS TO FINISH OUT. THE
REMAINDER OF THE YEAR THE
CALENDAR AGENDA. I SO I ASKED
MAYBE BERNIE OR OTHERS TO FILL
IN THE BLANKS ON HOW THIS CAN
BE ACCOMPLISHED WITH THE
APPROPRIATE. LANGUAGE BUT I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD.
OR JUST THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
POINT OF ORDER- WE BELIEVE THAT
THE ROLL CALL THAT WAS OPEN WAS
PRIOR TO MIDNIGHT- AND THAT IS
OUR FINAL DECISION THE C. WHEN
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
ON TO- UNFINISHED BUSINESS
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. THAT AND
THAT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
FILE ITEM NUMBER I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY MR PRESIDENT SHOULD MIND
MY HANDS UP I'D LIKE TO BE. I'M
SO SORRY YOU'RE OUT ORER
DELAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS THIS IS FILE ITEM FILE
ITEM SIX- SIXTEEN FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
BACK TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
SENATOR STERN SINISTER AND
PREPARE TO RESENT RENDON CENTER
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTIONS IN ACQUIRING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY GOOD EVENING.
CENTER STERN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD EVENING. COLLEAGUES
RESTORED TO DEFEND OUR
CONSTITUTION AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC.
I'VE SEEN SOME ENMITY TONIGHT.
TOWARDS OUR CONSTITUTION. WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT CHECKING OUR
CONSTITUTION WE SHOULD LOOK
FIRST AT OUR DUTY TO SERVE
PEOPLE NOT TO FAINT INEPTITUDE.
OR DELIBERATE MISINFORMATION
THAT WE'VE SEEN. I'M OFFENDED.
DEEPLY FOR THE TACTICS DEPLOYED
HERE. THESE TACTICS ARE WILL
NOT AND TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE ON TO NOVEMBER. AND
DELIBERATE MISINFORMATION IS
GONNA TRY TO CLOUD VOTERS MINDS
AROUND THIS COUNTRY TO MAKE US
DOUBT OUR VOTE TO THE BALLOT
BOX TO MAKE IS THAT MAIL IN
VOTING THE BIGGEST OUT HIS
ENTIRE DEMOCRACY HERE THEY WERE
PARTICIPATING IN. SO TO LET
PARTISANSHIP AND FRAUD TO
DOMINATE OUR DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
IS A TRAVESTY OF DEMOCRACY.
THIS BILL HERE WOULD MAKE IT A
CRIME TO DELIBERATELY SPREAD
MISINFORMATION ABOUT MAIL IN
BALLOT VOTING. AND THEREFORE
MAKE OUR DEMOCRACY MORE SECURE
A RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER STERN LADIES
IN GERMAN THE SENATE OR NOT
GONNA OPEN IT UP FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
WE SEE THAT SENATOR WILK HAS
HIS HAND RAISED CENTER WHAT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD EVENING.
SO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THAT
WAS ACTUALLY BEFORE AND YOU AND
YOU YOU SHUT ME OUT SO I'M NOT
GONNA I'M NOT COMMENTING ON
THIS ON THIS BILL I WANTED TO
SHARE YOU ACTUALLY ACTUALLY THE
CONSTITUTION WHICH I THINK
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL BUT WE
CAN RESOLVE THIS AT A LATER
DATE AND I WILL TAKE DOWN MY
HAND THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
WHAT WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO
SLEEP. SENATOR MELINDA IS. ONE
SECOND CENTER MELENDEZ.
THURMOND IS GETTING. YEAH MY
HAND WAS UP FOR THE ITEM BEFORE
BUT I WAS IN CALLING ON SEN
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER MELINDA'S. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE WOULD I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR GORGEOUS.
GOOD EVENING. I'D LIKE TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF. SB SEVEN THREE
NINE AND THE REASON WHY. IS
SPEND A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME.
OUT OF THE COUNTRY AND DEALING
WITH ELECTIONS AS THE-
INTERNATIONAL OBSERVER. AND I
THINK WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
IF ANYBODY. SAYS THAT FOREIGN
INTERESTED NON WAY ITSELF IN
WITH THE INTENT TO DECEIVE.
VOTERS I THINK THAT WOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE MISTAKE. THE REASON
WHY I'M JOINING IN ON THIS IS
BECAUSE I THINK THE THRUST IS
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTIONS
THAT GO INTO INFORMING THE
PUBLIC OR ONE THING. BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE THE INTENT. THE WHERE
WITH ALL. IN THE POLITICAL
AGENDA TO DISTRIBUTE
MANIPULATED AND ABSOLUTELY
BASTARDIZED. PHOTOS OR OTHER
TYPES OF INFORMATION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF DECEIVING THAT'S
NOT PROTECTED UNDER FIRST
AMENDMENT AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF FOLKS THAT WOULD
HAVE THE ISSUE HONOR WITH WITH
WITH THIS BUT FROM MY
STANDPOINT I IF YOU HAVE INTENT
TO DISTRIBUTE WITH THE INTENT
TO DECEIVE FALSE OR MISLEADING
INFORMATION TO VOTERS.
CONCERNING THE QUALIFICATIONS
TO APPLY FOR RECEIVE A RETURN
OF VOTE BY MAIL THAT UNDERMINES
OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM IN THAT
IT TO ME IS UNACCEPTABLE SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTINGSB SEVEN
THREE NINE. THANK YOU CENTER
BORDERS WERE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO LEADER OF. SO I
AM I AM A STEP ON THE PREVIOUS
ITEMIZE TO TAKE IT DOWN. THANK
YOU LEADER OF. BASINGER THE
SENATE WE LIKE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. KAREN AND- MANAGER
TERRY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FELL I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO AYE DODD. I TERRAZZO.
HI GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HURTADO AYE
JACKSON AYE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY HI
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI WE CASKEY
HI WIENER I. PLEASE ENTER THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE'RE
GOING TO ASK FOR THE NAME BILL
NUMBER AND PHONE BETTER SURGERY.
SIX EIGHT SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
ANDSTEAM FORGES. WE'RE JUST SB
SEVEN THREE NINE NINE FOUR JUST
HI CHIANG SB SEVEN THREE NINE
AYE CHANG AYE DALY. SALLY S. B.
SEVEN THREE NINE ABSTAINED.
GROVE. SB SEVEN THREE NINE OF
STAYING MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ SB
SEVEN THREE NINE ABSTAIN
MORLOCK. SIR MOORLACH I'M SO
SORRY YOU'RE NEEDS HER NO I
APOLOGIZE MISTER PRESIDENT OF
MORE LIKE SB SEVEN THREE NINE
HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. MORALE
IS V. SEVEN THREE NINE A STATE.
WILK. YES WILK SP SEVEN THREE
NINE HI WILK HI. PLEASE ENTER
THE SENATE EYES THIRTY TWO ZERO
ZERO ON EMERGENCY EYES THIRTY
TWO ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
SIMPSONS ARE CONVERTING.
CITIZEN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GIVE ME ONE MOMENT. ALL.
IN
GENERAL THE SENATE WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
FOLLOWING ALONG WE'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING OUT OF TWO
SUPPLEMENTALS FOR OUR NEXT TO
MEASURES SO FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX THAT IS IN
YOUR SETTLEMENT OF FILE NUMBER
TWO. THE SECOND MEASURE THAT
WERE ABOUT TO TAKE UP. HIS FILE
ITEM ONE OH FIVE WHICH IS IN
YOUR SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL. FILE
NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL FILE
ITEM ONE OH FIVE THE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN SO
LET'S FIRST START OUT THOUGH
WITH FILE ITEM NINETY TWO SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX CENTER
UNDERGOES PREPARED RISEN. I OF
CENTER CAN YOU PLEASE READ. NFL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG AND ACTUALLY INTO CIVIL
PROCEDUREAND ACQUIRING THE
URGENCY THERE OF STICK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. GOOD MORNING
CENTER NUMBER COULD MORNING
MISTER PRESIDENT AND SENATORS-BOB S. B. ELEVEN FORTY SIX
CONCERNS ELECTRONIC SERVICE
REMOTE DEPOSITIONS AND PRETRIAL
DEADLINES THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIMPLY MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN A TRIAL DATE IS MOVE THE
APARTMENT STATES SUCH AS THE
DISCOVERY DEADLINE EXPERT
EXCHANGE. THAT'S ALSO MOVED
HIGHER DR VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BERG. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE IS THERE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ANC NINE BETTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BELL AYE BRADFORD
AYE CABRERA HI DODD. HI DURAZO.
HI GALGIANI HI GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO AYE
JACKSON AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. I MONEY HI NIELSEN.
HI PAM FIVE PORTANTINO HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI MY COUNTY HI
WIENER HI. LAYS IN GERMAN THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TRANSITION TO THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WITH
THAT. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE EACH INDIVIDUAL AT CEDAR
NAME. BILL NUMBER INVOKE CENTER
MORLOCK- WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
ROLL CALL BUT I DO SEE YOUR
HAND RACES ANYMORE LOCK. MISTER
PRESIDENT AFTER THE ROLE I LIKE
TO ASK A QUICK QUESTION
ADMINISTRATIVE QUESTIONS PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND ARE MORE
LIKELY TO CONTINUE WITH HER
ROLL CALL- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE NAME BILL
NUMBER AND VOTE MATTER SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE RE. FAX PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HEY BATES SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX BY EIGHT FIVE
LARGEST. SPLM FORTY SIX FOR
JUST ONLINE OR JUST I CHIANG. A
CHANGE AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX I.
CHIANG I DALY. I'M SORRY S. B.
THIS IS A SB ADMIT YES IT IS
SIR THIS IS SB ELEVEN FORTY SIX
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO. SB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX. DALLY OF STATE.
GROVE GROTESQUELY ELEVEN FORTY
SIX SIXTEEN MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
SB ELEVEN FORTY SIX OBSCENE
MORLOCK. MOORLACH B. ELEVEN
FORTY SIX HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
IST. SIR I APOLOGIZE AND IN
TOMORROW WE'RE GONNA JUMP BACK
SINCE WERE ON FILE ITEM NINETY
TWO SB ELEVEN FORTY SIX. I WAS
CLOSE. IF YOU DON'T MIND IS
REPEATING WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SIR. HIS
LAST NIGHT. HEY SB ELEVEN FORTY
SIX AM SAME MORALE. THANK YOU
VOTING ABSTAINED WILK. WILK S.
C. ELEVEN FORTY SIX HI WILK HI.
HIGHS THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY FOUR
FIVE. HI CERTIFIED NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THE ASSEMBLY
MOVEMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LASING JERRY LISTEN THEY WERE
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
PRESIDENT- I DO APOLOGIZE
CENTER MORLOCK THAT'S MY DAD
CENTER MORLOCK FOR WHAT PURPOSE
YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN GOING THERE
BUT I APOLOGIZE WHEN YOU'RE
WHEN YOU'RE SEQUESTERED BY
YOURSELF- IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
KNOW WHAT THE AGENDA IS SO
COULD YOU EXPLAIN. WHAT WE'RE
DOING- ARE WE ADDRESSING ALL
THE BILLS OR WE JUST ADDRESSING
URGENT BILLS SIR WHAT. EXACTLY
ARE WE DOING FOR THE NEXT. WELL
WHATEVER TIME I'M I'M JUST
PULLING CLEAR IN A STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS THAT A GOOD
QUESTIONS ARE MORE LAAKSO
CURRENTLY THAT WHAT'S IN FRONT
OF US. ARE MATTERS OF URGENCY
AT THOSE MATTERS OF URGENCY CAN
BE TAKEN UP AFTER THE MIDNIGHT
HOUR SO WERE SIMPLY ADDRESSING
THOSE MATTERS OF URGENCY THAT
ARE IN FRONT OF US. IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER NUMBER NINETY TWO
THERE WAS A URGENCY BILL. YES
ALL THESE URGENCY BILL SIR.
THEY ALL REQUIRED TWO THIRDS
VOTE YES SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SEVERAL. ALL RIGHT. THERE'S A
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE WE'RE NOW
GONNA BE MOVING FORWARD TO OUR
SENATE SUBLIMINAL FILE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
ITEM FILE NUMBER THREE WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP SPACE. ONE
OH FIVE YEP SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. CENTER
BRADFORD IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
SENATE RAFFERTY PREPARED RISEN.
YES HE IS. ABOUT PHONE AWAY UP.
LET'S TAKE A QUICK MOMENT.
FOR
THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST
GIVE US A- QUICK MOMENT AS-
WE'RE COLLECTING HER PAPERWORK.
ALL RIGHT CENTER BRADFORD IS
NOT PREPARED TO PRESENT IN FILE
ITEM ONE OH FIVE UNDER THE
SUBLIMINAL FILE NUMBER THREE
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY GOOD
EVENING CENTER REFERRED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS IS A
THREE FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN ON
CRACK ON CONCURRENCE IT DEALS
WITH. A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
HIRING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM THAT
WILL HELP SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES STRUGGLING DURING
COLD AT NINETEEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE DOES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS WERE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
FINAL CALL MISTER PRESIDENT YES
CENTREBOARD JUST I'M SO SORRY I
JUST INTO YOUR HANDS- CENTER
BURGESS WE RECOGNIZE CENTER
BRIDGES ON THE ITEM. I
APOLOGIZE CAN YOU TELL ME THE
FILE NUMBER. YES SIR THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE. SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE'RE NOW
GOING TO TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR BATES GOOD EVENING
CENTER BATES. YES PLAINTIFF
INFORMATION MISTER PRESIDENT
MIKE MY FILE SHOWS THIS AS A
TWENTY ONE VOTE YOU KNOW. I'M
ASSUMING WHEN IT WAS GUTTED AND
AMENDED THAT IT. NUMBER URGENCY
CLAUSSEN'S PUT IN IT SO THAT IS
TWENTY SEVEN NOTES IS THAT
CORRECT SENATE RATES IF YOU
DON'T MIND JUST GIVE US A QUICK
MOMENT I'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU.
SENATE RATES APPRECIATE
THAT INQUIRE RE- IN CENTER
BATES. THIS IS MY MISTAKE THIS
IS NOT A TWO THIRDS VOTE BILL
THIS IS A- TAX LEVY MEASURE.
AND IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WITHIN A TAX LEVY
MEASURE THAT CAN TAKE IMMEDIATE
EFFECT BUT ARE NOT URGENCY IS
SUBJECT TO THE TWO THIRDS. THAT
SAID THIS IS A TAX LEVY MEASURE
AS SENATOR BATES. THAT IS
ELIGIBLE TO BE TAKEN UP AFTER
MIDNIGHT. I'M GONNA READ THIS
TO YOU IF IT'S ALRIGHT- AND IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU CENTER
BATES I'M GONNA READ FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THAT
WITH YOUR PERMISSION- STATUTES
CALLING ELECTIONS STATUTES
PROVIDING FOR TAX LEVIES OR
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE USUAL
CURRENT EXPENSES OF THE STATE
EMERGENCY STATUTES SHALL GO
INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. UPON
ENACTMENT. AND THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR BEING TAKEN UP
AFTER MIDNIGHT. CENTER BATES
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I THANK YOU
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
APPRECIATED THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER RETURNING FIRE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS TO SENATOR GLAZERS.
ANALYSTS PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I
GUESS I'D LIKE TO HAVE MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE AUTHOR.
GREAT RESPECT FOR HIS HIS WORK
AND- JUST NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
BILL AND HASN'T BEEN HEARD IN A
SENATE COMMITTEE. THERE'S NO
INFORMATION- AT LEAST
ELECTRONIC VERSION OF THE
HEARINGS THAT WERE HELD IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SB LACKING IN DEPTH
OF ANALYSIS TO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR. I PROVIDING THAT MORE
INFORMATION TO US. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOONER GLAZER ISN'T
DIRECTED IS A QUESTION. YES YES
SIR. THERE'S A QUESTION FOR
CENTER GLACIER TO CENTER
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD YOU
HAVE TO QUESTION FROM SENATOR
GLAZERS. SURE WHAT THE QUESTION
WAS. ALL RIGHT- WHAT WE ACT%
QUICKLY GO BACK TO SENATOR
GLAZERS INNER GLAZER CAN YOU
PLEASE RESTATE IN THE QUESTION
PLEASE. SERVICE CENTER
BRADFORD- THERE IS A LACK OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT YOUR
LEGISLATION. IS THAT IT DIDN'T
HAVE A HEARING IN THE SENATE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT. PROCESS IT
WENT THROUGH IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY- WHERE WAS HEARD.
THERE'S NO INFORMATION ON THE
FLOOR VOTE SO I WAS HOPING THAT
YOU COULD PROVIDE FURTHER
BACKGROUND ABOUT. THE MEASURE
OF THE PROCESS YOU WENT THROUGH.
THE REASONS AND THAT IT'S SET
NECESSARY FOR US TO TAKE THIS
ACTION TODAY I HEAR AN
EXPECTATION THAT THE ASSEMBLY
WILL REMAIN IN A HIDDEN IN IT
PRESIDENT TO TAKE THIS MATTER
UP LATER THIS MORNING THAT THE
INTENTIONS THERE YOUR
CLASSIFICATIONS. THIS ISSUE WAS
WELL DEBATED WHO WAS HEARD AND
NOW REVENUE AND TAXATION AND
ASSEMBLY AND IT MADE IT OUT OF
THAT COMMITTEE AND MADE IT OFF
THE FLOOR AS WELL IT'S A BILL
AGAIN THAT ADDRESSES STILL
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT WERE
IMPACTED BY COLBERT NINETEEN
THAT DIDN'T RECEIVE PPP. AND
MORE. EARLY A LOT OF A MINORITY
OWNED AND PROVIDES THEM- AGAIN
UP TO A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A HIRING TAX CREDIT FOR
PROGRAMS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING DURING CALL IT
NINETEEN I. S. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN RESPONSE TO THE
CALL THE CRISIS CORRECT BY
GRANTING SMALL BUSINESSES ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR FEWER A
TAX CREDIT OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER NEW HIRE SO- THE
HELPS DEAL WITH MANY OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD A
DURING THIS CRISIS. AND IT JUST
MEANS THAT- ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EVERY PERSON HIRED
AFTER JULY FIRST COMPARED TO A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EMPLOYED
DURING THE SECOND QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR AND AGAIN THE FOCUS
IS ON SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE LOSS AND IF YOU'RE REVENUE
IN THE PAST YEAR OR IN THE LAST
YEAR AND I BEGAN TO TAX CREDIT
CAN BE USED FOR INCOME TAX. FOR
SALES OR USE TAX. THANK YOU IN
CENTER BRADFORD ACCIDENT
GLAZERS THIS ON YOUR OWN TIME.
I GET JUST ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR THAT- HELPFUL
INFORMATION. HI IS THIS THIS IS
THIS IS THE RESULT OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THIS A- A
PROPOSAL THAT THEY AND JOIN
WITH YOU IN AN SUPPORTING AND
FINALLY. IS YOUR INTENTION TO
BRING THIS BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR. CONCURRENCE TODAY OR NO
THIS IS- THIS THIS TO BE CAN
CURRENCY WOULD GO TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OF. YEAH WE'VE
ALREADY HAD. OUR IN DEPTH-
NEGOTIATIONS SOONER COPY ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO. A WILL HOLD
INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE WE
PRESENTED ON THE FLOOR HERE-
WAS IT. NO WE ARE SORRY I'M A
COMPANION BILLS THIS. WELCOME
TO THIS- YESTERDAY BUT- IT'S
BEEN WELL DEBATED AND- WITH
BOTH. THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF.
OPPOSITION ALL THE COALITIONS
THAT WILL WORKING. HARD TO MOVE
FORWARD IN. IN THE BUSINESS
AREA MAKE SURE THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PER. PROTECTING
PROVIDED SOME TYPE. OF RELIEF
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SURVIVOR IT WAS SHOULD WE TAKE
THAT AS A CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
HEARING SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION WHETHER
IT'S REMOTE AND OR HERE AND
CHAMBERS MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BELL FIVE BRADFORD HI CABRERO
HI DODD HI DURAZO. HI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
HURTADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING AYE NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN HI NUMBER HI
WAY CASKEY I WIENER I.
MINNESOTA CAN PHYSICALLY ABSENT
MEMBERS ONCE INDIA WERE LOOKING
FOR CENTER NIELSEN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE VOTE
BUT IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
NIELSEN. WHAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TRANSITION INTO THOSE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND WE
WELCOME- IF YOU DON'T MIND YOUR
NAME BILL NUMBER AND VOTE.
BETTER SECTOR. FACE EIGHT SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN ON BASE HI
FORTUS. SB FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
BORDERS ARE. FOR JUST I CHANGE
KST LIBERTY FORTY SEVEN I
CHIANG HI DOLLY. L. A. S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN HI DALLY
HIGH GROWTH. GROUP S. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN I. I'M SO
SORRY I LEADER GROVE WE'RE
GONNA GET YOU ON SCREEN EVEN
THOUGH WE APPRECIATE LOOKING AT
CENTER DOLLY- WE'RE GOING TO
PLEASE AND CENTER GROVE YOU
DON'T MIND PROCEEDING. AS A
SENATOR GROWTH S. C. FOUR ONE
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SO ONE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN I. THANK YOU LEADER
OF GROVE HI MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
S. B. ONE FOUR FOUR SEVEN I
MELENDEZ HI MORLOCK. SB ONE
FOUR FOUR SEVEN ABSTAINED.
MORALE YES- MORALE S. B. ONE
FOUR FOUR SEVEN ABSTAINED. WILK
PLEASE THANK YOU WILK SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN. WILK I.
BY THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
SENTIMENTS ARE ENCOURAGING.
BASIN GERMAN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ONE FINAL ITEM AROUND CHANGE
BUSINESS THAT'S FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY THREE. SEVEN THREE
THREE I APOLOGIZE YEAH THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING MY
MISTAKE. WE ARE NOW MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT CENTER BY CASKEY IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. BETTER
CENTERING CAN YOU PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AN ACTUAL RELATING TO LAND USE
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
OF SICK AFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB ONE SIX
EIGHT RESTORES THE RIGHT OF
CONSULTATION FOR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WHEN THEY MADE ONE
THERE MAY BE AN IMPACT TO
TRIBAL CULTURAL RESOURCES FOR
PROJECTS SEEKING SB THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING PERMIT
UNFORTUNATELY TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES WERE NOT PART OF THE
LIST OF EXEMPTIONS UNDER SB
THIRTY FIVE AND AS WE LEARNED
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING IT
WAS. EVERYBODY SORT OF. DROPPED
THE BALL OF THE STATE AS STAFF
IT WAS THAT THE TRIBES DEAD AND
THERE'S ENOUGH BLAME TO GO
AROUND BUT THIS LEFT INDIGENOUS
SACRED SITES VULNERABLE TO
DESECRATION WITHOUT THE RIGHT
TO CONSULTATION PROVIDED TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN SICK BUT
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO. SO AFTER
TWO YEARS AGO SHE TIONS OF
AMENDMENTS THE RESULT HAS BEEN
AB ONE SIX EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN TRIBES HAVE CONSTRUCTED
THIS PROPOSAL THAT RESPECTS
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY BY ALLOWING
MOST PROJECTS TO STILL ENTER
STREAMLINING. WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS HEREBY CASKEY DO A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE GOOD
EVENING CENTER WIENER. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT- I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SIXTY
AND I WILL BE VOTING FOR IT.
SEES ME I TODAY TONIGHT AS IS
THERE THIS MORNING I GUESS- AND
FOR THOSE ON THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE- YOU ARE OF COURSE
ALREADY AWARE. AT THIS WAY AS A
VERY- SO DIFFICULT BILL AND A
DIFFICULT. PROCESS WHEN WE
CRAFTED SB THIRTY FIVE AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AS THE SENATOR
FROM FREMONT NOTED HI. NO ONE
ASLAUG THIS ISSUE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE AN EXEMPTION FOR
SACRED SITES NO ONE NOT THE
TRIBES NO COMMITTEE THAT IT
WENT THROUGH NO ONE. AND OF
COURSE- WE NEED TO HAVE AN
EXEMPTION. FOR THESE CULTURAL
RESOURCES THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- NOW THIS BILL I WILL
BE HONEST AS MEMBERS OF HOUSING
VIDEO MY VIEW IS THAT THERE ARE
ON SOME CHALLENGES WITH THIS
BILL I DON'T LOVE THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED. IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS- THE TRIBES ESSENTIALLY
HAVE VETO POWER OVER WHETHER
PROJECTS CAN. ANSWER SB THIRTY
FIVE AND THERE IS NO LEGAL
REMEDY AT ALL IF SOMEONE
DISAGREES. WITH THAT
CONCLUSION- SADDAM HAS BEEN MY
CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL- BUT ON
BALANCE EVEN THOUGH I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF
THE BILL. I HAVE NO CONCERNS
WHATSOEVER ABOUT THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE- NATIVE AMERICAN-
NEIGHBORS- THEY HAD A CAMPAIGN
OF EXTERMINATION OF GENOCIDE-
OF EXPULSION OF FORCED
ASSIMILATION- PUT. ON THEM
FORCE ON THEM. AND WE NEED TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO BE ALLY TO
AND TO HELP LIFT UP OUR
NEIGHBOR NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES- INTO PRODUCTION SO
TO PROTECT WHAT IS LEFT. OF
THEIR HERITAGE- AND SO ON
BALANCE ON BECAUSE OF THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
BASINGER THE SENATE WITH
ACTIVITY SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HAINSEY NINE CENTER MY CASKET
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS.
AB ONE SIX THREE WILL ENCOURAGE
THE CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING WHILE PROTECTING TRIBAL
CIVIL RIGHTS AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES FROM FURTHER
DEGRADATION I ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
BETTER SECURITY PLEASE FOLLOW.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELL I BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I
DODD. I DURAZO. I GALGIANI HI
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ. I HUESO I
HER TADO. HI JACKSON I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I MONEY.
I NIELSEN FIVE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER FIVE STERN. HI I'M
BURKE HI MY CASKEY AYE WIENER
HI. WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY IF YOU
DON'T MIND GIVING US YOUR NAME
PHONE NUMBER AND YOUR VOTE.
MATTERS SECRETARY. YEAH SENATOR
BATES AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT HI.
BATES HI GORGEOUS AND YEAH
THERE WE GO THERE WE GO THE
CENTER FOR JUST ONE SECOND
PLEASE RIGHT IF YOU DON'T AYE
PROCEEDING NOW SO SORRY.
MORTGAGES AB ONE SIX EIGHT UP
STAYING. THANK CHIANG. CHIANG
AB ONE SIX EIGHT HI KAREN I
DALY. AB ONE SIX EIGHT OF
STAYING. GROWTH A GROUP AB ONE
SIX EIGHT AYE GROVE AYE
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AB ONE SIX
EIGHT I MELENDEZ AYE MORLOCK.
AB ONE SIX EIGHT HI ORLOK HI
ZERO IT MORALE. AB ONE SIX
EIGHT ABSTAINED. WILK WELL AB
ONE SIX EIGHT OUR WILK HI.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
SIMPSONS CONCURRED IN. BASIN
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE THERE
ARE TWO MEASURES ON CALL AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX AND EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY SIX. AB AND THREE
TWENTY SIX THOSE MEASURES FAIL.
ALL MEASURES ARE ENACTED ON
TODAY WILL BE MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO ENTERTAIN MOTIONS TO SUBMIT
LETTERS TO THE JOURNAL. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
PROVIDE HARD COPIES TO THE DESK
STAFF. ARE THIS GONNA CENTER
WINNER. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL REGARDING
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH PASSED OFF CONCURRENCE
EARLIER TODAY THE LETTER HAS
BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER WE ARE WE'RE NOT GONNA
GO TO SENATOR BOARD JUST COULD
YOU CAN CENTER GOOD MORNING
CENTER BURGESS. GOOD MORNING
OUR COLLEAGUES. IF YOU'LL
INDULGE ME IF I HAVE THE- THE
PRESIDENT'S AUTHORITY I'D LIKE
TO READ A AN OPINION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ALLEGED COUNSEL'S
OFFICE. CENTREBOARD YOU COULD
NOT NOW THAT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME YEAH IT'S WE CAN JUST. IF
YOU COULD PUT A QUICK HOLD ON
THAT WILL COME RIGHT BACK TO
USE PLEASE. CIDR WHY CASKEY FOR
PURPOSE- THE MEN UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE PROCEED I
MOVED TO REQUEST A SUBMITTAL TO
THE JOURNAL STATING THAT SENATE
BILL NINE AWAY. DOES NOT
INCLUDE REQUIRING LICENSURE FOR
CONTACTING ACTIVITY COVERED
ENTITY EXISTING PRIVATE
INVESTOR. THAT'S A GATOR ACT
THAT'S CHAPTER ELEVEN POINT
THREE OF DIVISION THREE OF THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
COMMENCING AT SECTION. SEVENTY
FIVE TWELVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS HEREBY CASSY WERE
GONNA ASK ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY JUST.
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOUR MUTED
AT THIS TIME THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR ABOUT GETTING CENTER
BELKIN MORNING CENTERVILLE.
SENATE BILL OF THIS PRESENT ARE
LIKE TO- REQUESTED A- MOTION TO
PRINT IN THE GENERAL LETTER-
REGARDING S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
ONE WHICH PASSED RECENTLY IN
THIS HOUSE. AND. BOTHSIDES
HAVE AGREED TO THIS LETTER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
BELT WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO THE DEAN AND SENATE AS
SENATOR NIELSEN. EARLIER THIS
EVENING SUBMITTED TO THE DESK A
LETTER FROM REPUBLICAN LEADER
GROVE- TO THE JOURNAL- I JUST
WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT THAT
WILL APPEAR THAN IN THE
JOURNAL. OKAY I SEE A BERNIE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
NIELSEN AT WE ARE CONFIRMING
THAT WE ARE IN THE SEAT OF THAT
LETTER WE'RE GONNA AND NOW GO
TO SENATOR GALGIANI THEY WERE
GONNA GO TO CENTER TO LET AND
SENATOR PAN. CENTER GALGIANI
THANK YOU MISTER CHAMBERS AS I
TO MAKE A MOTION TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL FOR SB
SEVEN FORTY ONE WE AMENDED THE
BILL TO DELAY FOR A YEAR IN
ORDER TO GET THE RECORDERS
ENOUGH TIME TO ACQUIRE THE
FUNDING NEXT YEAR. THE LEDGES
THE LETTER STATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO DO SO
AND THE RECORDERS WILL NOT ASK
THE GOVERNOR FOR VETO AS A
RESULT OF THE LETTER BEING
SUBMITTED. THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT THAT STERN FLORIDA
CENTER TO LET OF THE REGULAR
CENTER PAN AND THEN SENATOR
HILL. BETTER PRESENT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER. TO THE JOURNAL KILLER.
A CLARIFYING CAL FIRES ROLL.
SHOULD S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
BE SIGNED INTO LAW BOTH SIDES
HAVE REVIEWED AND APPROVED THE
LETTER THANK YOU. HE CENTER
CELERA GETTY GOOD MORNING
SENATOR PAN. IF YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL BE HALF OF BOTH
MYSELF AND MY JOINT AUTHORS ARE
LEYVA CLARIFYING THAT'S NOT THE
INTENT OF SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE
TO ALTER ANY EXISTING LAWS
GOVERNING PP IN THE WORKPLACE
BOTH SIDES HAVE REVIEWED AND
APPROVED THE LETTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER PAN GOOD
MORNING SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT I
HAVE A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL-
RELATED TO SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE APPROVED BY BOTH
SIDES TO DETERMINE THE-
CLARIFICATION OF THE INTENT OF.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY NINE THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER HILL. PRIOR
TO GOING TO CENTER GORGEOUS-WITH ACTUAR DO A FINAL CALL AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH A BETTER
ESTIMATE THAT A LETTER- TO THE
DESK AT THIS TIME. CURRENCY
NINE. AS IN GENERAL ARE NOT
GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR BORJA CENTER WE'RE JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE SIR
SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS. I GOTTA
TELL YOU TONY YEOMANS JOBS- IT.
INSTEAD OF REQUIRING GETTING
HANDED OUT TO YOU MAKING FOR
PURPOSES. OF RESOLVING AN ISSUE
EARLIER I WOULD LIKE TO
REFERENCE A LETTER FROM THE.
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL BUREAU SO
LET'S COUNCIL DATED TODAY.
AUTHORED BY. DIANE SAWYER
LEVINE OR ACTUALLY- BODYCOTE
COULD TINY DEBBIE LET'S COUNCIL
UNDER DIANE BOYER VINES. OUR
SIGNATURE THERE IS ON PAGE TWO
OF THIS MEMO THAT I JUST
RECEIVED. THE CONSTITUTION I
QUOTE IF I HAVE YOUR PERMISSION
MISTER PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT YES
SENATE BURGESS SAID THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S GONNA ANSWER
THAT INQUIRY- I SEE. HERTZBERG
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THIS ISSUE.
WELL I CERTAINLY APPLAUD THE
DILIGENCE OF ON THOSE ARGUING
FOR THEIR POINT OF VIEW HAS
BEEN DEALT WITH BY THE DESK AND
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
APPROPRIATE APPROACH FOR THE
SENATOR WOULD BE SUBMIT THIS
LETTER IN WRITING TO THE
SECRETARY OF SENATE. AND THEN
YOU CAN- I PROCEED IN A MANNER
THAT YOU DEEM APPROPRIATE BUT I
THINK THAT- WE CERTAINLY
EXHAUSTED THIS BODY AT ONE
EIGHTEEN IN THE EVENING AND-
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO MAKE A RECORD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. IN AND MAJORITY
LEADER I ACTUALLY I ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH YOU WE'RE ALL TIRED.
I WOULD LIKE TO READ ONLY TWO
SENSES. THE CONSTITUTION
IMPOSES S. CONSIDERING HOLIDAYS
LEDGES YOU'RE GOING TO MEET AT
A RIGHT AND I AM SO SORRY
CENTER BURGESS- BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING YOUR
LETTER. I WILL SUBMIT THIS IN
WRITING THANK YOU BUT I DO WANT
TO PUT ON THE RECORD. THAT ARE
ONLY CHALLENGES. ARE NOW MOVING
FORWARD WE DO APPRECIATE THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT- IS
THAT SIMILAR TO THE SECRETARY'S
OFFICE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING FORWARD LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO BE AN
ENTERTAINING. INQUIRY MISTER
MISTER PRESIDENT IS IT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE- THE DESK
IS CLEAR THATWE'RE NOT GOING
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS
METAPROGRAMMING POINT POINT ON
THE INQUIRY MR PRESS. MISTER
PRESIDENT LET ME SAY THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
THIS EVENING AND ORDINARILY I
MIGHT HAVE A WRAP UP- SAID
COMMENTS TO MAKEBUT I THINK
EVEN IN HAS BEEN LONG AND IT IS
MORNING SO I JUST WANT TO NOT.
OVERLOOK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN
TERMS OF THE APPRECIATION AND
THANKS THAT WE GIVE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO GOT US THROUGH THIS
DAY THIS WEEK AT THE END OF
SESSION. SO I'M GOING TO THANK.
BERNIE MADOFF BERNIE MCNULTY
AND THE DESK STAFF. HE AND THEY
LOVE A CHALLENGE AND WE
CERTAINLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO RISE
TO THAT CHALLENGE TONIGHT.
SUSAN DEY LOOK FOR WEDNESDAY IN
THE RULES OFFICE WHO HAS
SUPPORTED US SUSTAINED US. OUR
INCREDIBLE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE ERICA CONTRARY TO A
PROFESSIONAL BEYOND BELIEF. AND
OF WE COULD HAVE DONE THIS
WITHOUT THE STAFF AT LDC WHAT
IS INCREDIBLE JOBS. RISING TO
THE OCCASION OUR CHIEF SERGEANT
KATRINA RODRIGUEZ. AND IN FACT
ALL OF OUR SERGEANTS WHO HAVE
BEEN ON THEIR FEET ALL DAY LONG.
THE INCREDIBLE G. DGS STAFF
HAVE KEPT THE PLACE CLEAN.
SANITISE AND OF COURSE WE
RECOGNISE DIçN LAWYER VINE
EARLIER BUT LET'S RECOGNIZE HER
LEDGE COUNCIL STAFF. WE CAN'T
FORGET OUR CAPITAL NURSES AND
THE CSD OFFICERS THAT HAVE
GOTTEN US INTO THIS BUILDING
SAFELY. THE CHP. LAW
ENFORCEMENT. LET ME JUST SAY TO
THE PRESIDING OFFICERS OF THIS
BODY. PARTICULARLY TODAY
SENATORS JACKSON LEYVA MISTER
MCGUIRE. YOU CERTAINLY DIDN'T
SIGN UP TO HAVE TO DO THE WORK
YOU DID TODAY AND YOU WERE PUT
IN AN UNTENABLE POSITION. AND I
HAVE GRATITUDE TO YOU FOR WHAT
YOU WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
TODAY DESPITE THE CHALLENGES
THROWN IN YOUR WAY. WITH GRACE.
WITH CLASS AND YOU GOT THE JOB
DONE. THANK YOU. WILL YOU MAKE
SURE THEY DO ALL THE PRESIDING
OFFICERS AND YOU WERE GREAT
STAND IN DOCTOR PAN- THANK YOU
BUT TO ALL OF THE PRESIDING
OFFICERS BUT IN PARTICULAR
TODAY WAS TOUGH. I CANNOT SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT THE MAJORITY
LEADER. THE ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADER. AND THEIR TEAM OF WHIPS.
I THANK YOU. I HAVE TO THANK MY
INCREDIBLE STAFF IN THE PRO TEM
OFFICE- THEY HAVE DONE JUST
INCREDIBLE WORK AND I THINK YOU
KNOW WHO THEY ARE. AND THEN OF
COURSE THE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOUR STAFF. THEY HAVE WORKED
UNDER ALSO REALLY CHALLENGING
CONDITIONS AND THEY'VE STILL
MANAGED TO GET YOU THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED SO THAT WE
COULD DO OUR JOB. POLICE MUCH
LIKE OUR THE GRADUATES OF THIS
YEAR I TWENTY TWENTY WAS A
DIFFICULT YEAR FOR OUR YOUNG
FOLKS WHO WERE GRADUATING FROM
EVERY LEVEL OF SCHOOL TO THAT
NEXT LEVEL IT OVER YOU
CELEBRATE. WE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
GROUP OF EIGHTEEN SENATE
FELLOWS THIS YEAR. AN
ORDINARILY WE WOULD GET TO
HONOR THEM ON THIS FLOOR AND
ALL OF THOSE SENATE FELLOWS ARE
GONNA GET THE WONDERFUL
RESOLUTIONS SOMETHING TO
CHERISH AND HONOR FOR THE TIME
HERE. BUT THEY DIDN'T GET TO BE
HERE WITH US TODAY TO BE
RECOGNIZE WE DIDN'T GET TO DO
THE- FLOURISH AND ACKNOWLEDGE
EACH OF THEM INDIVIDUALLY. SO I
AM GONNA DO MY BEST TO SAY
THEIR NAMES- ACCURATELY
HOPEFULLY. THEY'RE ALL AT HOME
BY NOW MAYBE NOT MAYBE THEY'RE
STILL DOING THE WORK FOR YOU
BUT- YOU KNOW THIS IS BEEN A
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. AND ARE
WE GET THE BENEFIT OF THEIR-
PASSIONS THEIR HARD WORK THEIR
EXUBERANCE. FIVE THERE ABSOLUTE
PRIDE TO BE IN THIS BUILDING.
AND IT'S JUST BEEN AYE I WOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THE
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND HAVE A
BROWN BAG LUNCH. I AM ALWAYS
INSPIRED BY THEM. SO I'LL DO MY
BEST TO SAY THEIR NAMES
ADEQUATELY BUT- HE SHOUTED OUT
IF I GET IT WRONG. SO FROM THE
OFFICE OF SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO
ELIZABETH AGGREKO. FROM YES FOR
THE OFFICE OF SENATOR TOM
UMBERG EDWIN CHICK CROOKWELL.
FROM THE OFFICE OF SENATOR JOHN
MOORLACH RYAN GARDNER. OFFICE
OF SCOTT WIENER SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER DANTE GOLDEN. OFFICE OF
SENATOR PATRICIA BATES JESSE
PURSER. THANK OFFICES SENATOR
MIKE MCGUIRE IN A BILL HOPKINS.
OFFICE OF SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL YES CENA HAPPINESS.
OFFICE OF SENATOR BRIAN JONES
NINA CRUCIAL. OFFICE OF
MAJORITY LEADER ROBERT
HERTZBERG CHARLES ALLOWED.
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
HOW DID YOU GET TO MISTER
MCGUIRE AYE GUSTAVO ALBERTO
MEDRANO. GEN OFFICES SENATOR
BEN HUESO KENYA RONDO VERDUGO.
OFFICE SENATOR NANCY SKINNER
DID OVER. TO OFFICEOF SENATOR
BEN ALLEN ATTICUS RADIUS. OFTEN
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY OFF ANOTHER TWO FOR.
MICKEY SCOTT. OFFICES SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON INDIA
SHOULD HAVE GOT. OFFICE OF
SENATOR SCOTT WILK ISRAEL SIX
FELLOW JUNIOR. WELL WITH THE
SENATOR MARIA ELENA DURAZO HIAN
TRAN. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
OFFICE OF SENATOR RICHARD PAN
TI<c.cyan> SHOWS WHY. COLLEAGUES</c>
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GO
THROUGH THE LIST OF PEOPLE WE
NEED TO THANK YOU AND- AS
ALWAYS I HAVE GOOD BACK UP FOR
MY COLLEAGUES I HOPE THERE WAS
NO ONE THAT I FORGOT I
APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WITH THAT MISTER PRESIDENT- I
HOPE PEOPLE GO HOME TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO THEIR FAMILIES
TO THEIR LOVED ONES I KNOW THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO DO THE
HARD WORK I KNOW THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO REPRESENT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT. I WILL SEE YOU THE
FIRST WEEK IN DECEMBER WHEN WE
RECONVENE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. TEN RETURNING
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US IN CALFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE ARE OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED.